I don't think I need to tell you all
that I loved juicy Kaizen like if you
look at my channel it's pretty obvious
that this series is something I hold on
the same level as any other of the
greats or the nostalgic shows from our
childhoods what Giga akatami has managed
to do with this series here is goddamn
amazing the amount of perfectly done
foreshadowing that relates precisely to
the later outcome of the story or the
stuff you know that we've learned so far
just blows me away the fact that this
man over five years ago now crafted
everything that I'm going to go over
with all of the plot twists and mind
mounts in advance as Brilliance and I
truly don't know how it was even done
but yes just like I said before
throughout this video we'll be going
over everything that goes down inside of
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen so far starting with
the end of season 1 or about the chapter
67 Mark where the Gojo past Arc and
continuing up to the most recent
complete Arc which just happens after
chapter 215. this has taken so long to
complete like I think I've been working
on this project for over a year now so
if you do enjoy it please consider
subscribing as honestly it helps out
with pushing my content to a bunch of
new amazing people plus once you've all
caught up with read the most recent
chapters in support Geiger kotami with
its last year after Jutsu Kaizen but
enough of me yawning on as per usual
let's get into the entire story of
jijusu Kaizen so far
so as we leave the deaf paintings we
disappear 12 years into the past where
we find a voluptuous grade one sorcerer
called meimei along with the current
gray 2 sorcerer otahime so here our
girls have been tasked to track down a
curse spirit yet unfortunately both of
them ended up getting caught within a
barrier that never seems to end after a
brief chat udahima decides that they
should split up and move more
unpredictably to escape the barrier
however just before the girls are able
to put their plan into action the house
is suddenly torn apart by the
illustrious curse technique lapse blue
as udahime recovers from the sudden
eruption big Gojo appears asking as she
started crying which is actually so damn
rough for her either way as the two
sorceress dunk on odahime she tries to
talk back when all of a sudden a curse
burn appears instantly after the curse
word appears an even larger more
disgusting curse Spirit appears From
Below completely taking it by surprise
It's Quickly revealed that the number
two Gojo's best maze suguru KIRO had
ordered his curse to not eat the other
allowing him to assimilate it later so
the reason like Gojo and the others had
showed up in the first place was because
the girls were trapped in a rare type of
barrier that misses were space-time
itself Yaga had found it odd that both
of these Sorcerers hadn't touched base
for a few days so he ordered the others
to head out to check up on them the only
problem with him showing up now though
was the fact that no one even put up a
barrier before Gojo went wild causing
the local media to quickly catch on
shooting back to Jujitsu Tech as a
breaking case of an explosion that
destroyed a mansion makes a news and
absolutely paved and must have made she
questions what happened with the curtain
after being pointed out as the culprit
Gojo complains that Kurtis are pointless
since civilians can't see Jujutsu or
curses anyway yet suguru argues that
it's important that regular humans can't
see Sorcerers to provide them with a
natural peace of mind he believes that
jutu himself exists to protect
non-sorcerers annoyed with this though
goju believes that it's just a pain
having to look out for the weak and hate
all of those righteous ideals that
Sorcerers have just before the two
explode in Anger over their differing
opinions masamichi returns to the class
causing the boys to instantly change
their outward attitude with the
atmosphere beginning to change around
them masamichi assigns his skulls too
strongest on a mission they come
straight from master tingen so this tank
and fellow is kind of suspect apparently
there is a young high school girl who
was a perfect match for him this person
is simply known as the staff placement
vessel and the mission demands that the
boys locate escort the girl to master
tingen and then erase her after
initially thinking their teachers lost
his mind sugude puts the jokes aside and
asks if the mission is meant to reset
Master tinga's curse technique oblivious
to like what they're even talking about
though masumichi explains to Gojo that
tingen is an immortal being but his
coustic neck does not stop the aging
process so due to this once a certain
age is raged Evolution will occur and
master Tinker will no longer be the same
person so this tingen fellow is actually
the entity that strengthens all of the
barriers used by both of the Jujutsu
schools as well as all of the manager's
barrier techniques the period of time
that one body is active for tingen is
around 500 years before he has to go and
merge with a compatible vessel and
rewrite his body's information Nation
doing this will also refresh his
Immortal Curse technique and thus the
body will stop trying to change bodies
and evolution will not occur the
location of the star placement vessel
has been leaked and there are two groups
that are currently looking for the girl
one is the cursed User Group Q who wants
to take over the Jiu Jitsu World by
hitting Ting and lose or Reason the
other is the star religious group called
The Time vessel Association that
worships tinken as their God having
gotten the full rundown from masamichi
The Duo then leave on their mission and
begin discussing why the star religious
group the people who worship tinken are
trying to take out the star placement
this all sugru who like obviously just
pays more attention unlike Gojo explains
that they worship a pure master tenkin
and the merger would Sally the Purity in
their eyes they don't even curse you as
a group so right now he doesn't even
think they'll be able to interfere and
because of the suguru believes and they
should just focus on the curse User
Group Q Gojo who's probably like only
paid half attention as well stated that
they should be fine no matter what since
they are the strongest as the duo
continue they're suddenly taken by
surprise as a part of the building
nearby erupt spewing up a Thor of rubble
onto the street below adding to the
already escalating situation randomly
the star plasma vessel is thrown from
the building by one of Q's strongest
Fighters before the girl hits the ground
though ghetto quickly uses his ability
to summon a flying curse to rescue her
while asking the Assassin to not make a
mess since the boys are already in
enough trouble Gojo having watched
everything from the ground below notices
five daggers randomly throwing at him
and uses the infinity technique to hold
them revealing himself another q soldier
named Bayer confronts him admitting that
he knows the name of the famous Saturday
Gojo not bothered at all though with the
fodder Gojo taunts him saying that he
won't beat him senseless if he breaks
down and apologizes now so while all
this stuff is going down with like root
Q Kong are representative from the time
visual Association had met with a
mysterious member of the Zenon Clan
there the two plan the assassination of
the star plays in The Vessel however
after being addressed as a Xenon the
yolk dub in second most beautiful human
and jjk claims that he no longer it goes
by Xenon but instead goes by toji for
shiguro now he then without a second
thought accepts the contract to take out
the star placement of his soul back in
the battle suguru effortlessly
immobilizes kokon while they cursed it
wants to kiss him a rate over being
stuck cooking threadens they buy a q
strongest Soldier will come and take
them all out however ghetto Stone shows
kokon a picture with Bayer defeated on
his phone absolutely killing any hope
the little guy had hilariously from this
due to Q's stronger Soldier being
defeated the organization soon disbanded
meanwhile Kong finds toji bidding on a
horse race apparently he used the 30
million yen that he was paid in advance
to wee down Gojo and the sorcerers with
him slightly confused by his actions
Kong shows how skeptical he is of his
client as he needs to give a positive
report back to his clients however toji
is confident he'll get a return on the
money in the long run the representative
reminds the sorcerer that he's counting
on him and before he goes to leave asks
tochi how his son Mega me is doing yet
in one of those moments where I got a
hate on him for being a bum he says that
he couldn't kill less and doesn't even
remember who that is anymore back with
the boys and they previously knocked out
last we are finally introduced to Rico
who awakens in Gojo's arms and
immediately attacks him this is
obviously just for the fact that she was
knocked out with the last thing she saw
being her attackers so she presumed that
like they were her attackers as well
however her caretaker masato arrives
allowing them to all get on the same
page in casual fashion though as she
starts talking about herself in tinken
the two boys ignore her slightly
irritating her so rather than taking her
back to Jujutsu high right now Rico
actually ends up heading back to her own
School French Hoku girls high this is
for the fact that tenken's trying to
somewhat be generous towards Rico
because like obviously in a few days
she's no longer going to exist after a
short moment suguru checks his
surveillance curses which he put up
earlier and realizes that two of them
had already been taken out because of
this they all quickly come to the
conclusion that people are here for the
star placement this all so they both
head off to find her immediately so the
reason people are even showing up in
their first place is because of a single
and ready to mingle toji who placed
their 30 million bounty on Rico's head
and these men have come to collect it
speaking of the Devil Himself literally
well toji sits on the phone chatting
with Kong he learns that these Sorcerers
protecting Reiko haven't returned to the
school yet happy with learning this news
he knows that this is perfect for the
association as now more than just total
lunatics will go after the Bounty Kong
points out that the 30 million page one
was a service fee so if someone else
kills the vessel and claims the reward
toes you may end up losing all of the
money obviously Toby knows that Goku
exists so he isn't even worried and he
slide us with all of the fodder poking
at the sorcerers here toji himself isn't
even sure that he could take out the
vessel what Gojo still present and due
to this he plans on using random curse
users for the remaining 39 hours of the
mission to wear down Gojo's group pretty
much in toji's eyes it's free labor
taking this order and Kong realizes that
this makes the previously annoying time
limit of today's turn in their favor
with Toshi noted that things are
beginning to pick up his decides to keep
going himself soon and tells the rip to
have that 30 million ready back over at
rinchoko girls high the duo including
masato moved out to find Rico suguru
plans on heading straight for The
Intruders while the other two split up
to find Rico as the two chat ghetto
splits off on his own first wondering
who these curse users could be
associated with he knows that with Q not
around anymore hired Sorcerers for the
time vessel Association could be trouble
he made a turn down a hallway ghetto
encounters an ugly man who after
noticing this student himself covers his
front and rear with his own shikagami
with the old fart recognizing Guido's
uniform he assumes that there are
multiple opponents in the school he
analyzes him and recognizes that the
student's curse technique is some sort
of curse spur manipulation he keeps up
his conversation with suited while
simultaneously plotting to get in close
and deal some damage ghetto though just
tells the old fart to not waste his time
and instead completely engulfs the
hallway and his giant worm curse
believing that he's one suguru is taken
by surprise as the curse user appears
from the window behind find him trying
to use Guido's blind spot was advantage
while them daddy nun the old dog
believes that he has the upper hand now
however his life randomly and violently
flashes right before his eyes before
sukuru also violently dominates the old
man in close quarters beating him
senseless with ferocious succession of
strikes funnily enough from the moment
that ghetto saw the old dude he knew
that he wanted to get in close in state
their fighters who were presented with
only one single way to win are easy to
manipulate elsewhere the others continue
looking for Reiko who like I mentioned
before is in the chair pool with Gojo
having headed there he barges into the
building yelling for the girl and
surprising everyone inside were the
girls freaking out over Gojo's God level
of beauty the teacher gets them to
settle down and momentarily scolds Gojo
before also giving away her number while
the other girls continue to argue our
boy sneaks over grabs Rico and then
escapes the chapel with her knowing that
something's going down goju wants to
head straight for Juju too high but as
he runs across these rooftops he's
spotted by cursed user down below the
curse user doesn't recognize his student
but notices the girl he's carrying
masato though soon confronts the curse
user from behind and asks of his worthy
time vessel Association or cue not
answering her to engage any short
scuffle but musado easily takes him out
moments later gido arrives and based on
the conversation with the Enemy the
cursed user is able to confirm that the
girl he saw is the Bounty not the one in
front of him suddenly he melts into a
puddle of Mud making misato question if
the paperback freak was actually a
shukigami with that dude gotten now get
her calls his boy and informs him that
there is a 30 million Yin bounty on
reiko's head with a time limit listed on
a deep-knit website for cursed users as
Gojo then hangs up the phone the jewel
are immediately surrounded by four of
those same paperback curse users Reiko
like masado also assumes that the person
uses clones as shikigami while Gojo says
that their opponent is probably just
using jiujitsu sorcery the paperback hit
dude casually refuses though before
forming a fifth form and claiming that
being a professional sorcerer is more
danger than it's worth not waiting for
his enemy to form Gojo quickly attacks
and uses the acoustic neck lamps blue to
take out two of the Clones in an instant
having watched this Reiko mentions that
they weren't dispelled like the
shukigami but Goji reminds her that
they're not shikagani instead they're
actually clones of the real Caster made
from Jujutsu using a real person as a
substitute two of the Clones in getting
close to Saturday swung in atom but they
can't bypasses Infinity making them easy
prey for the counter-attack thanks to
the big brain Omega Shenron level 6 size
of Gojo he was able to deduce his
opponent's curse technique and divulges
his own Gojo's ability is the
convergence of an infinite series things
that approach him slow down to the point
that they honestly never reach him if he
amplifies certain aspects of it and
possible situations are truly born so
that's who attempts to unleash the
advanced version of RTC to eliminate his
enemy the acoustic neck reversal red but
it doesn't work instead he's forced to
just simply knock him out with a punch
this I'm pretty sure is just for the
fact that like Gojo actually can't
control it yet or Gojo using RTC would
have allowed him to exercise the curse
but because he wasn't a curse and just a
human got your head come out with his
hands and you learn more about like
Advanced versions of RTC later in the
series but I think this might have been
the first use of it here or it was just
Gojo not being able to use this
technique correct me if I'm wrong here
below plus I wonder if the paperback
dude is like Aina with his technique
won't spoil like for people who know who
Eno is but you know like the whole get
up is kind of similar here anyways
randomly Rico gets a text with a picture
of masato captured by the enemy kiddo
heard lifted behind apologizes for not
considering her importance with this
posing an annoyance Gojo believes that
the enemy will try to pull off a trade
and return for Rico but he knows that
since they have the upper hand all they
need to do is coordinate with your
opponents to find a meeting place they
consider taking Reiko back to the school
first but she refuses as she hasn't been
able to say her goodbyes yet and worries
that the merger will happen beforehand
if she heads there Gojo assumes her the
enemy will contact them soon and agrees
to bring Reiko alone but only under the
conditions that he isn't scared or
lowers the chances of masato's survival
like predicted the kidnappers call and
demand Okinawa as the mating Spa but
once the other group is easily able to
rescue masato and apprehend the
kidnappers like it's it's just so easy
it doesn't even happen on screen now
with the bass just with a plan to enjoy
themselves masato apologizes to everyone
for being captured by a non-sorcerer
member of the time Bissell Association
which I can't lie is just actually the
biggest L on her behalf as someone who's
meant to be there to protect Rico and
she actually gets captured by someone
who doesn't even have cursed energy
anyway sugude like the legend he is
right now in this story rip a movie
kiddo for sure she is blame with her and
explains that they were able to travel
safely to her on a plane aided by his
curse manipulation still they wondered
why Okinawa was chosen as their mating
spot with the kidnappers masato suggests
that maybe so they could attack from the
airport as they arrive however that was
impossible as it's actually revealed
they're just too high crazily enough had
taken those precautions by sending in
the other first years you high bar and
kintunan army back at the beach goju
decides it's best to leave the next day
as it'll help avoid more unnecessary
interactions with curse users get it
brings up the stress over Gojo keeping
his technique open worried that it's
takes in his body too much because you
assures him that he's fine and his
presence in general just makes
everything okay now finally on the last
day of the mission Gojo and crew
successfully reached the foothills of
Tokyo Jiu Jitsu high four hours after
Rico's Bounty was lifted with them
having passed through a number of Tory
Gates that puts them inside Tegan's
barrier and in their eyes finally safety
feeling that she's more than safe now
goju deactivates her six eyes technique
and The Constant Guard he had over the
group however as soon as he does he's
also stabbed from behind by no one other
than the Demon Lord himself toji
fushiguro kind of confused with what
even happened gojus just asks if he
knows this guy from somewhere but toji
tells him to not worry about remembering
some random guy's name funnily enough
Gojo actually slightly recognized hoji's
stature earlier in life and while he was
still with his innum family toji along
with the others once went to see a young
Gojo even back then during his childhood
he was a big deal and it was the first
and last time someone even noticed
toji's presence when he approached from
behind with the current happenings toji
had purposefully waited until Gojo was
worn down with having overuses sex eyes
then when given the opportunity to stab
him from behind in a complete surprise
he took it kicking things off between
two of the series strongest characters
Gojo forces himself up into the air
while ghetto and combination summons his
giant man-eating curse wound to Devour
the Assassin seeing his boy rushing to
his side because you assures him that
his wound isn't too severe as he
reinforce it with curse energy to reduce
any further damage he then tells him to
hurry on with a mission and take the
girl to tenken while he holds off the
unknown assailant not hesitating the
others hastily leave the area as toji
also slashes his way out of the giant
worm curse exercising it in the process
what toji looking around surveying the
area goju taunt's daddy stating that the
bounty has been lifted but Tojo reveals
that he was actually the maniac who
placed the bounty on Rico in the first
place he finds it funny on how they had
to go to Okinawa and add I told you is
playing consisted of creating an opening
of Hope with the illusion of goals using
the time limit that he had set up
annoyingly for toji though no sorceress
from Gojo's side were taken out in the
previous bout but he still managed to
get him to deactivate his curse
technique which was the overall goal
asleep paved goju initiates the battle
unleashing his curse technique laps blue
on tochi in an attempt to see him flying
however toji is fast enough to evade the
Sorceress technique while his enemy
having vanished Gojo realizes that toji
has absolutely zero curse energy meaning
that he's using nothing but an innate
physical prowess to fight because of
that he can't read his movements but he
is able to knock him away if he does get
the chance thinking some more he
presumes that his opponent also knows
about the Limitless technique and likely
is a plan for its abilities we told you
hiding away Gojo can't sense his
location so to fix this issue the big
brain himself decides to clear the area
of all possible blind spots using the
maximum lapse technique energy output
blue while the surroundings completely
gone now he surmises he's probably using
the forest's cover now but is taken by
surprise when toji uses a group of
random flying heads to appear in front
of him blocking the sorcerer's Vision
having seen the storage cursive wields
got your guesses that it had been
holding the flyheads along with any
weapon for shikuro might have because of
the Hebrew streams that toji's plan
might be connected to the curse tool he
just took out while this view still
partially blocked by this fly screen of
toji's got you plans on using blue again
to clear them until he realizes that the
sorcerer killer might have actually left
the area altogether and gone straight
after recode suddenly though toji
appears right behind him to which goju
notices in time and while studying the
weapon he wields notices the foreign
curse energy flowing from the curse tall
due to Gojo taking things precautiously
and overthinking the different
possibilities within the fight It
ultimately sealed his fate dashing and
toji easily maims the strongest sorcerer
alive plunging the Legendary Blade he
wields through him with Mr Saturday Gojo
stunned with what's just happened it's
shown that those items are thick the
special gray curse tool inverted Spirit
of Heaven can force the stoppage of a
cursed technique make any flesh of
Darkness told you having nullified his
curse technique Cuts him down with a
flurry of slashes to the leg chest and
head leaving a young Gojo and a heap on
the ground fully appearing to have
passed on elsewhere and actually under
the main level of this school and the
catacombs at the bottom of Tokyo Jiu
Jitsu High masato saves you final
goodbyes to Rico while the ladies having
said their goodbyes get released the
Star Plus my vessel to their main hall
of the Tomb of the star so will this
area being protected by a barrier that
only allows certain people inside ghetto
gives her some directions on how to find
tingen exactly however before she hits
off he then offers her one crazy dilemma
either she can continue forward and
choose to merge with tingen or turn back
and return home with all of them and the
moments before the machine had begun
both of the boys had agreed with each
other that they'd call off the mission
as the star placement vessel didn't want
to go ahead were thirds for Reiko it's
honestly really upsetting her whole life
so far has just been a tragic mess her
parents had died when she was young so
she believed that she would be okay with
this leaving everyone behind but now
after spending time with everyone over
the past few days Riku cries and admits
that she wants to stay being a man of
his word ghetto office to take her home
to what she agrees but sadly just as
they thought everything was about a
change for the better she is shot and
the kid dropping to the floor absolutely
mortifying a horrified sugadu as Rico's
body lays there on the ground before
ghetto toji reveals himself and states
that it's time to wrap things up
flabbergasted ghetto just asks him why
watoji confidently stating that he also
killed saturu Gojo having heard enough
and becoming filled with anger ghetto
brings out two of his strongest curse
spirits to destroy his opponent with
things hating up between the two toji
explains that the majority of the
barriers between jijuzu high are simply
Heidi nerd so if by chance someone knew
their location in advance they could
easily locate the Tomb of the star or
the cursed Warehouse which is actually
crazy if you think on that exact
statement here to how the person
controlling ghetto literally really did
this in the future advising mojito on
how to break into the cursed Warehouse
to steal chosen stuff but anyway done
with the chair sugodu attempts to
destroy toji with his rainbow dragon but
the Assassin quickly pops off some more
rounds at these sorts for it while he
continues talking he comfortably manages
to avoid the attacking curse and
explains how he also broke through the
defenses of the skull to completely hide
himself he swallowed his curse but he
uses to store curse tools allowing him
to stay invisible and because he's also
with Xenon as we know he probably also
knew a sneaky way inside annoyed get
adjusted mines that told you stopped
talking as he knows they're revealing
certain information can improve his
Heavenly restriction while kiddo doesn't
actually know though as how he tracked
him into the entrance of the tombs no
curse energy residuals were left behind
so it had to have been another way like
yeru suspected and to revealed that toji
actually used a much more human method
of tracking to find them due to him not
having any curse energy the specific
training the dude has gone through has
sharpened his five senses to their Peak
allowing him to detect curse Spirits
brushing Adam once more of the rainbow
dragon tries to take him out I told you
looking like the goat he is effortlessly
slashes it apart using a special katana
like curse tool what's even crazier
about this is that ghetto's rainbow
dragon had the strongest offenses out of
any of his cursed Spirits toji though
isn't impressive all-body sorcerer's
ability however he is randomly caught
within the innate domain of Guido's
other imaginary vengeful curse Spirits
for those of you like who are confused
of what an innate domain is an innate
domain is the World created by
themselves inside a curse Spirit here if
they're strong enough they can project
that externally like they did here when
changing the area from their normal
scene to a darker one whereas with a
domain expansion you trap people within
the orb while at the same time making
sure the surface area is small enough so
that they're able to fully project the
innate domain back with the uh crackhead
says the lady there's innate domain
unwillingly places toji and a pack that
will keep their domain there until the
question is answered weirdly the
eventual Spirit asks if she is pretty
but toji after getting a look at her
simply replies that she is in his type
having answered the question though his
Purge domain begin Vanishing allowing
toji to see these massive scissors
floating around him figuring that it's
the creepy spirit's ability our dead
effortlessly deflects all of the blades
with the inverted Spear of Heaven at the
exact same time ghetto comes in close
and attempts to absorb toji's inventory
curse but somehow it rejects his
manipulation done with his semi-grade
one sorcerer toji draws a second blade
from his pick curse throws the inverted
Spirit of Heaven into the sky and
slashes both suguru and the imaginary
vengeful curse spirit in an instant
turning to the sorcerer toji puts him
down another notch and leaves him there
knocked out claiming that he would have
easily killed him but the possibility he
could release all of the curse words
he's taken in throughout his life upon
his death irritates toji he tells him to
thank his parents for being born once he
awakes but states that despite all their
blessings and abilities they have lost
to a simple monkey who can't even use
the Jutsu and thus the rage against him
monkeys was born like looking at this on
a retrospective here is actually quite
insane this is the first time I remember
the use of monkeys being brought up to
explain someone without Jujutsu but
ghetto definitely turns that monkey's
thing into his whole damn Persona by the
time yudu comes around that's some mud
blood full blood level of Hasting in
this series by the way at the same time
in the foothills of jiu Jutsu High
goju's eye twitches skipping away from
our Gojo though because he's totally not
important to the overall story we see
the massive time diesel association
headquarters or more specifically the
child of the star area inside of the
building Koji delivers the star plasma
vessel to a direct representative of the
religious group sonoda looks her over
and confirms her passing stating that
they will pay tochi extra for his
troubles he goes on to explain why the
association did what they did Master
tinken began spreading Japanese Buddhism
during the Nara period and preached what
will become the foundation of the juices
sorcery the world of jiu Jutsu and
religion have never been able to agree
and from the disparity the time vessel
Association was born what's everything
going on the time vessel Association
couldn't afford to allow an impure
merger to take place and are already
ready to fall alongside the star if need
be you'll learn like more about this in
the uh perfect preparation Arc but even
here at the beginning of this video
you'll learn that tengen might become a
threat to humanity if he evolves so
thinking now it's honestly disgusting
that this tiny religious group would put
his eyes ahead of the entirety of the
Earth's population just because they
think Rico isn't Pure or whatever it's
actually the most scuffed religious
mindset by the way back with it Go and
as it goes to leave the representative
but she asks some Alfred meal sometime
but the man jokingly says that the only
Associates with toji in business or Hell
which is a giga level 4 shadowing I
shall say as toji exits the premises
alone he runs into a now restored saturu
Gojo and is very surprised to see
someone he thought he killed not too
long ago so the main reason Gojo had
survived back there was like he reveals
himself because he had used a reverse
curse technique to heal himself the big
brain genius had used his six eyes to
process the effects of his Limitless
technique as well as the reverse curse
technique however it's an obvious effect
because as like the first time he
figured out how to do it properly it's
takes his brain making him extremely
Delirious with a crazed demeanor yet
even still he brags that there at the
very edge of death satanu finally
experienced and understood the core of
cursed energy itself taking all of this
absolute nonsense and though Koji is
absolutely insulted by the idea that
he's lost to someone he just beat and
because of that begins taking out the
inverted Spirit of heaven and claiming
that the battle has only just begun to
which Gojo with a crazed smile screams
that he's oh so right expecting things
to have not changed toji attempts to
Blitz Gojo like he did last time
slashing at him several times however
Gojo was able to beautifully avoid them
and manages to get behind toji
levitating up into the air Koji turns to
face him but Gojo having cracked the
code itself learn to flow reverse curse
energy into his Limitless technique to
successfully unleash the curse technique
reversal red as the ability bursts out
the explosions repulsion power since
toji flying a few hundred meters but
leaves him mostly unharmed As Gojo flew
floats there proudly with an insane
smirk on his face Koji acknowledges that
his opponent is indeed a monster needing
to find a way through this new Gojo
stretches out his arm and breaks down
each of the abilities behind the
Limitless technique Judo Bean is in and
he knows about the logistics of red and
blue so he connects the inverted Spear
of Heaven to a chain to nullify things
within a certain range and comes up with
a plan for each of the distinct Powers
even so with all of his pre-planning
going on an uneasiness lingers over him
still he puts that aside and pushes
forward telling himself that he's gonna
be fine Gojo on the other hand looking
mentally insane levitates above him
upside down wearing the same insane
smile despite having lost their previous
fights looking at him toji begins to
hesitate but quickly calms himself down
and makes him move to kill the young
sorcerer seeing this God you apologizes
to Rico because he's not vengeful enough
for her but in his eyes he knows that
throughout Heaven and Earth he alone is
the honored one using the inverted
Spirit of Heaven toji created waiver
from all the stops go through it from
seeing the Assassin's exact location
only for the spear to suddenly burst
through the smoke in front of him rather
than flying towards the sorcerer Gojo
knows that innate techniques which are
passed down through families have a
spoken manual on how to use them yet
that word often slips out and other
families learn the ins and outs of how
these innate abilities work he knows
Koji must be a Zenon but even inside of
the precious Gojo family there is one
technique only known to a few the
emotions of blue and the reversal of red
colliding those two techniques creates
an imaginary mass that absolutely
annihilates everything it touches having
performed this exact set of movements
saturu points his two fingers forth and
unleashes the hollow purple technique
taking the most gifted non-sorcerer
Alive by surprise so remember how toji
felt an uneasiness just before or that
all stemmed from him breaking his own
rule of not actually working for free
yet he got paid just before for the Star
Plus movie at all but after completing
the job he should have just ran from
Gojo but he couldn't as the greatest
source for alive stood before foreign
he's always wanted sadly though it
caused hoji to deviate from his true
self and once he crossed that point he
had already lost and fortunately for him
and the sun he forgot all about for this
path toji was unable to put aside his
pity Pride watoji visibly broken goju
asks him for any last words to what he
says that he has none however after a
short moment he thinks of the young Mega
me and tells Gojo how his son will be
sold to the Xenon family in two or three
years so to do with her information as
he pleases at least we got to see Dad
finally come in clutch right as he drew
his last breath and tell goju about the
conditions that he had with Megami and
the xenons Hiro who's obviously woken
out from his bake down quickly makes his
way to the house of the star but it's
perplexed when he finds toji's inventory
curse on the ground once assimilating
the curse he goes inside to sadly find
Gojo holding Rico surrounded by the
worshipers applauding her demise looking
at his friend Guido has just left
shocked by how much he's changed even
questioning him if he's the same person
Gojo who's tiltering between light and
dark asks if his mate feels like killing
all of the non-sorcerers around them
because right now in his current state
of mind he doesn't think he'd feel a
thing you know luckily still of a sane
mind replies that it's pointless since
the ones in charge had already fled but
now that the sorcerers are still
involved the time physical Association
can't talk themselves out of their
involvement anymore still got your
questions if there even needs to be a
reason but sugude assures him that it
does especially for Jujutsu Sorcerers
skipping forth one year from that day
Gojo has gotten a greater control of his
ability demonstrates to his classmates
how the ability to automatically
activate and utilize the Affinity Works
he explains it's almost like an
automatic defense mechanism made from
Jujutsu that can distinguish between
mass speed shape and the intensity of
fused energy all in order to arrange the
danger of any approaching object also
because of this new Awakening goju can
pretty much have the Limitless active of
it all times whether it require minimal
resources if he did this back in the
past he would have gone crazy but using
a reverse curse technique at the same
time keeps him fresh and repairs the
damage being done to his brain here and
how joyous his friend is ghetto can't
help but notice that Gojo alone had
become the strongest which is really
really sad for his friend now that he
can handle any mission on his own Hiro
thinks he'll gradually be going on less
and less assignments with him plus over
the past year between 2006 and 7 there
was a massive rise in disaster curses
spawning all over Japan oh my Lord this
just sprang on me imma put a mark on
screen for those who don't want to be
spoiled on something to skip past right
now I think this was kinjaku like we all
know he was around at this time
obviously but in someone else's body we
don't know exactly whose it was probably
kaori itadores but this was definitely
him too he was probably purposefully
planting these like dirty curses all
over that year to mess up ghetto who had
consumed them eventually kinjaku stole
his body as we know and it probably
always planned it to happen after
finding him so just from that
information alone he needed a way to
either distance ghetto from Gojo or have
him taken out so he could take over the
body no just think on it with the stuff
that goes on here and after with ghetto
over the past year the endless cycle of
exorcism consumption constantly using
his curse Spirit manipulation was
beginning to weigh on gido he began to
lose his way due to the Hideous evil of
humanity initially and as we all saw he
wanted to follow through with his duty
as a sorcerer he was the one who guided
Gojo but now he couldn't help to think
about all of those followers of the Star
as monkeys after the confused ghetto
gets out of the shower he waits around
in a room alone to think until you comes
to give him some company he lets him
know that he's hidden off on a Faraway
Mission the next day and hearing there
they discuss souvenirs until suguru asks
hayabara if he's okay with being a
sorcerer you who's kind of got that like
Yuji level of Personality states that he
doesn't think about in-depth stuff but
knows that giving it is all towards
something he can help with provides a
great feeling for him with girua grain
the tour suddenly confronted by a woman
asking them what kind of girls they're
into oh the Barry herself walks into the
room causing ghetto to question her
identity funnily enough hayabara
actually answers and claims that he can
tell she's not a bad person before them
running off to get ready for his own
mission now alone the woman introduces
herself to ghetto as the other special
grade sorcerer Yuki sukumo here in her
name flexi switching his head as he'd
heard about her as the special grade who
doesn't take on missions and bums around
overseas my owner thought on this is
actually for the fact that Yuki has a
different outlook on thanks to the
higher-ups she explains that to Jukes
who ends up treating the symptoms of the
curses while she actually wants to go to
the root cause of it all wanting to know
more from her Yuki explains to him that
she desires a world where curses don't
exist full stop as we know curses are
born from the negative energy that leaks
from humans and because of that there
are only two ways to create a world
where curses don't exist they must
either eradicate curse energy itself
from all humans or teach the wider
population to control alerts Yuki knows
that the format is possible as toji was
a model case for it but throughout her
searching over the globe he was the only
person worldwide who possessed no curse
energy at all so the possibility of
humanity achieving his level is almost
impossible the reason tochi achieved
this level was because of his Heavenly
restriction which granted him enhanced
senses as well as the ability to resist
curses he was truly superhuman knowing
that ghetto feels broken after his loss
to this man Yuki tells him that there is
no shame in losing to someone as
powerful as him cases of heavenly
restriction are extremely rare in
general soyuki decided to focus on the
latter option for eradicating curses her
reasoning for that as Sorcerers don't
create curses unless the specific
conditions arise Sorcerers can control
the output of curse energy and it
doesn't leak from them at the same rate
or flow as non-sorcerers and in general
sense if every human became a sorcerer
it would be impossible for curses to
exist honestly still haunted by the
followers of the star ghetto asks Yuki
why they shouldn't just kill every
non-sorcerer to solve their problem
which I guess is the crazy third option
even though he snaps out of his crazy
maina Yuki explains to him they're
wiping out every non-sorcerer to force
Evolution might be the easiest route but
it's also the craziest she asks sugodu
if he hates non-sorcerers and sadly he's
even unable to give her an answer which
just shows how far he's fallen over this
past year he knows that he used to
believe that Sorcerers existed to
protect non-sorcerers but now he doesn't
even know if humanity is worth fighting
for man it's honestly so damn sad seeing
the complete change in ghetto from this
happy dude with a positive outlook on
things to this now gloomy dude with a
really dark disposition where he doesn't
see any good in the world at all Yuki
confirms the suguru that he must choose
between locking down on non-sorcerers
and resisting their failings just before
hitting out a new motorcycle she says to
him that she'd like the three special
Grace to get along and reveals that
Master tingen had stabilized sometime
later okay so for those of you who don't
know there is actually a connection
between Tink and and Yuki their kids
explained later on in the series during
the Yuki Arc I'm pretty sure let me know
your thoughts on it down below I think
tenkin is kind of a little bit of a
wiener for it in a way you know he's not
he's not a nice dude there's definitely
something stuff's going on later on we
see gito sitting with an Army in the
morgue morning over hayabara's death
nanami was told it was meant to be a
simple mission to take out a great tukur
spirit however in the random area they
travel to the curse was the subject of a
guardian deity's religion as the deity
of their area it became more and more
powerful with time and it really should
have been rated as at least grade one
suguru tells nanami to get some rest and
assures him that Gojo will complete the
mission they set out on and here in the
tsunami says that goju should just take
every Mission alone from now on sometime
later in the next month Hiro was sent on
a mission to investigate a village where
a random curse Spirit had been
kidnapping people after arriving the
sorcerer is able to exercise the curse
but ends up finding two young girls who
had been caged because they wielded Juju
too suguru tries to calm him down and
tell them they're not the cause of this
incident but the non-sorcerers around
them call them monsters as is later
revealed that sadly suguru ghetto took
out all 112 non-sorcerers and fled the
village with the girls afterwards the
original Target of emission they had
actually been doing the plague in of the
Volusia start with was thought to be the
culprit he had once further
investigation what Sorcerers took place
they were able to find residuals from
Guido's curse manipulation once YouTube
confirmed this masamichi was tasked with
giving Gojo the mission to slay his best
friend standing there neither of them
can even make sense of what happened
within misguided Ally but the news even
making goju Panic internally for the
first time in his life meanwhile in
Shinjuku Shoku was confronted by the
traitor but nothing crazy happens
instead they just have a short
conversation about the allegations
alleged against him with kiru confirming
them Shoku instantly contacts gojos let
him know where the traitor currently is
moments later goju finds Guido walking
through the crowd and Shinjuku and
demands an explanation for all of the
things that he has done having fully
turned down the evil road now Guido
explains that he wants to build a world
without curses and non-sorcerers sadly
not even suguru's parents were speared
in the making of This World making Gojo
Christian has friends broken morels
ghetto believes in this path though and
because of that he thinks that there is
meaning in all of their deaths but Gojo
claims that his goal is pointless
tsukuru though believed that his friend
could easily take out every civilian by
himself so it's not impossible he knows
that if they switch places The
Impossible could in fact become possible
due to this ghetto decides to leave the
area confirming to him that this is the
life that he has chosen he tries to
provoke his friend to kill him stating
that there is meaning in there too but
as our jjk0 series villain begins to
rise from the fires of evil ghetto walks
away and begins to blend in with a crowd
goju pulls up his finger in preparation
to unleash his hollow purple technique
however just ends up being unable to
kill his best friend allowing kiddo to
safely Escape eventually becoming what
we saw throughout JoJo
now arriving at the building at once
served as the time vessel association's
headquarters ghetto comes before a new
congregation made up of the remains of
the star religious group and the other
weirdos he tries to address in the stage
as their leader but none of these idiots
even listen to him so to fix the small
issue Geto makes an example out of
sonoda by brutally smashing him on this
stage in front of everyone turning
things up a notch ditto demands that all
of these pathetic monkeys obey him from
now on elsewhere this is random dude
with glasses follows a kid around who
turns out to be me making me questions
the strange man and asks why he's
looking at him so randomly obviously the
man with glasses is Gojo and it's for
the fact that Mega me just looks exactly
like toji as the toast speak goju tells
me that his father is from the Xenon
Clan they're a family who love people
Bliss for their certain hidden technique
and now that Mega me was nearing the age
where his curse technique will manifest
and makes it the perfect time to sell
onto the xenons the literal first grader
though like not first grade judicial
Tech first grader replies that he
doesn't care about what his father
wanted and his mother hasn't returned in
a while either which is you know really
damn sad standing there gaju asks Mega
me if he wants to go to the Zam family
but megami's only concern is for a
sister she will only go if the
conditions suit her after a small joke
from Gojo that shows that it's probably
not going to be right Gojo insists that
there is no way sakumi would be happy at
these Inn and family so instead he
promises to take care of things from
mikami and asks him to instead get
strong
on October the 19th of 2018 Gojo is
asleep when Mega me Yuji and nobara
arrive once awoken and after a small
greeting Gojo sends them to udahime's
location there she tells them that there
are two moles one of which is actually
one of the Jews who hire UPS since they
can't do anything about that presently
their main target is whoever is feeding
information to that set higher up nabara
asks of the mole is someone from Kyoto
surprising Yuji as utahime prepares to
reveal to them who it is elsewhere
kusumi meets with mikamaru she tells
them that their notebooks are due today
and he replies that he is going to sleep
Becca mikamaru's alleged Hideout udahime
informs the Tokyo first years that it
has to be kokichi due to the process of
elimination using puppet manipulation to
steal information wouldn't be difficult
for someone like migamaru at the same
time kikichi prepares for his visitors
however Yuji bursts down the door to the
fake Hideout confirming to them that
he's the mole and his actual hideout out
kokichi meets with mojito and gito okay
you know quick note weaves so I'm going
to call suedo Guido or sudo Geto however
you like to say it just ghetto from now
on so it doesn't get confusing but just
know it ain't actually ghetto so it's
easier for me to call him just ghetto
and so I can have that fair reveal on
all of you anyway kikichi comments about
how he had thought that they had
forgotten about him but getter replies
that they would never do that since
kokichi knows the consequences of having
a curse restriction as mojito suggests
that they kill kokichi since they have
all the information they need ghetto
tells them they have to heal kakichi
first before they can kill him due to
the terms of The Binding vowel between
them mojito begrudgingly uses his Idol
Transfiguration to heal kakichi giving
him a healthy body for the first time
mahida remarks that kokichi should show
some enthusiasm but he replies that
there comes after they settle their
business with no more words left to be
said the battle at the dam begins
kikichi calls an entire Army of
mikamaru's to his side as his
confrontation with gizo and mojito
escalates he enlarges his arm and
smashes the wave of mikamaru's aside
kokichi disappears and the confusion and
mojito figures that he run away without
any reason to kill them bored mojito
claims he's not in the mood for hunting
suddenly the underground League
collapses forcing mojito to quickly
Escape Outdoors mahito looks at the
giant lake with an excited Smile as
ultimate mikamaru mode absolute appears
from within its head doing final
checkups kokichi notices a curtain
forming around the area casted by gito
he thinks that he needs to escape the
curtain and reach Gojo to let him know
about Shibuya however the only way to do
that would be defeating mojito first
knowing that he won't stand much of a
chance he still doesn't plan on holding
back and will use all 17 years 5 minutes
and 6 days with of cursed energy he's
accumulated to win he starts off by
sending an entire Year's worth of cursed
energy and to his ultimate mikamaru and
blasts mojito with its Ultra Cannon
destroyingly damn and sending Rubble
flying having dodged the initial blow
hater knows these types of attacks won't
be effective and dives into the water
using a two-year charge of cursed energy
kakichi blasts the entire lake with
Miracle Cannon but despite his best
efforts mojito leaps from the water to
ready a strike at him kikiji believes
mojito was overlooking his offense so
now it's time to put his secret plan
into action mojito extends his arm and
grabs onto mikamaru's head to accurately
deliver a curse energy infused punch
which vigorously shakes the cockpit
inside kokichi inserts a small tube into
one of these side panels and activates a
curse technique charge the tip of
mikamaru's finger splits open to reveal
a small cannon which then instantly
fires a spike projectile that stabs into
mojito as he's flying around initially
mojito doesn't see it as a threat but
suddenly his wing explodes leaving him
open to get smacked aside by mikamaru
Mato crashes through several trees
confused as to how his soul was
destroyed mikamaru then absolutely
pummels the ground forcing mojito to fly
away in retreat kikichi notices mahita
reshaping himself to hide his injuries
making him feel more confident that he
might win even ghetto acknowledges that
kahichi is skilled and his strategies
are working against mojito kakichi then
uses an insane five-year charge called
pigeon Viola to send five Cannons of
cursed energy shooting at HIS opponents
mojito shapeshifts and tries to avoid
the bames but he's taken by surprise
with makamaru crushes them from above
the curse narrowly avoids getting hurt
but makumaro follows up with another
strike that seems mojito flying back
into the trees again confident that
he'll be able to achieve his dreams
kokichi activates another curse
technique charge reshaping mikamaru's
middle finger into a spike however the
big bad wolf activates his domain
expansion the self-embodiment of
perfection which is just like hella clay
man honestly love the growth of Mojito's
character throughout the story dude
thinks he's like Perfection but he's the
absolute like opposite of everything he
thinks it's so good Idol Transfiguration
automatically hits and forces ultimate
mikamaru to collapse appearing to Signal
kokichi's demise confident in his
automatic win strategy mojito turns his
back to the giant cursed corpse and
States kokichi shouldn't put so much
faith into a strategy suddenly mikamaru
gets back up and stabs the spike on his
middle finger through Mojito's back it
is explained that the curse technique
tubes contain simple domains the domain
for the weak invented in the hean era
out of the four tubes that contained it
they first failed the second protectedly
cockpit from the domain and the third
appears to have finished mojito off for
good as his body seemingly explodes
after being stabbed mikamaru Roars and
turns his weapon towards ghetto ready to
use his remaining nine years to finish
him off however the cockpit abruptly
explodes from the impact of Mojito's
enlarged first horrified kikichi looks
through the broken window to see Mojitos
the ranged smile kahichi takes the last
technique tube and desperately rushes
towards mojito and in attempt to stab
him yet just as the tour about to touch
and skips away to recalling talking with
Kasumi about getting to know one another
better she made a promise to come see
him but sadly mojito is ensured that
that will never happen nikamaru
collapses for good with its Pilot's
blood dripping from the Titan's head
rest in peace mcamara obviously big Giga
loves this character and he like
literally wears the disguise in public
so I wonder if perhaps he found kikichi
to be an extremely human character who
to everyone else seemed bad but to you
know us readers we realized there was an
entire level to his thoughts that no one
else had even considered from the
beginning anyways after leaving ghetto
suggests to mojito that perhaps he was
cutting it a little too close but mojito
believes that it was all according to
plan ten days later we arrive at the
moment you have all been waiting for to
what is the absolute crumbly crop of
hands like oh my God I can't even right
now nothing in jjk even compares so far
to the absolute brutality that happens
next so yes finally on October the 31st
2018 the record of Shibuya incident
begins at 7 pm when a curtain is cast
with a 400 meter radius in the middle of
Shibuya City the rules of this cursing
are that non-sorcerers can enter the
curtain but they cannot exit trapping
themselves inside jujusu Sorcerers and
managers can move through it as they
please but the reception is blocked so
all communication has to be maintained
outside of the curtain over with our
favorite manager kyotaka ijichi he
informs an army team of this situation
outside the curtain in the shibuyu
station an army expresses that the
situation is quite a pain while Eno
tries to inform Mega me about the
curtain obviously migami already knows
like what occurred and everything is so
he just completely ignores him and anami
ends up asking ajichi where Gojo
currently is but meanwhile just outside
of the Shibuya City Business Center
nobody is found where the normally busy
intersection is something terrible must
have happened and everyone would have
spread out probably the edges of the
curtains there are asking the exact same
thing bring Saturday Gojo akari another
manager from Tech relays this
information to the Xenon team the old
dog mayobiso understands that the
non-sorcerers were told to say it
Sorcerers are free to move in and out of
the curtain so that makes it impossible
for them to break the barrier with Brute
Force the ideal strategy is to look for
and neutralize the cursed user who cast
the curtain however each team is on
standby for now because the higher-ups
decided that Gojo should work alone to
suppress the Shibuya incident as quickly
as possible inside the curtain the
civilians dressed in their Halloween
costumes or discussed this situation at
8 31 PM satsulu Gojo arrives inside of
the curtain and makes his way inside of
the Hikari Shin cues Shibuya shopping
mall he analyzes the situation and heads
straight down to basement floor 5 the
lowest level basement with his subway
trains operate at Ayo Yama Cemetery the
Maymay team awaits further instructions
Yuji is eager to help and may surmises
they'll be called in as backup shortly
wee-wee maymay's freaking weird younger
brother feels that she shouldn't be used
in such a way okay one sick I just need
to cut myself off here like I get it bro
your sister is absolutely banging and
stuff but it doesn't mean you need to go
like all in zesty but well anyway they
didn't get a message that another
curtain has appeared along with Gojo's
arrival because of this mei's team turns
and runs towards Meiji station back with
my dad saturu he descends into the Tokyo
Metro onto a specific platform of fail
to pronounce probably way too many damn
times to even bother trying to say again
where he's confronted by jogo Hanami and
choso satoro tells Joko to not have an
excuse for losing this time and Joker
replies that this stronger sorcerer
should have his first ever excuse ready
sick burn Joker Joker heading in with
the freaking sick burn hanami's Roots
block all possible excerpts but Gojo
claims he wasn't going anywhere anyway
everyone's standing on the outside Lanes
of the platform is certainly forced onto
the tracks surrounding the fort Jiu
Jitsu used with non-sorceries saturno
nonchalantly tells those around him to
stand out of his way if they don't want
to die he realizes they're blocking the
exits created a blind spot so we can't
break through just in case there are
people on the other side hitting for
Gojo jogo Burns through several
civilians and chosu attacks with slicing
exorcism both anami and jogo attacks
Arturo but are instantly stopped by his
Infinity they strengthen their curse
energy and activate domain amplification
forcing saturno to dodge he surmises
that they learned this technique from a
curse user as normal barriers are meant
to trap their targets in a box but
domain amplification metaphorically
surrounds the target with water like
curse energy with this method the
cursors can neutralize the Infinity for
those who are like obviously still
confused I just think of Kalua and as
like quick as reflexes when he
trains the uh like during that dark game
to get his like reflexes up with the
electricity and
down grab it as soon as things head to
the skin that's just kind of like what I
think domain amplification is like in my
head but I'm probably utterly wrong I
don't know someone let me know down
below prior to this should be incident
ghetto advisors his allies that Gojo is
best when he's working alone any
introducing Sorcerers and non-sorcerers
will only restrict his movements and
render him incapable of using his curse
techniques in this situation Saturday
would be forced on the defensive and
even his domain expansion would harm
people so he explains that the plan is
to miss around and force Gojo to think
of countermeasures for a period of time
until the prison realm is ready back in
the battle jogo snatches somebody's head
off and reminds Saturday the rules were
for him to not run away Saturday admits
he was surprised and Joker was pleased
to hear a possible excuse however Gojo
rejects this and removes his blindfold
revealing his six eyes then adding that
he's only surprised because These
Foolish curses believed they could use
their brain to defeat him looking at
Hanami he points him out and says days
that this is their third meeting and the
weed is getting cut first without fear
Saturday walks right up to jogo while
ignoring Hanami beside him they both
move to attack but Tatu accounts as
jogo's hand with his own body he avoids
an army strike and snaps jogo's arm
clean off then uses it to block an
Army's follower Patek and continues to
chase after jogo panami realizes satsudu
only made the threat earlier to confuse
them and not only that he also
deactivated his Limitless technique he
questions if Gojo plans to abandon
focusing on his technique and fight in
close quarters instead because of this
Hanami decides it's best to deactivate
his amplification and activate his
innate technique however this turns out
to be a fatal mistake as jogo turns back
to yell at Hanami Sato instantly grabs
the tree branches grown out of hanami's
eye sockets then forcibly pulls them out
completely from his skull seeing this
jogo runs away in fear shocked that
Saturday was still so strong while only
using cursed energy manipulation and
physical attacks Jose attempts to hit
Gojo with blood manipulation while
killing civilians along the way but it
stopped by Gojo's Infinity so that's
what it recognizes that choto is a death
painting and decides to ignore him for
now jogo and Hanami both attack him
again with domain amplification however
this time due to the now weakened Hanami
satook encounter by strengthening his
Infinity he turns and crushes Hanami
against a wall with his expanded
Limitless jogo attempts to divert his
attention by threatening civilians but
saturo doesn't hesitate to crush an army
completely annihilating the curse with
his Infinity turning him into nothing
but a mist of blood with an army
exercised Gojo turns back to meet the
despair joko's gaze and claims he's next
skipping away from the absolute
domination caught us laying down in
Shibu right now we find ourselves with
Yuji meimei and we we as they arrive at
Meiji xinji May station and that is the
last time I'm ever saying the full name
for that station where they are informed
that there are two barriers now
surrounding the station after being
informed about the situation may may use
the surability on some crows to
investigate the immediate area when she
finishes scouting she informs Yuji of
what she saw in the station Yuji asks if
mojito was down there but he may replies
that she didn't see him however he must
be in there since there are mutated
humans literally all over the place may
may even say so they will split up until
they each finish their respective tasks
at 903 PM as Yuji enters another
entrance he comes across a random bug
cursed Spirit who can talk and is
obviously somewhat strong Yeats this
thing is just like so damn relevant it
doesn't even get a name well it does
it's like grasshopper or kogai but still
you try finding a name that isn't just
grasshopper or some Japanese text that
translate to grasshopper it's that's all
that's out there I can't find anything
else Yuji asks the spirit if mojito was
here to which the bug says that he is
down below and that he is currently
protecting the barrier as Yuji wonders
if the bug creature had put up the
scream he notices an object and realizes
the curse Spirit was only guarding the
item that projects the screen the
grasshopper curse tells Yuji that
transfigured humans don't taste as good
as normal ones and that he knows this
because he's smart annoyed Yuji kicks
the curse into the wall he quickly
follows up while they punch to the grass
of his torso and states that the curse
needs to stop looking down on humans the
grasshopper says that Yuji isn't smart
and those who aren't smart die I
actually hate this grasshopper man he
asks what kind of curse Yuji thinks he
is and Yuji is able to pick up on the
obvious answer this makes the
grasshopper curse realize that Yuji is
actually smart like actual pug brain man
dude deserves to be in A Bug's Life not
jjk
[Music]
lower
hey hop go away that's fine then I won't
tell you my idea good the grasshopper
curse lunges at Yuji with his jumping
power and tries to Chomp down on him
Yuji avoids the attack while assessing
its strengths recognizing its ability to
communicate makes it a more powerful
curse It Gets behind Yuji and tries to
punch him but you can talk to his body
and continues to avoid getting hurt
the dumbass grasshopper asks if Yuji is
smart and his student reveals to it that
smart people don't generally ever brag
about being smart this genuinely shocks
the grasshopper curse who covers his
mouth from Surprise like dude I I can't
even right now bro like like being
serious I can't be serious with this
dude they then engage in close quarters
and trade blows the grasshopper believes
it has the advantage in a numbers battle
because it is two more arms however Yuji
easily overpowers and batters his
opponent with far superior skill the
grasshopper curse attempts to shoot
black mucus at Yuji but he Ducks under
and prepares to deliver an uppercut
however grasshoppers actually have an
expandable abdomen to lay eggs
underground and he juices this in an
attempt to strike Yuji with the extended
hard tip while he's low yuchi is fast
enough and knocks the appendage aside
before separating it completely will
they chop he then exercises these stupid
little grasshopper before breaking the
stake and undoing the curtain meanwhile
may make healthy transfigured humans on
the basement floor four it may decide
that they should stay and wait to
regroup with the Yuji before heading
down to the fifth level below them
mojito prepares to board the train from
Harajuku to Shibuya station he notices
that the grasshopper curse Was Defeated
and emits that it must have taken a
skilled sorcerer to do so mojito
expresses his disappointment having
desired to fight as well but knows what
he must do and sticks to the plan back
in the Pete town with our boy Gojo JoJo
frantically Huffs for ear as he runs
stumbling through the crowded platform
Sato follows close behind him with an
extremely dark and menacing presence our
brother choso lets jogo take all the
heat while quietly trying to hide in the
chaos among the civilians Joker tries to
push people in Saturday's way and strike
from behind but the infinity is able to
stop the person in mid-year as well as
jogo's punch choso nonchalantly shoots
three blood arrows from a good distance
down the platform the infinity stops him
and Saturday knows chose his location
but chooses to ignore him again honestly
think Gojo for oh he didn't just merge
choso first thing like he knew he knew
something was going on behind the scenes
anyway it's still worrying Joker
believes that 20 minutes should have
passed already down the line though
ghetto weights with the gone and states
that I need to get Gojo on edge more
before they make a move meanwhile at
Meiji station's fourth floor the Mame
team regroups and heads down one more
floor on their way down mamaka means
Yuji and States his strengths Yuji
replies by revealing that it wasn't
mojito on the second floor and that
wouldn't have been that easy if it was
carrying his sister's battle ax where he
certainly tells Yuji to graciously
accept his sister's compliment honestly
this of a kid needs to just leave
he's literally just a vehicle bro after
reaching the third floor they find a
civilian but his hit immediately
transfigures and he dies before he died
though he mentioned everyone was on the
train this makes Yuji realize that it's
headed straight for where Gojo is Becca
Hikari Shin Q's station so I thought it
was surprised to see that the train is
arriving some of the civilians attempt
to get on and flee but it's already
stuffed to the brim with transfigured
humans that started hacking as soon as
they are left loose Saturday watches in
horror while mojito hops out of the
train to greet jogo civilians run away
and fear as transfigured humans Rush
from the train indiscriminately
attacking everyone in sight Saturday
watches in horror and doesn't believe
whatling down the numbers of humans is
to his opponent's Advantage maido tries
attacking flying through the air swiping
at Gojo but he easily blocks it he then
figures out quickly that mojito is the
one that attacked Yuji in an army and
tries to attack him that mojito jumps
back out of the way the creepy boy then
comments about how he finds humans so
disgusting since there are so many of
them and as he says this people begin
pouring down into their floor from above
as Gojo figures they're the curse
Spirits have allies who are above
sending more people to their location
mejito uses idle Transfiguration
multiplicity body repel and choso in
combination uses his blood manipulation
convergence Supernova technique to
attack a crowded Gojo however Gojo
easily blocks them killing a bunch of
civilian and the process from behind
Joko appears launching at Gojo the
sorcerer manages to grab his arm but
Joker instantly save as the limb to get
away mojito and Joko think about the
current situation believing Gojo won't
use his technique as he doesn't want to
incur any more civilian casualties yet
obviously these negative IQ eggs are
absolutely shocked when Gojo goes golf
mode and activates his freaking domain
expansion start to lose All or Nothing
domain expansion of 0.2 seconds casts an
unlimited void over the platform the
time was an educated guess that assumed
non-sorcerers could only stay within the
domain for that long without suffering
permanent damage in that time half a
Year's worth of info flooded into
everyone's brains immobilizing them at
this level this special great cursors
could awaken at any moment taking it
into consideration Saturday focuses on
killing all of the transfigured humans
and in approximately 299 seconds 1 000
transfigured humans were annihilated
after the deactivation of the domain
Name by the hands of the strongest man
alive immediately after Saturday notices
a small box appear next to him on the
floor with the stage set for their plan
to succeed ghetto finally activates the
prison realm any flashback before the
battle is explained that the prison
realm is the final remains of the
Buddhist monk ginshin impact it is a
living barrier capable of sealing
anything even Gojo jogo inquires about
the conditions and go to reveals that
the target must stay within a 4 meter
radius for one minute annoyed at the
absurdity of this jogo threatens him
begin to assure Joko not to worry as his
version of one minute is slightly
different and they present ghetto orders
the prison realm to open the cursed
object breaks out of its Talisman seal
and expands into a psychoptic curse with
an eye in the center the eye meets sat
to those gaze and he instantly attempts
to flee however Gator reveals himself in
Greece saturno as if he had never even
died in the first place confused
memories of his best friend rushed
through Saturday's mind and he still
can't understand how ghetto could even
be alive he's sure he killed him himself
but his eyes tell him something else
when ghetto said one minute to jogo in
the past he Mint one minute worth of
time that processed within Saturday's
six eyes enhanced brain although it was
just a moment three years worth of
memories flooded in causing the prison
realm to instantly capture Gojo and
mobilizing him and shutting off all
access to his body's cursed energy
recognizing that he is lost he still
demands to know who gito is as Gojo
knows in his heart that suguru is dead
and that this man is a fraud the man
then removes these stitches and takes
off the top of his head revealing the
True Villain of the entire series I
think and that he is indeed capable of
switching bodies along with using dead
seed bodies possessed natural abilities
Saturday was still confident that Yuta
will step earn in its place however big
brain ghetto argues yutakotsu cannot
become the next Saturday Gojo he bids
farewell to satoru and tells him he will
release him into the new world after his
plan has succeeded so you know he will
come back eventually meanwhile down the
line team Maymay heads towards
Saturday's position suddenly ooji stops
and as you asks what's up he finds a
small makamaru like communication device
randomly on his ear asking if he can
hear his voice Yuji is quick to take it
off in attempts to break it but kokichi
quickly reveals that Saturday Gojo has
been sealed back at the station The
Imposter addresses Gojo and mockingly
bids him good night to which goju
replies by saying that it might be good
night for him but for him it's time to
wake up and ghetto's arm suddenly moves
up graving his own neck ghetto is even
stunned by this and tells mojito his
theory about the body and soul being
separate must be incorrect sasolo tells
them to get this over with and ghetto
agrees closing the gate and ceiling
started a Gojo at last meanwhile Maymay
doesn't believe kokichi but he provides
information around his own death saying
that he was killed by mojito on October
the 19th on October the 19th and that
this puppet is simply a contingency plan
there are only three of these puppets in
separate locations and one was given to
maymay's team because they are the least
likely to be the actual moles kogichi
warns them that there is a curse user
coming to attack them saying that they
are stronger than the Grasshopper And
likely around semi-grade one meimei
wants to ignore them and reach Gojo but
kakichi advises them to focus on taking
down the four barriers that have
appeared around Shibuya all the teams on
standby there have likely been caught
inside a curtain and are unable to use
cell phones this goes for managers as
well so kokichi tells Yuji to head back
to Meiji station and then go over to
Shibuya above ground from there kichi
asks meimei to defeat the curse user and
clear the path for Yuji to what she
agrees kirichi understands the Jiu Jitsu
world and Human Society it will be
absolutely ruined if Gojo disappears so
he asks them to put their lives on the
line to save him may may notes that
their enemies have arrived and this ugly
ass curse user abena appears for the
shikagami on a chain back at the Hikari
building choso and jogo finally awake
him from the estate after the unlimited
void suddenly the prison realm drops to
the ground out of ghetto's hand cracking
the floor inside saturu sits in an
unknown area surrounded by skeletons and
notices that time doesn't pass he admits
he missed up but believes everything
will be fine because he has faith in
everyone else teams kusakabe xenen and
an army will discuss the situation
outside the curtain timnanami agrees
amongst themselves that the most
concerning new development is the
appearance of another curtain trapping
Gojo and preventing Sorcerers from
entering it's already been almost an
hour since Gojo arrived in Shibuya so
from their perspective it's difficult to
understand why the enemy would wait
until now an army decides to head for
the curtain caster and asks Eno and
megame to do their best to rescue
civilians all three teams of Jiu Jitsu
Sorcerers then hid and to Shibuya at the
same time outside the perimeter of the
curtain ajichi talks on the phone with
the other manager akari he asked her to
confirm the situation inside the curtain
and get back out as quickly as possible
ajichi plans to get everyone off duty
involved but before he can do that he
suddenly stared from behind by the
freaking creep haruta shigumo pulls his
sword from ajichi's gut and watches him
fall onto the ground from behind a
mysterious monk orders him to continue
targeting the people in suits around the
curtin's perimeter then hid inside after
back in Shibuya station big brain Guido
explains that the prison realm requires
time to process Gojo before it can be
moved mojito suddenly notices one of
mikamaru's communication devices on the
roof nearby and destroys it kakushi
immediately relays the information about
the Enemy being unable to move Gojo to
Yuji he says that it's best to move in
on the Shibuya station from the
surrounding subways and once all the
curtains preventing its sorceress from
reaching Gojo are down they can then
take the station simultaneously Yuji
runs into the curtain trapping civilians
and using his blinding speed and curse
energy he clears out the group of
transfigured humans to help rescue the
civilians Yuji keeps up the momentum and
then climbs a large building with ease
before yelling out in an army yuji's
scream Echoes throughout Shibuya
reaching in an army team UT continues
yelling revealing that Gojo Sensei was
sealed tinkusakave hears this as well
and a new shocks tsunami to the point he
immediately changes plans Mega me is
also surprised to hear that his minta
has been sealed and an army says that if
it is true then all humans in Japan are
surely doomed ghetto gets mojito Joko
Dagon and choso into a group and informs
them of his next move he'll remain here
to protect the prison realm and ask the
cursed users on how they plan on dealing
with all of these Sorcerers hidden their
way chosu simply wants to avenge his
brothers by killing Yuji and nobara to
which jogo says that you is off limit
for being zakuna's vessel but choso
simply doesn't care mojito tells Joko to
calm down and playfully reveals that he
wants to kill Yuji too after seeing Gojo
in person Heidi was confident that their
side already holds a solid advantage
over the sorcerers and that they can win
without sakuna's help he expresses his
unusually messed up smirk and instead
suggests that they all try to kill Yuji
annoyed Dogo asks if mojito is being
serious and he replies that he is for
Real jogo knows that sakuna isn't the
Ally and could cause them all to suffer
but the era of curses will still surely
come regardless he believes curses do
not fear death and can walk their paths
sincerely to achieve their goals mojito
argues that even if a curse spirit is
constant along that path they still live
according to their desires he
acknowledges that Reviving sakuna is a
legitimate strategy but mojito doesn't
want to fight jogo over it instead
mojito turns it into a game if he
encounters Yuji first he'll kill him and
if jogo finds him first he can use the
fingers to restore sakuna's power chosu
adds that if he finds Yuji he will try
to kill him as well this annoys jogo the
Mojito is excited to see that choso
wants to play too Giro decides to pass
on the game and stay behind with the
prison realm choco interrupts and argues
that it's the safest and smartest
strategy for them all to remain in place
with ghetto and wait for Yuji and all
the remaining Sorcerers to come to them
however mojito choso and even Dagon run
off once the game starts determined to
not let them find Yuji first jogo runs
off as well and inadvertently decides to
take part instantly after ghetto notices
mimiko and nanako watching him and says
that he curses are smarter than them
they state that they helped with killing
monkeys and demand suguru kito's body
back as promised they don't want the
Imposter using their beloved Master's
body any longer it'll refuse us though
and tells the girls that they should
make a binding vowel whenever dealing
with a sorcerer he tells them to leave
unless they want to be killed by their
Master's body just freaking insanely
they disappear into the crowd and claim
he'll live to regret this but the
Imposter responds with a claim that it's
been so long that he's forgotten what
regret even feels like just a pretty
badass thing to say meanwhile Yuji
stands on top of a building in Shibuya
and continues yelling for an army after
an Army's team find him Yuji and
mikamaru bring them completely up to
speed as far as the situation revolving
around Gojo nanami agrees coordinating
an attack from the adjacent stations
makes sense for a battle plan but in
order for that to work they must lift
the curtain first the Nami asks Eno to
take the first years and lower the
curtain prohibiting the sorcerers from
entering the station whereas he's going
to hit outside the curtain and meet up
with a GG additionally Nami wants Eno to
pass along any information to the other
teams if he encounters them after the
grade 1 sorcerer leaves ain't no D
breaks Mega me and Yuji so they
understand the severity of failure in
this situation if Saturday Gojo
disappears The Gojo family falls out of
power and anyone like Yuji who was being
detected will be targeted by the issu
higher-ups sorcerers in the community
will fight for political power and while
they're doing that all the curses and
curse users that were held back by
Gojo's prisons will attack this means if
they're due to high Sorcerers fail here
in Shibuya the age of humanity will
surely be over in Japan meanwhile on top
of the Shibuya Tower three curse users
watch over the commission curtains
they're excited to hear that Gojo has
been sealed the old man wonders how this
will affect Japan to which ogami replies
that nothing will change as curse users
will curse and the cursed will die Yuji
tries to break through the curtain
preventing the sorcerers from entering
but the attack is ineffective and the
barrier doesn't even budge Eno is
impressed with yuji's striking power but
this just means that the curtain is
incredibly sturdy as migami's Divine dog
totality kills transfigured humans in
the background to save civilians He
suggests that they try and find a weak
point in the curtain Eno argues that
there is no weak point since they can't
get inside he believes that the curtains
cast is within the curtain but Yuji
explains how couldn't's worked at Meiji
station by staying outside the curtain
the risk of being seen increases and in
return the curtain strength does as well
hearing this making me surmises that the
curtin's projectors are probably
somewhere extremely obvious at 1001 pm
on top of Shibuya Tower Giro or Gyro I
don't know how to say his name exactly
awasaka looks down on the city and asks
if this is the most obvious spot to
strengthen the curtain ogami's grandson
agrees but notes that they will have to
kill the cursors inside the building
before getting to them however they both
taken off guard when Norway suddenly
appears flying above them as Norway goes
in One Direction Yuji goes on the other
then using a wire he wraps up all of the
curse users at once ogami's grandson
helps her get out of Harm's Way but
awakasa is swept clean off of the
building takuma takes his chance to
break one of the curse tools that is
putting up the screen but also realizes
that one of the enemies has taken the
other two curse tools with him
preventing him from continuing Yuji
further wraps up awasaka in a wire and
drags him downward at a faster velocity
Yuji snaps the wire and Dives inside the
building while yelling out for Mega me
to deactivate Norway while dropping
awasaka over 40 stories towards the
ground below back at the top of the
tower facing off with ogami and her
grandson Eno says that it's time for him
to start Paving his way to becoming a
grade one Jujutsu sorcerer and
passionately lowers his mask over his
face back below Mega me flares up his
cursed energy and demands that the old
man gets up awasaka stops playing dead
and smiles at his opponents nigami
reminds Yuji that they don't have time
to waste and he agrees on top of the
shibuyu tower cursed energy flows from
inu's body as he activates his innate
technique auspicious Beast summon Eno
possesses a seance curse technique that
allows him to become a spiritual medium
by hiding his face in doing so he can
summon and use the abilities of four
auspicious beasts first Eno summons
kaichi and shoots a horn-like projectile
with homine missile capabilities at the
two however okami's grandson puts his
body on the line to protect her Anu
thinks that he wants to rape up this
fight as quickly as possible and get
back to the first years because in an
army entrusted him with looking after
them he tells himself to understand the
facts and control the self in order to
eliminate one's a ego meanwhile Eugene
migami fight alongside the Divine dog
totality against awasaka their boys
don't find fighting the enemy difficult
but working together to be the hard part
of this battle they appear to be
overwhelming the old man but he remains
completely unscathed despite all of the
efforts he slices at Yuji with a knife
but gets caught in the Toad's tongue and
flung into the bridge structure above
him however he still isn't hurt annoyed
Megami points out that they weren't
meant to be wasting time back at the top
of the tower ogami's grandson defends
the old witch from takuma's barrage of
attacks while she continues chiming
behind him as ugami finishes her
grandson swallows something and starts
to transform into the literal civilian
demon the destroyer of freaking worlds
Daddy
though in typical Japanese mangaka
Cliffhanger style like I can already say
in this being the point in episode ends
on it skips away Back to December the
7th 1989 the day Saturday Gojo was born
in the past curse users were free and
used their techniques to kill others for
money however little changed that day
with his presence in the world the
balance of the Jujutsu Community was
completely altered the curse users were
stripped of their freedom and that
feeling of dissatisfaction has stuck
with owasaka and ogami ever since in the
present day awasaka continues fighting
with Yuji and migami he uses his Lust
For revenge on Gojo to fuel his anger in
battle and beats back the two First
Years the surprises these students as
they don't understand how he's
nullifying all of their damage they can
be figures out that it might be related
to his innate technique and decides to
yell out a bold-faced lie he says that
Gojo is in Shibuya Yuji is confused but
this helps Megan confirmed that the
cursed users technique isn't something
like damage nullification they could
counter Gojo's Limitless technique
ourasaka claims that he's ready to
finish their battle and make him a
response by unleashing his new rabbit
escape shikagami this creates a wave of
countless small rabbits that are
supposed to serve as a distraction
however abasaka has a random reaction to
them as is hit way harder than he should
have been the skits migumi's attention
and he immediately tells Yuji revealing
that he's figured out the enemy's curse
technique
confused takumaino looks across the roof
of the shibuyu Tower edogami and her
grandson who was shaped shifted into
toji for shiguro Eno figures out that
the old woman is a necromancer and he
can tell with just one look that toji is
ridiculously strong the Jujutsu sorcerer
attempts to summon his auspicious Beast
Ryu but toji rips off his mask before
Eno even knows what's happening he then
lands a powerful right hook on the
sorcerer's jaw followed up by grabbing
Anna's collar and pummeling his face
with a flurry of Rapid Fire punches down
below awasaka realizes the purpose of
megami's rabbits as more of a diversion
than an actual attack he wonders if the
Jews who hire students try to hit him
with a lethal Blow from behind with the
rabbit when suddenly the curses are
deactivated amigami's Max elephant falls
from the sky with him on top of Earth
awasaka manages to resist the impact and
the shukigami is deactivated just as
quickly as it appeared this annoys the
old man who demands mikami to man up and
fight him directly mikumi replies that
that's more of his boy's style and right
on cue Yuki Hills a freaking car at
Osaka the curse user is able to nullify
the blow though but it's still Blown
Away by yuji's pure strength migme think
it's awasaka's attention while Yuji
prepares a full power swing iosaka
believes he can easily anticipate yuji's
punch and make him his attack at the
same time as this curse technique and
verse makes strong attacks weak and weak
attack strong he believes the heart of
his opponents fight the easier he wins
this revealed though that our boys had
already figured out their opponents in a
technique and mega me surmises that the
inverse technique must have a maximum
and minimum limit as the cursed user is
reinforcing his body with curse energy
on top of it Yuji understood and
suggested that they attack with a strong
and weak attack at the same time migami
agrees stating that they just need to
keep the pressure on and prevent him
from realizing that they've figured it
out in the present exchange of blows
Yuji makes contact and his punch is
instantly nullified but a simple poke
from igamist Toad's tongue is enough to
do serious damage I would say I could
post blood from his mouth and before he
even has a chance to recover the guys
resumed their bait down injured for the
first time in this battle awasaka
refuses to lose and forces the boys back
demanding the kids don't get cocky
suddenly Yuji Gets behind the old man
and throws another powerful punch
abusaka turns around to counter it but
Yuji stops just before he adjusts his
strike throne and now weaker punch which
our suckers and verse makes extremely
powerful knocking him completely out
impressed by this Mega me tells Yuji
that he can pull off some pretty dope
ass moves with Osaka defeated Yuji and
migami break the two commission curtains
he was holding deactivating the curd and
preventing Sorcerers from entering
Shibuya station asmigami thinks about
interrogating the old man for some
answers Eno is suddenly thrown from the
top of Shibuya Tower migami notices in
time to summon Norway to rescue him from
falling to his death Yuji catches Eno
and is horrified by the shape he's in
above them and toji fushiguro's form
ogami's grandson comments that the
curtain is down and asked what they
should do now oh get me asks him to go
down and keep killing sorceries however
toji's personality tears its way through
taking over the body of the grandson and
telling the old hag to not give him
orders worried origami jumps back not
understanding how this happened as she
only meant to summon the body's
information and not be sold poji doesn't
even know what's happening either but he
figures his Heavenly restricted body
overtook the host's soul ogami doesn't
believe this to be possible yet to her
dismay toji decides to follow her orders
starting off by killing the old hag
first Gucci wants to go back up the
tower and avenge Eno that Megan reveals
that he's not dead and asks Yuji to
focus on rescuing Gojo while Yuji heads
to the station migami agrees to take
care of Eno the latter doesn't like the
idea of being alone in Shibuya but Yuji
is confident in having mikamaru with him
which is you know like pretty funny when
you think about it because the dude's
just the damn earpiece and like bro
ain't helping with any of the hands
meanwhile the Nami is left horrified as
he finds ajichi unconscious and bleeding
out at Shibuya station at the same time
between the stations may may easily
overwhelms the curse user abena in close
combat with her battle ax old kidio sits
on top of a Banner's defeated cursed
Spirit as meimei explains how her innate
technique Works May May grow up
believing her black bird manipulation
was a weak technique so she focused on
being effective without it Ebina begs
for her forgiveness and asks to leave
but we tells him to be quiet while his
sister is speaking memo explains that
reinforcing one's body with curse energy
can only take a sorcerer so far
realizing this meimei was initially
devastated but the realization allowed
her to go back and master her innate
technique making meimei until the
blossoming grade one sorcerer she is
today we weirdly claps and makes a
clap for his sister as well Mammy
asks her brother why person's life value
is proportional too to what she says
that life's value is in proportion to
how useful they are to meimei I love
Maymay bro but like I couldn't imagine
how cringe this would be in real life
since the little kids say that shirt she
then asks Sabina her service potential
and he's unable to answer Mammy believes
the fact that he can't answer as a curse
user and a murderer is the reason that
he lost she crushes his head with her ax
and reveals surface potential is life
itself for her we tells her sister that
the curtain has been taken down and
MayMay gets excited at the prospect of
Gojo owing her big time ghetto watches
her movements from the Shibuya station
and is impressed she won so quickly
meanwhile on Shoto bun kamaru bunkumora
street I'm not saying that one again the
creep user shigimo encounters a rata and
nobara in the middle of the road Novara
tells Anita to stay behind her and steps
up to face the curse user alone after
slaying so many male managers shigimo is
excited to finally find some girls to
play with which if her remember
correctly is like the exact same thing
he said at the end of the Goodwill art
the dude is just like a degenerate
person personified returning from taking
ajichi to safety nanami tells himself
that he never has or never will be
frustrated by his own uselessness he
feels that he's just living in the face
of all of the evils and the world he
thinks about his Fallen homies and
mutters allowed how dare they meanwhile
visiting fight against the transfigured
humans inside of Shibuya akari Nita
notifies them that it sounds like a
jichi was attacked while they were on
the phone Maki tells nabara and a curry
to go check on ajichi while she stays
with the old man while on the way nobara
and akari are confronted by the curse
user shigimo Navara believes that
shigimo is the one who attacked ajichi
and she asks Anita to pretend to hide in
these Subway entrance while escaping
through to another shigimo interrupts
the whisperings by throwing his sword at
Navarro but she deflects it with her
hammer and charges at him confident that
he's a mid-range fighter suddenly
shigimo figures out that akari is not
actually hiding as akari runs through
the station she passes by shigumo's hand
sword hanging off a wall this leads
chigamo right to her location where he
runs up to her and delivers a
soccer-styled kick straight to the
manager's chest I've sitting nobara and
injuring akari Navara tries to stop him
but the sword suddenly falls into
shigumo's hand allowing him to slash
nabari's leg leaving a shallow card the
cut distracts navara's attention
allowing shugimo to attack her upper
body with a sword Landing a fierce right
hook to her jaw completely dazing our
girl nabara loses her balance and Falls
onto her knees she can't believe how
perfectly her opponent keeps Landing
shots Shigeru asks Novara as she's
concussed kneeling over to talk to her
in a taunting manner he claims that
she's gotten a lot stronger since they
last met but it doesn't matter in the
face of his uncanny cursed technique
nabira tries to buy Time by asking
shigimo about his motivations however he
doesn't have any convictions and kills
simply because it's fun for him he cuts
akari while she's on the ground angering
nobara she tells him to stop and he
replies mockingly by asking her to make
him stop nabara stumbles back to her
feet determined to save akari and
Justice shigimo prepares to finish her
off they both detect an extremely
powerful presence now Army the big man
himself walks into this substation and
immediately glares at the curse user
while they're very less than happy
expression on his face shigumo notices
nanami's attire and wonders if he's
supposed to kill non-black suits too by
the way like you were about to witness
the strength of a pure nine to five
working man while shikimo wonders if he
can kill non-black suits nobara
recognizes nanami as the leader of
migami's Team the curse user tells the
newcomer to read the room as nanami
wraps his necktie around his fist and
walks towards him shigumo tries to show
that he has a hostage but akara had
crawled up the escalator while he was
distracted while he expresses that he
said that she got away nanami appears
directly behind him he asks gigamo how
many curse users there are and where
they are located shigama turns around to
quickly slash in an army and his
shoulder claiming he doesn't know he
tries to follow up with a Kirk but it
feels like he's hitting a stone wall the
Nami doesn't budge an inch and he's not
cut at all either surprisingly assailant
now hate this question asking where and
how many enemies there are shigumo is
about to claim that he doesn't know
again but nanami uses his ratio
technique to create a weak point in the
opponent's body and backhands the mofo
sending him flying across the entire
room like dude actually got dad handled
so good shigumo bleeds profusely from
his face as his legs shake and he's
barely able to stand he believes he
should have died and critics his curse
technique for saving his life he wants
to run but an army grabs his hair and
repeats his question once again before
shigimo can even answer an army delivers
a ferocious body shot that slams shigimo
into the wall behind him shattering it
upon impact whether his life and very
imminent danger the curse user calls his
curse tool to rescue him and flies
through the air in an attempt to slash
an army from behind but no Byron Nails
it to the wall shigumo tells her to stay
out of it but nanami interrupts and
grabs him by the throat instead of
replacing the question again the Nami
reveals he found several dead managers
on his way here he lifts his fist and
charges it with cursed energy asking a
shiggy moat is responsible terrified the
helpless piece of trash apologizes but
it's too late as Daddy hits him with his
curse technique smashing the boy's face
leaving him in an unconscious bloody
Heap nobara is Amazed by an Army's
strength noting that he is exactly the
model of what it means to be a true
grade one Jiu Jitsu sorcerer he walks
away from the defeated child and tells
Novara for the need to find akari
meanwhile Yuji dashes through the humans
getting massacred all throughout the
streets he wants to help but there isn't
enough time to save everyone in this
massive crowd either however did she
hears a familiar voice that might be
able to save the day Toge and yumaki my
favorite Mew arrives with a megaphone in
hand and immediately speaks to the
entire crowd commanding everyone to not
move shortly after helping Toge rescue
the civilians Yuji enters Shibuya
station at around 10 10 pm unbeknownst
to Yuji choso Waits inside the station
to confront his brother's killer back
with nunami he Nails over as he speaks
with Novara and akari who reveals that
the jichi will be okay but tells the
girls to not forget that ajichi
originally trained to be a sorcerer
instead of a manager so her ghost built
kind of different you know Novara and
akari also learn about Gojo's situation
something they didn't hear about as they
were indoors during yuji's yelling the
Nami asks them to wait for rescue while
he joins the Xena team and heads for
Shabu station nobara wants to go but
nanami insists that the coming battle
requires grade 1 and above Sorcerers
anyone else would simply be in their way
meanwhile underground meimei comes face
to face with ghetto she's surprised to
see him but quickly dismisses the idea
that he could be alive Geto tries to act
friendly but meimei hasn't forgotten
about a geta replies that he
feels sorry that he has to kill a former
friend and summons the special gray
disease curse this smallpox deity to do
it for him instead Maymay is surprised
to see him use curse manipulation but
still doesn't doubt her conclusion about
him for a moment getter reveals that he
doesn't have many curses left after the
attack on Jujutsu Tech in the previous
year but the ones he does still possess
are ones of pristine quality he leaves
the area telling May that if she can
exercise these smallpox deity then he'll
be her next opponent the disease curse
immediately activates its domain
expansion trapping meimei inside a
coffin the cursed chance grave causing a
large gravestone to fall from the sky
onto the coffin the curse then begins to
count but maybe breaks out before it
ends wee wee initially watches in horror
but is excited to see his sister survive
meme is impressed stating that it's been
longer than she can remember since her
life had been in danger for even a
moment at the entrance to Shibuya uji
runs inside and immediately finds choso
who recognizes him as his brother's
Killers he activates his blood
manipulation convergence then uses the
secret technique of blood manipulation
called piercing blood the ability shoots
a condensed cursed energy reinforced
Arrow extremely fast at Yuji Yuji is
able to block it but the attack is so
far boss and nearly Paces completely
through his left arm Yuji tries to close
the distance right after the attack is
done and hits him with his Divergent
first chosu blocks the hit but is left
confused by The Double Impact as the
fight comes to a pause choto asks Yuji
if his younger brothers left him with
any final words choto clarifies that he
means the two people Yuji killed and
this student laments about what happened
with a sad expression on his face he
says that they didn't really have any
last words but they cried before they
died chosa was initially shocked but has
then quickly overcome with rage causing
the bloodline going horizontally across
his nose to bubble and distort in shape
chosu asks ESO and kichisu to watch over
him as blood behind him forms an
intimidating face shaped by his malice
he tells his younger brother to take a
good look at their older brother as he
prepares to kill Yuji meanwhile inside
these smallpox deities domain expansion
manime is momentarily trapped
underground beneath one of the disease
curses gravestones the curse spirit
counts down from three again but maybe
breaks out of the trap in time having
experienced this a few times now in the
fight meme understands the process of
the technique first the target of the
domain is trapped inside a coffin and
then buried underground when you're hurt
by the weight of the large gravestone
lastly the curse counts down from three
and the target is infected with these
smallpox disease the curse hits May's
coffin with another gravestone but this
time she immediately cuts her way out
she believes this part of the process is
the most annoying and fears she won't be
able to fight ghetto freely if she's
heading in may also deduces that the
domain can only target one person at a
time and advises a counter-attack
centered around that because
instinctively targets the person with a
stronger cursed energy and only a single
Crow was caught inside the domain so
moment needs the disease curse to focus
on her brother before she can utilize
the birds she asks her little brother if
he's willing to die for her and in his
typical simp fashion he agrees to do
anything for her memory flees off to the
side while you you flares up his curse
energy the disease curse notices the
swelling energy and traps weary inside
of a coffin a single hit by the
gravestone would be enough to kill him
but as the cursed chance maime suddenly
slices off its hand with her ax the
grade one sorcerer tells the disease
curse that her brother's role is more of
that than just a pack mule you know I
highly doubt but he then proves this by
activating his new Shadow style simple
domain to protect himself when Maymay
asked if he was willing to die he
realized that this meant he was actually
allowed to fight meme says that his role
is to counter domains as she doesn't
like to be indebted to anyone the
special great cursed disease heals its
hand quickly and reaches out to attack
meimei when suddenly the single bird
flies to the back of the cursed Spirit
piercing and exercising it in a single
blow while the kursper is dying Mammy
asks the quickest way to raise one's
strength as a sorcerer and her brother
replies that it will be a binding vowel
with one's life as the trade-off for
more power momi's extension technique
bird strike exceeds the limits of the
Crow's cursed energy by forcing it to
commit suicide with a kamikaze-like
attack no one other than Saturday Gojo
has ever survived the devastating attack
with them defeated may may declares it's
time for the main act she calls a flock
of crows to her side that filled the
underground Subway and asks if they're
ready to die for her from these Shadows
big brain ghetto comes to confront her
admitting that she's not bad for a
Jujutsu Sorcerer of this era Back In the
Heat of battle against Yuji chozo uses
blood manipulation to control the blood
outside of his body and shoot his
piercing blood attack at ug quickly
realizes it's too fast and his chances
of avoiding it are only about 50 Yuji
instead decides to dictate the timing of
his opponent's next attack by jumping
off the ground the successfully baits
choso who willingly fires pissing blood
again at yuji's head just before he hits
the ground however Yugi drops his upper
body's weight all the way down close to
the ground at the very moment his feet
touch it quickly avoiding the Bane he
then immediately rushes towards choso
and attempts to close the the distance
between them chozuk means Yuji and bends
the beam down to try and hit him Yuji
though is from the land of weaving
weaving and is able to dodge it then
engages choso at close range he wants to
turn the exchange into a fist fight but
there's still a few floating balls of
condensed blood around them chosu
activates Supernova detonating all of
the condensed blood in every direction
like a buck shot severely injuring
yuji's back big brochozo follows up by
using blood Edge to stab Judy's foot
with a dagger made of blood however Yuji
surprisingly fights back with a stabbed
foot and kicks him away then using his
athletic abilities flip around choto's
guard he lands a heavy ax Kirk Yuji
realizes that there aren't any more orbs
of blood and focuses on stopping him
from making any more his caught off
guard though winchoso assumes the starts
for shooting pissing blood juji stops
running towards his opponent falling for
chosos faint chose within takes the
offensive casting flawing red scale on
himself and delivering several
successive blows to Yuji after smashing
him up against the wall choco uses
convergence and piercing blood to try
and finish him off however our goat
somehow has the skin of a freaking Rhino
and survives choto though admits the
blood wasn't condensed enough to kill
him still heavily injured Yuji starts to
realize he can't win when randomly once
again mikamaru starts speaking asking
what's going on she replies with his own
question asking we mikamaru has been
this whole time but he claims that he's
conserving energy because there's
something he still needs to do choso
watches confused while mikamaru
recognizes the death painting and tells
Yuji that choso is using blood
manipulation which is like pretty
obvious he says the inherited technique
is prized within the kamo family for its
overall balance and combat Yuji doesn't
find this info helpful as he just
narrowly Dodges another shot of piercing
blood mikhudmaru advises him to retreat
to the bathroom revealing that he has an
idea Yuji darts into a small hallway
surprising choso the death painting
believes that Yuji will hit a dead end
and skew It Up by piercing blood however
chosu runs into the bathroom where he
finds mikamaru's communication puppet on
the opposite wall chozo uses piercing
blood to destroy the puppet but water
certainly bursts out of every opening
Yuji heals hiding in the store behind
joso attacks him choto slides back after
blocking and believes that that was
yuji's last chance before death he
prepares to use the condensed blood
floating around him to finish the fights
but the water splashing around the room
abruptly dispels convergence chosu
doesn't quite understand what's happened
and honestly it kind of took me a little
while to probably get it as well but he
decides to use flowing red scale stack
either way focusing on controlling all
of the blood within his own body to
fight instead he doesn't get the logic
behind it either but he does understand
that they are fighting where he's
comfortable now in close quarters they
engage in a quick exchange of blows with
Yuji getting in the upper hand however
just as Yuji gets the advantage choso
used his enhanced strength to flick a
small blood meteorite straight into
Judy's liver Yuji is taken off guard
because he thought chozo was out of
projectiles thanks the mikamari's water
trick but immediately he recognizes he's
been hurt in an internal organ and
considers the thought of losing and even
dying however he Stomps on the damn
ground and regains his footing this is
like honestly our boys time freaking
shine right here Yuji converts his fear
and to curse energy and clears his mind
of all distractions getting ready to
truly die if that's what it takes to
bring down choso at the same time chosu
laments about how Yuji has only landed
three significant strikes yet he is
moderately injured from them he knows
using another surprise attack with blood
meteorite won't work so he improvises
and hardens his entire Fist and much of
his forearm using the blood inside of
his body by doing this chosa was
actually at risk of spontaneously
developing thrombosis but he determines
that Yuji is more of a severe Threat by
the way thrombosis occurs when blood
clots block veins and arteries which can
like result in death because it can't
flow properly around the body I'm pretty
sure Yuji and choso exchange blows once
again but Yuji is able to predict his
opponent's movements at close range he
avoids a punch and a sweeping kick
before hiding in a bathroom door and
locking it this confuses choso but Yuji
suddenly burst through the door and drop
kicks him in the face chosu narrowly
blocks with his heart in hand but Yuji
locks his leg around his opponent's head
and throws him with a fly and says they
take down while choso is staggered Yuji
closes these distance and flashes his
right hand as a decoy to land a hard
left blow to the body however something
just doesn't feel right to Yuji and
chosu abruptly cracks his collarbone
with a violent Hammer fist to the
shoulder this creates a gaping Dent
where yuji's shoulder should be leaving
him vulnerable to choto's next attack
the death painting finishes the fight
with a crushing blow to yuji's stomach
that scenes him across the room crash
him into a wall choto lifts his robe and
reveals that he had hardened part of his
body Yuji attacked seeing this Yuji
Falls unconscious still barely breathing
chosu wants to finish him off and before
doing so tells Jutsu sorcerer to ask his
brothers for forgiveness on the other
side however something freaking mental
suddenly stops choso like I'm Gonna
Leave You all freaking confused until
probably the next Jiu Jitsu kazm
explained video where I go over the next
heart this like moment is freaking huge
at that moment a memory was born inside
of choso's brain a memory of a past
event that never happened sukuna watches
this from his innate domain disappointed
with yuji's performance he calls his
student worthless and can't believe he
lost to such an inferior opponent
suddenly chosu's head begins to throb
and he stumbles away from Yuji abruptly
stricken with a headache he recalls
eating peacefully at a picnic table with
all of his brothers somehow including
our boy Eugene they were both eating
together with ESO and kachizu as well as
all of the other six brothers who were
still sealed Yugi even passed them some
food and called choso his big brojo so
yeah obviously I joked about big bro
choso but maybe I wasn't at the end of
the day maybe big bro Toto and choso as
a thing who knows when the memory ends
troso bends over forward as Swift drops
profusely off of his face he doesn't
understand what's going on and asks
himself why Yuji was a part of that
recollection as chozo stumbles away
confused mimiko and Hanukkah appear to
feed one of sakuna's fingers to the
unconscious ug yo it's time it's time
head team 20 p.m nanami and these
Innings head towards basement floor five
nanami informs him about Gojo's ceiling
and ghetto's involvement naobita
mentions he wouldn't mind the decline of
the Gojo family prompting Maki to tell
him to leave if he's not going to help
the head of the Xenon family believes
Maki as the one who should go home
nanami actually even agrees with naobito
having Left nabara Behind due to the
danger of this Mission Maki though
believes she's more useful than her
drunken grandfather irritated by hearing
this nanami asks naobito if he's been
drinking and he sorcerer claims he's
done nothing of the sword as they reach
the lower floors of this station nanami
thinks maybe he should have gone alone
Maki notices something while he running
through and an army sees it as well an
octopus type curse hiding behind one of
the pillars in the open area the Nami
draws his sword and prepares to exercise
him when suddenly naobito appears behind
the curse he traps the premature Dagon
in a frame using his curse technique and
while immobilized he lands a heavy
strike that since the cuts flying across
the Rome the impact civilly injures the
cursed womb causing him to vomit up
skeletal remains of the non-sorcerer
humans he ate earlier writhing in pain
Dagon calls out to his allies including
Hanami however after realizing Hanami is
dead it enrages him and forces an
evolution Dagon leaves his cursed wound
behind and evolves into a much larger
and fishier form as he generates a
sphere of water on the tub of his finger
naobito appears for the incoming attack
and togon unleashes a furious current
that floods the entire area Maki stabs
his spear into one of the pillars and
stands on top of it to avoid the water
she's shocked by the pure volume of the
water the curse spirit is outputting
however much of the water that comes
near beat his way is trapped within the
frames made by his cursed technique
neobitsu asked the curseberg if he knows
how many frames there are an animated
sequence waldegon is distracted by the
old man the Nami gets above him and
Strikes using his ratio technique Dagon
appears to block it but he's abruptly
sync crashing into the ground nanami
attempts to follow up with an attack of
her own butagon grabs the blade of a
cursed hole before he counter-attacks
naobuto traps him inside a frame though
and an army Dives down to strike the
cursed spirit yet Dagon is able to
protect himself by generating a whirling
Shield of water that circles around him
Marky laments being saved by naobito
humiliated by the fact she would have
died if he hadn't stopped a gun earlier
the old man playfully slaps to go on
Shield of water and commends him for
being able to pull off multiple
simultaneous curse techniques he
recognizes Dagon has massive amounts of
cursed energy and likely more techniques
up his sleeve in order to counter
neobito leads the way and claims they'll
all crush him with speed before he can
activate any more moves now be so nanami
and Mahi all started taking dagon's
Water Shield as fast as they can in
Rapid succession each of them gradually
begins to Pierce into it until naobito's
first breaks through completely before
he's hurt Dagon causes the water to
explode as a distraction and levitates
above Machi and an army however naobito
suddenly appears behind to gone saying
who foresaw the curse attempting to flee
up high he kicks the gun onto the ground
and follows up with a barrage of brutal
blows that overwhelms the curse Dagon
admits that the old man is the main
problem in the sujitsu battle that is
even faster than Joe go he then attempts
to form his fingers together to create a
hand sign but naobito unleashes a flurry
of punches that pounded gone into the
ground despite naobito's best efforts
though an uncanny seal forms undergone's
stomach area allowing him to cast his
domain expansion Horizon of the
captivating skanda inside this Coastal
type domain an army and Marquee are both
suddenly bitten by piranha kagami the
domains guaranteed hurt creates first
shukigami that don't even exist until
they hit the target which is honestly
like just cracked nobody so though is
easily able to counter the domains can't
miss attack when the secret art falling
Blossom emotion degon figures that the
head of the Xenon family had some kind
of trick up a sleeve considering his
skull level because of this he decides
to focus 70 of his power on naobito and
the other 30 on an army your man
obviously just completely forgot about
Marquee he unleashes his death Swan
technique calling upon a swarm of
shikagamu to attack his foes knowing
that shikagami will instantly eat them
alive he warns Maki to attack without
hesitation his warning is interrupted
though when the sugigami abruptly appear
to devour him first no better manages to
resist the wave of shukigami using
Fallen Blossom emotion but still
recognizes the situation does not favor
him he notices that the force of the
shukigami isn't slowing down at all and
wonders about the technique connected to
the domain his thoughts are abruptly
stopped though when they gone hides in
the Stream of shukigami and punches
naobito High into the ear as he
continues to get attacked now in the ear
the gun reveals death swarm as an
endless stream of shikigami that will
never stop Dagon turns to Maki and says
that she's the weakest here he quickly
Gets behind her and kicks her hard into
the forest area on the beach despite the
heavy hurt Maki survives and tells the
octopus to finish her off in one hit if
he's going to insult her strength as the
gong threatens to give her the same fate
as the other two the new generation
Sasuke and his domain expansion Chimera
freaking Shadow Garden is suddenly
activated instantly getting to gone and
marky's attention Megami appears from
the geyser and calls out to our girl he
extends his shadows out to her allowing
Maki to pick up this special gray curse
tool playful Cloud grateful for the help
Mackie tells Mega me that he really is a
cocky brat momentarily floating above
the tornado of Shadows Mega me looks
onward over the coastal area and notices
to go on he immediately recognizes that
the octopus like curse as the master of
the domain the gon believes migami is
foolish for entering his domain
voluntarily and prepares to attack him
Maki quickly attacks to gone with the
playful Cloud striking away a chunk of
the curse for its arm the gun is
surprised that he was actually injured
and Maki follows up with another blow
that seems to go on skidding across the
ocean water he recovers from the attacks
and recognizes that his guaranteed hit
has been nullified because of Mega me
locked in a domain tug of war Dagon
decides as best to crush Mega me before
doing anything else the curse Spirit
spawns fish from his body and sends him
swimming through the water at his
adversary nanami jumps across the Toads
manifested from megamese Chimera Shadow
Garden and slices apart the first making
me a surprise to see him and anami asks
him about Yuji and Eno migami informs
him of their status and an army focuses
on protecting Mega me so he can
concentrate on keeping the domain open
the gun is shocked and an army managed
to withstand death swarm from an entire
minute suddenly neobita appears behind
him and attacks with blinding speed
Dagon Ducks under the attack and is
equally surprised that the old man has
survived as well Maki comes out to
attack behind the curse and the gun
defends by spawning two large eel-like
shikigami to repel the sorceries now
beautiful trips the one attacking him in
a frame and crushes it with a powerful
Stone Maki defends herself as well and
they both stand on opposite sides of
Dagon now bittu tells him that all his
attacks did was get one arm he adds that
even if he was old and decrepit it will
still costly curse dearly an army
continues defending Mega me but a young
sorcerer is reaching his lamerts mikami
reveals that he's actually trying to
open a hole in the domain's barrier
rather than engage in a domain battle
the octopus curse likely can't cast
domain expansions twice in the same day
so after jiu jitsu Sorcerers can escape
they win an army makes sure Megami
doesn't plan on staying behind and the
student clarifies that he has no
intention of throwing his life away an
army calls out to the zenings and tells
them to assemble in a roundabout way
they put their trust in an Army's words
and Rush towards him digon is confused
for a moment but he quickly figures out
his adversary's plan he panics and
rushes to stop them nanami believes it's
too late as a whole appears in the
ground below Mega me that leads outside
of the barrier you guys don't even have
a clue what's about to happen if you
haven't read this before like hold on to
your damn MCS is everyone a symbols okay
as everyone assembles around this hole
something unexpected happens before the
Sorceress can even exit the domain toji
my father himself fushiguro suddenly
enters through the hole and they're all
forced to be a witness to the Flesh of
the man who is truly free and all of his
overwhelming intensity toji makes his
way into dagon's domain through the hole
that Megami had made in the barrier
surprise Mega me looked up at the man
floating in the air Maki notices the
Intruder is a human Jiu Jitsu Sorcerer
And Gone wonders why his adversaries
would let someone in rather than Escape
then in an instant toji disappears from
sight suddenly graving on to playful
cloud with blinding speed he easily
snatches the curse tool from Marquee
throwing her aside to arm himself for
the playful Cloud Mahi didn't even
notice any curse energy so she's shocked
that she actually lost in an exchange of
pure strength nigami then reveals that
the hole here just opened in the barrier
has been closed and it won't be easy for
him to open another naobito is the only
one amongst them who recognizes who toji
is upon uttering his name narabito
notices the sclera of toji's eyes filled
completely with black though ogami
science technique had the capability to
continue after death it wasn't even
meant to last ever the technique is
supposed to end when the host's cursed
energy runs out however the grandson's
Soul did not possess any cursed energy
as well and toji's body that overwrote
it did not consume cursed energy
therefore it will never end and now toji
can only fight completely on Instinct
until the vessel breaks he is a puppet
of pure Carnage and destruction the Khan
honestly messes up really badly right
here he notices toji has no curse energy
and says that he's a complete waste of
time he summons a shukigami to attack
but toji obliterates it in a single
swing with insane speed he then follows
up with a barrage of three-section Staff
strikes that injured a gun's head
sending him flying back surprised Dagon
recognizes that he grossly
underestimated toki's superhuman speed
and Power he tries to Summit a swarm of
numerous smaller shikigami to attack but
toji continues to get faster while
running on water like the God he is Koji
effortlessly rushes through all of the
fish striking him apart with a curse
tool on his way to attack Dagon digon
then summons his hardest and most
powerful shikigami to repel toji however
it's dispatched just as easily as the
rest it's explained that playful cloud
is the only special great curse tool
without a cursed technique and viewed
into it it is pure and solid power that
depends entirely on the wielder's
strength and toji's hand he annihilates
dagon's Water Shield in a single blow
slamming the curses hit violently into
the sand dumbfounded by the Newcomer's
domination Maki can only watch in
amazement with everyone else she asks
snail beater who the man is but he says
that toji is just a ghost nanami tells
migami to hold on to his domain for just
a little bit longer because they're
going to need a bit on toji backward
toji he rubs playful Cloud together to
sharpen its shape injured gun barely
stands back up and comes to the
realization that he's really about to
lose to a human without any cursed
energy he attempts to buy time until
migami's domain Runs Out by levitating
in the ear but once again naobito is way
ahead of him there Obito leaps on top of
dagon's head and stops his progress
saying this toji Stacks playful clouds
three sections on top of each other to
Vault himself into the air directly into
gone the curse puts others guard but
toji stabs playful clouds straight
through his face Dagon believes he can
still fight but toji brutally threads
playful Cloud through digon's head and
stabs him in the eye as well he then
breaks the chain connecting the three
section star together and rapidly uses
both sharpened sides to obliterate to
gone actually like shanking the
shikigami to death the domain is
dispelled in Marquee is shocked that one
lone fighter was able to exercise such a
powerful curse Spirit single-handedly
Megami is exhausted from holding his
domain for so long and takes the moment
to catch his breath nanami knows that if
migami hadn't shown up they would have
all been killed but now they have a new
problem they can't be sure if tochi is
on this side or not toji is still
fighting on Instinct bearing his fangs
at the strongest person around Mega me
may be exhausted but he's by far the
least injured so toji drags him outside
of this station in an instant before
Megami can even protest what's happening
he finds himself outside on the road
Megami lands safely but he looks back
across his street at his opponent with a
surprised expression he claims that this
ridiculous level of speed even passes
zakunas from back when they fought
earlier in the series honestly love how
Mega Meek doesn't even realize that this
guy's actually his dad I really really
can't wait for the day in the series
where he finally finds out who toji
fushiguro is or like hutoji Zenon is
because that's who he knows him as I'm
pretty sure Maki yells out of concern
for Mega me but she's immediately
interrupted by new presence behind her
jogo arrives morning digon and bidding
farewell to his friend Joker tells Dagon
to leave the rest to him and then he
looks forward to the reunion and the
wastelands within a second jogo then has
his palm placed on an Army's waist he
says that's one and blasts him with an
explosive wave of cursed Flames before
Maki can even yell out Joker lights her
on fire as well he says that's too and
moves to claim a third victim however
naobiso Gets behind jogo surprisingly
curse for the speed Neo Beto's in a
technique projection sorcery divides a
single second into 24 frames and uses
his field of view as the projection's
angle of You by doing so naobito can
trace a predetermined set of movements
to perform within those 24 seat frames
additionally anything touched by
neerbiju's Palm who doesn't abide by the
24 FPS rule while moving will be frozen
in an animation frame for one second so
pretty much they have to do the exact
same thing as naobito otherwise they'll
be frozen in a frame and he'll be able
to hit them the predetermined set of
movements cannot be adjusted once
started and its trajectory cannot
excessively ignore the lore physics new
Beetle was born with a natural sense of
strategic timing and movements so much
so he was then the fastest Jiu Jitsu
sorcerer excluding Gojo that being said
this was when naobito still had both
arms which is kind of like a big oof
moment right there two small volcanic
openings suddenly appear behind the
Obito and he cannot avoid the crossing
heat waves in time so he is heavily
burned by jogo's technique jogo says
that that's three and prepares to finish
off naobito when sekona's strong
presence abruptly gives him the chills
and grabs his attention meanwhile nanako
and mimiko remember what was going on
with that was sakuna's finger they
force-feed him one of sakona's fingers
and Joko then finds them soon after so
those battles were like kind of going on
simultaneously so you kind of get an
understanding of how like the fights are
working right now things are going on at
the same time as this is going on so
it's all very very confusing annoyed he
demands to know how many fingers they
feed him but the girls quickly flee
while zakuna's marks still remain on
yuji's face jogu decides to make Feast
of the situation get home inform Joker
beforehand that of Yuji ate a finger for
a day for 20 days he probably wouldn't
lose control of his body to Schooner in
contrast though feeding Yuji 10 fingers
at once might temporarily force him to
lose control Joker takes out a small
Scroll of 10 fingers and tells the king
of curses that it's time for him to wake
up oh yes it's that time of the freaking
battle it's time for the man himself
Joko looks over to see mimiko and nanako
they're alive but they didn't manage to
escape the station completely Joker also
notices that their faces indicate
they're afraid and surmises that they
likely can't use another curse technique
to get out of Harm's Way while he was
distracted though the silly volcano
doesn't even realize the hand-holding
yuji's face had been cut clean off jogo
and the girls are both shocked as an
ominous voice demands him to move jogo
Darts Away to position himself next to
the sisters he notices that in
comparison to Gojo zukuna's Aura is
filled with an overwhelming malice oh
honestly I wonder if something bad
happened in his past that seems to kuna
down like an evil path in comparison to
like Gojo heaven like the good mindset
and changing from what he thought
earlier on you know like in the
livestock just an idea because I think I
honestly think sakuna used to be a human
and he's turned into a cursed spirit
because people became defer him over
time anyway nanaku believes even one
movement will result in instant death
she tells herself to just breathe but
she's unsure of even that's safe sukuna
faces them and says they're holding the
heads a little too high the girls
instantly drop along with jogo but his
isn't low enough so couldn't create a
giant gash in the wall behind the trio
that cuts off the top of jogo's head the
curse Spirit begins to bleed profusely
across his face esakuna tells him that
one knee was still too high tsukuna
walks up to the girls and anarco uses
this chance to ask sakuna if he can free
sugudeo by killing the person inhabiting
his body nanako claims that nowhere
another finger is and will tell sakona
in exchange for helping him sakuna tells
the girls to raise their heads and gives
them a smirk suddenly memico's head is
sievered displeased sukuna asks of
nanako thought she could order him
around for just a few fingers desperate
for Revenge nanaku aims with cell phone
camera at sakona and attempts to
activate her innate technique sakuna
activates his first though and slices
the top half of nanako's head clean off
he follows up by dismantling her entire
body into tiny cubes then literally
slices her into nothing but a gruesome
spray of blood sakuna catches nanako's
phone into mices that the camera is
connected to her curse technique saguna
says jogo was next and asks what he
needs however jogo doesn't claim to need
anything this confuses sakona and jogo
clarifies his objective as to Simply
fully revive him joku implores sakuna to
make a binding vowel that will let him
take over yuji's body permanently sukunu
refuses this though and reveals he has
his own plans surprising jogo amused by
the curse for its desperation sukuna is
a token of his appreciation for the ten
fingers he challenges jogo to learn even
one hit on him if yoga can achieve this
sakuna agrees to work with his group for
now and kill every human and Shibuya
except for one to watch jogo willingly
accepts meanwhile Beckwith Father and
Son nigami tries to visualize winning
but toji is far too much of a monster to
even fathom defeating Megami activates
his rabbit Escape when both Fighters
notice sakuna's prison suddenly
appearing in Shibuya Megami uses the
torrent of rabbits as a distraction to
create distance from his adversary he
also summons Toad and asks himself why
he just felt sukuna toji instinctively
charges into the swarm of rabbits and
nearly stabs Mega me with a sharp and
playful Cloud polygamy Dives onto the
ground and avoids Earth running low on
cursed energy Mega me sole Advantage is
that shoko is stationed somewhere in
Shibuya flashing over there Yaga says
ajichi and Ino were both have perished
if not for her but Joker says that
that's only thanks to the prince
principles quick thinking they set up
the station before nonami even contacted
them freeing him to help up with the
mission honestly I think uh I think Yaga
might actually be the mole who was
feeding stuff to the High Reps and it
wasn't even kikichi in the first place
back in the battle tochi chases after
Mega me and nearly stabbed some from
behind luckily Toad's tongue pulled Mega
me away down an Alleyway to avoid the
attack Megami understands that toji made
short work of a special grade in his
shikigami are no match for him he needs
to focus on sacrificing his body rather
than his jackagami and decides it's best
to limit any injuries to something shoko
can quickly handle as toji stands at the
end of the alleyway Mega me surmises
that he has to predict his opponent's
timing because of his speed and
understands that any flaws in timing
will surely result in death toji
suddenly blitzes migami and nearly stabs
him again but his foot submerged inside
megami's Shadows Megami summons a sword
from his shadows and attempts to stab
toji with it however toji disappears in
an instant avoiding it with insane speed
making me believe so he is out of
options when toji suddenly records a
memory of his past it was their time
when toji agreed to meet with neobito in
order to sell his son to the Xenon
family toji believed that migami would
have potential and he could possibly
make something of himself in the future
taji never fit in but he thought that it
would be the best way to take care of
him in the long run after not speaking
in words since mikami met him taji
suddenly asks Mega me what his name is
to watch the goat answers perfectly
saying fushiguro proud that his son
chose foshiguro of his senen toji stabs
himself and the hid killing his vessel
in order to save his son from his
mindless Rampage his body collapses
shocking migami with the outcome of it
all and honestly this is why toji is a
goat like yeah he's strong and his
battles are probably the most hype at
this point but they do literally killed
himself for his son as soon as he knew
it was him he instantly did it like pure
chair dad as soon as he knew that his
son chose fushiguro of a Zen he was like
yeah man I'm out of here making me
kneels down and examines the body of his
deceased opponent he notices that his
face has changed back into ogami's
grandson and admits he was lucky that
this man decided to end dirts may give
me thanks about what Neo Beto said about
tochi and what his opponent said about
rejecting the sentence however Megami is
still injured from the fight and decides
to go see shoko as soon as possible
suddenly Mega Meat Slash from behind by
The creeper shikimo shigimo's
nose and teeth are still broken from his
fight with an army but he's alive and
somehow moving meanwhile the kusakabe
team wanders aimlessly around Shibuya
and umaki confirmed he relocated all of
the civilians somewhere safe and that
satorogo has been sealed Penna believes
in his hurry but kusakabi keeps coming
up with excuses to keep Panda's urgency
at Bay the kusakabo team is interrupted
by the appearance of two curse users
suda and nigai or suda and Niggy I don't
know how to say they're two former
commanders of gizo and three of their
foot soldiers are behind to cover and
Panda as well kuzakabe relishes the
opportunity to fight with other
sorcerers because it can buy him more
time he asks for the sorcerer's
motivations and tells them to take as
much time as they want Minami reveals
that they've inherited Suga dugetto's
will she in nigai intend on helping big
prank ghetto now despite mimiko and
nanako's miskavings skipping forward to
the conclusion of minami's story she
asks if kusakabi surrenders kusakawa is
disappointed this story finished quickly
but is still happy as the situation is
too good to pass out kusakabe activates
the new Shadow style evenly Moon sword
drawing takes that as his enemies
answer and begins activating a technique
of his own their fight is abruptly
interrupted by an explosion that
detonate an entire building behind nigai
there sukuna pummels jogo through the
ear and dominates their fight as the
letter Falls and Jin with blood spilling
from his mouth sukuna asks if that's all
he's got and Joker replies not yet Jacob
is a fire attack by concentrating Flames
between his palms but tsukuna uses his
innate technique to slash jogo's arms
apart while the cursed spirit is still
railing sukuna smashes his head with a
violent Hammer first the impact seems
juggle crashing towards the ground but
sakuna catches up to him with a quick
dive in order to smash his face directly
into the top of a tall building sakuna
and Joker crash through all of the flaws
of the skyscraper which severely injures
Joe go as the Moonlight shines through
the broken roof of the building sukuna
looks down on jogo and says the moon's
illumination makes it easier to see how
pathetic he is as Joker struggles to
regenerate his dismantled jaw among
other injuries he recalls gitto telling
him his strength is comparable to sukuna
with eight or nine fingers absorbed
despite knowing he'd be outmatched Joko
contemplates to himself that he didn't
expect the difference in their strength
to be this great sakuna suddenly appears
behind jogo the king of curses grabs his
opponent's collar and lifts of art
telling him to keep going until the fun
stops Flames are right from Olivia
forcefully open holes in the building
further destroying the structure skuner
though escapes out of the building into
the strait chasing him jogo follows up
using his strongest curse technique
maximum meteor for those who don't know
what a maximum technique is pretty much
that there is just like the strongest
kind of like innate or like ability that
someone can use outside of a domain
anyway anyway the kuzakabe team and the
curse users around them notice the
battle going on nearby kusakawa and
Panda attempt to flee and are
intercepted by and suit as
henchmen suda tells the underlings they
don't have time to fight because the
Cabe quickly Cuts them down with new
Shadow style battle saw drawing kuzakabe
tells the remaining Sorcerers they need
to flee and get away from the fighting
special grades however sukuna appears
next to kusakabe in an instant and says
he wouldn't allow any human to run
sakuna declares that all humans in his
vicinity aren't allowed to move until he
says so or else he will kill them this
leaves all of these Sorcerers forced to
watch as maximum mesia Falls drawing
closer to killing them all a few moments
later sakuna finally lets them all run
however this gives them little to no
time as maximum meteor crashes into
Shibuya decimating the entire area with
its impacts tired from unleashing his
maximum technique jogo stands atop it
huffing for ear after catching his
breath he smirks and says even an attack
that powerful must have injured tsukona
sokona's voice tells Joko that it would
only be the case if it had hurts he then
appears sitting beside him as if he was
never in danger he asks jogo waiwan uses
domain expansion Joker admits he would
loosen or domain struggle between them
and takuna believes his lack of
confidence stems from losing to Gojo in
the past entertained sukuna stands up
and suggests he begin fighting using
jogo's specialty this here is freaking
Dope by the way man like like zakuna
starts speaking in tongues I wouldn't
even know what this guy said sakuna does
something like no one even knows yet to
allow him to open and manipulate Flames
Joker was confused prompting tsukona to
realize a curspa wouldn't understand
this technique sakuna tells Joko to get
ready for a firepowered battle sukuna
and jogo stand Atop The Flaming remains
of Maximum meteor sakuna creates an
arrow of flames from his palms while
Joko swirls his Flames into a small
Fireball made of compressed energy
saguna takes aim by keeping the arrow
fully formed between his fingers while
in yeah good old Giga couldn't even
write it down jogo enters a fantasy
alongside his deceased allies Hanami and
Dagon death a stunning humans fear it is
a mirror for Humanity and the hito is a
manifestation of that reflection he will
continue to grow stronger toga believes
when they're all reborn they'll become
new entities despite this he hopes all
of them will be able to reunite someday
sticking to his ideology to the end jogo
says that curse Spirits are the true
humans when randomly sukuna abruptly
enters the fantasy and asks jogo if he
wanted to become human sukuna knows jogo
means he wants curses to take the place
of humans but believed this is foolish
jogo should have burned everything to a
sender without a second thought to reach
New Heights without ever being concerned
about Gojo sukuna believes jogo lacked
the hunger to take a hold of such
desires but even so the battle still
entertain him sukuna admits they
compared to everyone else he has fought
over the last Millennia jogo isn't half
bad he commends him telling him to stand
proud because he's strong acknowledged
for his strength jokoshi to tear and
asks what's going on back in reality
tsukun answers jogo's smoldering corpse
claiming that he doesn't know either
immediately after the monk arume comes
to escort Master sukuna which leaves him
surprised as he is someone from the past
elsewhere at 1107 PM exhausted and
injured Mega Me Slowly walks away from
his assailant he tells shigumo that the
10 Shadows technique begins when the
sorcerer who inherited the technique
receives two Divine dogs remember this
battle was going on between shigimo and
Mimi in order to use other shikigami
they must be summoned and defeated by
the sorcerer with the help of the Divine
dogs this allows the user to gain more
shikigami repeating this method until
they can amass up to 10 different ones
uninterested and mega me stalling
shigumo asks if this sorcerer is done
talking migami crosses the road away
from the curse user leaving a trail of
blood behind from his injuries shikamo
notices that Mega me isn't letting him
get close despite being on his last
leagues even so shigumo feels like he
won't even need to finish off his
adversary moments later Mega me
collapses and hits the ground with a
hard thunt proving this point making me
struggles to get back up but continues
to divulge how his technique works
either way saying that other people can
help with the exorcism ritual but this
will nullify the technique once it is
defeated this makes it a pointless
exorcism but even a pointless exorcism
has its uses Gojo Sensei explained to
migami why these Inn and family and Gojo
family are on such bad terms hundreds of
years ago the heads of household killed
each other in a battle the Gojo family
head was a limitless user with the six
eyes and the Xenon family head possessed
the tin Shadows technique Sartor implied
that Mega me could possibly rise to his
level one day however in the present
Megami still doesn't quite believe he
could become stronger than his mentor so
in a moment of utter despair he decides
to use his last resort as he believes
the head of the household at that time
that defeated these six eyes to use the
tin Shadows technique this way as well
meanwhile jogo's maximum meteor hits the
ground in the distance getting shikamo's
attention he asks himself who this
show-off could be and mega me redirects
his attention back to his explanation
nigami finishes divulging his technique
by revealing that a 10 Shadow's
technique user cannot use a shikakami
unless it has been exercised however
they can be summoned at any time using
an exorcism ritual shigumo turns back
around and notices migami sudden influx
of cursed energy the jujutu High student
claims they're not a single 10 Shadows
technique user has ever been able to
exercise the shikagami he is about to
bring forth making me summons the
eight-handed sword Divergent Cilla
Divine General maharaga dragging his
opponent into an unbeatable exorcism
ritual chigamo realizes the Grim
situation he's currently in amigami
who's also on his last leagues silently
apologizes to Yuji for what he's done
then tell shikamot good luck before
passing on maharaga thumps Mickey me
aside sending him into a nearby building
and knocking him out shikamma was
shocked by migami's willingness to
sacrifice himself and curses them for it
demanding the Jews who sorcerer get back
up and stop this cruel game back with
sakona after defeating jogo and
encountering a roommate he feels
something is up and leaves the monk
behind after telling them not to neglect
their preparations sukuna disappears and
a roommate says they'll be awaiting his
return honestly this hero is just kind
of like screaming to me that sakuna
knows something about big brain Guido's
plans and he might have even had some to
do with it in the past overall you know
what I mean just before maharaga crushes
shogimo sokuna saves the cursed user he
reads his situation instantly and
recognizes that Mega me is in a
suspended state of death to prevent this
sakuna uses a reverse curse technique to
heal Megami telling him that there's
still something he needs this student to
do shigumo wants to comment but saguna
tells him to stay there and stay quiet
so kuna surmises that in order to save
Mega me he needs to defeat the shikagami
saguna takes his fighting pose and saves
he'd like to begin the battle with just
a little taste Maharaja attacks swinging
down the blade attached to its first
sakuna blocks with his forearm creating
a Shockwave that knocked shigimo off
balance sakuna notices that the blade is
a missing a strange energy and gets out
of the way before it breaks through his
defense while in Medea sukuna delivers a
flurry of left-handed punches and
follows up by unleashing his curse
technique dismantle which slices the
shukigami's body all over while maharaga
recovers from the blows sakuna
recognizes the specialized blade as a
curse tool for cursed Spirits called The
Sword of extermination the blade is
enveloped in positive energy similar to
what's produced by a reverse curse
technique a sakuna was a normal cursed
Spirit he would have been sliced playing
through the eight-handed wheel on
maharaga's head turns suddenly healing
all of its wounds sakuna quickly attacks
again but this time his slashing
technique is deflected by the shikigami
surprising him maharaga swings its blade
again and tsukuna prepares to block but
this time it's immediately broken and
he's sync crashing through several
buildings from the impact amused sukuna
admits that his opponent isn't half bad
in an instant maharaga clears the area
just hit tsukunu across to follow up
with another attack it attempts to stab
sakuna in the face but he jumps above
the blade kicking his opponent at the
same time zakuna mounts his giant
opponent's arm and places his right arm
only shikigami's face stating that it's
his turn now skuner activates his
slashing technique slicing the entire
building in half the impact since the
shikigami falling out of the structure
only for sukuna to follow up could get
straight into the ground he lands beside
the sugigami and assumes it will heal
again based on its observations the
out-handed wheel turns and all of its
injuries disappear just as expected
sukuna Compares this ability to yamata
NOAA rochi For Us website want to know
is like a legendary eight-headed and
eight-tailed Japanese dragon think like
Orochimaru when he comes out of Sasuke
and Itachi ends up shanking him with a
dopa sword that's kind of like what I'm
thinking here I'm pretty sure it's taken
off that same kind of idea maharaga's
first attack was reinforced positive
energy when that didn't work it adapted
and reinforced its second attack with
cursed energy additionally it was able
to see sakuna's curse technique and
deflect it both of these things happened
after the eight-handed wheel turned for
the first time furu's incarnation of the
10 sacred treasures and the eight-handed
wheel represents a complete cycle of
harmony with this information secunda
doses that the shikigami's technique
allows it to adapt to any and all
phenomena sukuna admits that if migami
had Unleashed this creature when they
fought the first time and may have been
able to beat him he thanks migami for
showing him the way and activates his
freaking domain expansion the insane
malevolent Shrine man I honestly just
love how much Giga goes into depth on
Japanese mythology along with like
Indian and Chinese in other like sick as
cultures and like intertwines them
all into a story and that really reminds
me of what it felt like back when I was
a little kid to probably get into a
series like bleach or Naruto it's it's
just so good I absolutely love it
sukuna's technique is divided into two
types of slashing attacks the default
slash dismantle and the other cleave the
letter can be adjusted using curse
energy to cut down the Target and one
Fell Swoop malevolent Shrine unlike
other domain expansions does not
manifest a separate space using a
barrier manifesting one's innate domain
without a barrier is akin to painting a
masterpiece on ear without a canvas a
truly Divine and unparalleled technique
by allowing an escape route from the
domain using their binding vowel sukuna
increases the guaranteed hit accuracy to
nearly a 200mm radius he Narrows down
the effective range to 140 meters to
avoid hitting migami but mercilessly
slashes the wrist of shapuya apart
civilians who are hiding out nearby
after being rescued by any Marquee are
violently Torn to Pieces dismantle is
used on inanimate objects while anything
with curse energy within a range is hit
with cleave while malevolent Shrine is
active sakuna's slashing attacks
relentlessly cut down on everything
within its guaranteed hits effective
range with around 150 meters of Shibuya
decimated in an instant zakuna surmises
that the only way to defeat maharaga is
to kill it with a new attack before it
can recover however maharaga has not
only adapted to dismantle but to
slashing attacks in general many sakuna
needs to act quite clearly he activates
his mysterious flying technique again
and shoots a fire arrow at the sugargami
before it heals the impact creates a
giant barrier of explosive flame that
completely decimates the hellish
creature the king of curses walks back
to Mega me with maharaga's wheel in hand
he throws the eight-handed wheel past
jigimo in a disintegrates shortly after
solidifying sukuna's Victory annoyed
sukuna asks shigimo what he's looking at
and tells him to disappear from sight
feeling extremely lucky shigomo runs off
excited to have escaped another
dangerous situation his innate technique
stores Little Miracles from every day
that are released to save his life when
he's in danger the markings under his
eyes show how many miracles are stored
but he's not even aware how it works
exactly but leaving his escape the day
with his life shigumo runs off however
his body suddenly sliced apart as he
accidentally runs in to sukuna's domain
his body gruesomely falls into two
separate pieces and shigumo finally dies
finally out of like every death that has
happened so far throughout of the
Shibuya Arc this is at least one of the
most frequent deserved deaths dude
didn't realize his luck ran out after an
Army beat his freaking ass anyway anyway
asakuna walks off he can feel himself
finally losing control and decides to
take me to wish shoko and the principal
are after dropping Megami off sakuna
returns to the area in front of Shibuya
with his grip over yuji's body loosening
he switches control back over to the
Brad and tells him to take a good look
as Yuji stands there he's faced with the
Wasteland that used to be doggin's arka
District Chicago's corpse is in plain
view is the first thing for Yuji to see
as well initially dumbfounded Yuji
collapses as memories from sakuna's
Rampage Invaders mind he vomits and
cries after realizing that sakuna
murdered several people including mimiko
nanako and heavily endangering his
friends and colleagues as tears fall
from his eyes and he Huffs for ear he
tells himself to just die already he
frantically begins scratching around the
ground and continuing to tell himself to
die as his grandfather's words play over
and over in his head suddenly Yoji stops
and sits still for a moment before
raising his head and declaring that he
still needs to fight meanwhile inside
your booya station the goat nanami
despite being severally injured by
dagon's death swarm and jogo's Flames is
still alive and somehow walking around
with his sword they'll lift half of his
body is completely scorched including
the entire side of his face he walks
past a photo booth while traversing
slowly down the hallway after nanami
passes by mojito sneakily watches a move
through the station until the sorcerer
encounters a large group of transfigured
humans after descending the stairs and
coming face to face with his swarm the
Nami begins to daydream about Malaysia
he wishes he could have built a house on
a secluded beach and read the countless
box he never got around to finishing and
admits to himself that he's getting
tired yeah I think I think I'm all about
to hurt your souls with this one here
boys nanami asks himself if he's done
enough already but continues to fight he
ferociously slices through the
transfigured humans with his blunt sword
until a familiar hand touches his chest
an army looks up to see mojito and
claims he didn't know the curse Spirit
was around maheda replies that he's been
here the whole time and asks of the
sorcerer would like to chat since they
go way back
instead of replying nanami looks down
and speaks to you he wonders why he came
back to being a sorcerer himself and
asks hayabira what he was trying to do
you hire Buddha's Spirit appears and
points an army to his rights nnami looks
over to find Yuji entering the station
down the hall man this is so messed up
he tells hayabara that he doesn't want
to end up cursing the young man so like
a damn King in his last moments nanami
smiles to his Protege and tells him that
he's got it from here mahito promptly
kills an army by totally destroying the
upper half of his body shocking the poor
Yuji enraged in the next moment Yuji
rushes mojito really to take revenge for
his Fallen Mentor mahito calmly flicks a
small transfigured human at Yuji and
transforms it into one that can produce
spikes from its head Yuji avoids the
spike attacks but mojito uses the
transfigured humans to get behind Yuji
and prepare his soul multiplicity
technique he follows up by unleashing
Body repel and reaction that's due to
the social rejection of the fusion NATO
unleashes a Long transfigured human that
attempts to bite Yuji with its giant
mouth Yuji successfully grabs its teeth
and stops the attack the Mojito appears
from inside its mouth and lands a
violent right that smashes yuji's face
and splits it open Yuji asks how mojito
can toy so aimlessly with people's lives
and the curse Spirit just laughs at home
mojito doesn't look for a reason and he
isn't remorseful in the slightest the
best answer mojito can give is a
demonstration he creates junipay's face
with one hand and stabs it with the
other claiming Yuji and him are the same
Yuji tells mojito he talks too much and
that he will ensure that those are his
dying words he removes the blood from
his face stopping the bleeding and
revealing a large scar Nomi's voice
reminds yuchi that he must remain calm
so as he takes his fighting stance he
allows cursed energy to flow calmly from
his hands as he's determined to prove
that he is a jejutsu sorcerer Maiden
matches Yuji by concentrating cursed
energy and to his own fists while
contemplating his strategy Idol
Transfiguration doesn't work on Yuji so
mojito decides maintaining his body's
toughness is likely what Yuji believes
is best for him but instead mojito won't
change his soul shape at all and now
plans to stab Yuji through his heart in
one attack but when his first pierces
through the ear Yugi suddenly disappears
from his sight using the momentum from
getting to this lower position Eugene
strikes mojito in the face with the
Manji Kirk Yuji then follows up by front
kicking mojito as well but the curse
quickly transforms his arm into a spiked
Vine that forces Yuji back impressed
mehito admits that his technique wasn't
half bad and announces that it's time to
move on to round two maheso and Yuji
continue fighting in Shibuya the curse
Spirit attempts to slash Yuji but the
letter jumps over the attack after
missing mojito runs and uses a delayed
Transfiguration to catch Yuji off guard
he avoids it again and mojito follows up
with a punching attack from a large
enhanced extra arm wrapped around his
torso he's out of freaking Afro Samurai
or something with the extra arm Yuji
catches the attack and mojito
immediately recognizes the danger this
presents Yuji counters but mojito
immediately dismembers his own arm out
of fear he runs through the ticket gate
and merges back with his severed arm
once they're at a safe distance mahesu
knows they're taking directly is a big
risk for him so he decides to stick to
using transfigured humans however
reducing risk isn't the only reason for
the strategy mahiro then runs into a
different area in the station and
disappears from yuji's side the young
student gets spotted by two civilians
who warn him it's dangerous to be
looking around yuju believes mojito had
run upstairs and tries to tell the two
non-sorcerers to hide suddenly Mojito's
arm appears from the inside of their
mouths and punches Yuji the special
great climbs out of the man as if he was
his skin and transforms the
other civilian into a sword honestly man
like I forgot about this part like this
is some next little sneaker it's just
pure gangster by mojito man like turning
a person's body into a sword is so
freaking cool anyways mojito tells his
adversary to work on his imagination
skipping back to nearly two hours ago in
Shibuya station around the time mojito
choso and jogo began their hunt for Yuji
in order to find Yuji first mahito had
split himself into two presently
Mojito's Other Self Encounters nabara in
an alley way she recognizes him from
past reports from Eugene pedo takes it
as a compliment that he's famous but
nobara claims that he's only known for
being a coward amused mojito decides to
kill her nabara tries to remember what
it was like to unleash the black flash
attempting to tap into the core of
cursed energy and a short exchange
nabara manages to get the better of
mojito using clever explosions of your
pens and the environment around them he
admits that she isn't half bad but
doesn't believe her attacks can actually
bring him harm the curse bird
understands that nobara is an ally of
yuji's and plans to bring her corpse to
him and Destroy his soul so yeah get
ready
at 11 14 PM after an army left nobara
and akari behind the first year student
refused to leave with the paramedics
team they didn't tell nubara that shoko
was in the Shibuya District so she
didn't do anything Reckless however she
ignored nanami's orders to stay out
anyway and went off alone back on the
clock at 11 20 PM inside of the station
mojito skewers three innocent civilians
and uses them to attack Yuji as he comes
up like steers Lucy checks on the
conditions of one of the injured people
only for them to transfigure and explode
the blankets in yuji's eyes leaving him
vulnerable to an attack from behind
mejito transforms his arm into a spikes
club and prepares to finish him off
meanwhile in an alley nearby mojito is
still clashing with nobara she avoids
his hands but Mojito's double can't
transfigure other solves anyway this
double attacks by transfiguring himself
since this isn't Yuji and he doesn't
incur any risks Navarro tries to trade
blows but it doesn't seem to work mojito
casually avoids novara's projectile
Nails as she climbs up the side of the
alley onto a Higher platform she dropped
several Nails in Mojito's feet and
detonates them with The Hairpin before
coming back down confusing mojito with
her movements while he's focused on
Obara she activates herepin again and
her curse energy extends them until
Mojito's lower body immobilizing him
Novara mounts mojito while he's injured
but he doesn't see any potential danger
regardless however unbeknownst to the
special grade nabara has figured out a
way to attack his soul Mahira realizes
nobara was bluffing about not having a
plan but it was too late she hammers her
nail directly into his forehead and
activates resonance by using Mojito's
body as the Effigy nabara can use her
curse technique to attack his soul as a
result resonance also relays from the
double to the original soul and rebounds
the damage back greatly injuring them
both back in the other fight this injury
just happens to stop him from finishing
Yuji off Yuji manages to open his eyes
and recognizes nabara's needle sticking
out of the cursor's chest Mojito's
double is shock and realizes that Yuji
isn't his only natural enemy the girl of
steel standing before him can attack his
soul as well nibara reveals that she
felt her cursed energy activate
somewhere else nearby additionally she
doesn't feel Mojito's curse energy is as
strong as it should be she surmises that
mojito is simply a double they can't
properly use his innate technique amused
mojito looks the blood dripping from his
face and admits his adversary as
completely correct recognizing his
classmates curse technique Yuji
capitalizes and Paul's mojito with rapid
fire cursed energy infused punches while
Yuji bashes mojito into a pillar with a
Relentless barrage he solemnly thanks
nabara who she believes he hasn't been
able to save anyone and that he's wasted
everyone's efforts but novara's help has
shown him he's still not alone inspired
By nabara Yuji keeps the pressure on and
prepares to exercise mojito Here and Now
meanwhile in the alley the nail drops
from Mojito's doubles forehead as he
affirms her theory about him nobara
believes the real Jewel begins now but
the double decides to run away instead
and heads directly into the subway
entrance nubara could just ignore him
but she has a bad feeling about letting
him run loose and decides to exercise
him before Yuji can finish off Mojito's
main body this special Grace splits into
several small spherical versions of
himself that run across the room one of
them flares up its curse energy as a
Fang to get yuji's attention and allow
the others to escape the other Devils
then reform into Mojito's body as he
runs away both Mojitos into the same
Corridor with the two Jujutsu high
students chasing them Yuji initially
believes mojito is trying to heal until
he sees Novara he immediately yells for
her to run away realizing the danger she
suddenly in since maheso isn't able to
use the idle Transfiguration technique
on Yuji he made the second body that
can't use idle Transfiguration attack
Yuji and his other body that can use
either Transfiguration a technobirer as
no Barra and mojito fight he was able to
touch her and used his Idol
Transfiguration nubara holds her face
and recalls everyone in the village she
was from being crazy she used to believe
that lots of people were crazy and got
in the way of other people's lives but
that was until she attended Jujutsu high
and learned that being crazy isn't so
bad after all she pictures the images of
all of her friends and apologizes to
fumi for being unable to meet her again
and the future nobara looks at Yuji and
tells him to make sure everyone knows it
wasn't so bad and as she says that
nubara's face swells up around her left
eye and bursts from the effects of
Mojito's technique Yuji watches in
horror as nobara's eye shoots violently
out of her head and her blood splatters
on his face
Navarre lays before Yuji messing an eye
and likely dead losing to choso sukuna's
Rampage and anami's death had already
taken a toll on yuji's resolve having
reached its limit a long time ago yuji's
Spirit breaks after nobara is unable to
answer and he desperately screams her
name this douche happy with himself
commends his own talents and believes he
is a true curse he thinks successfully
unleashes a damn black flash on Yuji
just to follow up on his already dying
Soul Mojito's black flash sends Yuji
crashing through the station his special
gray continues to beat on him while
exposing yuji's determination for being
weak mojito believes that it isn't
simply a battle to fix something this is
a war of truths he believes Yuji is the
same as him because he kills without
hesitation just as Yuji saves people
without a second thought I truly do love
how well mojito has been written as a
character like I freaking hate this guy
so damn much like damn damn hero
believes that this conflict will
determine which of the two remains 100
years from now after thoroughly beating
Yuji down both mentally and physically
mahitu asks his student how he ever
planned on winning and if he's ever
counted how many curses he's exercised
matov has never cared about how many
people he's killed and he believes he'll
forget about Yuji eventually he morphs
his arm into a praying mantis like claw
and attempts to kill Yuji however there
is a clapping noise and suddenly mojito
is displaced you guys know what freaking
time it is right now our boy our brother
Toto the Eternal brother appears just in
time having used Boogie Woogie to switch
places with mojito he says that the
prosperous have no choice but to
eventually decline Nita also joins the
same after treating Obara Todo mostly
tells him to help his brother Yuji Nix
before telling his nearly defeated
friend that he must wake up
helpless and trembling on the ground in
front of them Yuji explains that he
cannot fight anymore not only did nubara
perish in front of his eyes but nanami
was killed by mojito as well to wear to
yuji's suffering zakuna slaughtered
potentially dozens of people and Yuji
felt he needed to help others to
compensate however he feels he failed
completely crying and wuthering on the
ground Yuji expresses that he simply
can't forgive himself enticed by yuji's
suffering Peter jumps at the group of
sorcerers with his arms shaped into a
thorned-like weapon Toto claps his hand
and activates Boogie Woogie to switch
mahili's position and the ear with a
writer behind him mojito attempts to
turn around and attack Toto but the
student suddenly switches the cursor's
position with Yuji taking off guard
mahil's left wide open to a powerful
kick that sends him railing towards
erata Toto quickly swaps a writer and
mojito again and takes position in front
of his Juniors to face off against his
special grade alone now what an absolute
G-Man mojito laughs and admits to
himself that Toto is extremely
disorientating at the same time Toto
tells Yuji that he believes as long as
they keep on living those who have
passed on will never truly have been
defeated here it's it looking for logic
in meaning and death can defile the
memories of the dead but Toto still asks
Yuji for what he's been entrusted with
Toto tells Yuji that he doesn't need to
answer him right now however until he
does the first year can never stop
fighting he expresses this to Yuji and
runs ahead to fight mojito alone a
writer quickly treats yuji's entries by
applying his curse technique he informs
Yuji that his injuries won't get any
worse from here on out unless he
sustains new ones Arata has already done
the same for Novara he admits that she
didn't have a pulse and isn't breathing
but encourages Yuji by adding that there
is a chance of survival Arata then takes
nobara and Retreats out of this station
mojito attacks Toto and tries to split
himself into a few different ways to
outmaneuver his opponent however Toto
proves to be too efficient at avoiding
mojito a small transfigured human behind
Toto transforms into a large Spike but
but the third year avoids the attack
mojito is disappointed his opponent
didn't even clap even so he's confident
after tapping into the power of black
flash he believes it's joined him even
closer to the true essence of his soul
Toto suddenly claps and interrupts
Mojito's train of thought Yuji appears
before the cursed Spirit back in the
fight he charges his fist with cursed
energy and reminds himself of the
nunami's last words focused and
recommitted on the battle Yuji unleashes
black flash on mojito destroying the
cursor's arm Mejia was knocks back but
quickly heals his wound amused the curse
smiles and says that Yuji is back from
the dead Todo welcomes him back into the
battle as well and Yuji stands ready to
fight beside him Elsewhere on a train
miwa holds one of mikamaru's
communication devices in her hands she's
disappointed as hikichi's voice and
forms her that the Shibuya incident will
be settled at any moment now he tells
her to turn back because it's too late
but Kasumi ignores him and asks why he
only allowed Toto and a writer to go
Pikachu doctor at the records so that
everyone else the only group including
otahime would be away from Shibuya on
October the 31st absolute lad man
presumi asks if she's useless and weak
since he didn't entrust her and everyone
else to go pikachi argues that he's the
weak one and admits he made mistakes
that he couldn't even go through worth
he confesses that there was someone he
loved and believed they would be fine
regardless of the state of the world as
long as they were together well there's
time running out kikichi says his final
goodbyes to me were as she cries kakichi
asks her to find happiness and adds that
as long as she does there his wish will
have come true for a moment kikichi
appears sitting next to her in the
reflection of the window as he says his
goodbyes His Image disappears for the
last time as she looks up into the
window the other members who were left
outside the incident can hear me were
sadly crying from Elsewhere on the train
Mai asks urahime about mikamara's
betrayal but odahime doesn't believe it
matters since kikichi was killed old
Cameo as there's a point in mcamaru
expected so little from them but Momo is
simply enraged that he made her Junior
Cry If Only They understood man what was
really going on meanwhile the battle
between the hiso and the Jiu Jitsu
sorceress rages on with this fighting
Spirit reignited Yuji fights effectively
alongside Toto to keep mojito on the
defensive mojito knows Toto's soul is at
full strength and one Transfiguration
might not be enough to kill him yuji's
soul is much less stable but mojito
isn't exactly in great shape either he
feels at less than half of his full
strength after having has double
destroyed and being hurt with a black
flash NATO plans to deal with Toto
switching first and tries to use a
transfigured human to distract ug
however the head was surprised when Toto
uses Boogie Woogie to swap places with a
trans-fucking human this allows him to
get behind mojito and force the curse to
destroy his own weapon at the same time
Toto thinks about feeling like he's
being left behind now that mojito can
use black flash as well YuYu refused to
get left behind and use the technique
during her
refuses to let Yuji feel alone and
finally like the big brother he is
unleashes his own black flash pummily
mojito with a perfect Kirk NATO's arm is
broken by Toto's black flash but he
still doesn't believe Toto will be able
to hurt him even so this special grade
recognizes that all three Fighters have
reached 120 percent of their potential
mojito then voluntarily vomits up
several miniature transfigured humans
and combines them using Soul
multiplicity meso immediately activates
body repel creating multiple
transfigured snake-like heads that
attempt to chomp at his enemies as the
attack breaks through the underground of
Shibuya Yuji and Toto are forced to move
innovate all of the attacks in the air
they later recognizes that mojito is
countering Boogie Woogie by attacking
from all directions meso empathetically
tells Yuji that it's their last chance
to curse one another asking if the curse
is forgotten about him Toto swaps all
three of their positions so he's holding
mojito then slams him head first into
the ground Yuji attempts to smash
Mojito's head with a kick by the cursed
dismembers himself to avoid the blow
this special grade's body grows two eyes
and transforms its arm into a blade
before rapidly attacking at the same
time Mojito's head grows a separate body
and stands behind his other half to
activate Soul multiplicity this time
mojito combined two Souls with weak
rejection to form one powerful
transfigured human using polymorphic
Soul icy mirror Toto uses boogie boogie
to continuously give his side the best
spot against the enemy while believing
Mojito's body contains the most of the
power but the heat itself is the real
him because it used either
Transfiguration before taking out the
hero's real self Turtle attempts to take
up the polymorphic Soul isomer however
much to his surprise Toto is suddenly
smacked aside with a powerful blow the
impacts in some crashing through an
entire floor and out the other side into
the road but he still manages to recover
his balance the soul confronts the
Sorcerer And Toto counter-attacks by
infusing a rock with cursed energy and
swapping places with it behind his
opponent much to Toto's surprise one hit
was enough to kill the solo icing his
advises that its explosive power was the
result of mojito expanding numerous
Souls at once to manifest it there are
two more now confronting him and Toto
asks for their forgiveness before taking
each of them out while mojito was free
of Boogie Woogie he decided to pile on
the attacks against Yuji he uses a more
ferocious version of body repel to
attack but the sorcerer avoids the
attack and drop kits mojito through the
air the curse counters by grabbing
yuji's leg and slamming him onto the
ground when he does settles for any
crash mojito attempts to follow up the
attack however he's irritated to fight
the top note go standing back at his
brother's side maida was surprised not
even two polymorphic isomers were enough
to stall or defeat Toto he can't
transfigur Toto without being able to
touch him and sukuni retaliates of
mojito attempts a domain expansion it's
too complex for mojito to exclude Yuji
from a domain's barrier so he decides to
take inspiration from the big man
himself the duo are both shocked when
mojito suddenly activates his domain
expansion just like Gojo mojito
activates his All or Nothing domain
expansion for 0.2 seconds taking both of
his opponents completely off guard Toto
acts quickly and activates a simple
domain which he learned from Yuki even
faster though is Yuji who's already
running towards mojito in an attempt to
exercise him before either
Transfiguration can activate however
despite their speed mojito was the
fastest the two-step process of
realizing one's innate domain and the
activation of the acoustic technique are
combined into one by mojito who had
awakened through black flash as a result
of activating his domain expansion
mejito enters sukuna's innate domain for
a moment he asks sakuna if this is a
safe place and inquires about his
agreement with Yuji the king of curses
remains silent but mojito continues
questioning in order to challenge sakuna
he arrogantly claims Yuji will be dead
before sukuna can even switch places
with him and tells the king of curses to
just shut up and watch the balls on this
guy man as the self and body element of
perfection ends Toto's left hand begins
to transfigure Yuji turns around to
check on his brother but mojito knocks
him to the ground while his back is
turned Toto quickly Sievers his own hand
but thus sleeps invulnerable to the
approaching special grave after
activating domain expansion the user's
innate technique becomes difficult to
control mojito became aware of that fact
after escaping against an army he
instead a text holder with a strong
punch enhanced by black flash that sends
Toto into Relentless pain big brain Toto
though instinctively concentrated olives
cursed energy to defend the blow and
minimize all of the damage maido then
becomes able to activate idle
Transfiguration again and plans to kill
Toto with the next herds maidu's Focus
though is suddenly interrupted when
Toto's necklace Falls onto the ground
and knocks open a small picture frame
containing the photos of Yuji and takada
while his opponent is distracted Yuji
uses Mojito's hand to clap and activate
Boogie Woogie Toto instantly switches
places with Yuji who strikes mojito in
the face with another black flash total
collapses and looks at his remaining
hand while expressing that he's lucky to
be alive ready to finish the fight alone
now Yuji looks back at Toto and thanks
him for all of his help final battle
Shibuya finally begins or is it the
final battle I guess we'll find out I
guess we'll find out next heavily
injured mojito creates a polymorphic
isomer to hold Yuji off he admits total
was a problem for him till the very end
but despite his depleting condition
mojito believes he's found the true
essence of his soul Yuji defeats the
polymorphic isomer and as this happens
medo evolves into the final stage of his
being emerging from a cocoon of probably
cursed stuff you know who knows he then
instantly activates Idol Transfiguration
on himself making himself into an
instant Spirit body of distorted Killeen
this form is just like super clean man
like it's probably one of giga's out of
this world type not just the normal
like anime character face I love her
like made up that's probably why I like
it in the midst of these City's ruins
Yuji glares at his greatest enemy in
wonders what is newest Transfiguration
brings the curse Spirit feels reborn and
asks Yuji to wish him a happy birthday
to celebrate their momental occasion
having Unleashed black flash maheda
believes he is tapped into his true
unbridled Soul Yuji didn't take his
adversary to be one for a self-discovery
journey amused mahiti replies that only
after killing Yuji does the curse Spirit
feel that he can truly be reborn the two
fighters instantly Blitz one another to
reignite the battle nahida makes the
first move creating a shock wave which
is the wave of his arm Yuji Duck's under
the wave and attacked with a straight
kick that's caught by the blackheads
protruding from Mojito's head the curse
tries to take the advantage with a tail
whip but Yuji blocks it he is then able
to Parry Mojito's punch encounter with
an uppercut to his body however yuji's
curse energy infused punch deals
absolutely no damage at all Hayden
knocks Yuji away and forces him to
realize that the curse Spirit
transcended Away Beyond his former State
they trade blows but uses attack are
unable to reach his opponent any longer
Yuji is overwhelmed and slammed into the
street creating a giant Crater from the
impact the street crumbles apart and
Yuji falls down to the bottom as water
fills the bottom of the crater where
Yuji now stands across from mojito the
former realizes he can only win using a
black flash infused punch with maximum
cursed energy mehito attempts to take
advantage of yuji's small laps by
rushing in however the curse Spirit
immediately stops the tendrils on the
back of his elbows partially
disintegrate and mojito even coughs up
blood getting hit by black flash so soon
after deactivating domain expansion
seriously injured mojito amused with the
final standoff mojito wipes the blood
from his mouth and States both of them
have plenty left in the tank mojito
rushes his opponent creating a giant
Splash in the water from his incredibly
fast movements Yuji immediately clinches
his fist in his palm and charges all of
his curse into Earth mejito attempts to
attack Yuji from behind but they Source
directs under in time the curse right
then tries to come Adam with a right
hook but Yuji uses the back of his palm
to Parry it having been a bunch now NATO
knows that he's vulnerable to being hit
by another one of yuji's black flash
attacks meaning going in recklessly will
only lead to his end believing he is a
countermeasure in mind mojito partially
deactivates his distorted killing form
on the left side of his body this
special grade believes Yuji will aim at
his sweet spot and that will lead to the
chance to counter and decapitate him
Yuji indeed does strike and Mojito's
left side appearing to Take debate but
just as mejito goes for the kill a
second impact throws the trajectory of a
strike off Judy ducks and then hado's
missed attack and prepares to deliver
the final blow the kusper reinforces the
left side with his instant Spirit body
of distorted killing and tries to hit
his opponent first suddenly though algo
the Broski the Bro the brother Toto's
voice Echoes through the battlefield
interrupting Mojito's momentum Toto
tells the curse spirit that an arm is
simply a declaration and an act of
Applause as an acclamation of one's soul
tamus man is a poet man best little
friend though uses his freaking
amputated hand to imitate clapping with
his remaining hand trying to anticipate
this switch Mexico quickly turns around
and attacks he ends up hitting nothing
though and realizes that he's been
utterly fooled by Toto One Last Time
Toto apologizes and claims that Boogie
Woogie is already dead Yuji takes
advantage of his allies clever thinking
and Strikes mojito with a black flash
imbued with maximum cursed energy the
impact from yuji's blow is so Fierce It
Coats his opponent in a streak of cursed
energy that blasted kusper completely
out of the crater mojito was heavily
injured and forced out of his distorted
killing four additionally this special
grade is out of transfigure humans as
desperation sets in for mojito for the
first time in his existence Yuji stands
over him just as the curse proclaimed
earlier in the fight Yuji admits that he
is mojito he no longer requires a reason
to kill him and will exercise cursors no
matter what form they take fully aware
now that is nothing but a cog and they
struggle between two sides Yuji is
confident to play his role as a juutsu
sorcerer against the threat of cursed
Spirits Maidu desperately tries to flee
as Yuji chases from behind like a wolf
chasing the rabbit through the snow well
dude wait when this when this was going
down for the first time I was breaking
screaming and chanting like oh my God
man I can't actually like the pages want
to fire like full-on they want like
seriously oh my God before Yuji can
finish mojito off someone appears gitto
suddenly appears before mojito standing
over him and looking down on his fellow
special grade flashing away at 10 36 PM
in Kuala Lumpur Malaysia was you know
obviously is a big shout out to our boy
in an army and obviously this is like
where they were going to escape to after
if things went bad I think anyway meimei
teased wee-wee about sharing their beard
until someone gave her a call back she
revealed to that person that she was
nearly killed by kiso and had to escape
using wee Wee's technique she advises
them to sell all of the Japanese stock
and Tokyo real estate immediately having
also already exchanged her Yin meme
expects a possible negative Chain
Reaction could still affect other nearby
developed Nations Japan's economy is the
third largest in the world and could be
in for a major decline around the same
time Panda located kusakabe choso was
continuing to have flashbacks of Yuji in
his life alongside his brothers after
a tear for his brothers chosu
decided he needed to move unsure of
himself now chosu needs to know what
Yuji is at 11 36 PM ghetto asks mojito
if he is in need of saving Yuji acts
quickly recognizing ghetto's name and
appearance he demands Gojo back and
rushes towards the curse user get a
nonchalantly though explains that people
of the medieo period spoke of a
mysterious connection between catfish
and earthquakes at the same time he
summons a small catfish co-spirit that
swims and into the underground suddenly
a gigantic hole created by the curse
appears underneath ug the first year
loses his balance and appears to fall
into the hole however Yuji abruptly
Falls onto the ground as if the hole
never even existed completely dazing him
ghetto asks if Yuji believed he had
fallen and saves from a side view it
just looked like he suddenly flipped
over he explains the strengths of
kerspur manipulation lies in the higher
number of moves at the user's disposal
Beau wielding multiple curse spirits of
semi-grade 1 and higher ghetto can
unleash different types of attacks every
time his opponent adjusts ghetto
demonstrates this using a curse that
takes the form of a swarm of centipedes
crawling out of a black webbing to
ensnare Yuji then the catfish curse
opens another hole at the same time
suspending Yuji in the ear without any
balance before stacking another
centipede attack and smashing the
sorcerer into the ground as Yuji lays on
his hands and knees bloodied from the
attack ghetto realizes that the first
year had nothing to do with the events a
year earlier and did Yuji simply demands
saturno bear in ghetto laughs in
response while admitting that tsukuna's
vessel is tough mahido attempts to hit
ghetto from behind but his hand is
easily avoided the curse Spirit admits
he knew Yuji was tough all along since
he was born from humans ghetto then
absorbs mojito as the cursed Spirit
utters his final words send him for Yuji
holding mojito sealed inside a black orb
ghetto begins to explain maximum
techniques they are an innate techniques
most powerful art outside of a domain
expansion kusper manipulation maximum
Uzumaki combines the curse spirit in the
user's position to unleash a burst of
super condensed cursed energy randomly
ghetto begins to laugh Yuji asks what's
so funny and the curse user replies that
he accidentally started acting like
suguru continuing on about Uzumaki he
explains the technique is powerful but
he initially believed and negated the
great number of moves at the curse
manipulator's disposal Giro admits he
was wrong about Uzumaki because when
semi grade 1 and higher curse Spirits
are utilized realized the curse
technique is extracted pretty much what
he means is he's able to use any curse
technique from a semi-grade one or
higher and still use maximum makes your
using all of the other curses that
remain as well plus probably some of the
power from that curse I would imagine
but he won't lose like that ability of
like idle Transfiguration or like say
any other ability that he might get in
the past ghetto swallows the black orb
containing my hexo officially adding the
special grade to his collection while
looking up ghetto tells Yuji it's
foolish to think he wouldn't notice Momo
is floating above him on a broom using
the lantern as a signal for her allies
to attack from long range kamo is the
first to act firing cursed energy
infused arrows at the enemy ghetto
avoids the arrows but immediately
notices a speeding bullet coming
directly at him however he simply blocks
mice bullets with a curse as me rejoins
the fight she recalls her past and how
she met her main tour in junior high
deciding to become a jiu to sorcerer
despite having even held a wooden sword
Maywood quickly slides in behind gizo it
activates new Shadow style while
recalling her blistered and bloodied
hands memo puts everything into the
swing she's prepared to never even use a
sword again and attacks with battle
sword drawing however hito simply
catches the blade with his bare hands
and shatters it immediately after
negating me was attack keto activates
maximum Uzumaki with the technique
having been divulged Yuji knows about
uzumaki's power and yells for the curse
user to stop Mama also looks down and
moves to save miwa but sadly Uzumaki
destroys the ground with a blast of
super condensed cursed energy leaving a
gaping hole in the ground from the
impact however the technique didn't
actually hit anyone and ghetto admits
that it's nice facing someone with
experience rather than his students
kugosabe was able to use his new Shadow
style to cancel out part of the curse
technique and protect me were at the
same time Panda arrives to the
battlefield and checks on Yuji he's
relieved to see that Yuji is back in
control of his body he asked if the
curse user has the cursed object holding
started a Gojo hemo asks who the curse
user is and Panda can only say that it's
a mysterious person that has assumed the
identity of sucre by controlling his
body suddenly our boy the other brother
chosa arrives on the battlefield
surprising Eugene welcomes him but our
boy in the middle of is like I don't
even know if you can call this a midlife
crisis or cursed crisis you guys choose
what one he completely is he's a mix in
my mind still finally recognizes the
curse user as one of his three parents
so yeah this is kind of messed up right
man like for real there is uh chosu's
mother the curse Spirit who got her
pregnant which is freaking weird man and
the man who told me to chose his mother
to create the cursed womb death
paintings chosu hated this person and
now that person is inhabitating sukuru's
body this thing is no one other than the
most evilest sorcerer in history the
prolific narutoshi kmo of obviously this
is kind of confusing for those that are
sitting there like yo wait you say
Naruto shikamo that's that other dude
like it even it even confuses the
students here so I don't blame you
pretty much this dude's just old heirs
man like just think of he's always from
the past he's an old chemo
udahime clears it up more that chosu is
referring to the stain of the camo Clan
kuzakabe believes that it makes sense
for him to be someone with absurd
barrier techniques cursed objects and
the ability to switch bodies ghetto
claims that narutoshi Kemo is just one
of the many names he's gone by so
possibly the dude could have even been
like far older than we even suspect at
the moment because we don't know where
he started you know where did the brain
dude start from Chelsea rushes at
narutoshi however a roommate abruptly
Cuts him off sliding next to ghetto and
telling the bottom feeder to step aside
rough arumi tells choso not to make them
wait any longer but Chelsea replies for
the curse user to get out of his way and
repeat that he's yuji's older brother so
yeah it's a finally explained here why
he thinks that a side effect of chosen
his curse technique is that he can sense
the transformation of his younger
brothers through their blow connection
just before finishing off Yuji in their
fight earlier in Shibuya chosa could
feel the sensation of death coming from
Yuji just like he did with his other
brothers to choso this can only mean
that Yuji is also his younger brother by
the way I'm just calling brain dude
brain dude or brain or narutoshi until
we know his name I'm not going to call
him kamo I'll just call kamo kamo so it
doesn't get confusing yeah narutoshi has
extended his life from moving from host
to host making it possible that Yuji and
choso could share some sort of blood
relation in order to fulfill his duty as
an older brother chosa was ready to
protect Yuji with all his string Koso
activates blood manipulation convergence
surprising kaimo with how Superior it is
to his own chosu fires piercing blood
and it almost reaches urume's face in
the blink of an eye the monk is
surprised by the immense speed of
piercing blood and barely manages to
stop hurt geto's sidesteps the attack
while it draws a hole through one of his
Partners cursed energy reinforced hands
JoJo swings the stream of blood sending
the arrow back to slash at narutoshi
this breaks up the ground and choso uses
the blood he placed there to disrupt
ghetto's footing they then engage each
other by trading blows in close quarters
narutoshi is the first to land a
significant strike and suggests choso
shouldn't strain himself after fighting
so much earlier on chosey doesn't
believe being tired is any excuse to
stop putting his life on the line to
protect his younger brother confused
Panda asks if Yuji is really related to
choso Yuji doesn't believe they were
related at all and reveals how chosu had
nearly even killed him earlier which is
you know like what the what the man
regardless of his relationship with Yuji
narutoshi points out that choso is
creating a disturbance that their need
to take advantage of the two cores still
going strong Panda goes out in full
Guerrilla mode while the others follow
behind him he activates his unblockable
drumming beat but suddenly a roommate
activates their innate technique ice
formation a roommate uses Frost Khan to
release an icy Mist that freezes choso
narutoshi Panda and
asks them not to kill the sorcerers
because he needs Messengers and a
roommate heals his hand using a reversed
curse technique discouraging kusakarbe
who considers these curse users to be on
a whole other level chosu activates
flowing red scale to rapidly increase
his body's temperature and melt the ice
a roommate appears in front of choso but
Yuji one of the only ones who wasn't
Frozen dropkicks choso out of the ice to
save him from a roommate annoyed the
monk asks who does the vessel think
their body belongs to you believes that
he wasn't Frozen due to sakuna and asks
choso what side he's on chosey denies
he's fighting with his Sorcerers and
States once again his yuji's older
brother he even asks Yuji to try calling
him big brother just once which reminds
me of obviously of Toto so hard man
usually ignores this because he notices
Momo flying down towards the group on
her broom Momo uses her winside to
launch a blade of cursed energy from her
broom at the two cursed users a roommate
is able to block this attack with their
bare hands frustrating Momo with Yuji
Momo and choso the only one still mobile
the Kyoto student tells the other two
that they need to buy time for utahime
dissatisfied with noonian Messenger as a
reason for keeping this mini Sorcerers
alive a roommate activates ice formation
they claim Yuji alone will be enough and
creates a steam of icicles that
surrounds both curse users and splits
apart to freeze them the flying ice
splits attack and freeze Yuji choso and
Momo in place a second wave of sharpened
icicles attacked them from above pretty
much much to maintain their deaths until
a mysterious shikigami suddenly appears
to break the ice apart this special
great sorcerer Yuki appears on the
battlefield she asks kiddo the same
question again from all those years ago
inquiring as to what kind of girls he's
in too so you know like if you're
wondering who Toto's taught by it's Yuki
it's this chick here the special great
sorcery Yuki the third one that we
haven't actually properly met the two
Sorcerers Clash philosophies regarding
the future of Humanity's relationship
with cursed energy Yuki believes humans
need to break away from cursed energy
while ghito believes optimizing it will
bring about the evolution however the
world get up issues would be full of
Bloodshed because Japan has a virtual
monopoly on cursed energy something like
that would cause the other world powers
to retaliate and use humans as an energy
source ghetto doesn't care if the world
ends up that way he believes there is
more to the human potential Beyond
Sorcerers and cursed Spirits he
attempted to create their death
paintings to bring that potential into
existence however Giro has deemed that a
failure and has since realized that
anything he can create on his own does
not exceed the bounds of his own
personal potential the answer he seeks
is hidden within the darkness in only
the chaos that narutoshi can't even
control can bring it forth he reveals
that he's already extracted the curse
technique he needs to begin this process
Yuki has a realization and asks what
happened to mojito prompting Yuji to
reveal that gitto had just absorbed him
the curse user remotely activates idle
Transfiguration on every human he's
marked he thanks Yuji for bringing out
Mojito's full potential because his
cursed energy stopped improving the
moment it was absorbed the two types of
non-sorcerers have been marched prior to
the remote casting of idle
Transfiguration the first type are
non-sorcerers who are meant to stay as
such but instead have awakened new
cursed techniques much like junipay the
second are vessels that ingested cursed
objects like ug Guido's plan is to
release a thousand malevolent Sorcerers
and get them to fight one another Yuki
doesn't believe a thousand rational
people would fight one another to death
the kiddo assures her he wouldn't make
any oversight annoyed yuhi asks Yuji to
help her beat up the Imposter Yuji can't
move though due to the ice holding him
but chosu's poisonous blood abruptly
causes a roommate to collapse down onto
one knee and the ice suddenly starts
melting before they move though Geto
declares the cursed objects he provided
were created from the sorcerers he made
vows with a millennia ago however those
vows became null when he obtained Suka
dugito's body Yuki understands the
implications of this just as narutoshi
announces that this is the world of the
future he shows the prison realm to his
enemies and bids farewell to Yuji
claiming to expect a lot from him in the
coming times the young man calls out
Gojo's name one last time and gitto or
narutoshi or brain or whatever finally
addresses sakuna directly he tells the
king of curses that an error reflecting
the he and era is coming and that the
Golden Age of Jujutsu is turning foreign
so as we start back out we see Tokyo at
night slowly as it zooms out it reveals
that the entire area is now pitch black
okay like Giga straight off the bat
comes out and hits us with the hunter
hunter level of infodum literally the
text covers the whole page and another
complete double panel afterwards anyways
anyways random people begin discussing
this situation and reveal that the 23
Wards have almost been completely
destroyed by the way these Wards are
like just like districts or areas of
Tokyo that it's broken up into because
it's such a large place anyways anyways
these randoms he'll probably just use
higher-ups or Japanese officials claim
to create an evacuation plan for 5
million residents estimating that at
least 10 million curse Spirits have been
released one of them is flabbergasted
that they plan to evacuate the entire
area wondering about what the various
consequences could be another says that
they should expand the two barriers to
the boundaries of the prefecture and
another worries about making public the
existence of cursed Spirits which you
know obviously confirms that it's
probably just used to higher-ups talking
about stuff right here someone assures
the others that the sorcerers are
protecting the evacuees inside the city
with another adding that they can tell
the public that the curse Spirits only
appear in Tokyo as someone else worries
about an intervention by foreign
military the others debate back and
forth about how to handle the situation
with nothing ever being cemented
elsewhere at the same time in a
convenient store a young girl kneels on
the floor when she suddenly spots a
creepy figure in the doorway telling her
to come just you know really weird when
you put it like there the confused kill
asks where who mother is and the figure
replies that everyone is all outside
safe with him she stays in response that
she doesn't have a brother but the
figure simply repeats the girl's Words
which just leaves her even more confused
the figure says to come again and as the
girl walks outside a horrid curse spirit
with the razor sharp teeth opens its
mouth to devour her finally like I've
been waiting so long to talk about this
dude since it dropped my charger k0
video people have been asking where and
like how what happened to him you know
like well here he is leaping down from
above the one and only Yuta akotsu
suddenly appears in stabs the creature
directly in its head with a calming
smile on his face he asks the girl as
she's scared while also making sure that
she isn't hurt you don't notice the area
and doubts that she lives here they're
noticing how worn her shoes are he asks
how far she's walked as Judah tells her
that she has done a good job the curse
suddenly Rises up from the ground and
opens its mouth to devour him but it's
suddenly thrown back and splattered
against the wall as the girl notices the
attack luta asks Rika to chill out a
little while also covering the girl's
eyes and turning her away from the
Carnage by the way like I should mention
I'm like 80 sure that this is during the
morning on the 1st of November and maybe
a day later but I'm assuming that it's
directly after the Shibuya incident Arc
because that's kind of like how I've
read it here anyway anyway moving
forward in the night Yuna meets with his
so-called higher-ups who praises efforts
however he bluntly tells them to get to
the point
one of them Chuckles and says that his
killing of cursed Spirits proves nothing
Judah asks in reply if you should enter
a binding vowel assuring them that he
will follow through with any said plan
he says that since Yuji itadori cut off
in yumaki's arm during Shibuya then he
will kill him personally as the meeting
ends five notices are made known by the
higher-ups first ghetto was confirmed to
be alive and has been sentenced to death
again which is you know like kind of
funny but like obviously it's not ghetto
and surely they know that at this point
or like are trying not to believe it at
this point secondly Gojo is considered
an accomplice in the incident and has
been permanently exiled removing his
seal would be considered a criminal act
this is obviously you know something
they want they don't want uh someone who
can threaten their power to come back
and actually kill them like kojo has
threatening them and they pass before
third masamichi Yaga is to be freaking
executed for inciting Gojo and ghetto
and causing the incident at Shibuya
pretty much their thought behind behind
us is that he's their teacher he gets
killed because you know like he should
have taught them better pretty much or
at least you know like there is another
reason but we'll get to that later on
and not in the sucks so we will wait for
that fourth yuji's execution will resume
now and be carried out immediately and
lastly Yuta akotsu is appointed as
yuji's executioner so we got a bit of a
main story character rivalry going on
here right now the prequel or main story
you know like who's your guys favorite
character out of geek guys 2 main
characters anyway anyway skipping
forward to the Zenith Estates after
being critical of Marquee the
misogynistic Jeju K Andrew Tate the
small man himself naioya joins Ogie and
janichi as they wait for the news about
naobito's death Naomi criticizes his two
relatives which causes them to get
aggravated after neoya are the sly mofo
heirs defuses the entire situation that
he created which is like more than
Andrew Tate could ever achieve a man
named for a Darcy I I hope I got that
right probably didn't enters and informs
the three that the old man they would be
to has passed away Judo was injuries he
reads near a Beetle's will and announces
the neoya will become the 27th head of
his inner family and inherit all of his
assets once he is approved by either ogi
or janichi however in an utterly bizarre
twist of fate for adarte in reveals that
there is a clause based on a written
agreement with toji it states that if
Gojo has died or become mentally
incapacitated mikamik fushiguro will
assume the role of head instead hearing
this naoya is live Furious and knows
that the others would prefer to have
anyone other than himself as the head of
the clan he quickly learns from a female
attendant that Mega me is looking for
Yuji in Tokyo and tells her to inform
the higher-ups that he will kill Yuji
personally in addition he plans to take
advantage of the chaos in Tokyo and kill
migami to cement his role as the head of
the family skipping away from probably
my least favorite of The Big Three
Families apart from you know Marky and
Maya of course but you know those two
babes come soon probably in the next
dark I'm pretty sure anyway flashing
back we find Yuki on the phone with
someone who she apologizes to for not
making a move sooner she clearly remarks
that she may not necessarily be on their
side adding that she just wants to read
the world of cursed Spirits she says
that she and her comrades will take
responsibility for delivering the kids
who were present finally revealing that
she plans to confront tingen herself I'm
guessing that she's probably on the
phone to a bunch of higher-ups like the
same people that called her in and you
know if you guys have any dope theories
let me know down below it'd be super
interesting if she was actually talking
or like in coats or say a roommate or
another of these like mysterious
characters because that's just how she
feels to me right now she's a little bit
mysterious and still quite annoying like
even even now in the story so finally we
make our way over to Yuji as he sits
alone and despondent on a large
staircase choco approaches him and asks
about his injuries but Yuji says that he
is fine because of sakona but can also
tell that he is growing stronger and
side come choices say that he will be
fine by himself while he collects the
remains of his other family members and
tells Yuji that he can return to jiu
jitsu High however Yuji replies this
okona has something planned for Mega me
and that he himself has killed too many
people which again reminds choso of his
murdered Brothers calmly he says that it
was a misunderstanding and that
forgiveness isn't involved when it comes
to Brothers then is the two head out to
deal with more cursed Spirits both naoya
and Yuta are seen moving out to track
Yuji down and kill him standing alone on
a bridge Yuji collects his hands
together multiple times to draw out
several cursed Spirits he leaves them
down into an underpass which chosu
appears killing most of them with a
single shot from his piercing blood the
one remaining kerspur leaps towards
choso but Yuji easily crushes it against
the wall exercising the curse Spirit
having seen this Chelsea was surprised
by not only yuji's power but his agility
and control of cursed energy describing
him as a demon god even though he still
hasn't fully recorded from the fights
throughout Shibuya dude like literally
as a demon god he has the immortal King
inside from Brother choso you gotta
realize that one man he calls Yuji
impressive and addresses some as his
little brother once again which you know
I absolutely love Yuki asks if he is
going to continue doing that and chosu
answers that he will adding that yuji's
father had stitches on his forehead
which is obviously implying that yuji's
father would have been brain con and
like oh my Lord I don't even want to
talk about the crazy ass implications
that this would throw into the story
like if it is true it's just mental
suddenly naoya appears above them and
knows that he doesn't see Mega me SC2
below noticed him naioya asks if they
plan to run hearing this though just
leaves Yuji slightly concerned as he
doesn't know why he would to which Naomi
reveals that yuji's execution will now
resume since Gojo is no longer around to
protect him taking all this in Yuji
theme remembers Eno's words about how
there are many Sorcerers Gojo has saved
by protecting them from the higher ups
nayuya tells Yuji then he doesn't care
whether he lives or dies since his
business is with Mika me but states that
he can't allow him to be moving around
freely so instead he'll incapacitate him
and wait for Mega me Yuji asks what he
wants for the sorcerer to which you know
you replies that he plans for him to die
preferably after he writes something to
help his cause in the instant Naomi
leaps down and although Yuji notices his
technique he is unable to avoid a
punctual's face which sends him sliding
back before Yuji orchoso can move in to
land ahead of their own nairu quickly
jumps away and tells Yuji that he is
stronger than expected and also wonders
to himself about the identity of the
random men with him now he goes on to
ask the two if he should increase his
speed but all three of them suddenly
stop when they feel an overwhelming
presence Yuji initially thinks that it's
Gojo but then describes it as something
far darker and creepier he looks up and
sees the big man himself another of the
extremely freaking rare special Grace
Sorcerers Yuta who calmly prepares
Katana while commenting on the fact that
Yuji is not alone as Yuta and sheets his
Katana Yuji asks who he is and choso
seems to recognize his objective Yuda
jumps down from the balcony and destroys
a portion of the wall on his way down
leaving both toso and Yuji dumbfounded
with the show of Destruction
slowly approaching him he asks who the
random is to which choso says to Yuji
that Yuta must be his executioner
nowhere raises both his hands and
assures the kotsu that he is on his side
having heard the name yuchi recognizes
him as the student mentioned by migami
and like Gojo he's also a special grade
Sorcerer of unfathomable power now you
introduces himself as marky's cousin
saying that his objective is to kill
Yuji as well he assures Yuta that he
won't interfere but goes to ask for
something in return while they do this
chosen Whispers to Yuji that he needs to
run away since they still don't know the
track to naio's speed Yuji asks if he
will be okay holding him off and as he
releases blood manipulation chosu tells
Yuji that he has to focus on getting
away from Utah pointing out that if he
tries to fight someone of that strength
he will be killed no makes Awards on the
other side Neu asks you to hold off on
telling the higher-ups if he does kill
Yuji revealing that he is bait for
someone he intends to meet back with the
brothers Joseph Whispers to Yuji that he
will meet him at yesterday's sport to
which Yuji agrees then quickly after
Yoda agrees to naoya's plan leaving
chosu to him everyone suddenly makes
their move with futa instantly sprinting
past choso towards Yuji chisel attempts
to slow him down with a pacing blood
Shore but now you manages to interrupt
the attack Yuji Springs away from Utah
it's being caught by surprise at the
other's speed as Chelsea wonders if they
guessed his last move he really is up
his blood manipulation once again but
nayoya quickly strikes him before he can
use it although he is unsure as to why
choso has the blood manipulation ability
now he remains unfazed by it with the
exception of piercing blood he ends his
explanation since the wrist is obvious
to him telling choso that it's now time
for him to die however chosu's mood
changes as he becomes serious and he
asks naioya and he thinks he will leave
alive after he just tried to murder his
little brother it's so funny like you
just got like a a crew of these jacked
up ass Brothers following him around
making sure that he doesn't die at the
moment I absolutely love it anyways
anyways skipping away from the underpass
Gigi Sprints toward a car rested on its
side and leaps over it with you to
quickly running to the other side with
his Katana ready however Yuji grabs onto
the car and transposes his Direction
just barely dodging the attack utility
stunned since he thought he made contact
telling Yuji that he's just like Marky
with his natural physical abilities Yuji
then punches her car towards yusa and
since he knows that he can't win out on
the open tries to run towards a set of
buildings however the car is suddenly
thrown back above yuji's head stopping
him instantly you'd ask Yuji if he is
surprised since he doesn't look like the
strong type Yuji recognizes though the
enormous amount of cursed energy pouring
from him and realizes that the two are
Polar Opposites which is you know like
hella cool Queen vs king type thing I'd
love to see like more hyped Feats from
like Riker and Yuka in general and
sakuna as well and Yuji just so we
compare them up in this massive battle
to see who would come out on top when
they're going like falter against each
other honestly like let me know what you
guys think down in the description below
I've always loved the idea of these two
just going freaking at it for like hours
on end kind of like a like a one-piece
Battle of like akanu versus alkaichi
where they fought for like seven days on
an island and changed the geography of
their area like I love that whole idea
anyway YouTube then reveals that while
he has more cursed energy than Gojo they
teach you six eyes allow him to reduce
the curse energy when he activates a
technique to almost zero allowing him to
fight almost indefinitely after you just
says that he is done getting up big Gojo
he Sprints towards Yuji who while
overwhelmed remembers Toto's words about
an elite sorceress flow of cursed energy
and it being difficult to read due to
these strikes and seems to make contact
with his side of yuji's head but this
student quickly recovers and recognizes
the yuda's body and Katana are
constantly surging with energy he tells
himself that the issue as it has moves
but the fact that it's decisive with
every strike and can reduce any damage
you take to a minimum he remembers
nanami's final words to him and tells
you to that it's hard to idiot however
you music keeps on the offensive and
although Yoji Dodges almost all of his
strikes one of them grazes his cheek and
opens up a cart he realizes that he
needs to do something about yuda's
Katana he tells himself that he doesn't
need to fear blades if he reinforces his
body with cursed energy but also can't
overthink the situation otherwise he'll
end up dead as he dashes towards a large
SUV he jumps inside the open window and
spots a knife on the seat he quickly
picks it up before jumping up the
opposite window and continuing on
running usually leaps over the hood and
attacks him with his Katana though but
Yuji uses the survival knife that he
just picked up to block the strike yujit
is taken aback at first and wonders
where in the world did Yuji get a knife
from but quickly realizes that it must
have been inside of the car Eugene
lunges forward to close the gap and
abuse the knife of cursed energy trying
to fight back he remembers Gojo's words
about not relying on cursed tools to the
detriment of his own cursed Energy's
control as The Clash continues Yuji
knows that he hasn't learned how to
fight this way and then in a quick flash
Yuna tells him that he is focusing too
much much on his Katana before raising
it above his head and kicking him in the
stomach sending them reeling back you
can't believe the power of His Kirk but
even still he quickly recovers user then
follows up with an even more powerful
strike that breaks Eugene's knife and
cuts into his stomach however did you
use the momentum of you to strike to
Lodge his sword into the ground he then
follows up and pins it down and breaks
the blade with his faults which is like
insane by the way I I know this isn't a
curse tool or anything but still it had
good his curse energy flowing through it
and most likely protecting her in some
kind of way even Yuda is surprised at
first but calms himself down while
saying aloud that the fight was never
going to be easy although Yugi's wound
is deep he tells himself that his vitals
are intact and that both of them are now
unarmed but as he moves forward to
strike a large ominous creature suddenly
appears behind him and puts both of its
hands around his head she is Frozen in
fear and Judah tells reiker that the two
were just playing Yuji Hill was like
obviously confused and that's to know
what to make of it or the name or what's
going on wonders if it's a shikagami as
usually struggles user tells Rika to
hold the students still he then proceeds
to calmly stab him in the chest with the
broken Katana as Blood starts to drip
from yuji's mouth Yuta luxem in the eyes
and apologizes inside of Yuji sukuna is
completely caught off guard at first but
soon notices something and puts on his
malevolent Smile Back In The Underpass
with another of the parallels like just
gonna add in some more of my own brain
cells right here but I don't know why
it's taken me this long to realize both
parties in this Arc are like parallels
or like opposites of each other and the
regards that choto loves his siblings
will nail you despises his due to his
raker and Yuji has sakona like I find it
pretty interesting how Giga always seems
to have a bunch of differing themes
going on throughout each Arc literally
like all at the same time anyways
anyways chosu's struggles to keep up
with the speed of naoya who uses his
basic pitch version of projection
sorcery to Dart around and hit show also
well they Hard Punch towards Garts
railing from the attack chozu tells
himself that he has no clue what kind of
curse technique naoya is using and that
he most likely won't reveal it since he
is winning so easily now he continues to
overwhelm El boy with strikes while
trotto comments that convergence isn't a
viable option since he can't even
control the blood outside of his own
body Mr big bad zening then compliments
him on his strength while asking exactly
who he is choso and typical big
profession confidently says that he is
the oldest of 10 siblings before
suddenly using the ORD over flowing red
scale stick changing in markings on his
face and causing new ones to appear by
the way the reason this technique
literally like shits all over camo's new
one is because big choso has improved on
the basic version and pretty much made
his own kind of like what other
characters do with barriers and their
own abilities throughout the you know
world after chosu says that he is the
oldest of the 10 siblings now he
clarifies that he's asking about his
curse technique and toughness suddenly
disappearing from his view chosen
notices they blew beside him though and
quickly turns to face the incredibly
fast naioya who realizes that chozo has
focused flowing red scale and the muscle
of his eyes to raise this sharpness so
that he can adjust to his speed however
naio easily counters chosu's counter
striking him and his stomach and saying
that he always assumes someone will
counter him first as chosu recovers from
the strike blood solubicans to pour from
an open wound in his chest Naomi reveals
that he decided to use a knife to affect
his blood manipulation asking him how
long he can continue to fight in that
condition oh boy now condom messed up
here with just one damn thing he
disrespected his younger siblings and
doesn't even freely realize what chozo
is as well like I can't even believe
that at this point chosu looks like a
pale zombie anyway anyway Jose convenes
his plan will Naomi continues talking
about how using hidden weapons isn't
considered cool he adds that many do
carry them around and are often
dependent on him saying that the way in
which his older brothers show off their
weapons is pathetic and how he was
always disgusted at the fact they feared
toji chozo mentions naria's dislike for
his brothers and Aria says that the
older brothers who are weaker than the
younger brothers should just hang
themselves and die since they are
pointless which is so freaking wild man
like this guy's mind is so damn broken
at this point he needs help man someone
help him Josie replies they know you may
be the way he is now because of his
brothers and the way they treated him to
which naoia scoffs at chosu's cliche
reasoning big bro choso continues by
saying that regardless of their strength
older brothers are role models and give
their younger brothers the chance to
avoid their mistakes that they make
themselves or to follow behind them if
they go down the right path he asks
neoya so consider the possibility that
he is strong only because his older
brothers are weak Josephine reveals that
he is strong because he had no one older
to guide him forcing him to face his own
mistakes and continue walking ahead of
his younger brothers as the blood from
choso's wound Paul's at his fate and
begins to blow away from from him now
you're back's up and wonders how can he
survive after so much blood loss it's
been finally explained the death
paintings have blood mixed from curse
words and humans allowing them to not
die from blood loss since they can
convert cursed energy bear into blood
chosen raises a wall of blood which
causes nailya to lose sight of him
however a slower slicing excessive
attack comes shooting out of the blood
which an area easily Ducks below and
comes to the conclusion that choso is
finally dying from the blood loss
however chosu suddenly appears several
faked to the left of Mr misogyny and
finds a pissing blood shot which he
barely Dodges but quickly understands
that he can't make contact worth while
the Wall of Blood still flowing toward
him now your barely blocks a kick from
chosu and finds that some of the blood
has actually stained his Akama he
wonders if the blood now covering him is
also affecting his movement opposite him
and Standing Tall chose to prepare to
fight another piercing blood shot as
blood hovers around him almost mimicking
The Wing King ability that is of hair
possessed he tells naoya that he knows
what comes next and then now it's
checkmates Naomi remains confident and
tells himself that he can still move
despite the binding effect he tells
choso to go ahead and fire but as he
dashes towards him here's a moment of
hesitation where he wonders why chozo
isn't releasing the attack as then
explained in a typical cutaway anime
manga style that the move choso would
use was his own so you all know a
of ability is about to go off created
after he honest technique for a hundred
and fifty years choso then releases a
supernova attack causing a large orb of
blood to shoot out in several directions
and strike all over the entirety of
Neo's body leaving him utterly finished
chosu apologizes and says that he lost
because he didn't love his brothers
however behind choso Yuta suddenly
appears Dragon an unconscious Yuji by
his hoodie chosu tries to react but due
to effortlessly strikes him in the side
of the face which in turn knocks him
straight to the ground as naily looks up
you just says in what feels like a damn
degrading tone that he seems to be hurt
like oh you're okay down there in a
little little nail your man you seem a
little bit hurt as Judah looks down on
the wounded naota the lesson please
beget him before vomiting up blood he
worries that chose his blood
manipulation poisoned him but assures
himself that it isn't the effect of a
curse technique he then realizes that
choso must be a full-on curse because of
how much blood he used then guesses that
his own body is rejecting the non-human
blood Hooter still standing above him
offers to heal him with his reverse
curse technique if he tells his
superiors that Yuji is dead well that is
the end of the battle that takes place
and finally wraps up all of the madness
that has literally been going on for
over 60 freaking chapters but don't
worry because imma finish off this video
with probably the most freaking mind
twisting and series changing moment
anyways a man named jyn is seen holding
their baby which is obviously the big
man himself Yuji and his Daddy-o or
hopefully anyway the man tells his
father that if he wants to talk about
her he will just leave the older man
who's revealed to be yuji's grandfather
was Suki itadori tells Jin that while he
can live his life however he pleases he
will die if he does not give up on her
Jin tells was okay to not say such
things in front of Yuji since babies
apparently remember more than most
believe and you know like we've seen it
now which is an example of it and I hope
we get other flashbacks like this stuff
revealed to us from like yuji's parents
because I want to know so much more
about this stuff here super interesting
to me and Liz none of it out there
butsuki mentions the fact that Jin
wanted a child with a normal woman named
kaori but before wasuke can continue on
about her death a woman with stitches on
her forehead interrupts him and
addresses him as her father-in-law
asking what he's talking about okay so
the flashback ends there but well this
Insanity did she have the trial before
brain Queen took over or was it after as
Franklin even in her head or is it a
tattoo like I'm obviously assuming that
it's a brain Con in there and then it's
taken over uh during the pregnancy or
before Yuji got pregnant she came back
from the dead and then bonked with Dario
and now yuji's here and that's why he
has the blood relation with chozo and
that's like kind of my thoughts on that
and real sure but let me know yours down
below Yuji suddenly awakens the next way
fire as an emotionless Utah sits nearby
he's surprised that he's not dead and
you just Smiles with relief revealing
that goju had come to see him around
September and asked if he would watch
over Yuji skipping back to then goju
tells Yuta to take care of the first and
second years if anything happens to him
while akari should be fine YouTube
wonders if goju means get a new
girlfriend which is like randomly funny
since you can't imagine anything
actually happening to the big man
himself goju specifies that his primary
concern should be the first year named
Yuji isadori goju then asks where
miguelas but you do replies that he
doesn't want to see Gojo and this is
probably to do with like Miguel and the
special rope that he had during JFK zero
you know like in his fight that he had
with Gojo back in the present you just
says that he put on an ax for the
higher-ups so that he would be the
Executioner in charge and know all about
the details of what's going on he adds
that to get approved as yuji's
executioner here to enter a binding
vowel to actually kill him a confused
Yuji asks how he's still alive then to
which Juda replies that the very instant
his heart stopped he healed him with his
reversed curse technique he adds that
not many people even know that he has
the ability and guessed that it would
work on ug Judah points out that because
it's the second time that yuji's death
has been staged the higher-ups will
learn the truth soon but will consider
his death sentence complete for the time
being Yuji wonders why he's doing all of
this for him and Judah replies that Yuji
is important to people who are important
to him he tells Yuji that he also used
to possess the power that he couldn't
handle but says that while he invited
his own upon himself usually did not and
shouldn't be blamed for that which is
you know like super wholesome from him
because he knows where he's coming from
Yuji says that they blame isn't the
issue but before he can continue migami
finally shows elf and suddenly walked
out of the darkness while telling Yuji
that they should head back to Jujutsu
high before making me can finish
mentioning rejoining the Oddish students
Yuji interrupts him by telling him not
to acts like everything is normal and
nothing happened he also remembers
yuji's words about not being able to die
yet and says to himself that Youjizz
unsure whether he deserves to live or
not realizing that it's the reason why
he held back when the two were fighting
Yuji then yells out and pure desperation
that he has killed people and many
others are dead because of him the mega
me rebuttals that it's all their fault
telling Yuji not to be selfish or give
up by himself as Yuji stays quiet and
says to himself that he knew megaby
would say there making me looked at his
sigh and says that they introduce whose
Sorcerers not Heroes fighting for
justice he explains that they can never
be judged for what they do and just have
to keep proving to others that they
deserve to exist and in debt they can't
think about themselves with all of the
other people they have to save Megan me
reminds Yuji that that was his original
motive but Yuji closes his eyes and says
that it's because as long as migami is
around him he will suffer migami like
the best freaking mate you could ever
have then tells yuchi to start by saving
him and begs Yuji for a strength
revealing that brain con has started a
culling game for those with cursed
energy and his sister sukumi has
awakened one and is now trapped the
culling games ate known rules are then
explained by the way there are like many
more rules that have been added or
updated throughout the current Cullen
game Arc this is just the core 8 rules
that are first revealed to them the
first rule is that players must declare
their participation at any given barrier
within 19 days after Awakening a curse
technique so like people like sukumi
this is why she's in grave danger
because she has to go into a barrier and
activate her like Chester participate in
this culling game she has no other
choice players who break the first rule
could have their curse technique removed
and this honestly results in death
that's what happens when you run out of
cursed energy you die 3. non-players who
enter the barrier become players and are
considered to have declared their
participation upon entry 4. points are
scored by killing other people 5. points
are determined by the game master with
sorcerer's worth five points and
non-sorcerers worth one point players
may spend 100 points excluding the value
of their own life with the game master
to add one new rule seven the game
master must accept any new rule except
those that have a considerable and
prolonged effect on the game so
literally like no one can be like yo
cancel the game or in the game it's you
can't make that rule and finally the
last one that has been revealed so far
eight players have their curse technique
removed if their score stays the same
for 19 days so you know like there's a
whole mixture of things going on right
now like sukumi is in Mad danger she
either needs to kill people or they need
to implement some new rule that means
they can transfer points to people so
she has more points after 19 days and
doesn't die pretty much with migami's
sister having been revealed to be caught
up in the culling game for shikuro like
the best friend he is tells Yuji to let
go of his past mistakes the things he
can't control to instead help save his
sister now thinking about his
grandfather's final words Yuji comes up
with a compromise he instead asks Yuta
to kill him in the event that zakuna
should ever take over his body again
YouTube believes that the big man akotsu
is stocky enough to be able to take him
down to which the second year agrees
saying that he'll do what he can so
after the agreement migami lays out the
plan to them they first need to contact
tingen and find out how to actually
unseal Gojo and what Brian kon's
objectives truly are the game itself is
a form of Jujutsu terrorism on a scale
that has never been seen before and
migami believes that they need answers
to ever mentioned questions Yuji asks if
Yuki would know to watch mikumi reveals
that this was her idea and obviously
this goes to prove that instead of the
higher-ups like I said in the previous
video it was actually Mega me that she
was you know in contact with a tune that
yoga he is hiding at Jiu Jitsu High
currently and waiting for them while
trying to avoid the higher-ups there
Yuda goes on to say that there is a
problem with contacting tingen due to
the recent events back in the Gojo past
Arc tingen's concealing barrier is
active and shuffles over 1 000 doors
continuously with only one leading to
him Yuji interrupts and asks what the
situation with nobara is but only gets
an encouraging saddened look as a
response from his boy trying to contain
his emotions Yuji leans over and also
looks to the ground while repeating I
get hurt
chosu who I somehow forgot to mention
was still around because he's my boy
abruptly makes it known that he may know
a way past Yuji asks what he means and
chosen reminds them on how mojito had
stolen some of sukuna's fingers in death
paintings from Jujutsu and the past then
goes on to say that he thinks he can do
the same thing skipping forward all four
of the boys which by the way like what a
freaking goated group right here they
all into this school in secrets and
meets with Yuki and Mahi inside seeing
Maki for the first time since Shibuya
it's obvious that she's visibly taken a
freaking beating from a fight with jogo
and Dagon there even after shoku's
reverse curse technique her body is
still severely mutilated concerned for
her Yuda goes up to Marquee and asks if
it's okay for her to be moving seeing
this though Yuki explains to him that a
reverse curse technique can't actually
prevent scars from Burns Mikey was
literally only able to survive Joker's
Flames because of the physical
durability granted to her through her
Heavenly restriction Maki then asks Mega
about their plan to slip past the
concealing barrier choso like the big
Pro years volunteers to inform the group
and explains that between the correct
door and the tomb is a cursed Warehouse
where his brothers are currently being
stored his connection to them will allow
him to guide everyone to the correct
door Maki is satisfied with the plan but
she needs clarification on who exactly
choso is after a brief silence Yoshi
reluctantly tells everyone just to think
of choso as his big brother for now
which like oh my Lord choso must have
had like fireworks go off inside of his
head or something like even in reality
he's visibly shocked and excited to
finally hear that Yuji is saying his
name skipping forward chosu guides the
group to the correct door confident that
his brothers sleep Beyond it Yugi is
surprised to find that there is no solar
path Beyond the Doors just a massive
drop into a forested area filled with
tall old trees after Yuki tells them to
move forward and searches the elevator
the group walks past a warehouse which
also stops for a moment he reluctantly
touches the door and asks his brothers
to just wait a little longer for him to
return and save them honestly I want to
make shoso who's one of either choso's
brothers or sisters I feel like it's
going to be a goated female version of
choso like honestly we just we gotta
have her in the series as well if chosa
was this cool after the group takes the
elevator down to the Tomb of the star
Yugi notices blood stains on the ground
and asks what happened Yuki says that
it's the remains of when everything in
the Jiu Jitsu World began to distort
even picturing the demon himself for
shiguro in her mind after a moment Yuki
moves on and leads them directly to the
main Shrine and once there they walk
into nothing but a completely stark
white void with everyone confused Yuki
says tingen is currently rejecting them
normally The Entity doesn't interact
with the world but Yuki thought contact
may have been possible now that Gojo has
been sealed she also considers the
possibility that tinken isn't rejecting
everyone and instead just here this is
you know obviously just due to the fact
that she has her own agenda and in some
ways wouldn't mind knocking off all of
the higher-ups Just Like Gojo unsure of
what to do Yuda tells everyone that they
should hit back since migami's sister
doesn't have time to waste suddenly a
voice rings out and asks why are they
all leaving so soon the thumb of an
entity then appears Master tingen
finally reveals himself while saying
it's a pleasure to meet the children of
the Xenon family machizane's descendant
which I I really hope I didn't botch
because it always sounds so freaking
weird in my head the death painting womb
and finally sukuna's vessel while
everyone else is surprised by tingen's
thumb like shape Yuki asks why tingen
didn't address her in the Greet him
Tegan replies that this isn't the first
time they've met Yuki's next question is
why the Tomb of the star was closed to
which it's revealed tingen is unable to
see into the human heart and feared that
Yuki was aligned with kinjaku finally
like oh my God I can stop calling by the
900 names I keep giving him as it's
explained through tingen here that
kinjaku is the real name of the body
switching entity that was once known as
narutoshi kamo and now inhibits the body
of suguru ghetto Yuji by the absolute
melon he'd hears Cuts in on the
conversation to ask why tingen looks so
freaking weird while mikumi stands their
surprise with Yuji tenkin explains that
even though his curse technique grants a
form of immortality it's not anti-aging
11 years ago when the star plays
murphysil failed tingen's aging process
accelerated and the self-awareness it
had as an individual diminished
therefore it was forced to evolve and
now technically has become one with the
world itself which is a lot to take in
and has so many implications in this
story they have like even yet to be
explained like what even is this
Evolution he was meant to go through
like why was it considered bad and the
Gojo past Arc if he didn't assimilate
when now he can still control the
barriers and all of that kind of stuff
anyways anyways mikimi and YouTube I get
to the point and ask about kinjaku's
objectives along with unsealing Gojo
from the prison realm tingen goes on to
say that he will provide information on
one condition at least two of the three
people prison that a special grade must
remain at the Tomb of the star to serve
as guards since the lot are kind of
confused as to why tenkin explains that
kinjaku wants to force the evolution of
all of the people in Japan but he can't
do this while tenkins barriers are
active because that requires an insane
amount of cursed energy starting an
evolution of that scale using the cursed
technique as utterly inefficient instead
the Mythic kinjaku has chosen is to
merge tenken with mankind itself since
evolving into this new state it is now
possible for tenkin to merge with
someone who isn't the star place for
vessel any human who merges with the
tingen evolves into something Beyond a
sorcerer that is both there and not part
of the Physical Realm at the same time
tinken stabilized and maintains
self-control even after evolving thanks
to the barrier techniques but says the
world would end if anyone merges with
him it's explained that there would be
no boundaries between individuals and
the impurities of millions of humans
would flood the entire world what
happened to Tokyo would engulf the
entire planet resulting in a world of
cursed Spirits what's actually insane is
that tengen also can't refuse the merger
because they failed assimilation has
caused them to turn into more of a curse
Spirit than a human being which is
obviously a perfect Target for someone
with curse manipulation so kinjaku's
plan is finally revealed Honestly though
like the amount of time that must have
gone into this plan and sitting upper in
preparation and getting all the people
that he needs to get it must have been
absolutely freaking mental anyways due
to the threat of kinjaku coming to
unseal the tomb the corridor is
rejecting everyone that approaches hence
you know like the white room King Jacob
was the one who set the plan in motion
that stopped the merger 11 years ago it
was also involved with sukuna over a
thousand years ago to which Yuki wonders
why as he making a move just now it said
that the tingen star plays my vessel and
six eyes are connected by Fate kinjaku
has been defeated by two different
success users in the past and after a
second defeat he managed to kill the
star plasma vessel and the next
six-sized user the day after they were
born yet despite all of these efforts
they still somehow appeared on the day
of the merger were tingen being left at
a dead end made him switch to the method
of sealing the six eyes instead of
attempting to eradicate it completely
however an eternal fate that neither
tingen or kinjaku ever expected 11 years
ago the Heavenly gifted demon toji
fushiguro intervened a man who escaped
curse energy entirely and therefore was
not bound by the chains of Fate that
affected the Jiu Jitsu World an effect
told you destroyed the Destinies that
bound tingen the star plasma vessel and
the six eyes then along with toji came
Suga dugito a boy who just happened to
be able to manipulate curse Spirits then
after what could have been thousand
years worth of research kinjaku secured
the prison realm six years ago and all
his plans fell into place so in all
actuality this game is a ritual to
really the people of Japan for a massive
merger with tingen it uses the player's
curse energy and the barriers to
transfer everyone to the other side
through these weird veil-like Customs
Tinker can be forced to merge with all
of humanity in order to pull off
something of this level kinjaku has
restricted himself with these binding
vowels one stipulates that he is not the
game master so even killing him will not
end the game instead the only way that
it can end is once all of the players
are dead and there are rules in place to
ensure that nothing can interrupt the
original ritual the other best possible
course of action for them would be to
expend 100 points to add rules when
migumi's sister and others who are
unwilling to participate can escape the
game free and Saturday Gojo would also
be extremely ideal but before tenken
reveals how they're able to do this it
requires the group to to pick two of
them to serve as guards they are like
big thumb dropping a truckload of
freaking insane information that changes
the entire landscape of the world like
it truly goes to show how much time and
effort has gone into this plan on
kinjaku's side even now if he dies his
plan is still in place and he expects
that he will come out on top no matter
what following this Yuki and choso
volunteer themselves as chosu knows Yuji
will need you this help and this will
also give him a chance to protect his
brothers shukinjaku comforting In Here
yupi Also isn't finished talking with
tingen either way and would like to stay
back if that's meant with the others
wanting to be around everyone else you
happily agrees with the plan after
thanking them tingen then proceeds to
take out the back of the prison realm
explaining that it is a separate cursed
object that will be necessary and
unsealing Gojo after hinjaku found the
front he had the bag back in jahu now be
as complete authority over their prison
realm as the bearer of the front gate
and can block them from accessing the
bag breaking it open is instead the only
way and would require curse tools they
can cancel curse techniques like the
inverted sphere of heaven or the black
robe however both of those were lost in
secret battles with Gojo so like
obviously for those who don't know what
these are it's the blade that toji used
in his fight with Gojo 11 years earlier
in the Gojo past Arc and the black rope
that Miguel used against Gojo during the
night parade of a hundred demons and
juicy Kaizen zero but you know anyways
anyways in an attempt to look for more
of like that rope user had already been
searching in Africa with Miguel but
sadly to no avail as it takes centuries
for them to create something like it
however there is still one way to get
into the back of the present realm a
thousand years ago there was a female
sorcerer who called herself Angel she
possessed a curse technique that could
extinguish others curse techniques
pretty much nullifying them her name is
hanakurasu and she's been incarnated as
a culling game player honestly this
character poses so much of like a
curveball the game whilst kinjaku
decided to also revive or bring back
this sorcerer what's the specifications
around her coming back and being a part
of this game there has to be some like
reasoning behind it allowing someone who
would like pose a threat to the
Integrity of the game to come back and
participate in the first place seems
kind of wet you know tingen repeats that
Angel's technique will be necessary to
open the back of the prison realm with
everyone confused making me asks what
Angel is and tinken can only say that
she is in the colony on the east side of
Tokyo it is then shown that there are 10
colonies that are connected by barriers
that form a line down Japan this line of
barriers will merge everyone in Japan
with a tingen and transfer them to the
other side Hokkaido isn't actually
included because it's already been
established as a sacred area that has
been assimilated which is like what do
you mean by that is Ricardo reminiscent
of ancient Japan in regards to the curse
spirits and fights that are currently
going on there anyways anyways this
whole mental idea of evolving Humanity
by merging the people tingen's current
state is extremely complex and sounds
somewhat exaggerated however this is
only a testament to how serious the
situation actually is tingen then
reveals that a curse head and sacred
merged with every single person in Japan
in preparation for the merger and
believes it will now only take about two
months to fully complete the ritual the
group then goes over the rules of the
Cullen game once again the first rule
states their place must declare their
participation at any colony of their
choice within 19 days currently it's 9am
on the 9th of November and all players
have awakened their curse techniques
around midnight on the 31st of October
which was when kinjaku initiated the
Countrywide idle Transfiguration this
only gives migami's sister 10 days and
15 hours to declare participation in the
Cullen game the second rule states that
anyone who breaks the first rule will be
subject to curse technique removal Marky
had previously talked with shoko about
this rule of the game believing the
acoustic removal implies that it's not
through idle Transfiguration or a
binding vowel but instead she thinks
that it must be something that must
happen to the user's brain which would
in turn kill them as if it was a vowel
all players could simply refuse
participation tenkin confirms shoko's
theory meaning that people like Maki Who
currently don't even possess cursed
energy aren't actually at a risk of
dying rule number three explains that
anyone who enters a colony after the
games have begun will be considered an
official participant civilians until the
barriers will be given one chance to
exit and there are currently no rules
about entering or exiting colonies when
the game starts players will be given an
incentive to move towards the colony
excerpts this serves as an incentive to
stimulate participation as in order to
confine players effectively they must
believe they entered the games of their
own free will the fourth rule was the
one it states players score points by
killing one another the fifth one
specifies that each player's points
value is determined by the game master
currently Sorcerers are worth five
points and non-sorcerers are worth one
having just heard of this game master
tingen explains to them that each player
receives a shikigami known as cocaine
this creature serves as the games
interface while the game master serves
as the program that runs it in some way
obviously this concept is super
confusing as gike is on his astral shirt
like even Yuji is left in a comically
lost State rule 6 states that players
can spend 100 of their own scored points
to negotiate a new rule in the game
these rules can't be subtracted but
migami thinks they might be able to
create other rules as roundabout ways to
counter the original ones without
disrupting the game in accordance with
rule 6 rule 7 states that the game
master must accept any new rule as long
as it doesn't have a long lasting effect
on the game the group wonders if the
rules of fear buttingen assures them
that King Joker receives no bias towards
himself with these rules and they can
expect to be treated fairly just like
any other player the eighth and final
rule states that a player will be
subject to curse technique removal if
this score does not change for 19 days
this causes usually to worry about
whether or not he'll have to kill others
but again Mega me suggest that he might
have a few ways around that with all the
information thoroughly reviewed Maki
then begins to go over everyone's role
Yuki and choso will remain at the Tomb
of the star while Al Gil Maki will
return to the zinning clan to collect
the missing curse tools now that Mega me
is the zening Clans leader Marky will be
able to use this to her advantage to get
them Mucky then inquires about the
location of Jose kamiya's Workshop which
she will go to before recruiting Panda
to the group this juuzo dude in his
Workshop is the guy that gakuganji
fought and the one that Gojo later
absolutely mangle like broke all his
limbs they must have interrogated him
for the location of his Workshop where
he made all his weird ass tools and
stuff anyway you will instantly take
part in the Cullen game to gather
information long performing sister and
the others have to join Yuji will try to
avoid nearby colonies to prevent
collateral damage in case something
happens but because of this he might be
out of touch since the barriers likely
block phone reception he quickly
realizes this presents an issue as Yuji
asks you to kill him should sukuna ever
appear again they both think for a
moment until migami says that Yoda can
just kill Yuji if he dies first but Yuji
wants to try and prevent migami's death
in the first place Maki tells Yuji and
Megami that their role is to find Hikari
Kenji the suspended third year and to
recruit him to their group despite his
Moody attitude akari is apparently
insanely tough With Yuri going as far as
to say that when he's riled up hakaris
passes everyone even him in strength
after this everyone finally moves out
but not before Yuji thanks choso for
everything he has done so far and while
he waves goodbye his big bro tells him
to not go dying on him out there
meanwhile it probably a similar time and
a random comedy club called the public
stand everyone sits around bored with an
act that's obviously bombing on stage
like the man visibly sucks ass at comedy
his name anyway turns out to be fumuhiko
takaba his mate tells the 35 year old
takaba to quit because he's simply not
cut out for the job this massive
Japanese dude who just happens to be in
the corner says he doesn't mind his dumb
jokes he thinks there are two types of
comedians who will always be in demand
Comics who are funny and Comics who
wholeheartedly believe that they are
funny kin who's the mess of Japanese
dude asks takaba which of the two he
believes he is takaba says it's 50 50 at
first before receiving a strange impulse
then deciding to change his answer to 70
30. well well hasn't an Army's technique
revived itself and someone else I don't
know just a thought I love the idea that
it could possibly be The Reincarnation
of nanami's technique or at least I hope
it is anyway skipping back to a moment
shortly after Panda's birth masamichi is
seemed confined and is cell with both of
his hands bound it's explained through
geckukanji that it's normal for a cursed
corpse to operate independently as they
usually consume cursed energy provided
by its user in comparison panda is a
self-supporting curse corpse that can
generate his own cursed energy pretty
much like the man literally created life
itself because of this the higher-ups
were in the process of designating him
as a special grade and actually imposing
him with an indefinite restraint after
stating this to him Goku ganji asked how
Panda was made but masamichi insisted
that he didn't know now in the present
Yaga is only run but Chillin only forest
with one of his dolls the curse corpse
is able to talk and calls out to
masumichi saying everyone is worried
about how gloomy he's become masamichi
pets his head and reveals that he won't
be able to return anytime soon adding
their Master tinken protects the forest
they are currently hiding in after
saying he'll be fine on his own they
head over to a tree where Yaga opens a
small door inside many of us small
harmless independent cursed corpses
reside knowing that they will never see
him again they tell him they will all
miss him meanwhile and so the isolation
holding chamber etches you too high
kuzukabe uses his Katana to cut Panda
free he goes on to say that he is doing
this as a favor to repay masamichi but
make sure to tell Panda to not reveal
who helped him flashing back to the past
once again we learn they must admit she
created an independent cursed corpse
with kusakabe's nephew's Soul
information kusakabe's sister had lost
his son and couldn't live on without the
support that he was providing her one
day when she was brought to Yaga a small
dog-like doll asked if that woman was
his mother then goes on to say he's a
genius after being confirmed right by
Yaga kuzukabe's sister immediately
recognizes her son's mannerisms and
instantly darts out of a catatonic state
to embrace him after the two console
each other masamichi explains that he
couldn't allow takuru which is the real
child's name like not the doll but like
the real a child to live with his mother
as he couldn't risk getting out that a
fully independent curse corpse existed
even still kusakabe apologized and
emotionally expressed his gratitude
towards masamichi for doing so by the
way this whole moment it just happened
was actually before Panda was even born
I forgot to mention that but it probably
makes a bit more sense on how the fact
that no one knew an independent curse
corpse existed at the time back in the
present day Yaga is confronted by an
unknown sorcerer he asks we must meet
she is going without any of his cursed
corpses to back him up while removing
his jacket are the freaking absolute
Beast he is the principal simply replies
that he is going to see his son this
sorcerer is left slightly confused as he
doesn't know what masamichi means but
goes on to explain the severity of the
current situation the principal finds
himself in he says the only way to save
himself now is to reveal how to create
independent cursed corpses immediately
asimichi says that his adversaries have
gotten comfortable getting pushy without
Gojo around to which the sorcerer
degrees especially as it's been
accompanied by a veteran sorcerer On Cue
gaganji suddenly steps out of his
shadows and Deals masamichi a fatal blow
to his chest shattering the electric
guitar and leaving immortally wounded
with two deep cuts across his front
forming an x-shape that also split his
blood alongside the wall yakuganji tells
the sorcerer accompanying him to leave
the two principles alone then with his
last words masamichi suddenly begins
explaining exactly how to create
independent cursed corpses he states
that his Soul's information can be
replicated from physical information and
imported into cursed Corpse's cause
these cores must contain three highly
compatible Souls which are always
observing each other this is the only
way Souls will stabilize and give rise
to self-awareness and self-sustaining
cursed energy confused and shocked by
all over this dakuganji asks why
masamichi would tell him now instead of
trying to live by revealing this earlier
just then before passing away masamichi
replies that it's a curse being passed
on from him
instantly after Panda arrives only
moments too late just as masamichi dies
gakuganji throws down the broken remains
of his weapon and anticipation for panda
to retaliate however Panda simply walked
straight past them towards masamichi
without so much as ever glancing
egokanji
confused he asks why panda doesn't fight
but Panda reveals that he's not like
humans and their behaviors do not blind
him he understands that kakuganji was on
good terms with masamichi and these
orders probably came from the higher ups
even so Panda sheds a tear for his
father and tells Gago kanji to remember
that even pandas cry which is just like
too damn sad man recent peace big
musumichi absolute go anyway anyway now
we skip away to the absolute brutality
that happens over at the Zenon household
I call my Lord you guys are not ready
for what is about to happen if you have
not seen this moment you are going to
literally freak it is so good our girl
oh let's get into it so in order to
fulfill her role in helping with the
culling game Marky returns to a place
where she's never felt welcome as she
enters these Indian household to collect
the curse tools she's immediately
greeted by the misogynistic neo-year
seeing how scarred she is now he taunts
her as he believes or Maggie head was
your attractiveness and now that it's
gone he asks if he should mercilessly
bully her like he used to in the past he
continues to throw abuse towards our
girl however she just ignores his crude
ass and heads on underground after the
scene means some of the stairs into the
underground Corridor Maki finds her
mother awaiting her there she reminds
her daughter that they cannot enter the
warehouse to which Maki like the boss
she has nonchalantly holds up their keys
while saying that Mega me is the new
head of the clan and gave her permission
and a flashback we find out that Marky
was actually the person who revealed to
Mega me that he had become the head of
the clan heavily reluctant with the idea
of being head making me suggest that he
let Maki take over for him instead but
she denies the option as she knows no
one would accept her she points out that
he's inherited visiting Clans prized tin
Shadows technique and achieved its
domain expansion Mega me really didn't
want to take the role as hid and asked
if things like acceptance mattered if
she becomes a clan hid she would still
get the resources but Maki doesn't
believe she's good enough to make this
home a place where my belongs not yet
once Maki said that about her sister
migami finally understood in the present
as Marky cruises past her mother she
suddenly screamed at by her to stop and
instead come back marky's mother asks
why her daughter is always like this and
tells her to at least make her mother
proud once for giving birth to her
however Maki just completely ignores her
pleas and continues on until she finds a
door that seals the cursed Warehouse
after using the key to unseal the chains
holding their doors together Maki
finally enters however she's instantly
shocked to see her father unexpectedly
sitting inside of the room without a
single curse tool in sight maki's father
who was another of the misogynistic lot
reveals that he anticipated Mikey's move
and emptied out all of the curse tools
beforehand he stands up and reveals mice
injured body behind him Mai seen Maki
there for the first time calls her an it
for coming which is really random when
you put it in that context meanwhile
junichi meets with nayoya to fill him in
on the circumstances jinichi explains an
aoya that Mega me is the better choice
for the clan head because of his good
relationship was set at a Gojo and
narutoshi kaimo at the same time jinichi
refuses to allow an outsider to inherit
the entire Fortune naioya asks why they
don't just get rid of him but then you
need she explains that they can't do
that killing Megami outright will hurt
these inning Clan standings while the
other Gojo and kamo Clans and they would
fall behind in the power vacuum left
behind by Saturday
asks why they're doing it now if that's
the case engineer she explains that
they're going to take advantage of the
notice from Jujutsu headquarters it's
explained there through them that it's
been deemed a crime to unseal saturno
Gojo so this inning Clan is going to
execute migami Maki and Mai as Rebels
plotting to do so now he is amused by
the plan and while killing his own
daughters will boost okie's credibility
know your wonders if he is actually okay
with the idea to which as the battle
begins between father and daughter
junichi reveals to naoya that this plan
was originally ogi's idea which just
goes to show like how up this
inning Clan is and how old all of their
thoughts are like look at the house the
woman the men the clothes like literally
everything it's it's time to move
forwards in and Clan you just you guys
just do not get it like don't get me
wrong I actually love it because that's
the whole point of the sect in a way to
make you hate the group while still
wanting to know more about all of them
especially naoya like that dude has just
reading absolutely perfectly back as the
battle starts off Okie activates his
falling Blossom emotion he explains that
he kept Mai alive as a bargaining chip
in case Marky arrived with any unknown
curse tools that cause in an emergency
situation Marky wields juuzou's
Masterpiece the goated curse tool dragon
bone its effect or ability I guess is
that after accumulating cursed energy
the user can eject it out the back of
the blade to increase its cutting power
Mikey plans to take advantage of ogi's
ignorance and bait entering a single
strike Jewel while actually intending to
hit back multiple times just before
ending's standoff Augie asks why Mikey
thinks neobito was chosen over him as
head of the clan Mahi asks if it's
because he's a terrible person willing
to kill his own children which instantly
prompts Okie to start the fight as Okie
darts forward she blocks his first slash
and follows up with an attack of her own
utilizing the momentum granted by cursed
energy shooting out the back of the
blade oh he tries to Parry but quickly
notices his katana blade is actually
broken allowing Marky to get behind him
and go for the finishing blow however
with some unrealistically Fast Tire me
from an old-timer Okie quickly spins
around and counters for this blazing
curse technique momentarily solidifying
his blade before he cuts Mikey down
Mikey's already busted eye as a game Hit
and cuts open along with her lower
abdomen which was sliced through from
the attack left with death injuries Maki
doesn't understand what happened until
she realizes that Oogie's blade has been
replaced by the Flames of his cursed
energy as she falls defeated Okie shoots
a tear and reveals he couldn't become
head of the clan because his children
are indeed worthless
man I like I said I hate this in
family's ideology and like Jujutsu in
general like if you wanted your kids to
improve you would teach them techniques
and not treat them like absolute ass all
the time it's not Marky who's the
failure in this like situation Mr ogisan
it was your failure as a hero to teach
your children correctly and guide them
and now it is time to pay the
consequences as Ogie drags his twin
daughter's bleeding bodies down a
corridor leaving a trail of their blood
behind him he explains why Marquee lost
he says that she stepped in close and
treated her opponent like a swordsman
and not a sorcerer he repeats that he
did not become head of the clan because
of the quality of his children naobito's
projection sorcery technique doesn't
have much of a history outside of
passing it down to neo-year so this was
not a determining factor and a choice
the only difference between them was how
strong their children turned out to be
Oggy states that children must not hold
back their parents and tosses his
daughter down a flight of stairs like
the trash he thinks they are into an
empty large room he explains this area
is for training and discipline a
plethora of curse Spirits are kept fear
they will eat the twins as soon as Ogie
leaves he mocks Marky and claims her
Heavenly restriction is nothing compared
to other sorcerers who trained and
reinforced their muscles with curse
energy every single day for years on end
her father then turns his back on his
daughters and says farewell to the
stains of his life one final time before
the curses move in Mai is able to sit up
and puts marky's head on her lap as she
feels Mikey's heart beating she notes
how tough her twin truly is okay I used
to hate Mai but like really in this
moment right here it fully changed my
total outlook on her I always thought
that she was just another of the Xenon
household content with the way things
are and that's why she was always a
towards Marquee but right now we
find out that Mai suspected that this
would happen someday and is ready to do
what his name necessary to save her
sister she opens marky's mouth and says
this sucks before breathing the life
back into her suddenly Marky awakens
somewhere on a beach as if she's been
rescued from drowning and she's like so
cute literally like she breathed the ear
back into her after drowning in the crap
from her family like it's such a great
analogy right here from Giga she's
laying next to Mai who explains that
she's going to use a construction
technique to make something but will
then die from this strange due to the
injury she's already sustained Mike gets
up in his sand and walks into the water
or saying goodbye and wishing her twin
good luck in life this greatly confuses
Marquee who gets up and begs her sister
to come back Mai explains that she knew
for a while that twins are a bad Omen
for Sorcerers to gain one must give
however that rule doesn't always apply
to twins because curse energy treats
them as One Singular entity even if
Marky wants to get stronger she can't
because why doesn't so it was sad and as
messed up as it is as long as Maya's
around Marky can never fully develop in
an attempt to get her sister to stop
Maki tells her that she understands but
she still doesn't want to lose her
sister and runs after her asking for her
to come home again Mike extends her hand
to Marky telling her that she is only
going to leave her one thing so make
sure to throw the rest away my will take
away all of the acoustic energy when she
dies so in return she asks Maki to
promise her just one thing destroy
everything Maggie takes a small read
from his sister's hand and reflects on
the time they were happy as children and
the next moment hell itself has returned
as Maki awakens in reality noticing that
she's holding a sword handle instead of
a read and a moment of beauty she's been
protected by her sister who has
tragically toppled over her with no more
Life Lift a new body overwhelmed by
emotion Mahi cries out and tells my to
wake up while a bunch of cursed Spirits
Rush up behind her skipping over to the
old man as he walks away he notices
something that just doesn't feel right
and turns around to see what's up
Suddenly all of the cursed Spirits I
exercised instantaneously confusing Okie
as their presences just vanish for him
okay like remember our girl is now
outputting zero NADA none literally no
curse energy at all in her stuff it's
just them pure gains time to see what
really pays off physical strength
through training your entire life or
curse strength Ogie Ogie readies his
Katana and says Maki strolling through
the Shadows of the doorway before she
gently places Mai's body down okie's
body begins to trample with fear as he
knows his mind has tried its best to
forget this feeling Mucky emerges from
his shadows and instantly reminds him of
no one other than the demon Warrior who
possessed no cursed energy the breaker
of fate himself toji Zenon struck with a
jolt of fear Oogie immediately activates
his curse technique blazing courage
causing his katana's Broken Blade and
scorching Flames that blaze a circle
around him with his scorching blade
pointed at Mahi Oogie threatens to burn
his worthless child to the bone in a
fight to the death however before he
could even finish talking Marty like the
freaking Beast she's always being
effortlessly decapitates his head while
walking past him in fact I don't even
know how much of a specific buff this
was like we have to get big old broken
Ronin on or something but the slash was
so damn fast that Oogie never even saw
it coming Maki stops behind her father's
defeated corpse as it falls to the
ground she looks at the last gift my
gave her then really to keep her promise
gripsley cursed tall in her hand and
tells Mai it's time to get started time
to start the absolute destruction that
is about to happen like oh I can't wait
literally like as an alarm bell sounds
out notifying the zidane Clan janichi
and naoya leave their mating room and go
into a hallway young rantus Inn and
finds them and tells jinichi that Maki
has gone mad and actually killed Okie
which leaves the others completely
surprised so since these inning Clan is
like just freaking massive they have a
variety of different groups consisting
of people with varying skill levels one
of these is the 50-man kukuru unit that
gets dispatched to apprehend Marquee
following in the Posse ass way of every
sin and male this Captain noblewakizen
tells his men that she must have killed
Ogie in his sleep or in the bathroom
obviously it's severely underestimating
her stream this kukuru unit is made up
of Zen and men who do not manifest and
innate technique but are still able to
use cursed energy they end up fighting
Maki in the curse Spirit Room and
surrounds her with at least 20 men from
the unit standing there alone looking
like the complete hellhound where the
dragon bone in one hand and Mai's
Creation in the other Marquee can only
think about her sister she wonders what
her plan was and if she should really
have given up on becoming a sorcerer
alongside my she figures that that might
have been the right answer all along and
apologizes to her sister for potting her
through all of the pain that she did
from around her the 20 kukuru unit
Fighters all attack while Mahi remembers
Mai's final request destroy everything
Mahi opens her eyes just as one of the
men attempts to slash her instantly and
on some freaking Matrix level she
avoids the blade and cuts off both of
the man's hands in one fluid motion then
bolts over his back and cuts down
several of his allies before finally
beheading the fodder fall below her
despite their numbers the kukuru units
frankly nothing compared to the now
unrestricted Mahi who effortlessly kills
one after another and successively
brutal fashion oh my Lord I love this
fight like the look on everyone's
freaking face as she's just annihilating
them as perfect this absolute egg
novawaki arrives back somehow expecting
Marky to actually have been finished off
already yet ezzy stroll certain he's
unpleasantly surprised to see that all
of his men have been turned into bloody
corpses by an unscathed Marquee suddenly
our new beloved icon of female strength
notices a surge of cursed energy nearby
coming from chojiro zinen instantly
she's tossed flying up into the ear by a
pair of gigantic stone hands the then
attempt to smash her while she's falling
back down to earth no Milwaukee
recognizes this attack as chojodo's
curse technique and note that the hay
have now arrived which by the way is a
group made up of only the strongest
comprised of everyone in the family with
a semi-grade one or higher rankine so
now the proper fight begins this stone
hands aren't enough to hold Maki as she
tears her way back out novawaki and
chojido attempt to stop her but she jams
her hands into their throat at blinding
speed literally killing them both before
they could even react ranta watching
this uses his paralyzing technique to
try and hold Maki in place while yelling
for gin nature to hurry up and finish
her off while do you think she Sprints
in to kill her Maggie fights back and
forcibly breaks out of ranta's technique
this literally sends his technique back
at him or something similar to that
inflicting a horrendous amount of damage
to his face still despite bleeding
profusely Ryan to make sure to tell
junichi that Maki has indeed become just
like toji however unlike toji who never
decided to destroy the entire clan on a
whim Mahi will do that if she is not
killed here and now junichi attacks
Marky and launches a huge number of
cursed energy propelled fists running
down from the sky at her this problems
everything in the immediate area which
causes ranta to believe they actually
succeeded at his final moments rancidin
collapses on his knees while they smile
thinking they won and succumbs to the
previous strain of his injuries while
Mahi the complete and utter God walks
out of the dust and smoke with janichi's
head hanging from her fist
finally the misogynistic neoyazinen who
secondly under being an absolute hoe as
the head of the hay Squad confronts
Marky via a small traditional
japanese-style bridge that extends over
a nice Pond standing there he of all
people calls Mahi crawl and asks if she
even has a human heart to which Marky
with a cold and callous face replies no
as your heart has already been taken
from her skipping until we flash back
during aaliya's childhood we find that
he's always been wrapped in Cotton wool
and constantly praised by his family
members he was recognized as a genius
and many always believed he would grow
into the head of the clan after naobito
love how Megami just showed up on the
block out of nowhere and messed up that
entire plan for him anyways anyways now
you heard of a black sheep any Clan who
didn't have any cursed energy and went
to see how pitiful that person was
however after seeing him naioya was
physically shaken upon seeing toji's
Cold Yet unconsumed and eyes back in
reality now nalia initiates the fight
quickly sending a series of Rapid
punches towards her however Marky is
able to Parry the majority of them or
try and account the number of movements
in that singular moment sadly while
she's big braining his technique now he
interrupts it and grabs her causing her
to be Frozen inside a frame then using
the Extreme Velocity his technique
provides naioya kicks Maki through civil
stone structures surrounding the area
now you're standing there thinking he is
the top G as adamant to himself that
Marquis is not toji regardless of a new
Boost in power yes she ain't even at the
same power level yet bro she just
unlocked the full extent of her Heavenly
restriction like Goku wasn't all of a
sudden Super Saiyan 3 when he unlocked
Super Saiyan 1 like it's not how it
works you've got you still got to train
and build time you know anyways nowhere
thinks that the sin of insignificant
people is the ignorance of strength
everyone misjudged toji because of his
lack of curse energy and naillou doesn't
believe anyone other than Gojo truly
understood who he actually was using his
curse technique now he continually
builds up momentum and overwhelms Marky
with one high speed move after another
being a massive toji in goju Fanboy now
he desires to prove that he is the only
one who will stand with him as one of
the strongest not Marquee even with her
improved abilities Maki is starting to
get hurt by naria's attacks and
struggles to keep up admitting that this
situation is getting bad for neoya and
like in his fight with choso he won't
stop building up speed this time he
understands that strength equals weight
and speed and plans to pierce Marty at
Max velocity having already gone
supersonic Mikey gained a steel body
that is broken away from cursed energy
in exchange for Maya's life she welcomes
a head-on collision and takes the stance
of the shiranui Garter which for all of
my Japanese lovers out there is a
specific form that sumo wrestlers take
Maki attempts to take on the brunt of
Naomi's supersonic speed in order to
stop his movements even if it means
sacrificing ropes appearing to stay
through maki's defensive strategy now he
attacks her with his palm in doing so it
forces Maki to follow the 24 frames per
second roll of projection sorcery
failure to do so means being frozen
inside a frame for one second like what
just happened with her previously when
she was kicked across the yard still
moving at top speed and seeing his
adversary as nothing more than an
imposter Neo believes Maki is frozen and
prepares to finish her off however Maki
actually isn't even phased by his
technique and is even obeying the
specific 24-frame rule of it now being
able to move fast enough Mikey turns
around and counter attacks intercepting
naria's path with her first now your
attempts to call Maki a fake but before
he finishes she smashes his face into
the ground with a monstrous punch that
ends the fight and he forms now your
skull now acting like the absolute boss
she is she looks down on her pathetic
bloody cousin and asks him to repeat
that
so I guess all of the action in regards
to the Xenon Clan mutilation ends there
but we still have just one more massive
moments I probably should Chuck in here
for all of you guys because I oh my Lord
it wraps everything up just perfectly
having Lefty Battlefield now Marky finds
her mother in a kitchen area like of
course like where else would she be and
he's dead in the household it's just so
so freaking sexist off them marky's
mother tells you to stay back but Maki
wants to know why she screamed at her to
come back earlier in the corridor to
destroy to even recall what happened
only moments prior mucky's mother can
only ask what Mikey is talking about
they're satisfied Marquee approaches her
mother who yells out in panic several
times before he blood is splattered on
the wall okay I'm not gonna lie this
does confuse me a slight bird I think
Mumsy turned the blade on herself right
here but honestly let me know what you
guys think down below I really don't
think Marky actually sliced up her mum
outside throughout and around the estate
the hay and the kokoru squads have been
completely decimated with their corpses
lining the area somehow like the
cockroach she is nailya heavily injured
but still somehow barely alive walks
around pouring blood from his face until
he finally collapses through a door onto
the ground inside he mocks Marky for not
ending him and leaving him like this
when out of freaking nowhere marky's
mother walks up behind him with her
throat already slits and bleeding so
she's definitely approaching death for
sure but still somehow holding a kitchen
knife difficult is in an estate like
thing nail you who's currently too
pitiful to even protect himself then is
probably the woman he hated the most the
mother of Marky and Mai stab him through
the back with a goddamn kitchen knife
which by the way is something that this
said should happen to any
female who is weaker than any man so
like oh my God you've got to chill out
with him sneaky little like four Shadow
Wings here and there now it calls her a
piece of trash but either way ends up
dying a pitiful death with a woman
laying on top of him unable to do
anything about it on top and fading away
the girl's mother admits that she really
was was glad to have given birth to two
amazing girls
after absolutely ruining the entire Zin
and family tree Mahi exits the property
with Maya's body Mama arrives just
moments later having been chasing behind
my and concern seeing now that Mai has
died as a result of not being there to
help Momo cries and sobs over her
regrets silently Mikey hands over Mai's
body to which Momo asks Marquee what
she's going to do now but our girl still
obviously shaken remains completely
silent as she walks away with a blade in
her hand later on it is explained that
these inning clan members who were not
even prison at the estate that day also
died violent deaths Mucky literally
hunted them all down in one day and
killed them all it's crazy no residuals
were found other than Trace Amounts from
a cursed tool skipping back now to the
moments before leaving tingen yujin
migami were given the third and final
third Year's location that being the
gambling madman Hikari Kenji it is
explained that Hikari is currently just
chilling out while being suspended and
makes money as a bookie for an
underground fighting Club the spread pit
level Fight Club puts Sorcerers against
one another in hand-to-hand combats
these Spectators are mostly
non-sorcerers which just goes to show
that Hikari literally doesn't care about
the Jutsu regulations now arriving at a
parking garage the two Sorcerers removed
the Jiu Jitsu uniforms in an attempt to
try and trick Hikari into thinking they
aren't associated with the school Megami
goes on to say that he may not associate
with him if he realizes they're also
students from jujutsutic it's a great
area for them but to Hikari they might
as well be with the higher-ups if he
finds out who they truly are Yuji
wonders though if akari will actually
help twitch mikami is unsure regardless
of the situation though they need his
strength for the culling game and would
do their best to recruit him mikimi and
Yuji walk into the entrance of the
parking garage in a minute by two men
the security guard look and do tells the
kids to get lost and instantly throws a
strong hook at Mega me however it stops
just short right before hitting his face
as the security guard slowly pulls back
his first he tells Mega me that the one
rule of the fight Club is that nobody is
supposed to say anything about the club
he demands to know who told them and
threatens to beat him up after finding
out I honestly love this whole idea with
like Hikari being like a Brad Pitt type
character having this fight club and
everything it makes me feel like gigay
is a part of the generation that I grew
up as a part of and watch these movies
while I was growing up and just really
enjoy them and everything and now we're
getting to see you know like his little
enjoyments from Western culture plopped
right into his story here which is
absolutely fantastic Mega me claims not
to have gotten the person's name before
he killed them himself it was a cocky
sorcerer that disappeared about a month
ago to which the guy recalls some dude
who disappeared about a month ago but is
unable to verify who it was exactly
mikumi asks to take his place instead
and threatens to murf The Bodyguard if
he refuses the manager then gives him
message from the boss to add an
additional fighter to today's tournament
however only on the condition that Yuji
is selected as fight her knowing that
Yuji is perfect for the job Mickey keeps
up his act and asks that he fight
instead that it explains to make me
though that the boss doesn't like him
and refuses to let some fights to watch
migami having noticed all of the cameras
around him decides to happily accept the
invitation dude is out playing like some
4D level chest trying to trick everyone
including Yuji at the moment like yuji's
probably just standing there utterly
confused after leaving and confirming
that akari must have been observing them
through the cameras they go over the
plan firstly your tears to look for and
make contact with a carry on the inside
while Megami attempts to sneak in the
parking garage from outside obviously
this is hella risky because if they
discover Mega me sneaking around they
will probably instantly distrust ug so
if they are discovered they decide to
use Force to make their way through to
Hikari but only as a final Resort even
though the best course of action would
be to let Yuji do his thing first
sakumi's deadline is fast approaching
which causes Mega Meek to get a bit
recluse it's currently 5 PM on the 10th
of November leaving the group nine days
to rescue sakumi before the deadline
closes that evening Yuji returns to the
parking garage for the fight the man
there preps Yuji by explaining the
details of how the tournament works
there are only two rules no retreating
and no Jujutsu which obviously piguji is
completely fine with as the dude was
first and foremost a physical Beast
anyways anyways now heading down the
stairs towards the arena Yuji asks the
dude what the boss is like to which he
says to Yuji that he can only find out
if he actually meets him he then
explains that there are two types of
matches scripted and unscripted ones
these so-called scripted matches are
actually script written by the boss and
the Fuji is able to put on a show in an
unscripted fight it will likely get his
attention possibly resulting in some
kind of me same arriving at the arena
now which is like this dopa section of
the garage where the Upper Floor has
been almost entirely renovated into an
area that allows Spectators to view from
above Yuji is introduced to his opponent
and someone that I can 100 say surprise
is absolutely like everyone here even
rereading the section I forgot this
Beast made his appearance here with that
good old fighter announce a voice the
infamous John Bobby Begins the
tournament by introducing the newcomer
itadori against no one other than Panda
and in monitoring room somewhere nearby
chilling like the absolute King he is
Hikari says with his associate as the
fight begins he expresses his
displeasure as he believes things are
starting to cool off Hikari doesn't
believe there is any fun in knowing
who's going to win an unscripted fight
he doesn't think anyone will be able to
defeat Panda and is barely watching
however the lovely lady with him points
his attention over to the television we
Yuji is absolutely pummeling Panda and
spectacular fashion by the way for those
wondering like the comment says just
above I'm pretty sure Hikari and Panda
obviously know each other and a probably
extremely well on that like classmate
level type beat or friendship back in
the fight Eugene panda work together to
put on a show that entertains everyone
watching in fact the fight is so damn
good it impresses even the goat himself
Jon freak and Bobby who screams that
this is the best fight he's ever seen
while the two trade blows Eugene Panda
have a cheeky conversation to exchange
info Panda has been allowed into the
fight club but akari and the other cute
third year with him are actively
avoiding Panda as well after finishing
their small conversation and agreeing to
end the fights Yuki lands a powerful
fake body shot that Panda sells with a
way over the top reaction to convince
everyone that he's been defeated big
Bobby announces Yuji as the winner
leaving a lasting impression on everyone
watching even akari upstairs and has
little content box admits that he's
impressed with yuji's ability to fight
in three dimensions while still dazzling
The Spectators he calls one of his
managers and gets him to bring Yuji up
to his office he wants to strike a deal
with him while the iron is hot and write
scripts for yuji's future fights this
chick chilly nearby who turns out to be
be another of Jiu Jitsu High's third
years called Carrara Hoshi tells akari
that it all just sounds boring to her
elsewhere at the same time Mega me like
the slimo for years uses a Do's Shadow
to eavesdrop on the conversation without
being seen the manly phone asks Sakari
what to do about the other brat
referring to Meek me who's like right
behind him to what shikari says he plans
to have Carrara keep an eye on him after
leaving the area Panda finds Megami in a
nearby Forest he asks Megami if he
thinks that Yuji will be able to contact
takari to which Mega me thinks that he
will but asks Panda why he actually
hasn't seen Hikari himself Panda knows
where Hikari is and says that he's in
the monitoring room on the roof but
can't get close to the door because of
the Hoshi girls curse technique it
doesn't matter what he seems to do walk
or run he cannot approach the door
Mickey asks if it's only active when
Carrara is in the monitoring room but
panda is unsure since she's always with
akari rather than forcing the issue
panda Spectators to avoid getting on
akari's bad side he goes on to say that
he thinks yuji's charm will work on
akari but is also apprehensive because
Yuji is an extremely bad liar as we all
know from literally every time this dude
has had to lie about like anything so in
an attempt to save his ass Panda gave
him some tips beforehand just in case
something random happens worst case
scenario would be for Hikari to discover
Yuji as which is you too high and boost
him out Panda wants to secure the area
and monitor the door to prevent this
meaning that they'll need to murk a few
of the fodder security guards to get up
there he knows where all the cameras are
and their blind spots as well as the
possessions of all of their lockouts
Mega me acknowledges that they might
have a solid plan but carrara's
technique remains a random factor in
everything that they do so if akari and
Carrara do end up getting Yuji outside
the door making me says that they'll
just have to give up on their objective
altogether later on and after winning
another match in the fight club Yuki
sin's Mega me a text at 12 58 saying
that his meeting with akari at 1pm while
each of the five Lookouts maintain their
positions Carrara nicknames him you and
shares that Hikari had to repeat a year
in junior high Judy notes how cheerful
Carrara is to which she replies it's
because akari is starting to feel hot
again having received the text making me
snakes into the first guard's Shadow and
mounts him from behind he chokes the man
unconscious tapes his mouth and zip ties
his hands together all done extremely
quickly the second guard then walks in
without noticing a single thing as
immerse Megami quickly slides into his
shadow then continuing on the UFC style
takedowns he knocks him out with a
perfect triangle choke at the same time
two other guards notice Panda playing
with a tire initially confused one of
them wonders if he eats fish sausage
while the other recognizes Panda from
the tournament suddenly Panda switches
on them and knocks them both out before
taking the sausage then hitting up the
emergency stairs panda regroups with
migami on the roof and moves with him to
guard the monitoring room door when
suddenly and unexpectedly Ferrara walks
out of the room just below them for a
moment Mega me and Panda just stand
there completely stunned looking up
Carrara quickly notices the pier and
instantly makes a connection that Mega
me and you are both from Jujutsu high
like Panda Carrara believing that
herkari is in danger reaches through her
phone and tries to contact him however
mikami summons his base of the shikigami
the Divine dog totality to try and stop
her the shikigami rushes Carrara and
tries to restrain her but it sent flying
back into Mega me having dropped her
phone Carrara runs towards a monitoring
room while Panda who's kind of just
standing there tries to explain that
they're not enemies Carrara doesn't
believe that they have a simple request
for Hikari and is upset with him for
simply betraying them due to carrara's
technique holding Panda back Mega me
orders has a Divine dog to intercept her
path this instantly stops her but migami
is also suddenly pulled towards the
shikagami he realizes that in addition
to being unable to reach Carrara he is
now unable to even separate from his
Divine dog while he thinks about how
this this technique Works neither he nor
Panda have noticed a small random star
symbol on Panda's ass that reads star am
I like all my Lord bring back Professor
diavolo from the one punch man video
we've got some space facts here boys so
Amaya is actually a star in the Milky
Way and Maya is also like the
traditional name of the star known as
Delta croxies it is visible from Earth
and is only 364 light years away or if
you want that in miles it's about 2.139
quadrillion miles away anyways meanwhile
inside of the monitoring room Hikari the
final special grade student finally
meets with Yuji for the first time and
typical Jujutsu cars in fashion akari
had some other bizarre but intriguing
question he asks Yuji would you believe
me if I said you could work for one hour
a day and make one million yen a month
unsure as anyone would be in the
situation Yuji just blankly stays back
in confusion confused Yuki asks what he
would need to do but akari says he would
have to pay 200 000 Yen obviously like a
cheeky Guru scam right here but you know
what I like a lot more than
materialistic things knowledge the more
you learn the more you earn you know I
read a book a day not to show off it's
again about knowledge in fact something
happened that changed my life I bumped
into a mentor like yeah okay dude
totally I'm sure that's how it actually
works even Yuji out of everyone doesn't
agree as he thinks that this one just
feels kind of shady Hikari agrees and
points out that it's a classic con with
get rich quick scammers sell tips it's
an obvious scam but akari notes that
there are still a lot of people who will
fall for it and adds it up to something
that he calls the fever Hikari explains
they're both the scammer and the scammed
are in a favor to change their lives
people get high on the fever and make
stupid decisions yet without it people
can never fall in love akari loves the
fever and asks Eugene if he knows the
most direct way of engaging with it dude
Curry is such a such a tricky character
to get around and like write and stuff
Yuji kisses correctly and says that it's
gambling I find this like part
absolutely hilarious but apparently lots
of girls dumped akari in the past due to
his constant gambling but guys want to
points out that life itself is actually
a gamble Society tramples on losers who
don't know when to quit but akari points
out that everyone gambles what people
truly hate is losing Hikari goes on to
say that he wants to control the fever
of the entire country using his fight
club which is really like the Fight Club
movie if you think about it like
hikari's character in general is rarely
playing on that Brad Pitt side of uh the
main character's brain and everything
he's going for that like I want to
change the entire world Prospect or like
the entire world feeling he says that he
wants to take advantage of the current
chaos and expand his business making the
Jujutsu headquarters aware of his
Ambitions needing strong allies for this
he asks Yuji if he wants to get high on
his fever Yuji prepares to ask for help
when all of a sudden they're interrupted
by a phone call which completely changes
the atmosphere after it ends he offers
Yuji a drink which he refuses because of
his age hearing this he brings up out of
the blue that started Gojo can't drink
either Juju pretends not to know who
Gojo is but akari who finds a suspicious
finishes his drink and asks if Yuji is a
spy from jujuts who tick before Yuji can
speak up to Defenders case akari tosses
the drink glass right at his face
YouTube flicks the cup but akari quickly
activates his curse technique summoning
two tall sliding doors that attempt to
close YouTube between them Yuji jumps
above the horizontal doors and tries to
speak up but akari continues his attack
trapping him with his doors and kicking
him in the face while revealing that a
call from Carrara means something bad
has happened Yugi recalls what megumi
said about only asking for cooperation
and hit but zakari in an attempt to get
him to listen however the third year
doesn't give up and refuses because now
his fever is running cold meanwhile
outside the room Carrara is in a
deadlock with panda and mega me since
they are stuck making me tries to
explain that they're not on the Jujutsu
high side side and they need hikari's
help but Carrara just doesn't listen
confused as to what happened between
them and the higher-ups panda explains
to mikami that conservative members of
the community prefer traditional Jujutsu
while akari has Blended hers for
technology so just think of the moment
during the Shibuya incident where mimiko
and nanako got absolutely murked by
sakona and he was like oh a curse camera
technique cool that was a blended
technique as it had been like blended
with the camera and the cell phone
Carrara points out they're ju too high
lost because they have their priorities
backwards but adds that they always have
Gojo to clean up their messes so why are
they even here asking for help megumu
reveals to her that satello Gojo was
sealed during shabuya but Carrara makes
a face of comic disbelief as she
obviously just can't believe that that
could ever happen realizing this Megami
decides to activate his rabbit Escape
summoning dozens of his rabbit shikigami
as a large swarm of rabbit shikigami
cover the roof he notices that each of
the rabbits are marked with a symbol
saying a Crux none of the rabbits can
actually get near the monitor room when
migami notices another symbol starget
Crux has been placed the rabbits quickly
spread across the entire roof so that
migami can see where and where they
can't go seeing this Crow repels them
but is still confused at the whole point
of it herrera's innate technique Mark
shukigami the same as Sorcerers so just
like with the Divine dog Carrara
believes that migami will attract all of
the rabbits and suffocate inside of them
however he suddenly dispels them all
Megami asks Panda however Escape was to
which Panda confirms that the shukigami
were attracted to him and the second
floor but they couldn't reach Carrara or
the monitoring to war Panda finally
figures out that he has been marked with
the symbol Amai and migami has been
marked with a Crux Megami isn't sure
what's going on but he knows that
carrara's curse technique is very likely
based on the constellation of stars Rara
notices that Mega me is figuring out how
her technique works and puts her
attention on her Mega me turns to
Carrara and says that it might be based
on the Southern Cross constellation
Carrara is surprised that he gets
correctly but gives it away that he got
it correct with your reaction which
continues to air to her frustration
Chrono knows that if migami continues to
figure out how the technique works then
it'll eventually reach the monitor room
Kara resolves to hold him off and try to
prevent that no matter what Megami
thanks sakumi for teaching him about the
Southern Cross but is still confused
because he knows it should have four
specific points Mega Million Panda get
close to one another and discuss
carrara's curse technique he initially
thought that it assigned them each a
point on the Southern Cross to maintain
distance between each point however this
can't be the case because Carrara can
approach the door and mega me can
approach Panda making me realizes that
it's more likely that the acoustic Nick
has a determined route where there is a
sequential order for who can go near
what depending on what point they've
been marked worth Panda considers that
the technique doesn't affect the yozer
the mega me debunks this because the
Divine dog totality couldn't approach
Carrara earlier if Carrara and the door
both hit stars that repel Megami and
Panda then Carrara could simply flee
Mickey being Panda surmise that this
must mean the Southern Cross has five or
more points as if there were only four
stars one of them should be able to
approach the enemy sorcerer since that
isn't the case here there must be a
first star between them that they must
go through in order to reach her and the
door Panda asks what they should do if
there are six or seven points but migami
says five is already too many to make
sense for a cross obviously though if
you live in like NZ or Australia or even
pretty much anywhere in the southern
hemisphere you know for a fact that
there are actually indeed five stars in
the Southern Cross anyway anyway knowing
that she might be foiled soon Carrara
goes on the offensive she ferociously
jumps on the hood of the car and marks
it with himai sending it flying up at
Panda the car flips into Panda but he
manages to catch it and assures Mega me
that he's okay one megaby runs away
Panda tosses the car away from him to
which me can be concerned reminds Panda
not to throw the car away or else the
Mark will simply Attract it back to him
and as he says this the car comes
shooting right back at Panda slamming to
rexley into his head while sprinting
they can be surprises that contact needs
to be made by the user to place a star
Carrera marked migami by marking his
curse energy through his Divine dog in
order to Mark more objects like the
monitor room door or the car they need
to be charged beforehand while someone
else's cursed energy honestly Mega Meat
is just so freaking big brain right now
have he had the raw strength of Eugene
dude would actually like be pure
Insanity anyways anyways Mega me focuses
on seeing the curse energy residuals on
the car and find some from someone other
than Carrara continuing with his theory
migami assumes the technique doesn't
have a long range and eventually finds a
parking stop marked with a fifth star
Mimosa Mega me quickly touches the
parking stop and doesn't notice any more
residuals he knows carrara's curse
energy is already marked with a star so
he assumes they can't use the curse
technique to Mark another object with a
Crux and attract more objects to him
however to making me shock a bunch of
objects marked with the Crux are already
heading directly for him finally it is
explained that carrara's curse technique
love Rendezvous marks five stars with a
Southern Cross motive to Target curse
energy for one star to approach another
it must follow a determined order or
else one of the targets for the same
star will attract dirt the order follows
the stars from nearest furthest on a
diagram constellations come across as
flat but space is actually a
three-dimensional area and each star is
a different distance from Earth migami
was marked with a Crux so he must travel
through mimosa and Ganan in order to
reach go Crux or in my monkey brain
speak he has to go through the parking
stop Mark then Carrara and finally he
can make it to the monitoring door
anyways anyways cryo admits she's
impressed that migami figured out how
her technique works that being said
prior believes Megami was too quick to
conclude that more objects couldn't be
thrown at him while Carrara can't Mark
more than one star with the same icon
she can simply remove the monitor room
door marker and Mark other things with
migami's motoff instead suddenly hurray
is called off guard when the Divine dog
randomly reappears behind her megamese
jacked up shikigami quickly immobilizes
Carrara confusing her until she comes to
the realization that Mega me never
dispelled it instead he was able to
guess which one would attract the other
and maneuver so there was a war between
them then after waiting for a while he
unjammed the Divine dog from the wall so
he could take advantage of the fact that
Carrara was now approachable with
Carrara now stuck it forces her to
release a love Rendezvous making me
quickly restrains Carrara so that she
doesn't run away but simply asks her to
listen to what he has to say he then
dispels his Divine dog totality while
simply asking her to listen still
skeptical crowd doesn't think Miami
could have known whether he or the
shukigami would have been pulled Mega me
and my city took a gamble but now he
knows that the one with the high accuse
energy output does the attracting
initially the Divine dog pulled Mega me
but the opposite occurred when Mega me
reinforced his body with cursed energy
Mega me then let's Carrera go and begs
her to listen because he's frankly just
no time confuses to why he would release
her Carrara decides to believe him
however the monitor room door is
suddenly seen flying off its hinges with
Yuji bursting out migami quickly
realizes that Yuji has been head outside
the room and right on cue the fighting
thing Hikari walks outside visibly
irritated with the whole situation Fuji
tells Mega me and Panda to stay out of
it prompting her character believe that
he's being underestimated he immediately
throws a devastating punch that smashes
yuji's face and sends him flipping
across the roof Hikari eventually
notices that Yuji isn't even resisting
and in that moment the first year
Springs back to his feet standing there
Yuji spurts blood out of his nose while
akari is just blown away no team that
his adversary doesn't even intend to
dodge to him yuji's lack of resistance
all but confirms he's not a spy so akari
says they'll hear Yuji out on the
condition that he can remain standing
and flew raise up his curse energy
Carrara urges him to listen but akari
claims that he just said he would before
asking Yuji why he's asking him for help
specifically Yuji says that all of his
seniors have confirmed Hikari as strong
annoying him akari punches Yuji again
and while he's railing through the air
usually compares to Carry's reinforced
punches to getting hurt with a serrated
bat which like oh my Lord the cheers
greater level of curse energy right here
irritated Curry yells at Yuji stating
that Sorcerers understand asking one
another for a favor is equal to asking
someone to put their life on the line in
order for her character take such a risk
he needs Yuji to prove here and now that
he has the fever to convince him Yuji
claims that he doesn't have a fever and
is just a cog a cognitive machine that
sorcerer's need to eliminate curse
Spirits typical depresso Yuji right here
like even akari finds his answer
extremely boring so he decides to wind
up another punch prompting migami to
express his concern akari strikes Yuji
with the hardest blow yet
line across the roof into a wall and
appearing to finally knock him out
Hikari begins to tell them to leave but
Yuji suddenly reappears behind him
Hikari is genuinely surprised and backs
up wondering how he's still standing
after suffering three literally
mind-altering blows he asks Yuji what he
is to what she replies while the same
answer is before he believes His
function is getting rid of curses and
since Kari isn't necessary for that Yuji
decides he won't stop until he agrees
Yuji think it's Up All In A Curry's face
and asks him what his function is Hikari
who still surprise asks himself if this
is the look of a cog in fever he goes to
punch Yuji once again but finally
Carrara interrupts and manages to get
hikari's attention she asks Sakari
ifuji's fever is burning hot enough for
him yet standing there he recognizes
that carrara's point is undeniable
acknowledging that it is indeed true he
then suddenly agrees to hear Yuji out
and tells me give me and panda that he's
willing to cut a deal honestly if you're
confused as to what happened don't worry
because Mickey and Panda are like just
as confused as everyone else as to
what's just happened he asks Carrara if
what they said convinced them to watch
she confirms skipping forward akari
finally sits down and listens to what
they've got to say he's completely
surprised to hear that Gojo was sealed
and Panda adds that masamichi also died
in a fight with kakuganji recently after
Shibuya obviously this is like the first
that they've all heard of Jagger's death
as well Eugene mikami a concern for
panda since Yaga was pretty much his dad
Hikari expresses that he's bummed out
now that everyone who's ever taken care
of him is out of the picture honestly I
think like as in everyone he was
probably referring to Yaga Gojo nanami
and like maybe even ghetto from a school
as well before he passed away Hikari
agrees to help combat the culling game
however he tells him to not get the
wrong idea and makes it a point that
everyone understands that this is a deal
and that they must return the favor at
some point in the future and want to
know more and asks what exactly he
desires but Mega me Cuts in and comments
that he doesn't think whatever it is
will be difficult which annoys akari
Hikari calls mikami a sea urchin head or
a pretty much and asks him what
he could possibly know probably Mega
Media flicks on him saying that he's
literally the head of his hidden Clan
who starts off and is like no I don't
want the role Marquee like maybe you
should have her and now he's flexing on
Hikari right here shocked Hikari finds
us even more of a surprise than the news
about Gojo and Yaga he believes that
with the backing of The Big Three
Families making revisions to society
will be easy however the funny part
about this is that like I just talked
about earlier in the video Maki actually
destroys the entire sitting Clan the
next day so her fight and all of that
with my dying Etc happens after this
point so I don't know why Giga decided
to write this backwards here maybe he
just thought of that afterwards and
thought he'd throw that in just to add a
bit more like confusion of the story so
thank you very much Keke with everyone
in agreement Yuji states that they need
to decide what colony to go to when
suddenly cocaine remember like the game
and to face thingy that was explained
right at the beginning of the arc
appears above Eugene and makes a loud
ringing noise cocaine announces that one
player has added a new rule to the game
allowing players to have access to
information on other players this
information includes their name number
of points number of rules added and
their current Colony this rule was added
by a new mysterious looking dude named
Hajime kashimo a sorcerer who's over 400
years old no sakuna and is currently
dominating the entirety of Tokyo's
number two Colony after making the
announcement kogane introduces itself to
Yuji its voice differs to that of the
announcements because now it's acting as
liaison for the culling game assigned to
Yuji instead of the announcers migami
doesn't understand why Yuji has already
been considered as a player before
entering a colony which is actually
super interesting and I'd love to like
know what you guys think it could be but
like Yuji I believe it has something to
do with sukuna and most likely the the
fact that sakona was a cursed object
linked to kinjaku in some kind of way
Megami points out that that's still
strange because Eugene just the sukuna's
fingers of his own well unlike the past
Sorcerers who were in contracts with
kinjaku so yeah there definitely is
something else going on what if perhaps
it was actually The Vow sakuna made with
Yuji you know the one that he doesn't
actually remember currently even
happened just an idea Yuji hasco game
show him his own player and Foe and
migami uses the list to find kashimo
identifying them as the one who added
the rule Megami believes that they can
get through the culling game without
killing anyone by forcing someone with
enough points to add another role the
two players that already fit their bill
are G makashimo and heromi hikaruma in
order to save sakumi the first rule they
have to add will need to offset rule
eight Megami states that they can do so
by adding a rule that allows players to
transfer points between each other after
adding that rule Megami suggests adding
another one that allows players to spin
points to remove themselves from the
game entirely to which Hikari points out
that that might actually conflict with
the long lasting rules of the game but
Mega me figures that maybe it'll work
under the right conditions but
ultimately it's up to the game master
and regardless the team now has a plan
while they look for the sorcerer known
as Angel they will also search for
Hajime and hegaruma then attempt to take
them down for their points
so as we start back out we find
ourselves in the middle of a Japanese
criminal trial it's explained that in
Japan 99 of criminal trials ended a
guilty verdict a young man sitting
opposite the newest Qi higuruma who I
introduced right at the end of the last
video explains that he had a cat who was
lost and while looking for it he was
confronted by the popos being struck
with a difficult Choice the young man
decided to flee because his cat would
have died as where he loves it's a rule
that he can't own any pets we find that
in March of 2016 a mother and daughter
were both slain and Mario Kart City this
caused the prosecutors of the case to
instantly suspect the young man they
arrested him and charged him a suspicion
of murder and robbery after Kisa fled
the initial questioning by police
officers they followed him to his home
and found it bloody blade which is like
bro why have you got this knife dude it
ain't exactly looking good for you here
anyway once a lab analysis was completed
it confirmed that the blood on the knife
was matched to the DNA of the two
victims despite the outstanding evidence
and practically being caught red-handed
by the cops keita insisted that he was
innocent while reviewing the case with
his co-worker Shimizu higuruma explains
that Kita told him he picked up the
knife even though it wasn't his
obviously Shimizu doesn't believe that
that could have possibly happened and
instead thinks that he fled from the
authorities because he was simply guilty
here for some reason hegaruma argues
that he only fled because in the past
he'd been illegally harassed by police
officers causing him to always be weary
of them he claimed he was going to give
the knife to the police later because
his hostile was skitchy as hell and
didn't allow him to call the police
there the reason for this is because his
job around the hostel was to care for
the elderly who had nowhere to go
employees in the hostel are given a
place to stay and some food but I only
paid money under the table on the New
Year while at the same time still being
overcharged each month for rent
obviously as you could imagine this
affects how all of the residents would
live more than a few of the residents
who do live there have criminal records
and ever since the 2011 earthquake
Relief Fund money started pouring into
the region causing more shady non-profit
business to begin appearing hegaruma
believes it's likely that the weapon was
actually lying around and Kita indeed is
telling the truth so well obviously big
kuruma is a freaking G man is working on
the higher cognitive frequency and is
probably the only damn lawyer in Japan
that is adamant and taking on the courts
themselves plus freaking Giga again
added in that 2011 tsunami slash
earthquake reference there I absolutely
love how it makes us feel as though this
could actually be going down in Japan
right now or is retelling an event that
actually affected the world over the
past few years anyways anyways hegaruma
forms a plan to take on the case he'll
continue gathering information while his
overworked assistant takes care of
pretty much everything else the sexy big
brain Duo go ham working tirelessly
until the day of the trial then on the
day they somehow managed to earn an
innocent verdict for keita Shimizu was
surprised they actually got the verdict
but higaruman knows the prosecutors will
immediately appeal in a post-trial
meeting hikarumo reveals to case her
that nothing from the robbery that was
stolen was ever found in his room and
someone disappeared from the original
residents soon after the crime happened
above everything else cater also
appeared on a convenience store camera
at literally the same time as the time
of the death hearing this he thanks
hegaruma but the lawyer simply
emphasizes that there will be a second
trial sobbing Peter specifies us that he
means he just wants to thank her garuma
for believing in him however as per
usual at the retrial the broken Japanese
Judicial System unfortunately found
cater guilty and the young man was
sentenced to life in prison it's
explained that independent defense
lawyers like higuruma rely on limited
funding and no Workforce public
prosecutors have access to tax money and
much greater Manpower because of this no
new evidence was ever presented at the
second trial and the court passed out
his sentence on the shaky argument that
there was no reason to suspect the
random person who just happened to go
missing straight after the murder which
is like Nadu that that guy straight up
gaptive because he committed the murder
and now you're completely locking up an
innocent person here a cane anyway
because of this a third trial before the
highest court is unlikely as they refuse
to hear most cases get an affair hearing
is improbable and the system itself
unfairly branded cater is guilty from
the very beginning and sadly this is
just the reality of the situation in
most countries from the US to New
Zealand as soon as you have Blake being
set in front of the jury you already
have somewhat of a bad connotation put
over your head it was so like moral of
the story obviously is just don't get
yourself in a situation where you're
going to be charged for something in
court obviously you can't always do that
but anyway disparate and angry caser
looks at hegaruma was sorrow and
disappointment in his eyes standing
there shocked her groomer just asks
himself why his clients always look at
him this way losing touch with reality
for a moment he thinks back to a
conversation he had about his mental
state there he replied that it was his
intention to save the week he's always
been the type of person who couldn't
just ignore things Justice is supposed
to be blind and people close their eyes
to spare themselves from The Hearth
truce of reality but even if he's the
only one her guruma says that he wants
to keep his eyes back in court now the
judge announces that if there are any
objections that in my must be filed
within 15 days not freaking happy though
and wanting to make a damn change he
could rumor abruptly interrupts and
slams his table with a mallet that turns
out to be a judge's gavel of his own
this leaves absolutely everyone in the
courtroom surprised and as shizimu
begins to move away a large dark curse
begins to form behind hagarumar refusing
to allow the trial to end in this unjust
Manor higuruma snaps and tells everybody
that nobody is allowed to leave because
now they are having a retrial as per
usual with other gecko you're skipping
away from this straight away and going
over elsewhere just before 6am back on
the 1st of November when we find
ourselves with kinjaku who's legit like
creeping onto Starsky by the way just
gonna blow your minds if you guys
haven't realized this as well this is
the freaking girl from the very first
episode or chapter yuji's old friend
like the one that like he saved right at
the beginning so what the actual hell
does kinjaku have in store here like
with her anyways anyways petrified as
you would be with waking up and finding
a man like in your beard sitsuko asks
who this weirdo is as explained to her
that he is a sorcerer who placed a
barrier over scene dye and that the
region has been chosen to host a lethal
contest where players will fight to the
death the remains of an execution site
nearby serves as the center of the
barrier with a radius of around five to
six kilometers which is super
interesting like I wonder if he had to
set up a bunch of these like execution
sites throughout each barrier in his
thousand years or so proceeding this
event Sasuke who are already inside of
the barrier are given one chance to
leave so this explains the confusion on
how they were going to be like notified
of the current situation with the
barrier he says that as she chooses to
leave she'll awaken outside of the
barrier confused with his word him of
just like everything says asking
questions if she's still dreaming but
kunjaku replies that the space between
dreams and reality is a curse I don't
know if this dude was the only one to
show up personally to Sasaki but he
takes a hold of her hand and warns her
to be careful then as he slowly guides
her to the safety of the barrier exit we
get to witness the current Carnage
taking place across the Battlefield then
skipping back to the duo just before the
part weighs for good kinjaku
mysteriously thanks asarski for getting
along with his son and suddenly after
she wakes up outside of the barrier with
the other OG friend from the first
chapter or episode a Gucci who's glad to
have found someone that he knows so it's
always good to see a Gucci doing well
again as we left on the note that he was
in hospital and everything anyway he
points out the gigantic barrier wall and
explains that everyone saw the same man
during their dream however to further go
on to my point on him physically mixing
her unlike the others Sasuke asks if the
man had mentioned his son but that isn't
the case with him skipping away from
that now and back to the present day
which is the 11th of November Eugene
Megami continue planning for their part
of the game they're unable to find a
player named Angel but apparently
they'll know who it is when they see
them Baker Curry decides that him and
his boy panda will go over the Tokyo 2
Colony while Yuji and Megami will head
into the number one and Carrara stays
outside of the barrier by the way it's
recently come to my attention that
apparently Carrara is neither a male or
a female so apologies for not realizing
that in the last video but it does go to
show just how like Untouchable is do
just knows everything that's going on
with our culture and today's generations
and all I absolutely love it anyway
Curry plans to handle this mysterious
Hajime kushimo himself since they did
player with the most points and likely
as the strongest Yuji begins to bring up
their perhaps he and mega me shouldn't
travel together due to how zakona has
been acting hella sus with him recently
however making me just tells Yuji to
just shut up and stop being so
self-centered because the others can't
exactly change their roles after a
little squabble between the boys and
skips forth to 12 p.m the next day when
everyone all reaches their designated
barriers inside of Tokyo before entering
kogan explains to them that inside the
barriers the lethal competition no one
is the culling game is taking place and
asks that the new players are willing to
enter and declare their participation in
the game and probably the exact same
time migami Yuji Panda and Hikari don't
hesitate and all agree to enter diving
straight into Tokyo Colony number one we
find this babe hanyu asking for a signal
from a dude she's forcing to work for
her called Ren he tells her that he
can't do anything though if no one shows
up which leaves hanyu annoyed she
activates her curse technique snapping
your hair to this real like topaz
looking chair on her back and threatens
to run run over if he mounts her off
again outside and approaching the colony
nigami explains to the absolutely
confused Yuji that they just need to be
weary of incarnated sorcerers that have
lived throughout the past eras still
somehow confused over this Mega me says
that some of the players are from over a
thousand years ago and even those from
only a hundred or two hundred years ago
have a completely different mindset
compared to the modern day ones first
and foremost they are Sorcerers who
valued life differently and fighting to
the death was a normal thing for them
some people even desire to achieve an
honorable end in battle and that's why
Mega me thinks they've agreed to become
players to achieve the warrior-like
deaths they couldn't before nigami
doesn't believe that they'll be able to
negotiate with past Sorcerers to which
Duty adds on then they need to be wary
not of just people but curse Spirits as
well they knock on the barrier wall of
Tokyo Colony number one and immediately
cocaine appears to greet them it
announces that the Cullen game is taking
place inside and anyone who enters will
become a player in the deadly
competition Megami declares his
participation but oddly like maybe you
guys all saw but maybe doesn't exactly
pick up on it here kogay never asks Yuji
if he actually wants to join the game
determined to save his sister though
making me reminds Yuji that the first
move is to get information on hiromi
higuruma the duo steps inside the
barrier however they both suddenly
separated sent randomly to different
locations inside of the colony Yuji
finds himself falling from the sky
confused by his circumstances while also
wondering where in the world Mega me is
as then explained to us that when a
player enters the game's barrier they
transferred to one of nine different
locations student individuals position
themselves at those locations to
literally spawn Camp unsuspecting people
who don't know this unspoken rule it's
giving back over to the sump who's
actually just one of those spawn campers
he notices Yuji falling from the sky and
uses a guiding like baton to Signal hanu
using uku's technique to propel herself
can you bursts through the air raming
directly into the chest of Yuji she
carries on and smashes them straight
through two buildings with an attack
that would have utterly pulverized most
players however your he has just
freaking built different like man is
constructed of a different material and
somehow he quickly recovers from the
impact surprising hanu sliding back
across the roof of a building Gucci
manages to get some foot in and takes
his fighting stance recognizing her
opponent's toughness hanu calls your
partner to her side but Yuji quickly
throws you rock he picked up in the
previous attack they had tanu in her
stomach seriously injuring her heavily
injured she slowly begins to lose
altitude before falling into the
building below her behind a surprised
Yuji hanyu's partner who's the type
bulky ass dude called hubba appears
using his helicopter-like curse
technique to levitate he angrily demands
to know what Yuji has done to his woman
over on a nearby building Ren notices
that helper has appeared and that hanu
was easily taken down thinking on this
newcomer for a second Ren thinks that he
might know him before remembering
someone named itadori meanwhile mikami
Hotel you ain't no simp knocks down a
female player and draws his curse talk
she asks him why he'd do there but Mega
me angrily replies that it's because she
literally attacked him he asked this
hella cute girl like oh my Lord that
hairstyle is too freaking fire like
chill Giga anyways anyways he asks her
for informed hug Aroma but she instantly
starts acting difficult she says that
she'll only give him the information if
he acts as unite and protects her
reluctantly anad agrees but not on the
way she wants which annoys her he tells
her to walk in front of her and only
promises to protect her if she's telling
the truth if this isn't the case he
implies that he'll literally go demon
time on your ass and get some points
unlike Yuji making me literally does not
care about racking up 100 points on his
own if need be unintimidated though the
girl responds with a devious smirk and
tells me to instead call her Remy back
over the battle with Yuji he begins his
fight with hubba by tossing his Stone
charged with cursed energy directly at
him this has imposed much of a threat
though as he easily destroys it with his
fast rotating propeller saying this Yuji
uses the opening to close the distance
he runs across the roof of the building
and uses his correct physical strength
to LEAP into the air grabbing his
enemy's leg hitting flanks his ass
directly down and drags him through the
side of the building utterly destroy
nerds hubba manages to get loose and
tries counter-attacking but Yuki sees it
in time and decides to retreat he
realizes the hubba isn't taking
advantage of The High Ground and only
attacks with a weapon on his head by the
way I just noticed but both of the
people ugs fought here so far have had
some like weird ass obsession with
turning their heads into some sort of
like military vehicle like hanu's got
her jet here and obviously this dude's
got some kind of fetish for helicopters
anyways anyways Yuji ends up leading the
student doors where it's much more
confined however hubba instantly drops
down after Yuji confident that his
propellers can literally shred through
everything inside finding home hubba
spins towards his opponent head first
like a drill attempting to oblit to race
everything and his path thinking yuhi
believes that hanyu was easily defeated
because of her hair based technique that
left the rest of her body unguarded by
cursed energy but no matter how tough it
is the kid will always remain a vital
spot so as long as he can hit them
without touching the propellers you he
is confident that he'll be able to
destroy his opponent as his adversary
finally closes in yujiko's pure demon
mode and punches hubba directly in the
top of the head and simply stopping him
in his tracks and leaving the bulked up
dude bleeding from the top of his head
still despite his brain getting
absolutely pinged around inside of his
own skull hubba remains standing he
begins laughing and overconfidently
assumes that Yuji had broken his hand
then just as he says that Yuji is
finished our boy just doesn't even care
and casually finishes hubba off with a
kick sitting and flying back through the
corridor standing there shaking off the
damage that he just took nuji realizes
that he still needs to ask this man
about her garuma yet as the confused
Yoji goes to ask him Ren suddenly
appears behind him saying that he knows
about hagaruma and asked ifuji actually
remembers him Ren by the way is just
another random dude from like a sister
school to eugees that kinjaku has
probably done the dirty with he wasn't
friends with Yuji and yujifily enough
doesn't even recall who he is here Ren
notices that Yuji is obviously
suspicious of him so he says he really
only knows him as the tiger of West
Junior High which embarrasses yuchi back
with mikami as he walks through the
streets of the Remy he asks her if she's
not a sorcerer from the past she
confirms she's from the modern day
prompting Mega me to question her reason
for fighting to which he explains that
plays who began inside the colony have
been experiencing the culling game for
12 days already she's not participating
in the game to win most people like her
are just trying to survive Remy claims
that she's seen players go mad with
power and tells Mega me to stop thinking
in terms of time periods as it's
pointless now hearing this making me
realizes that he accidentally mislead
Yuji with their plans earlier due to
this Mega me tells Remy to wait up and
reveal where she's leading home and
certainly raging at him though Remy
refuses because migami could simply
eliminate her after he gets this
information but he argues that he could
lose like a rumors location if Remy ends
up dying at the same time she asks
renway's helping since he was just with
the previous Sorcerers but Ren reveals
he was being forced to work with them
and would have been eliminated soon
anyway hearing this Yuji finally stops
and asks where hegaruma is then there's
some pure cheekiness as revealed through
Wren and Remy they had a groom his
location as in one of two different
areas so obviously one person is lying
here Ren claims hegaruma is an ikibukuro
or Remy says that he's in Shinjuku
having both gained this info separately
Yuji and Megami hope that the other is
headed to the same destination yet as we
know one of them is indeed being misled
and it's instead showing that someone
has actually taken them to another
mysterious but absolutely ripped man
hoarding receipts skipping away for a
second we go into a flashback where we
find and any other student who are
approached by bullies big brain Wren
using his like 1000 IQ didn't stand up
to the aggressors but he knew how to act
so that the bullies wouldn't get
agitated and would instead stop
bothering him he knew the bullies were
arrogant despite not being smart or
athletic so he focused on staying out of
their way here we smiled and went with a
flow even at other people's expense
because nobody would bother him however
in that same instance how young Legend
refuses to sit by and watch someone else
get bullied Ren who was just standing
there just assumed that another
had showed up who didn't know like how
to avoid trouble but it turned out to be
the infamous tiger of West Junior High
big freaking Yuji itadori the bullies
attempted to beat on the newcomer but
all three of them are utterly photorized
and brutally knocked out just by a
single head each turning to Ren Yuji
asks if he's next but Rin was just too
shocked and could only stutter in
response skipping back to reality and
over with the two lovebirds is a hit off
at a station migami immediately
expresses some concerns about going
through ikebuka pero he believes that
they should have taken a more direct
route to Shinjuku instead but Remy
argues that the route is simple for her
and she has a base nearby where she
wants to rest and bathe meanwhile Ren
takes Yuji to a theater in akibukuro the
hagaruma uses as his base excited to
have quickly located his Target Yuji
thanks Ren concerned though Ren asks
Yuji if he's really going to go inside
alone to which he says that he's in a
hurry to meet up with an ally and
assures run that he'll be able to escape
if anything goes wrong yuchi like the
Happy he is Skips off into the
theater without a care in the world
while Ren lamians sitting idly by unable
to stop him after entering the theater
and rolling down some stairs someone
else introduces himself as Reggie but as
per usual with gigay and him skipping
around all throughout this like section
of the arc right here he's not greeting
Yuji No in fact migami has walked into
an ambush of his own inside of Remy's
so-called base where another player was
indeed waiting for him Reggie reveals to
mihime that Remy had tracked him which
immediately seems bigamy into an utter
rage pissed off he looks back at Remy
who simply tries to taunt him now that
she is supposedly safe not worried at
all though our female loving Mega me
tells her to shut up then instantly
summons has a Divine dog totality
stating that they're wasting his time
remember how Yugi was just surprised
before this well Yuji upon entering the
theater finds hegoroma chilling in a
freaking bathtub filled with water while
he's still fully clothed in his suit but
man I love figarooma dude gets the
coolest introductions and honestly looks
so freaking clean here I'm not sure what
film as well this is from but I know for
a fact that this whole clothed and
chilling in a bathtub is definitely from
a movie that I've seen but I just can't
remember the exact one right now anyway
lying there and that Bell Delphine holy
bath water hegaruma claims that it feels
better than he expected we're just like
holy dude chill man he explains that
he's going off the rails and doesn't
care about anything anymore so he's
trying stuff he never thought he would
have done in the past hearing him ramble
Yuji finds it kind of funny but since
he's the Pro-Tech he tries to get
straight to the point and asks the
suited man to talk but the lawyer claims
it cost 5000 Yen per every half hour
hegaruma says that this was just a joke
though because he wanted to play the
part of a greeting lawyer for once Yuji
who's obviously like yo what the is
this dude on quickly realizes that he's
not an incarnated sorcerer from the past
to do a genius itadori deducing this he
believes that they can communicate and
make a deal instead of fighting but you
know if you go for Remy's saying then
right now Yuji is utterly stuffed either
way and won't be able to tour anyways
anyways YouTube Reveals His and megami's
points plan but hearing it hagarumita
climbs Because he believes the
Cunningham presents a few possibilities
he's interested in so obviously our
ex-loy has gone a little bit nuts here
with his sudden power and wants to know
more about the rules of the culling game
in comparison to that of societies
heguru resents the question of what if
the Cullen game punished rule Breakers
without charges prosecutions or trials
we're fully in that Law and Order Arc
right now boys Japan's Rogue lawyer
recognizes that the rules of the game
aren't perfect but he still preserve the
basic mechanics of the game and see the
curse technique removal process for
himself Yuji who's probably like just
chill man tries to get hegaruma to
understand that the culling game is a
ritual for sacrificing everyone in Japan
but he just doesn't believe it instead
he points out that the cullingham's
rules celebrate permanence something
Yuji can't argue with because he
literally doesn't even understand it
himself when Innovative options and
patience Yuji let the muscle hide ears
Ops for his own form of persuasion
getting ready to throw some freaking
hands he demands that he let him use his
points however soaking wet just like
myself after reading this Arc hegaruma
stands up out of the tub and asks Yuji
if he's ever killed anyone then armed
with the gavel in his hand and his
shikagami by his side hegaruma claims
that it feels better than he ever
expected standing opposite him Yuji
knows hegaruma has eliminated at least
20 players because of this he decides to
stay on the defensive to anticipate an
attack unexpectedly though you hear his
caught off guard is her groomer
instantly activates his own main
expansion deadly sentencing noting the
immediate danger Yuji rushes the lawyer
and tries to attack him before the
kurstick knee can activate Yuji throws a
head kick but his foot slows and slops
right before it can reach his opponent
higuruma explains to him that his domain
forbids the use of physical violence on
each other which causes Yuji to be
transported back to the other end of his
Court's room judgment which is the name
of the shukigami begins stating that
Yuji is Under Suspicion of entering the
Pachinko parlor on July 16 2017 and
Sendai City despite being underage Yuji
isn't sure what's happening at first
until he remembers The Parlor the
Judgment was referring to as per usual
Yuji literally can't lie and makes it
pretty obvious that he has been there
higuruma explains that judgment knows
everything about everyone and the domain
it's explained that hegaruma isn't privy
to all of this information beforehand
and the verdict is solely decided by the
arguments presented in this courtroom
additionally as a confused Yuji reacts
to this some evidence in a folder
randomly appears that's been submitted
by judgment to be looked over it's not
necessarily conclusive but our boy who
physically like cannot lie won't be
informed of what's inside either instead
his goal is to defend his case and
dispel all doubts to win an innocent
verdict from judgment so yes well you
all thought the perfect preparation Arc
was crazy with some of the techniques
like Remy's and how they all worked but
I can tell you for a fact that father
Gage was just warming up his holy pencil
right there like my brain writing these
scripts sometimes and figuring out how
these techniques exactly work as mental
everything just feels so well thought
out with him anyways anyways this
trial-based Goose technique makes Yuji
realize that he's being prosecuted by an
actual lawyer the absence of a fatal
attack in hagarumus domain makes usually
remember a past convo worthy thumb or
explain that a domain expansion was a
more common technique for Sorcerers of
the past because they didn't incorporate
guaranteed hurts which is different to
today's as I think so far throughout the
series everyone who's cast a domain has
had a sure hit guarantee old school
domains used to be used in such a way to
force people to obey specific conditions
of the occurs technique constructing a
domain will can't miss attack like
digons or jogos for example requires a
lot of skill and the number of users
will theme heavily decreases over time
due to them fighting obviously which is
why most people have to bear on
Surviving this short hit domain to
defeat the enemy whereas Yuji surmises
that hecaroma's domain as the old school
type meaning it isn't necessarily lethal
and can't physically harm him if he
sticks to the conditions that hegaruma
explained beforehand continuing to
explain a rumor says that both
participants each have one chance to
make a statement once both parties have
made their case against each other
judgment will deliver a verdict you he
asks what happens if he's found guilty
the Higa rumor isn't sure how to answer
that question instead he tells Yuji
here's one of three options as a
response silence confession or denial
surprised juji asks if it's fine if he
lies in court to which hugoroma points
out that there will be no need for
trials if everyone was just honest in
the first place then tells Yuji to hurry
his slow ass up and make his statement
because judgment is impatient taking a
moment Yuji thinks about how to properly
defend himself he knows that he did go
into the pachenko parlor that day and
even one on the machines this means that
line is his way to get off clean but he
isn't sure what the evidence is after
going over all other hypotheticals if
you decide to go with the second option
which was confession and claims that he
only went inside the building to use the
bathroom however hegarum is a part of
the goddamn Yu-Gi-Oh universe and had
set up his trap he instantly reveals it
retorting with the evidence which turns
out to be a damn photo of Yuji inside of
the Parlor using a cash exchange
absolutely dumbfounded with his own
stupidity Fuji face Palms while
sidokaiba himself adds that after
gaining all of this evidence it puts a
supposed restroom story and to question
because of this he states that is
certain Yuji into the Pachinko parlor or
the intent of playing on the machines
Yuji trying to be cheeky asks the lawyer
what law he's breaking in to which is
explained that the premises forbids the
entry of miners currently in Japan there
aren't any laws for actually punishing
those miners over this but it's still
considered illegal puzzled he states
that this isn't an unfair trial puzzled
he states that this is an unfair trial
because there's nothing he could have
said to win however hagarumu reveals
that Japan only forbids miners to gamble
meaning cash exchanges are separate
entities in themselves because of this
if Yuji wanted to win the verdict all he
actually needed to say was that he'd
never seen The pachenko Parlor before
having come to a conclusion judgment
finds Yuji guilty sentencing him to
confiscation finally we can stop with
all the the Yip yep and get to the
proper Beatdown material and like y'all
don't realize this but after this fight
here we don't see you for an extremely
long time to savor this fight before we
move on to some of the newest and
coolest characters in manga anyways so
randomly the domain is dispelled and
judgment disappears as it does so he can
rumor immediately attacks by throwing
his gavel which connects with yuji's arm
dealing way more damage than it should
have smelling blood in the water
hegaruma closes the distance and summons
his gavel back to his hand he then
charges it with cursed energy to
increase its size and proceeds to smash
through yuji's defense sending him
crashing through several seats in the
theater getting back up YouTube realizes
that he's in an even worse situation
than originally thought now he's
completely lost the ability to
manipulate curse energy but honestly
hegaruma probably got the worst matchup
here as we all know for a fact that our
boy's physical strength is so damn
broken it's comparable to having a
freaking Heavenly restriction on himself
continuing to attack a groomer launches
and smashes down his Mallet atop ug
seeing it in time though Yuji jumps back
to avoid it but this insanely big brain
lawyer makes the gavel appear in his
other hand allowing him to quickly
attack back yet again after the barrage
ends Yuji who would narrowly managed to
dodge tries to counter-attack with an
elbow bag Aroma instead of switching
hands like he just was now morphs the
shape of the gavel into a flexible Hawk
which manages to wrap around yuji's
elbow before tossing him away it's
actually crazy when you think about how
strong hagaroma really is like this dude
didn't have a cursed technique up until
extremely recently and only in the
basics of barrier techniques by
analyzing his own domain expansion
somehow this mad genius had worked back
from there and gained an instinctive
grasp or how to reinforce his body with
curse energy so somehow within just 12
days of Awakening hegaruma managed to
blossom into a fighter who's comparable
to someone like freaking an army or even
meimei but probably even stronger before
entering the colony so literally for no
point he exercised a few cursed spirits
and then soon after has eliminated at
least 20 players becoming one of the two
current Front Runners in terms of points
standing there he asks Yuji if he can't
control his curse energy which confuses
him because he thinks hegaruma is the
reason for it but apparently the
confiscation penalty takes away the
person's ability to use techniques in
the first place so because Yuji doesn't
possess any kind of technique the
effects literally fell to stopping him
from utilizing cursed energy altogether
concerned over this hiruma quickly
surmises that it must be due to an
incredible physical prowess determined
to crush Eugene with all of his might he
gruma shifts his gavel into a staff and
attacks with a flurry of swings using
his insane agility though Lucy is able
to avoid each swing then grabs onto the
staff's middle section only for hegaroma
to make a theme instantly vanish before
he can pull it away jumping back Eugene
kicks the bathtub directly towards the
lawyer however he simply destroys it
with his gavel unleashing a rush of
water and broken tub pieces erupting
through the water hegaruma increases his
gavel to a freaking massive size and
slams it down on top of Yuji however
like someone please explain to me how
even this isn't enough to crush Yuji and
even freaking impresses her garuma who
Compares his experience to fighting an
indestructible doll Gucci who realizes
that he's in deep water though considers
hikaru's nickname to be exceptionally
strong and thanks that this muscles will
mean that there's some sort of relative
weakness he frantically records his
interactions beforehand and remembers
the mental notes he made about the
trial-based curse technique then in a
moment that plays even me away every
time I read it Yuki calls out and
demands a retrial like how does he even
know what this is in the first place
because of this it instantly transports
them both inside of the domain to some
sort of momentary safety due to what
happened in the previous trial a Fuji
doesn't confess his guilt outright he
can request a free trial that can't be
refused yet this play of his utterly
backfires is in this new trial judgment
announces that our boy is being accused
of mass murder and Shibuya on October
the 31st 2018. then like last time
hagarumo received some evidence to go
over but before he even has the chance
to speak who she immediately confesses
his guilt as we all know by now he won't
let alone can't lie and will refuse to
deny what happened shocking lawyer
bleeding from his eyes with rage the
erase judgment declares Yuji as guilty
he punishes Yuji with confiscation again
as well as an additional punishment
which turns out to be no other than the
freaking death penalty so for those of
you who are wondering yes this is the
third time now that a boy has been
sentenced to death in some kind of
manner after judgment gives Yuji his
penalty hagarum is gavel transforms into
an Executioner's sword which has the
added effect of being able to kill its
targets with just one cart hegaruma
believes emphasizing with people means
understanding all of their weaknesses
but he can't help but perceive that
fragility itself is ugly including Yushi
everyone is weak and ugly to himself
regardless of the aspirations to improve
in life while hagaroma continues
screaming who he tries to keep him back
by launching several theater chairs in
his Direction then penis cheeky old self
luji throws as a Jutsu hijacket of the
strict Aroma leaving her a moment to get
in and behind him quickly higgerum
returns but in that moment also notices
Yuji who now throws his hoodie and
manage is to block the lawyer's site
momentarily dropping to the floor
usually throws a sweeping Kirk a
hagaroma who's somehow able to keep up
is able to just jump above it as he
floats there he can remove appears to
land his final blow with the
Executioner's sword while Yuji below
prepares to land in Upper cards and the
usual manga fashion though we get
absolutely cucked as it goes away into a
past conversation between Mr Josie Kawa
and her current mentally insane lawyer
there haggaruma refuses to become a
judge because he felt like his Ambitions
in life weren't good enough as explained
that he's reminded of his memory because
Yuji for some bizarre reason confessed
to a crime he did not commit the
evidence on the retrial was about
sukoona's Massacre and hegaruma knows
that Yuji wasn't the one who committed
that crime so he can't seem to
understand why Yuji would confess to
something that he didn't do because of
his confusion over this hagarumo
willingly deactivates the Executioner
sword allowing yuji's insanely strong
uppercut like this is just pure physical
strength by the way like look how ripped
he is right now boys this punch directly
hits him in the body probably cracking a
rebel tomb and seated him crashing back
into the seeds before he even bothers to
get up and he hurts I grew mistakes to
Yuji that the absence of reason or
control signifies non-components he adds
that sakuna was in position of the body
and since Yuji didn't surrender control
willingly he is innocent who she doesn't
see it that way though and he still
claims responsibility for it believing
that death really only occurred because
he's too weak Yuji who's still confused
over why he deactivated his technique in
the first place asks him so getting back
up now Hikaru explains that he
remembered why he got into law in the
first place as there are still other
weak people out there who need his help
heguruma invites Yuji to sit down after
he's gotten his clothes back on and
agrees to give him his 100 points
however before he does so he asks the
young sorcerer if he's ever killed
anyone on purpose twitch Yuji somebody
responds that he has then in a quick
flash we see the moments preceding
keita's trial and now hegoroma had
brutally murdered the prosecutor and
judge thanking him thus he asks Yuji if
he felt awful about it as well
so that there officially brings the
first beat down of this like amazing
of this amazing colony to an end but one
thing I do want to say is I goddamn love
pick a roommate and I really really hope
that he sticks around any story after
this point even after the killing game
like ends it would be nice to have him
as a great addition to like the Jujutsu
Tech staff honestly I think he is just
truly a good person who is blinded by
just how Society is and his insane
increase in power that he just received
from kinjaku which makes me also wonder
are all these new techniques and modern
day civilians have found themselves
worth actually just another
reincarnation and instead of a person
being reincarnated it's technically a
curse technique itself that's being
placed inside of an individual who meets
the right conditions anyways now that
the two were just chilling out hagaruma
tells us cocaine to add a new rule to
the culling game that allows players to
transfer points between one another as
usually anxiously Waits cocaine relays
the message to the game master but just
moments later he breathes a sigh of
relief as the rule is allowed and
hagaruma transfers one of his points to
Yuji so that neither of them will be
affected by cursed technique removal for
at least 19 days abruptly getting up now
and leaving her groomer says goodbye but
Yuji who's just like yo wait up dude
asks him what he's going to do now he
explains to him that he wants to use
hecarima's strength to help them in the
culling game but the Louis explains that
he killed a few people before coming to
Tokyo due to how he feels about this now
he wants to take responsibility and plan
to turn himself in once the barriers
reopen but until that time happens he's
going to ponder his best cause of action
and doesn't feel comfortable staying
around Yuji because it just makes him
hate himself even more sadly hegaruma
leaves the theater leaving out boy alone
to lament over this situation despite
accomplishing his goal now we move on to
the next round of heat boys seeking
massive Battle of this dopas Arc here I
don't know if you've seen like gigay's
recent posted with Hana and him honoring
Takashi sensei's ethereal level of
writing but dude said he hoped he could
warm the pages to a similar degree to
Takashi since his writing and years to
come I don't like actually believe how
humbled this goat is I he doesn't
realize he's already setting his pages
on freaking fire and it's definitely
become one of the hottest dudes on the
Block where they're constantly releasing
manga each week especially in the
western side of the world meanwhile and
over the other side of the Tokyo Colony
regica means mikami as he says he can
already tell that the young man is
strong just based on a shikigami
unbeknownst to Remy Reggie was actually
just using her to lure in potential
allies and now seeing Megami here he
asks him to join their group then asks
what he knows about the culling game
well that means any Master thumb making
me reveals that it is a ritual for
bringing Japanese people to the other
side so that they're no longer
considered human hearing this
explanation Reggie cracks up and asks
smigami if he knows kinjaku surprising
the younger sorcerer as he had figured
he'd run into a person with a connection
to kinshaku sooner or later which he
explains that the ritual explanation is
probably just the cover for kingjaku's
real plan and hold I don't want to spoil
anything I want to like catch up and
probably reveal like the true play
myself because Reggie may look like a
silly mofo but this dude is a genius for
stating this cheeky foreshadowing right
here continuing with his big brain
explanation assuming that 1 000 players
were equally divided among 10 colonies
Reggie suggests that each colony of 800
players is top heavy in regard to the
player's skill level players like
hashimo and hegoroma are much stronger
than most of the other combatants and
between the two of them they have
already eliminated roughly 60 players
within just the first 12 days which
makes sense to Megami is like the Tokyo
calling number one has been extremely
quiet ever since he entered he asks
Reggie if all these strong have already
waited out all of the Wake that's early
on in the game and if the game has
reached a deadlock due to those
circumstances Reggie confirms this then
goes on to explain the transferal
process isn't just a way to spread out
players but actually a way to stimulate
a second Awakening of new modern day
peoples curse techniques some of the
Waker people even die during their
transfer process but this doesn't
benefit the ritual in the same way that
a drawn out merely would Reggie drops a
freaking bomb saying that kinjaku is
currently overseas in China meeting with
the government officials there so like
why is that Beijing I don't know what Mr
G and his boys are doing over there but
anyways he explains that he's pretty
soon that kinjaka would drop his own
metaphorical bomb on all of the players
once Only The Strongest Ones remain at
that point Reggie believes the Cullen
gamble have served its purpose so for
now he's just focused on Gathering
strong allies and storing points nikumi
asks how rimi fits into his plan because
she's obviously a weakling with no value
to which Reggie clarifies that Remy is
useful for learning people as they tend
to drop their guard around a woman
making me asks regi at the total points
of everyone in the group adds up to 100
to which originally confirms that they
have over a hundred points in total
having been confirmed on his suspicions
making me reveals that a new rule will
soon be added that allows players to
give points to each other he demands
that Reggie and all of his allies hand
over their points to him and only then
will they consider joining them
immediately Reggie is like oh oh well I
guess this tour has broken down causing
a random fodder player to shoot out
behind me me and try to attack him with
a set of claw hands so obviously this
dude is another of the guys I like to
call it body modification curse users
with Yuji we had the cap dude and of
course the rocket here girl now we've
got claw man right here Mega me manages
to slip into the Stone's Shadow then
there's this Divine dog attacks Reggie
he reappears from below the fodder claw
man picking him up and simply throwing
his ass off the side of the building
it's per usual though Megami always
double Taps his opponents and commands
in a way to dive for him shockingly
player and slamming him into the ground
below probably murking him back in the
building two kitchen knives are suddenly
shoved into the Divine dog's mouth and
capacitating the shikagami as Mega me
turns back Reggie says that he knows
what he's up to and wants his adversary
he'll die if he doesn't fight for real
on cue a random eye suddenly appears
over the side of the building next to
Mega me and abruptly detonates causing
an explosion which almost takes out even
Reggie above them we find a player named
iori hazanoki one of Reggie's allies and
another of those body modification users
the now one eye sorcerer begins breaking
off some more of his teeth while asking
if the target is dead however nigami is
saying quickly darting out of the smoke
and immediately avoiding a follow-up
attack sent by Remy he manages to grabu
here and slams her onto the ground
aggressively he asks her if she's
heading north but before she can answer
hazanoki jumps down from the floor above
and tosses his teeth at Mega me at the
same time Reggie also sends through a
few receipts that transform into gas and
splash all over Mega me soaking hum then
in some crazy ass combination with the
gasoline hazunoki detonates his teeth
resulting in a massive blast that erupts
through the top of the building
seemingly taking out both Remy and mega
me exit in a room Reggie asks if they're
finished but hazunoki says he saw megamy
duck into another room to avoid taking
damage inside of that said room making
me moves a door that he used to protect
himself in Remy and asks her if she
understands now as the explosions could
have easily killed her as well proving
that she's completely and utterly
disposable making me tries to leave her
behind but Remy attempts to stab him
again with her hair then enter only
switching up she desperately begs Mega
me to say that he likes her and then he
will protect her disgusted making me
realizes that Remy is the type of trash
who only cares about words rather than
someone's actions so like remember that
random dude making me disposal right of
the style of the scuffle well it turns
out he didn't actually die and stupidly
the man decides to reach when they
battle he compliments Mega me for
getting the better of him before but
notes that this student must be in rough
shape now he mentions it was a pain
scale in the building and hearing this
Mega me is like yo what what are you
dumb dude why didn't you take the stairs
suddenly both of their code games appear
and announce that a new rule has been
added to the culling game so this is
obviously the point in the arc that Yuji
and Higa rumors battle ends with them
finally adding that new rule surprise
and reinvigorated making me Smiles
instantly he restarts the fight kicking
he fought a full back and summoning his
prolific Max elephant which materializes
inside the building completely
destroying the upper floors as it comes
thundering down sticking with light in
itself nigami then uses the way to catch
himself allowing him to mount chizuru in
mid-air after getting on top and still
falling making me slashes his face over
and over with the health of a sword
before jumping off and kicking him into
the ground below having crashed heavily
into the ground Chooser who curses
mikami yet before he can even get up
Mega me who ain't no damn Yuji simply
slashes his face open with his sword and
eliminates him for a moment make me
questions what he's doing because I need
more points in the future but quickly
refocuses by reminding himself that
tsukomi won't have to participate in the
Kelly now Esco game rewards him with
five points migami reaffirms to himself
that he just needs to deal with the
difficulties as they come descending
down to ground level with their
opponences Reggie has left surprise and
even embarrassed by chizuru's lack of
skill back with our boy he notices that
he's still at number two to one and is
now feeling the effects of the first
explosion thinking on what to do for a
moment he deduces that he can't Flay or
use his domain expansion because the
environment still isn't compatible with
his technique before he can think up of
anything to do has an Nokia abruptly
spits out another one of his bomb teeth
but completely and utterly out of
nowhere someone literally no one saw
coming showed up until they blast face
first like an actual champion to protect
him as all of them stand there utterly
confused the newcomer named for Mexico
takaba who was the failing comedian that
I introduced right at the end of the
previous Jitsu Kaizen video or it might
even mean the one before that one now
well he and one of them might Superhero
level voices states that two-on-one
fights are unfair and calls Richie and
his minion complete cowards he adds that
their attacks have done zero damage
however it's shown that the attack
completely busted open his face and hid
making it clear that he was in fact
heard confusing Mega me looking at Mega
me takaba decides to help him because
their 35 year old can tell whether
someone is good or bad just by their
face yet after looking at him again he
realizes that Mega me actually has a bad
face but writes it off is all
revisionist which is just obviously
wrong I mean to say relative making his
just left stun with this new person but
regardless of his personality this
random man just saved him so the Jiu
Jitsu High student is willing to trust
him for now Regine hazunoki don't even
recognize takaba they try asking what
time period is from to cover though who
isn't even listening to them explains
that his costume is based on a funny
superhero causing his intimidation
factor to suddenly flare up while
preparing to tell another absolutely
terrible joke the enemy Duo prepare for
an attack but to cover darts into a JoJo
whisk pose and tells a joke they could
say did silent reaction takaba screams
that damn it's a tough crowd but
continues to Hype himself up nonetheless
even though his opponents are stiff
takaba will continue to do what he does
best because he's an Entertainer of the
highest degree he screams flying forward
and delivering an insane double-footed
flying dropkick that connects with
hazanoki's face sending him crashing
into a nearby building sent in there
Reggie notes the shift into Carver's
output of cursed energy and quickly
realizes that the failing comedian is
actually super strong takaba stunting on
all of them does a handstand while
explaining that he's an old school
performer who's pro-violence using
Fusion to his Advantage Megami tries to
launch a surprise attack on regi from
his own shadow but his foe manages to
jump away from the ground in time to
avoid it now back with his new teammate
migami tries to explain to him hasn't
know he's exploding body part but only
ends up getting annoyed telling takaba
to stop getting so close to his face
bringing out co-game they use him to
confirm that hegaruma was indeed the one
who added a new role he's surprised and
is sure to see that Yuji had completed
their mission because of this he states
that he's done with this colony and
tells Reggie he'll let him go if he
backs off Richie just straight up
annoyed now refuses because he needs to
make up for his teammates lost points
over in their absolutely ruined building
hazunuku recovers from the Dropkick that
he just suffered and calls out to zakaba
the comedian though still just
absolutely ignores him and instead
introduces himself properly to Mega me
since tacaba is most likely going to end
up killing the bomb guy making me
requests that he take hazanoki's point
if possible to which he accepts on the
condition that he continues to entertain
as first and foremost he is a performer
satisfied takaba begins sparking almost
exposing himself to the young man while
hazanoki in return sends an explosive
eye directs the atom not phase to cover
simply knocks it away with a random
paper fan he manages to close the
distance on his opponent sliding in
behind him and utterly destroying his
rectum with pervy sages Infamous 1 000
years of pain seen in his enemy into a
severe belt of pain enraged and getting
utterly photorized as the Noki swings at
him but takaba immediately follows up
with a powerful kick to his dorm that
sends his opponent through another
building standing there Mega measly
flabbergasted with takaba's show of
strength and expresses that he's glad he
isn't his enemy twister Kaba tells him
to stay alive while he goes off and
pounds his opponents some more over with
Reggie he stands there thinking that
zakaba is toast either way because
hazanoki will go all out after being
mocked so much with his objective
complete Megami tells his adversary to
worry about himself so that he can fight
him for real instantly he summons his
max elephant leaving Reggie blown away
they're making me has such a large
chickagami in his Arsenal Max elephant
attempts to spray Reggie with a torrent
of water but he somehow manages to Dart
away from the burst attempting to take
him by surprise he can be leaps from the
building above but Richie notices in
time and throws a receipt which
transforms into a net and ensnares the
recently created rabbits Mega me himself
though narrowly a voicing it and jumps
onto a chain-linked fence to break his
fall as Megami jumps back into the road
rigid activates his innate curse
technique contractual Recreation and
transforms several receipts into kitchen
knives those in knives fly forward
towards mikami as projectiles but he's
able to deflict them with a blade of his
own some rabbits are pierced by these
knives allowing rigidism eyes that
unlike the other shikigami they can
reappear regardless of how many are
destroyed which he figures that Megami
has likely figured out how his coustic
Nick Works due to this he uses a receipt
to recreate the contract and endows
himself with a relaxing two night stay
at a five-star Japanese Inn in contrast
Mega Millions worn down from the
constant fighting on top of having you
some
lowering his overall capacity bridges
surmises that Miami can't reconjour his
shikigami after they're injured and
without the flexibility the Divine dog
provides him he's Limited in his options
the old school ads that both of them
lack big finishing moves and will need
to pick away at each other over time to
achieve Victory torch migami is like
yeah bro in that case I'm absolutely
so I'm a run for now out of
nowhere no waiting swoops down gravy
Mega me however Reggie quickly summons
the trash taste boys drones equipped
with the lost luggage cameras to follow
his opponents through the sky while he
watches on a phone then summoning your
moped Reggie begins to pursue his
adversary through the streets and tracks
migami's position to a gymnasium Reggie
questions whether he really tried
escaping or if he's in fact trying to
lure the fight inside of the gym Mickey
is glad to see that the area is spacious
looking up though he suddenly sees
Reggie appear on the balcony who asks
what his opponents is plotting making me
replies that big Reggie is likely
planning something as well and the
letter claims that it's hard to tell
because Sorcerers are nothing but con
artists which is completely utterly true
and I love the whole idea of Reggie's
thoughts on Sorcerers here it's all
about like conning your enemy into
believing you've played your final move
but actually you've just laid a trap and
con him into a false sense of security
anyways with the main part of this
absolutely insane battle begin suddenly
two trucks appear out of nowhere and
come crashing through the walls of the
building acting quickly making me is
just able to slip under the vehicles yet
as he watches them crash into the other
wall two potted plants are recreated
above Megami their drop down onto his
head cracking his skull open Richie
follows up by repeatedly slicing
megamy's back and left arm with a small
knife Megami tries to retreat but gets
distracted by the unorthodox projectile
Reggie had just created he's taken off
guard when they silly old carrot begins
to break apart and reveals a hidden
kitchen knife inside shooting forth the
Knight stabs directly into migami's
elbow while Richie then follows up with
a brutal front kick to his face having
been knocked down negamy slides across
the gym floor thoroughly overpowered
it's explained that other things Reggie
recreates behave like shikigami
obviously knives and other things like
that can't normally fly through the air
but Reggie is able to get them to do so
with a single command big freaking Mega
me though a man made of a much darker
material response by stating that
barrier techniques are difficult for him
and he's simply unable to make an
artificial environment over a real one
however Megami doesn't need to
physically create a barrier no instead
he can use the entire gymnasium as a
perfect space for his domain as planned
Mega me casts has got a damn domain
expansion the insane kamira Shadow
Garden and forcibly encloses the barrier
around the gym to trap Reggie inside
ceiling has faked Richie who really
doesn't think migami was a sorcerer
capable of using domain expansion as
utterly taken by surprise immediately
though he activates his special
anti-domain technique called Hollow
wicker basket which if you see my video
going over like all of the jjk barrier
types you know that this is the original
form of the current simple domain Reggie
believes he successfully protected
himself from the domain until four toads
appear from the liquid below his feet
and wrap up both his legs with their
tongues confused which he doesn't
understand how he's been hit after using
Hollow wicker basket and to explain that
technically Reggie's technique does
nullify this seed guaranteed hit from a
domain but because Bick Holden megami's
domain isn't complete and doesn't
actually have a can't miss attack it
only serves as an extension to his
cursed energy and Tin Shadows technique
that soul and Perfection has taken
Reggie off guard and making me notices
his expression change before Reggie can
finish berating Mega me for getting
cocky he's ambushed by two Shadow clones
Richie is unable to avoid the barrage of
hairs due to the Toad's tongues
preventing his movements after getting
pummeled over and over Richard post back
to the ground and summons combat knives
to sever the Toad's tongues free to move
again he summons a machete and prepares
the counter attack however nigami's
clone prevents Reggie from gaining any
momentum by coming up from below to
graber's League then the Clone throws
Reggie towards me give me his main body
who's also armed with his sword and
already bringing it down on Reggie
somehow though Reggie is able to block
this attack like his reflexes are
literally insane here but now the only
reverse cards been played by our boy and
it's a three-on-one with the other
Shadow clone appearing and elbowing him
directly in the dome heavily damaged now
where he just narrowly defends a slash
from Mega me and commends the Sorcerer
for his increased function of the curse
technique considering it worse than a
lethal domain Reggie is aware that if
migami uses Max elephant and showers him
with water he'll lose this fight
refusing to allow that to happen he
activates his coustic neck and releases
a multitude of receipts into the ear
above his head mikumi tries to destroy
the receipts using no way but it's just
not quick enough to stop ridge's
contractual Recreation from active
invading three cars are suddenly
generated from the receipts was dropped
straight into the shadowy floor which he
understands that the entire domain is
migami Shadow but noticed that Megami
has only kept one curse tool onto the
length of this entire fight he theorizes
that this is because Mega me has to be
the weight of anything kept within his
shadow and now Reggie is using the cast
to turn the domain's conditions back on
mikami heavy mean forced to the ground
under the immense weight Richard
believes migami might be able to summon
shikigami still so he keeps his guard up
and plans to keep on piling weight until
his opponent is completely crushed Mega
me though like we all learned this
throughout the first battle against that
silly old cursed womb he literally is
insane and the dude does not care about
life anymore to the point that he tells
Reggie he's forgotten something
important he reminds him that an
incomplete domain is still a domain and
there is Shadow All Around the both of
them migami who doesn't care certainly
conscious Max elephant from these
Shadows above Richie causing the massive
shikigami to drop down directly on top
of him having turned their fire into a
10 weightlifting competition making me
remains confident as he asks Richie
which of the two of them will be crushed
first let's explain that the average
human being can withstand about five to
six units of G-Force before losing
Consciousness making me weigh 60
kilograms and is currently carrying 2.4
tons of weight which equates to 40 units
of G-Force a fully matured elephant
weighs three to six tons and making this
domain increases the Precision of his
curse technique replicating Max
elephant's weight realistically with an
intense weight falling atop him Reggie
fractures his right fibula and heel bone
due to the pressure alone hitting lament
over not saving the trucks he used
earlier for more weight at this moment
he's been soaked with water by Max
elephant but there are still receipts he
can release including the special Ace
that he has up a sleeve Reggie wonders
if he can enter the shadow below him to
release his Ace and finish off Megami he
dismisses this idea though because
anything caught in the shadow after it's
dispelled might be unable to escape
furthermore he's unsure of what it's
actually like inside of this sticky
shadow we substance he decides this
option is too risky and tries to
withstand the elephant's weight while
releasing his Ace attack regi attempts
to hold up the elephant with one arm
while taking out another receipt but
before he can fully activate his
contractual Recreation Regice succumbs
to Max elephant's immense weight and
falls into the shadow below him without
any buoyancy or resistance inside of the
Shadow Reggie Falls and begins to lose
Consciousness due to the lack of oxygen
laying there above his likely defeated
opponent making me wait until he's sure
that Reggie is dead before dispelling
the domain and emptying his shadow
suddenly and coming back like a damn
King riding one of his cars Reggie flies
back exploding through to the surface
rescue from certain demise now he
convenes making me strength and emits
he's a strong sorcerer before
immediately stating that he's even
stronger though he activates another
contractual Recreation and summons a
small two-story freaking wooden house
that weighs at least 30 tons to crush
mikami in the next second Megami makes
an extremely drastic move despite using
his Ace Richie somehow abruptly finds
himself underwater again and being
strangled from behind as explained now
Megami is using his extreme weight to
drown Richie but because of just the
immense Force that's being placed on him
he has to deactivate the curse technique
and then register the weight of the
objects before he does actually end up
dying himself coming to Regis able to
swim back to the surface and realizes
that he's inside of a pool on the
basement level of the gymnasium making
me fled back into his shadow and entered
the domain making it so that the house
broke the floor and forced Reggie into
the pool below it's unclear how Mickey
me was able to move despite the immense
weight but Ricky theorizes that he did
so by ejecting himself from the shadow
kind of like a seesaw making me straws
up on his opponent and tells Reggie his
receipts are too weak to use now
normally splashing their seats with
water isn't enough to make the print
fade so that alone isn't enough to stop
Reggie from reducing things however so
can the receipts prevents Reggie from
fulfilling the condition that requires
burning of the receipts which G also
notes that making me can't summon
shikigami anymore to watch the sorcerer
agrees stating they're from now on this
is a straight up physical fight to the
death Reggie though doesn't actually
believe this he expects Megami to summon
a shugigami and plans on countering
Megami as soon as he lets up dartinan
Reggie's initial base attack gets palmed
off but as he planned he uses that
momentum to sing meghami's sword arm
bouncing back having no defense left
Reggie lifts loose with a multitude of
kicks smashing the young sorcerer over
and over again making me admits that
Reggie is a tough opponent made evident
visibility to withstand Max elephant
he's also a talented martial artist with
some really dopas techniques but he just
isn't fast enough just before Reggie is
able to land a direct hit on Megami a
portion of the far left side of Reggie's
face his ear and much of his left
shoulder are completely sheared off by
someone he thought that he dealt with
already having suffered a lethal blow at
blinding speed Richie looks back to see
no one other than the Divine dog
totality which is just pissed atom while
the dog even has two scars in its nose
from the knives it's explained that Mega
me was waiting until Reggie had
completely dismissed the dog and hearing
this would you repeat that a sorcer is
indeed nothing but a con artist as he
collapses to the ground and a pull of
his own blood Reggie lays bleeding out
on the ground looking up at Mega me and
realizes that the domain and the Paul
concealed that Mega me could still
strike with his Divine dog Mega me
didn't flee into the gem using no way
instead hit Lord of Reggie inside
standing above him make me inquires as
to what ridge's relationship to master
tinken is it's shown that there really
isn't much of a relationship he only
knows him as the hermit who is Immortal
and isn't surprised to find out he's
still alive at this time defeated with
dignity Reggie tells his cocaine to
transfer all 41 of his points to Mega me
with your boy is a little annoyed about
but Reggie tells him to just consider it
a good deed before death he ads that
he's just a spectator and isn't close to
King jaku at all well this final word
said Richie tells his executioner to let
fate toy with him before he also dies
like a fool moments later mikimi
received five points for the death of
Reggie Starr damn is actually such a
firefight like I love how much
foreshadowing for future events are
people throughout the story here like is
that how Megami is going to end up dying
having zacona who is fate in this
context I guess toy with him before he
kills him like a fool and again those
who are like past chapter 200 now also
know big Richie was correct when it came
to this just being the beginning of
something even larger back to the fight
over the other side of the city a
massive explosion a set off on the roof
of a building hazanoki who's still
fighting with takaba wonders if he's
finally had his Target yet the comedian
appears right beside him and comically
encourages him to stay focused because
his opponent is a tough one continuously
irritated by takaba's Antics hazanuki
tries to punch him only for his first to
slide off this new dude's weird Saucy
coating hazanuki is just really
frustrated by this fight as he doesn't
understand why to cover won't take any
damage regardless of how many times he
gets bombed kogane interrupts the battle
for a moment to inform them both that
Reggie has been eliminated surprise
hazanoki decides to walk away from the
fight entirely initially Takara is fine
with us telling his opponent to bathe
and brush his teeth once he gets home
but after thinking for a moment and
sticking with the original plan takaba
starts to piss the hazanoki for his
point only to be repeatedly denied as it
skips away from them it's explained that
big fumuhiko's curse technique is called
comedian it's actually like too broken
of a technique so broken in fact that it
has the possibility to even rival that
of gojos by anything that takaba thinks
is kind of funny or is funny in general
becomes reality itself for him but
unfortunately you know takaba is a
little bit mentally lacking and is
completely unaware of how this even
works elsewhere she's distress because
she's always been told throughout her
life that men are supposed to be wolves
who would tear up but they've always
come to take care of her which is what
do you mean by getting torn out her pin
and New Zealand made some crazy slang
anyways she doesn't know how to go on
and still thinks that wolves will
continue to help her until she's
cornered by a deadly Hound which turns
out to be migami's divine dog before
mikami can make good honest threats
takumi's voice randomly appears and
tells her brother to stop before he
kills someone in Cold Blood causing his
Divine dog to disappear and Remy
surprised that she's being lit go
annoyed and just completely exhausted
now making me tell the sister to just
shut up before he collapses to the
ground unconscious just as happens
though like literally something I didn't
even think like happened throughout this
Arc happens no one other than the angel
herself hanakurasu descends upon his
body
foreign just like I previously mentioned
we have now left the Tokyo Colony number
one we Gucci and Megami are to fly over
to gekko's other main character they no
longer depressed Yuta akotsu who's
currently in the Sendai Colony there are
currently four powerhouses at the center
of the conflict and just like the Tokyo
Colony Cinder here has also reached a
deadlock due to only the powerhouses
being left over drove like dewala is a
viscerin of the Civil War of War a war
in which was like literally him versus
everyone else so the dude must have been
pure Insanity it's explained that he
currently sits at 91 points and has the
ability to use two kinds of independent
shikigami that can compose a domain with
their like orbiting thingies somewhere
else inside of the Sendai Colony we find
a damn JoJo character under the name of
Rio ishigori this man currently sits at
77 points and has the highest cost
energy output of all of the players in
the Kalin game so like does he even
surpass Yoda perhaps anyway shooting
over to another Powerhouse called takako
uro as explained that this babe of a
character is the former captain of the
sun moon and star Squad who are group of
deadly assassins directly affiliated
with a fujiwara clan which in our own
world the fujiwara clan prospered for
around 1200 years from the 600s
dominating the Imperial Court until
1868. so Giga being Giga has probably
taken her directly from a specific time
period throughout those 1200 years and
assuming she's insanely strong it was
probably during the golden period or the
hean period of 794 through 1185 where
they held most of their dominance in the
court anyways skipping over to this bug
who's kuroroshi which is a special grade
cockroach curse that kinjaku had
released from kiddo's curse Spirit
manipulation and it was probably one of
those like very few special grade
Skittles keeping hidden during the night
parade it's explained that it currently
has 54 points and is lined dormant until
the unfavorable conditions disappear due
to their conflicting abilities and
Natures the four powerhouses falsely
standoff rather than Alliance however
they did lock falls apart when one side
eventually collapses Drew flock dewala
you said old school fart is cut down by
Tokyo Jiu Jitsu highs infamous second
year student Utah akotsu who now has 35
points so like man has literally become
demon mode throughout this part of the
story remember how he had also lost his
uh ranking after the end of jjk zero
well let's explain here that he
reclaimed his rank three months after
the night parade of a hundred demons and
still possesses unusual strength second
only to saturo Gojo so the height for
this battle is absolutely insane right
now takako and Ryu who are nearby
observe the developing situation and the
Sendai Colony due to Utah being himself
to reflect a while has fallen and is
patrolling sugigami are disappearing Ryu
uses his cocaine to check who defeated
dhruv and discovers the player as due to
akotsu takaku does the same and while
she's glad the ugly shikagami are
disappearing she's concerned about a new
threat that will surely emerge back with
Ryu he realizes that he was only able to
get close to Drew without provoking him
before because he was occupied in battle
Future these two new Sorcerers both know
that following Drew's defeat kuroroshi
will likely emerge next back over with
her boy though after cutting down drove
he regroups with a crowd of civilians
he's been protecting he tells them that
it's time to head north to the edge of
the barrier but notices a mother and
daughter struggling to go on because of
this he changes his mind and tells all
of the civilians they can rest inside of
the stadium that was serving as Drew's
base suddenly though he's interrupted by
a buzzing and collectoring sound that
indicates some sort of danger due to
immediately orders everyone to hurry
inside of the stadium and he draws his
Katana he looks out and sees an
overwhelming swarm of cockroaches
chasing people it's funny like cutting
myself off for a second you know it's
like a mega miguji Fusion like The Best
of Both Worlds man will murk anyone when
necessary and also save the helpless as
much as possible anyways anyways ljjk
Hannah Montana jumps four thinking he
can save through a many man but as Judah
grabs the man's arm he's unable to pull
him away in time and sadly the
Cockroaches Devour the civilian's lower
body then as the Cockroaches jump from
the man's body to attack Yuda quickly
blocked with his Katana and notices that
all of the bugs are indeed real and sex
reinforced with curse energy the Swarm
attempts to rush past Utah to ravage the
other civilians but he summons Reiki to
stop them the Demonic Powerhouse himself
then uses that curse devil IQ and
smashes down on a bridge collecting the
structure on top of the Swarm forcing it
to go back towards Utah the special
grade sorcerer then abuses Katana with
cursed energy and swings it with enough
Force to create a large blast of cursed
energy that disintegrates the whole
swarm in one shot watching the action
from afar Ryu comments that while yuda's
cursed energy output isn't anything
special his overall cursed energy
manipulation is extremely impressive
also observing tsukaku outro states that
Utah's overall curse energy is
bottomless and that the Cockroach curses
are disgusting so this elbago it's
explained that he was a poor matchup for
drove so to play things safe it went
into like a dormant Stace until droof
was eliminated the curse has an endless
appetite and 18 stimulates its ability
to perform parthenogenesis which and now
monkey bring terms and that took me five
times to say just means This creepy old
bug can self-reproduce not needing a
male or female partner now awakened the
Cockroach curse is starving and its
instincts immediately lead it to devour
YouTube while preparing to face off
against kuroroshi you'd upon us his
objective in this Colony he knows his
resources are finite and it's only a
matter of time before overall allowing
passage in and out of colonies is added
however dangerous players like truth
can't be allowed to leave the barrier
either with the likelihood that there
are other players just like him used to
knows that communication between
colonies is necessary to prevent anyone
dangerous from leaving them in addition
to the rules Megami proposed in the
meeting with tingen Yuta understands his
allies need a means of communication and
a way to move in and out of the colonies
so in total that's four rules the group
needs to create to get a handle on the
Cullen game which is actually insane
because that's at least 400 points or a
majority of the reincarnations kinjaku
has actually brought back anyways Yuda
feels that the Shibuya incident
exhausted all of his allies and he
doesn't want to make his sense say
Keller's best friend again poised and
ready to engage the enemy player with
his Katana usually resolves to kill King
and obtain 400 points all on his own so
let the absolute bloodbath begin
noticing yuda's battle starts kuroshi
bulks up and reveals a curse talk called
the festering life sword an enchanted
blade that makes his life and death
itself armed with the festering life
sword kuroroshi ferociously attacks only
to have his arm immediately cut off by
Utah the sorcerer then uses his Katana
to pen the kusa's arm to a rock
literally disarming it by turning the
arm into a freaking barbecue sword
skewer you didn't quickly for his help
with a dead level backhand strike that
since kuroroshi's getting back across
the water the Cockroach curse tries to
fly up above the bridge but Yuda who's
just too damn quick jumps on top of the
bridge first then grabs and flings a
piece of railing that hits kuroroshi in
the chest taking this moment Yuda
capitalizes on the opening he created by
Cindy kuroroshi down and to the water
below with a sick diving slash as the
water clears though it's revealed that
the curse managed to stop yuda's blade
by using a swarm of cockroaches Yuda
swipes the Swarm away with a sword while
kuroroshi manipulates his bugs into a
twister of cockroaches to malevently
stand on below uterus aware that he's
been watched by the two other players
with high scores he knows he can easily
exercise kuroshi by driving reverse
Coast energy into his body in a similar
fashion to how we revived Yuji in their
fight however Yuna doesn't want the
observing players to see that he can use
a reverse curse technique additionally
he can't call him Rika because she's
protecting everyone else at the stadium
kuroroshi is indeed a dangerous opponent
but Yuna wants to exercise her without
relying on either of his two backup
techniques out of nowhere though this
bug somehow manages to speak which you
know actually makes sense it's over time
special grades can like easily develop a
language anyways it asks you to why he's
interfering with his feeding referring
to her not letting him Munch down on
those civilians back there to a Tudor
responds by asking the curse white kills
people and kuroroshi simply replies that
it likes the taste of iron then going on
to chart binding over and over again
kuroroshi uses its Earthen insect trance
technique to summon small and seek like
curses that carry these unproportionate
looking nutsacks with them instantly a
swarm of cockroaches shoot down in a
rounded forcing him to stab the shallow
water below him to create a shock wave
allowing him to hide once this swarm
dissipates the curses from kuroroshi's
previous technique attack user from
behind Judah slashes them apart but
sadly the toxins from their big ass sex
blind him for a moment giving kuroshi an
opening the Cockroach curse retrieves
the history life sword and slashes at
his Target Yuda manages to block with
his Katana but a festering life sword
shoots something into his shoulder as
her boy darts back he figured that the
curse tool might be able to shoot
projectiles but he instantly realizes
something's wrong and more insect-like
curses suddenly grow out of his shoulder
wound taken by surprise Yoda tries to
cut them off with his Katana but this
gives kuroroshi another opening to
attack closing in the Cockroach curse
slashes Yuta across his abdomen opening
up another wound and causing more curses
to spawn from it Ryu and takako watching
shock is kuroroshi then grabs you with
his body fully expecting her to defend
though plays the infamous Ono reversal
and grabs the cursor's face before
sinking his teeth into kuroroshi's
exoskeleton then as he's munching down
he drives a reverse curse energy blast
through his teeth into the Cockroach
compromising the Integrity of its body
and exercising his special grade curse
Hiroshi Falls to Paces while you just
spit its remains onto the ground earning
himself another five points from kogang
with the curse Spirit out of the way and
Utah in a vulnerable state uru decides
to take advantage of the situation and
confronts him directly levitating upside
down behind a new rival or her Whispers
And to shoot his ear taken him by
surprise before you can confront the
danger directly though or reduces the
dopas curse technique to heavily distort
the space around them instantly this
Distortion fractures the terrain around
her and launches you to backwards taking
the hit head-on you know minimizes the
damage and starts to wonder how exactly
she caused so much destruction but
before he has time to think Oru follows
up her attack with a punch Yuda is just
able to weave past the hit and try us to
count with a punch of his own however
Oro grips down and warps the sky around
his fist completely stopping his
calendar attack and turning his hand
into some spaghetti ass noodle which
like reminds me of Harry's hand after
the Quidditch game and Chamber of
Secrets anyways anyways while you just
stands there confused by his distorted
appendage Ro knocks him back with
another attack now out of combat yuna's
arm quickly returns to normal without
any damage leading Juda to assume aura's
curse technique manipulates space
without actually crushing anything
within it similar to how like a Lin's
crease Distortion that's just an idea
but I I wonder if she could also create
some sort of pocket Dimension or
Wormhole hear me out it does sound kind
of crazy but as she could grab two
specific points in space and distort
those points to make them touch
technically that's how we think a
wormhole might work over a 3D plane and
from that it opens up this series too
late the idea of time travel or a high
domain like the fourth dimension or
something anyways you know it sounds a
bit bizarre the reason I say this is
because uru discloses her ability right
now and reveals her curse technique
treats the sky as a surface for example
or can physically grab an open space
making it a tangible object which in
turn allows you to manipulate it as if
it was some sort of curtain both of her
previous attacks on Utah bypasses
defenses and scent of flying so he
figures that there must be some sort of
tractor ability if warped surfaces are
able to accomplish that and patiently
uru waits for her opponent to attack so
she can counter with her technique but
instead Judah asks her a question he
asks if a roe wouldn't complain if she
were to be killed and why exactly she's
seeking out conflict he understands that
powerless people get desperate but this
doesn't apply to uro because her curse
technique makes it such a formidable
opponent compared to the majority of
other sorcerers in the culling game uro
explains to him that she doesn't take
receiving her new body lightly as
essentially incarnated Sorcerers have
returned from the shadow realm she feels
like someone without regret wouldn't
have joined the culling game in the
first place so as the first step in her
new life she is prioritizing points and
that's why she's attacking still
confused probably even like more than us
reading right now because it made no
sense to me what she said there Judah
asks if uro has a lover or a companion
she's fighting for the reason he asks
this is because he simply can't
understand why someone would spend time
killing people thousands of years later
even if they have regrets listening to
you to blame it on though uru gets more
and more pissed off all culminating in
the point where Yuda asks her how she
could possibly be so desperate that
she'd only return for her own selfish
game I write and literally blowing blood
vessels on a dome Oru asks a future as a
descendant of the fujiwara clan claiming
that someone of his blood wouldn't ever
understand her which I don't think he is
he's a michizani's descendant so I don't
think that's fujiwara someone let me
know down in the comment section below
Ryu though remember they're like random
apparently op JoJo's character from
before well his ass interrupts the
conversation by using his insane Granite
blaster for a massive wave of cursed
energy from his head at both players
leaving the previously beautiful city
now just a pile of rubble having an
attack from a nearby rooftop Ryu claims
Yuta and uro's flirting is made making
him hungry for battle uru decides that
there's no reason to let Ryu go now now
that the colonies did look is broken use
it in uru simultaneously decide it's
time to take Ryu out they both Dash in
straight towards Ryu exciting the
long-range fighter who responds with a
volley of cursed energy beams their
weave after the approaching Fighters
Juda is narrowly able to avoid the
initial barrage using his agility but a
second wave of attacks appears to take
him off guard decimating him and the
bridge is standing on however once the
Smoke Clears Ryu who thought he landed a
direct hit notices that Yuda is gone
suddenly Judah leaps up from behind onto
the roof to confront Rio directly
forcing him to realize that you'd use
the whole Rica made in the bridge to
avoid the beams and get out of sights
having successfully closed the distance
between them Yuna attacks the ancient
sorcerer directly before darting back
into his fighting pose and declaring
that it's time to bring the fight into a
closer range amused by yuda's display of
skill Ryu asks if fighting up close will
satisfy his hunger elaborating on his
comment you asks if someone should tell
a child in front of her face to calm
down and eat slowly Yuda suggests that
someone should do that and Ryu actually
agrees admitting that it was probably a
bad example lighting up a city where you
says he didn't have any major regrets in
his first life where he fought worthy
opponents and had met a good woman even
so he still suffers from a thirst that
no one understands and because of that
he's still unsatisfied he says that
cigarettes have a sweet aftertaste but
his life has never had that kind of
dessert instantly Ryu unleashes a flurry
of attacks causing you to quickly
respond with punches of his own giving
them both a chance to feel for each
other's combat prowess Judah notes that
Ryu has an explosive cursed energy
output combined with very precise and
quick movements even without his
Advanced toughness a direct hurt from
Ryu would cause significant damage after
exchanging several blows and parrying
one another both Fighters turned to land
a spinning attack however Ryu clashes
his back against Utah and expels a blast
of cursed energy that sends the letter
flying back off the roof due to crashes
to the top of another building those
using his footing for a moment but
quickly manages to regain his balance
immediately where you heavy notices
stumble follows up with another Granite
blast attack sitting in a beam of energy
directly at user but somehow you're just
able to deflect it with his bare
freaking hands like some Harry Potter
spell without a wand level of holy
then Yuda in a damn flash quickly closes
the distance and tries to crush his
opponent where they Fierce right hook to
the Dome crushing Ryu into the roof and
cracking the concrete floor below him
however it actually seems that Ryu had
condom into a false sense of security as
he counters with another beam of cursed
energy that Utah is unable to fully
overpower as he blasts you to back where
you tells him that you are my dessert
Eros like just rolled up on the scene
take advantage of yuda's unfavorable
positioning in mid-air and targets him
with a curse technique let's explain
that technically she doesn't hit the
person with her technique but strikes
the surface of the sky and steered
having revealed the extent of your
Technique or it breaks the surface like
thin ice and smacks your opponent
straight down onto the brick road below
irritated by the end interference where
you shoot a wave of curse energy at uro
and tells her that she's in his way
telling him to silence himself though
Oru uses her technique to warp this
space around the cursed energy beam
firing it right back at him and heading
him directly injured Yoda then manages
to return to the battlefield which
amuses uro who claims it's great that
he's tough as she's going to toy with
him eljojo wannabe who's still
recovering from his own attack notices
that Yoda is constantly using his
reverse curse technique to heal himself
and using up all of his near bottomless
curse energy lit down by his opponent's
receding strength Ryu comes to the
conclusion that Yuda is not the dessert
he had been searching for to quench his
gluttonous thirst thinking on what to do
himself Yuda knows that Ryu doesn't
Target civilians but he wouldn't care if
they ended up as collateral damage in an
attack you knows that he wanted to put
more distance between fighting and the
stadium where the civilians are just in
case but that isn't likely to happen
anymore instead Judah decides to use his
full strength now he pulls out and puts
on his ring then calls upon raker and
asks her to give him everything Rick is
suddenly manifest as a curse Spirit
right next to him leaving both Ryu and
uro confused by the stone of events
we're always shocked Yoda wasn't already
using his full power and Ryu doesn't
understand how yuda's curse energy is
already filling back up for those of you
like confused think of Rika like a water
tank of cursed energy and when Yoda
decides to open that tap he can just
refill his deflated curse energy on top
of that break your tears open a chest to
display a freaking arsenal of cursed
tools kept inside her body for you to
choose from so Riker the curse is
technically different to Riker orimoto
and once the young child's spirit
peacefully passed away at the end of jjk
zero the cursed Spirit itself stayed
directly connected to you this ring and
while the connection is active Reika is
capable of storing cursed energy for you
to completing her full manifestation to
Aid him in battle and can even Supply
cursed talks for him though he can only
maintain the sustained connection for up
to like five minutes having chosen the
missile arm Rika attaches the casing
around yudu's right arm to improve his
overall striking power ready to
re-engage in the now three-way battle
Yuda Begins by having Rika saw through
the air towards Arrow who now prepares
to Sky manipulation technique and
response however Utah suddenly create
superlific snake eyes and Fang Sigil of
the enumahi clan on his mouth and
activates cursed speech commanding all
of his opponents to not move Oru tries
to cover her ears but she's just too
late and is immediately immobilized
which I wonder if that implies that the
inumaki clan had been around from the
time that URL was previously alive as
she reacted like she knew what the
ability was anyways unable to defend
herself or it was pummeled by a large
barrage of strikes from both Yuta and
reiker cylinder shooting off yusufin
drops down and launches himself off
wreck his arms like he's a goddamn
volleyball towards uro continuing to
pressure her Ryu tries to intervene in
their fight and launches a beam of curse
energy claiming that Yoda's approach is
too soft Ricky though cuts it off and
slices the attack in half with one hand
impressing Ryu who believes that Riku
might be even more durable than Yuta
himself irritated by the pain Ricky
angrily lashes out punching Ryu in the
face and sending him flying off the roof
he tries to follow up with another
strike but Ryu quickly counters with an
explosive punch of his own smashing Rika
back into the roof of an opposing
building excited with the potential to
satisfy his hunger Ryu fixes his hair
and claims he has an appetite that calls
for an extra large helping back with the
other two though you just summons a
bunch of small flying shikigami by using
strains of his hair as an intermediary
uru destroys one of them using a new
technique and claims that members of the
fujiwara are only standing away because
they fear her true potential going on
that typical anime level Spiel she
explains that she is the leader of the
sun moon and star squads Affiliated
directly with the tour of the fujiwara
clan there were assassins that pursued
lives or selfless devotion and these
shadows and didn't even be names a
particular Sorcerer of the fujiwara clan
though gave takako her name only to
execute her as a proxy to cover up his
own crimes of killing someone else and
the clan suddenly though always cut
offman's sentence and cut across her
chest and herps by the shikigami those
trajectories of the shikigami constitute
a domain which uro immediately
recognizes as Drew's technique remember
like that old man from the very
beginning of the fight she realizes that
Judah isn't a cursed speech user with
the ability to summon shikigami instead
he's a sorcerer with the ability to copy
others curse techniques Judah proceeds
to follow up and knocks uru down to
where Ryu and Enrique are fighting he
tries to capitalize with a straight
punch but uro manages to stop his attack
and break his armored shell with the
Icebreaker effect of your Technique
uninjured by this exchange though you
details uro that regardless of what his
ancestors may have done living for
herself will only get her so far yet
those words just hit a complete block
and only served to further annoy uro who
claimed that saying things like live for
others is something only those who have
achieved something can do the
conversation is interrupted though when
they both notice a massive surge in
reuse curse energy Ryu thinks his
opponents need to shut up because words
are utterly pointless at this stage of
the fights are you guys already as the
three of them suddenly look at each
other prepare to bring this three-way
battle to a climax the trio of sendo's
strongest sorceress all activate their
domain expansion simultaneously
instantly and like because of the three
overlapping domains they cancel each
other's short hit functions out without
that Advantage Ryu and uro know that
they need to stop yosa from taking the
initiative by keeping Reika out of the
barrier Ryu knows idioturi knocked Rika
over 20 meters away so it was unlikely
she would be able to reach the barrier
in time but outside it's shown that the
last vestiges of Rika or imoto's will
inside of Rika couldn't accept that she
was unable to protect Yuta causing her
strength to wretch it up another notch
suddenly kuroroshi yes remember that
damn cockroach from back at the
beginning of the video that just got
milked by user randomly appears and
infiltrates the freaking barrier while
it's cockroaches outside occupy recur so
remember how I said this dude was able
to self-reproduce and all that kind of
stuff well before going Dorman kuroroshi
actually reproduced used via his
parthenogenesis after Judah exercised
the parent roach the country's cursed
energy of fear was transferred into the
new Offspring kuroshi the player is
indeed perished but Karoshi the curse
spirit is still completely active three
overlapping domains are more complex
than two and the conditions imbued
within the barriers complicate things
even further with the addition of an
unexpected Intruder the barriers are
completely compromised and begin to
shatter falling to Pacers falling out
themselves Yuna notices that uro is
totally focused on kuroroshi obviously
this is due to her technique being at a
complete disadvantage with the roach
because of this Yuna takes the
opportunity and literally kicks uro in
the back while she's distracted sending
her flying towards the ground almost
like cementing her death seeing her
coming down the cursed roach rushes to
War 2 or the festering life sword uru
tries to respond by activating the curse
technique however as we all know from
the past events with mojito whose
techniques are difficult to use
immediately after using a domain
expansion and uru's ability to
manipulate space Burns away in her hands
leaving it open takura Roshi's assault
the roach curse slashes uro's left arm
and quickly these disgusting and
sick-like curses spawn funny wound
severing her limb completely Rika who's
also there acts quickly by devouring
uro's arm before the roach could
impressing Ryu he notes that Yuda is
thorough and that it's unlikely that uro
can regenerate her entire arm even if
she uses a reverse curse technique I
write over the loss of her arm or her
angrily calls out to The fujiwara
Descendant cutting her off though Ryu
tells her to stop because she and
kuroroshi uninvited to his table yes if
you have noticed everything to do with
Ryu ishigori has something to do with
eating food like the dessert thing from
earlier or now the whole like you ain't
invited to this table you can't eat from
this table type thing anyway anyway
let's explain that ryu's curse technique
is called cursed energy discharge and is
the only sorcerer capable of outputting
the same amount of power regardless of
if his technique is active or not
instantly he blasts Oro and Karoshi with
another jacked up Granite blast
incapacitating Euro and partially
destroying kuroroshi making it simple
for you to exercise with his reverse
curse energy excited for his dessert now
where you fixes his drip and welcomes
Yuta to the table he charges his cursed
energy and takes aim while opposite him
you don't know that his own curse
technique has yet to replenish but with
yusa and Reiki working together to
counter the ancient sorcerer as the next
move the table is set for the final
battle as in explained that Yoda can
only unleash a direct beam of cursed
energy while Rika is completely
manifested even at full power Judas
blasts are slightly weaker than reuse in
order to win The Exchange unit intends
on a rapidly building up cursed energy
and firing first before Ryu reaches
maximum power however ryu's Eyes Express
over 400 years of hunger waiting to be
satiated and his gaze pleads with Yuta
to use his full power although Utah
would never find true meaning and
conflict reuse gaze melted his heart not
in my damn heart as well look at those
eyes it's so damn beautiful anyways Yuda
agrees to go all out on this just once
and both Sorcerers unleash their curse
energy the blasts Collide and they curse
energy beam struggle that's extremely
reminiscent of an old-school DBZ Blast
Off sadly though Yuda is quickly
overpowered by ryu's blast the duo are
seemingly hit and sent back into a
nearby building which Ryu immediately
expresses How Sweet the first taste of
his dessert was the gleeful sorcerer is
quickly surprised though when he begins
to feel his opponent's cursed energy
swelling up wanting a male hit his eyes
he screams in us for another beam
struggle in retaliation reikifies a
blast of cursed energy while Utah
simultaneously rushes forward it's
showing that Yoda actually jumped
forward at the exact same time the blast
hurt launching him at high speed towards
the enemy sorcerer breaker is also able
to shoot completely on her own but Ryu
believes he's jacked enough and somehow
he blocks The Beam with his bare hands
as well claiming that he can do whatever
you to can hit takes aim at juta and
expects to finish him off for this next
attack due to the cursed energy he
extended on top of just using the domain
expansion however as his Granite blast
shoots out and unbeknownst to Ryu yuda's
curse technique had already replenished
he takes this moment and uses oru's
ability to warp space redirecting ryu's
blast up into the ear shocked where you
realizes hey Yuda can actually copy
people's curse techniques and tries to
symbolize what condition he must have
fill to do so he recalls Riker devouring
Euro's arm and figures that there must
have been when he satiated the condition
yuru notices were used like a focus
capitalizing on it and scores a direct
hit to ryu's chest with oro's thin
Icebreaker move quickly he follows up
with another combination downward punch
using Riker that hits so hard it causes
Ryu to begin bleeding profusely from his
head so remember how there was like a
time limit on rika's manifestation well
five minutes have now passed since you
to dawned his Reign causing the
connection between him and rake is
actually in Ryu takes advantage of this
by heading right here with his full
power an attack that was too much her to
handle even more fully manifested
because of this freaky quickly reaches
the limit and disappears from the battle
leaving Utah to continue fighting on his
own the big man himself Ryu is excited
that there's even more to their battle
even after clashing at full power he
happily declares that this final course
is the dessert he has been longing for
standing there you'd have surprises the
Ancient One by grabbing him with both
hands and pushing their weight down so
hard that it cracks the ground Beneath
Your Feet after effectively immobilizing
them both due to claims that the fight
is over confusing Ryu while shigori is
looking down at the cracked ground his
Granite Blast from earlier yes remember
that one Juda shot up into the sky using
uro's technique well it rains down to
rexley on Ryu and surprises the
unsuspecting sorcerer completely
toasting him still standing there though
like like an actual champion but still
defeated Ryu quickly realizes that he
was just hit by his own beam as Judah
redirected it back down using uro's
technique at the same time Rica had hit
him despite his defeat for us satisfied
with the high level of battle he
participated in and thanks you sir now
that his stomach is finally full not
gonna lie getting those the terminology
of this saying so damn well and we all
just ate as well as Ryu ishigori did
right here boys anyways anyways
following the end of the battle in the
Sendai Colony you're the first talks to
the defeated uro in order to retrieve
her points she tells you to this like
extremely ominous statement they
probably will 100 play a role later on
in the story she says that his strength
has a limit and she's seen a power
Beyond the Horizon of the strongest
Fighters and curses with their very own
eyes in that moment she imagines
sakuna's original form and claims that
such power takes the form of
overwhelming a Christian that disregards
anything else like a Calamity Yoda then
moves on to Ryu who tells him that he's
too soft and he won't receive praise for
his actions he'd replies to him though
that takako also told him something
similar that there was no value in
sparing an opponent's life having heard
this where he was surprised to learn
that uru survived and believes his blast
must have been weakened after using
domain expansion which like I brought up
earlier makes sense as most of the time
after using a domain someone's technique
will slightly falter in comparison to
before the domain was used anyways
anyways Ryu sits up and asks what uru
kept getting upset about during the
fight and asks if it was a lover's
quarrel you'd try splitting him off but
after persistine explains that anything
he could have said to her would have
just led to violence because he's
blessed Ryu doesn't really understand
what you'd mean by this but still
respects his words after a brief break
our man decides to get back on his
mission and asks Ryu to hand over all of
his points the ancient sorcerer is like
kind of initially confused by uh what he
means about this but cocaine explains
that a new rule was added a while back
that allows players to transfer points
to one another Ryu believes he
understands that's why users sped their
lives now but still asks if he would
have killed them without their rule Yuda
suggested it definitely was a
possibility and smiles while telling Ryu
to just be grateful to his new comrade
which you know could be uh interesting
with that little comment there for what
could happen in the future little use of
Ryu tag team like Duo anyway thanks to
the point transfers from uro and Ryu on
top of the points he already gained from
eliminating drift and kuroroshi Yuda now
has a total of 200 points putting him at
the halfway points and their plan to
bring down the killing game
so to start things off here we're
actually throwing away any idea of that
silly old culling game and going back to
before the Countrywide idle
Transfiguration where a young man with
blue hair and blue eyes named Charles
Bernard filled out as visitors
registration at shuacia's Publishing
House in Tokyo two of these staff
members noticed and discussed if he
brought a manga submission in also
commenting on how unusual it is for a
Gaijin to do so Charles later ends up
meeting a show Asia staff member to
review his manga submission while I'm
probably sitting on the desk Charles
expresses that he's always pondered what
makes a manga Creator they don't need
licenses and in child's opinion
experience doesn't necessarily validate
a creation either which you know does
make sense like you see armor for
example never had in manga before Attack
on Titan but anyways anyways the
employee looked over at Bernard's manga
while hardly listening to his words
wishing that he would just sit in the
chair he only commented on the
foreigners Japanese saying that it was
pretty good but Charles responded by
repeating the same sentiment bag
confusing a man hate to cut myself off
again but if you guys watch anyone who
like makes Japanese content and lives in
Japan as a Foreigner this is a pretty
common thing to hear to the point that
it's like almost an underhand insult by
the Japanese people to like Outsiders
living in Japan but anyway anyway the
employees stated that it's obviously the
case because he's Japanese and Charles
reveals that he was actually born and
raised in Japan although his parents are
French the employee apologized for
assuming and Charles dismissed it
because he believed it would be the
start of a long relationship between him
and the publishing Studio yet this dog
of shueisha employee is mostly
unimpressed by Charles's manga
submission and critiques the story The
genre the tone and most of all the
artwork he used one example of one panel
where a character's finger is bent too
much in One Direction the employee tries
to show Charles by pointing his own
finger in demonstration but Charles
immediately breaks it to match the
Marcus our hearts irritated Charles told
the man to watch movies or stare at
photos if he wanted realistic artwork he
believed a publishing house should
appreciate the passion that can't be
replicated in precise artwork Charles
finishes his tirade after assaulting the
employee and storms out of the building
deeming the experience is a waste of
time so yeah I don't know what that was
all about probably just a small warning
from gig8 any future Publishers about
his artwork skipping forward now to the
fateful day of November 12th we find
that somehow this pure manga reading
degenerate Charles is outside and on a
ferris wheel with akari Kenji inside of
the culling game he asks Takara if he
knows what makes someone a manga Creator
yet as we could probably imagine an
annoyed Hikari answers that he simply
doesn't care just lacking there and
chilling out Charles is thankful that
there is still electricity power in the
area but akari isn't and suggests that
he normally wouldn't ride a ferris wheel
with another man Charles points out that
he could have refused the ride but Curry
wants to scope out the area in case he
brings a girl back one day because you
know big brain thinking and all
pre-planning for future events as the
man knows that the killing game ain't
gonna murk him for sure but anyway
Charles is surprised to Carrie believes
Tokyo will recover from the culling game
claiming that he is the exact opposite
as someone who's only come to gaze upon
the end of it all ever since curses
flooded Tokyo there haven't been outlets
for manga and creators that Charles
respected are giving up Charles asked to
give him a reason to fight because the
heroes and battle Marcus are always
fighting for positive reasons while the
culling game only incites fights for
negative ones Charles asks akari to
provoke him enough to instill hatred
inside of him to the point where he
could take him out without any remorse
hearing this Hikari decides to oblige
and thoroughly insults child he says
that it would never reach Charles's
creepy manga because his gloomy
disposition might affect him then and
probably one of the best and tired damn
lines so far of the manga he also tells
Charles to stop whining and start
fighting creepy otaku insulted and with
tears in his eyes Charles asks what he
would say such a mean thing ready to
fight Hikari for his rude comments
Charles conjures the g-war stuff a
pin-shaped sphere immediately he
attacked bursting through their pod and
forcing the carry onto the ferris wheel
whereas the soul continues Charles
thrusts his spirit akari's head several
times while quoting a poem from a
Creator he admires Hikari simply avoids
his strikes and jumps off the Furious
wheel onto a building below causing the
Frenchman to chase after standing there
it is showing their special grade is a
little annoyed because Charles is
actually quoting a comment from katsura
hashino which akaro just doesn't
consider as a poem Charles expands upon
the poem by explaining that a mangaka
enters a fictitious space in their minds
where anything is possible because to
them reality just isn't satisfying he
continues by stating he believes his
reality has been overtaken by Jujutsu
and because of this he has lost his
motivation as both a margarita and a
Creator he asks Sakari what that feeling
is called and the suspended student just
simply replies that he's just getting
bored with this as his fighting Spirit
then begins Rising Charles suggests that
they fill in his God is called Despair
and steered fueled by his sorrow for his
opponent Charles strikes hard with his
g-war staff and scratches akari's cheek
open drawing a bit of blood at the pin's
tub noticing that the spear is a pin
akari asks him if it's okay for a
mangaka to use their drawing pin for
violence but Charles argues using a
reference from Captain Tsubasa following
this he activates the condition for his
curse technique and Mark zakari with a
glowing Square curiously confused Hikari
asks what's going on as he throws a
flying kick but Charles is able to avoid
it and immediately counter attacks with
an attack surprising the former easily
though Hikari maintains his balance as
he's knocked back several meters from
the blow although he personally didn't
take any damage his sleeve was cut wide
open while examining the tear Hikari
also analyzed the way the Frenchman
moved and decides that it has to be more
than just a simple reflex noticing the
special grade sorcerer took his hands
out of his pockets for the first time
Charles Thompson for it and then
explains that the glowing square is
actually a manga panel that lets the
user see their opponent's next move
currently the Frenchman can only see one
second in advance but as the pins tub
fills with Curry's blood the former will
be able to see further into the future
having heard this hikaradesh is straight
at Charles to confirm this ability as
effect and nearly lands a powerful right
Hawk with the letter admitting that it
would have taken him out if not for the
effect of the g-war staff quickly after
Charles counters with his attack and had
to carry across the head with the blunt
end of his spear affirming to Hikari
then the Frenchman can really see the
future however Hikari is unimpressed by
the students ability and just disappears
from Charles's line of sights before he
reappears and punches Charles in the
back stating that he needs to be able to
see him in order to see the future
through his technique to counter Hikari
attacks Charles repeatedly from his
blind spots without losing up in an
attempt to retaliate Charles tries to
stab akari in the back but the letter
has already anticipated that he would
try there and intercepts before striking
him again before Charles can turn around
and recover Hikari completely and
utterly blitzes him while stating that
he can't just go easy on him because he
knows Charles would just selfishly
attack someone else later continuing
Hikari believes that in order to stop
this he needs to utterly break Charles
and hits him with an extremely powerful
punch heading quickly goes to get behind
him but Charles is able to recover from
the previous punch in time and
reactively Strikes his blind spot
cutting the Curry's forehead I rate over
how the battle is going now Charles
claims that the vessel container in his
heart is broken and is spilling out in a
gush of emotion hears it now due to
gaining more ink in his pin he can see
two seconds into hikari's future and
will be waiting in his own blind spot
confused says the waihekari isn't
intimidated though Charles asks his
opponent why he's just standing there
posing while in the situation don't
actually think Charles has ever bumped
into anyone who can use the domain
expansion and due to this while Hikari
stands there he uses both his hands to
form the proper hand sign to cast his
domain expansion the idol death gamble
due to his domains guaranteed effect its
rules are instantly transmitted to
Charles's brain instantly the soon-to-be
mangaka begins to understand the rules
of akari's domain expansion it's shown
to us that the idle death gamble is
based on the Japanese Pachinko machine
inspired by the Shoujo series sea yard
private Pure Love Train during the
domain's active phase the user must hit
the jackpot by getting three of the same
symbol which will allow them to get a
bonus there's a flow of three different
levels of determines the percentage of
increased probability and also the
probability of the jackpot through a
visual effect which akari can choose
though ultimately this depends on the
so-called luck Hikari refers to also
certain Richie scenarios can be
activated at points throughout this
process and chance boosters allow for an
increase in the chance of a jackpot
having heard all of this child yells at
annoyed by the sudden info dump that was
thoroughly just implanted into his brain
as the first stage of akari's domain
begins quickly Kenji releases a green
and red vigil effect attack which
Charles Dodges out of the way causing it
to activate into a raichi scenario
changing the scene around them it's
explained to the confused Charles that
if the character Yuki passes through the
gate then akari immediately hits the
jackpot Charles attempts to swipe at it
but it's just a visualization so nothing
happens meaning all he can do is wait to
see the result which is you know like
kind of sucks it's almost just a
guaranteed jackpot whenever a right here
scenario pops up I wonder if like that's
a house rule type thing referring back
to how his domain is based on pachinka
machine but anyway anyway back over due
to the indicator being weak the Richie
scenario fails causing them to reset
back at the beginning of the domain's
expansion these sequence of events
leading up to either the reset of the
domain or a jackpot are considered one
of akari's full rules giving Charles a
very strict time limit to defeat
gambling sorcerer standing there Charles
thinks about how he can't use his manga
curse technique to predict the outcome
meaning that the process will repeat
continuously until he defeats him or
Kenji draws a winner which he knows
would result in a loss for him however
to kenji's surprise watch House's most
infuriated ad is the presentation taking
the Beloved private pure love trained
manga and turning it into something
bizarre for gambling he continues to try
and attack questioning how long he will
keep up with the jackpot rate being only
one in 239 however Hikari is still able
to easily Dodge each attack while
confidently stating that he's never gone
past 30 times this time Hikari activates
a Raichu scenario with an 80 success
rate leaving them too anxiously watching
as they continue to Juke it out he's
unable to focus on kenji's future
attacks as he tries to pay attention to
the reichi scenario calling on the Yume
character to get on the train and hopes
of preventing the jackpot sadly for him
though the train leaves and Hume
disappears allowing Charles to slice it
to carry side Charles explains while
confidently standing there that if it
was a game of skill rather than luck
Hikari might have won but as he turns
around he is utterly shocked to find you
may is still standing there saying that
she mustly train meaning that Hikari had
actually indeed won the jackpot quickly
Hikari darts in and kicks Charles away
declaring that he uses skill to grab a
hold of luck elsewhere in Tokyo number
two Colony Panda sits alone atop a
shipping container in a shipyard upon
smelling the air he notes that roughly
three people have been dismembered
nearby he can also hardly sense the
perpetrator's presence which might
suggest that they can freely activate
their curse energy Panda reviews the
plan that he and everyone had agreed on
beforehand they'd planned to leave the
fighting just to Hikari but the barrier
just like over in Tokyo Colony 1 with
Yuji and Megami split them up upon entry
to one of those random spawn locations
after a bit more thinking Panda decides
to take off and rolls his cute behind
off the shipping container to go in
search of Hana once he landed he he
looks both ways and size a breath of
relief however at that exact moment
Hajime kashimo walks right around the
corner in a split-second reaction Panda
plays a real-life Panda and initially
this does work however Hajime has an
omega-sized brain and summons his Gogan
to a side to ask if that Panda was
actually a player with the letter pretty
much instantly confirming nerds
witnessing this happened in front of his
teddy bear eyes Panda was surprised to
learn that they have that function yet
before Panda really had any time to
react the ancient god-level sorcerer
Hajime had quickly charged at him and
delivered a powerful blow to his torso
completely erupting a large portion of
the stuffing holding him together before
following up this brutal attack and
completely electrifying him then not
done Hajime while insulting his strength
hits him with his staff and knocks Panda
back into a container having been
brutally beaten Panda notes that
hajime's cursed energy is similar to
megami's new way where both have
electrified cursed energy surging
through their bodies with his Panda form
destroyed the Puppeteer begins
transforming into his gorilla mode and
Strikes Hajime with the prolific
unblockable drumming beat noticing a
change Hajime takes a defensive start
and endures the multitude of blows he
says that the attack wasn't too bad but
it wasn't great either and follows up by
using his staff to tear off the Panda's
right arm then continuing with his old
school brutality he throws Panda's own
arm straight back into his face
completely blind in the defenseless
spear allowing the sneaky sorcerer to
approach him for the puppet's right
dartinan he delivers a flurry of
absolutely brutal hurts directly aimed
at the Panda's face sending him shooting
back into another container as the
broken sorcerer strolls up on the Beast
and Panda he calls him pathetic and weak
before asking if he knows the current
whereabouts of sukuna taken by surprise
Panda doesn't know why he's interested
in him but quickly comes to the
realization that he wouldn't be a good
matchup with Yuji so while trying to
think up an excuse he says he doesn't
know noticing the massive amount of
stalling before answering his question
though Hajime realizes that he's indeed
lying and demands that he spit it out as
he'll show Mercy if he does having
thought up an excuse now Panda says that
his uncle goes by the same name so
hearing it took him off guard initially
Hajime who easily figures out that he's
still lying doesn't appreciate being
looked down on by the cursed puppet and
tells him to stop playing with him
annoyed now Panda retorts by saying he's
the one being looked down on and tells
him to be aware of his sister as anyone
who meets her eyes she tries to kill at
a pure embarrassment all of a sudden a
massive horn is seen from Panda's nose
as his body begins to transform and this
head Morse into a giant Triceratops
skull however in that exact moment
Hajime charges up his own attack and a
lightning bolt appears between them as
soon explained that kashimo separates
the curse Energy's charges like
electricity when he strikes an opponent
so like all of the hits of these Lanes
on Panda earlier it transfers a positive
charge into the target then when the
negative charge that lays inside of
kishimo as discharge and launches
directly at the Target without shooting
off any other surface this results in
lightning that like literally cannot
mess as it will travel directly to its
opponent pretty much taking away any
need for Kashima to actually use the
domain as this is kinda a short head
technique in itself sadly for panda as
the transformation is still happening
that said lightning bolt strikes and
absolutely decimates Panda mortally
wounding him standing above the now
fallen puppet Hajime once again asks
Panda about sukuna's whereabouts ah boys
here here's the saddest part here's the
saddest Panda chipper so far as we flow
into a flashback we see a young Panda
being beaten up by his big brother
gorilla the young Teddy screams for a
sister's Aid and an angry Triceratops
marches over demanding that gorilla sees
the bullying yet the young gorilla tries
to say that they were just fighting like
a dude from a game here and there
Triceratops says that Panda should get
the next turn to fight back with gorilla
being completely fine with it listening
to his older siblings Panda looking like
hella cute man rolls up to smack his bro
if you few times however he quickly is
punched in the face by the letter making
him cry even more completely blown away
with what she just witnessed Triceratops
then runs off in Pursuit while Panda
continues crying out behind them later
on panda is seen holding a Santa Claus
ball while trying to follow his older
brother and his puppet friends not
wanting him to follow because they find
the lake training wheels absolutely lame
the fox Whispers something and he
raccoons ear and he tells Panda that he
can actually join under the conditions
that he throws his ball into the river
initially Panda hesitates claiming that
it was a gift from Santa but after the
two pressured him and seen his older
brother's grumpy steer Panda tosses the
ball into the river Blown Away with him
actually doing it the raccoon and the
fox tell him they're throwing stuff into
the river is illegal as it would harm
the environment before they ran off
aiming to tell the police which is like
who is Gorilla hanging out with these
are the worst puppets I've ever met
gorilla really asks a sad and Panda way
through his ball into the river telling
him that it was a precious gift from
Santa breaking down in tears even more
Panda screams at him that he just wanted
to play with his big brother at night
before bedtime Triceratops berates
gorilla for bullying Panda instead
telling him that when other kids peck on
him he has to be the one to stand up for
him gorilla counters this by stating
that she plays with the other girls and
wouldn't understand because of this he
says that he can never have fun with
panda around as he holds him back and
only ever seems to start crying when she
shows up gorilla thinks that she's far
too caution him but Triceratops views
this differently she knows that no
matter how main gorilla is to him Panda
strikes off all the bad things and
cheers up by the time it's time to eat
he literally doesn't have a bad bone in
his body and believes that that's how
Brothers should always be she belittles
Gorilla by saying then maybe he's the
spoiled one as Panda always ends up
forgiving him for his transgressions
suddenly interrupting the two of him
pending storms into the room with a
beetle and shows it to gorilla who
immediately points out that it's
actually a dorkus Titania stag beetle
and screams while throwing it out of the
window in horror before going to beard
gorilla and his sister to open the piggy
bank to see if they have enough change
to buy a replacement ball for panda as
he then begins trying to sleep he just
thinks that an idiot like Panda would be
fine with any ball suddenly though in
the middle of the night a voice tells
him to wake up coming out of a daze he
notices they're both he and Triceratops
are being led by a strange ghost man
who's obviously like some puppet version
of masamichi for real but anyway he
quickly recognizes this figure as their
father and asks where they're going and
for how long to which their father
answers that there's no reason and that
it's permanent at that moment a
terrified Panda bursts out of the house
desperately searching for his big bro
and big cerseus gorilla screams back for
panda and tells his father to stop
however the ghostly man just tells him
that that's enough gorilla Cuts in by
saying that Panda can't survive without
him since he's literally terrible at
everything he does and we get left
behind because he's completely helpless
by himself not understanding what's
actually going on though the father
tells him that they're the ones being
left behind and not Panda so be a good
big brother and say okay goodbye I
confused gorilla gets defensive
wondering but how in the world he was
going to buy a ball for him tomorrow and
that he needed him there to talk to
these shopkeepers instead of their
sister but sadly after his second
thought he finally catches on and fully
begins to break down in tears not
wanting to leave this world and his
little brother sighed back in the real
world now Hajime kashimo stands over the
bloodied mist of pandas obliterated
corpse while prodding the beer he knows
that he didn't gain any points from him
before realizing that he probably hasn't
found the core of the panda years he
picks up Panda's head with his staff and
asks once again about the whereabouts of
sukuna but Panda simply replies like the
true friend and Legend he is that pandas
are very tight-lipped taking this as an
insult Hajime threatens to fully destroy
the rest of panda yet just as he raises
blood loss to do so the legend himself
with his cursed energy already fully
flared up and with the anger of the
entire Jiu Jitsu tick on his back drops
in completely destroying a shipping
container in the process instantly he
screams at his boy asking if Panda has
lost some weight seeing his classmate
arrive panda is happy and shouts at
akari's name while an initially confused
Hajime begins to get riled up
supercharged with an incredible volume
of cursed energy akari rushes in to
rescue Panda from kashimo he delivers a
right Hawk so powerful that it disarms
kashimo and sends the sorcerer crashing
through several Freight containers oh
like this battle was going to be so
insane boys and and girls of course
anyways instantly Hikari follows up not
giving kashimo any time to recover
having closed the distance the special
grade does a sick two-footed jump
throwing himself into the air and
delivering a flying drop kick to his
opponent's face the hejima just narrowly
avoids while still in media though akari
swings his leg straight back in an
attempt to land ahead with his opponent
just barely having his nose grazed
essajime stands there in shock hikari's
physical power is so overwhelming that
his kicks excess cursed energy dense
another shipping container and
completely deforms it sending opposite
her Gmail Hikari is a little certified
by the curse energy protecting his
opponent but also barely feels the bad
side effects from it Kashima was
impressed that his opponent can ignore
the electrification and asks his name
Hikari introduces himself while kashimo
is just completely fascinated by the
insane curse energy output and
mysterious music surrounding his
opponent moving into his fighting stance
kashimo also introduces himself and as
zakari hears his name he realizes that
he is the player with 100 points knowing
that he needs them he cheekily asks if
he can use those points of his
Victorious with kashimo green and asking
to know more about sukuna if he's the
Victor feeling it coming in akari is
suddenly and orgasmically distracted as
a large influx of cursed energy received
as a bonus from hitting his domain's
jackpot envelops him noticing that
something's up kishimo uses the
opportunity to barrage his opponent with
several hits but quickly becomes
displeased as akari isn't resisting at
all as he begins to tell Hikari to not
disappoint him the special grade
sorcerer switches things up a little and
rattles the ancient sorcerer with an
Abrupt right hop to the sure that since
kashimo absolutely flying after posing
literally playing the ear guitar to go
along with his own damn theme song
Hikari instantaneously disappears from
his spot he was in to follow up with a
flying knee to hajime's gut prompting
him to admit that his opponent isn't bad
at all Landing back on his fate Hajime
regains his balance grabs onto the lake
a carrying Nathan with encounter attacks
with a spinning elbow straight to the
chin of the sorcerer overcoming it
though Hikari will stands the attack and
forces kashimo to release his grip by
jumping down and completely smashing the
ground beneath their feet with a
straight punch jumping back out of a
Curry's range Kashima who's charged back
up discharges the same lightning attack
that defeated Panda being able to see
the approaching lightning akari is able
to avoid the Direct Hit to his head but
sadly his arms blown off by the attack
glad and confident that his opponent
won't be able to recover in time after
being hurt hashimo rushes in to finish
him off however the carriers on his Dawn
level of strength and literally does not
care about his arm at all instead he
surprisingly counters where they kick
straight to hajime's face and follows up
with a punch from the same that was
supposedly just seated blown away by
seeing hikari's arm reappear hashimo
just manages to block the attack and
assumes akari used the reverse curse
technique to quickly heal himself it's
then explained that when akara hit the
jackpot with his domain expansion it
resulted in a bonus of unlimited curse
energy throughout the round Hikari
himself never actually learned to use
reverse curse technique but the
unlimited curse energy coursing
throughout his body as a result of
hitting the jackpot automatically heals
his body with Earth in other words Curry
is pretty much damn Immortal for 4
minutes and 11 seconds after hitting the
jackpot this time limit comes to an end
as the ancient sorcerer notices the
random music surrounding Hikari has
stopped causing his opponent's cursed
energy to recede to normal however
during the previous round and due to
hawakari's curse technique Works after
he hits the jackpot his curse energy and
technique is replenished allowing him to
cast another domain immediately so for
as long as akari continues to hit his
jackpot he can use his domain over and
over and over again so this is the main
reason why Harry is absolutely broken
and Gojo reasons that he could surpass
him someday man literally has figured
out an infinite cursed energy hack like
this is some game of magic or something
like oh my Lord but anyway anyway
because of the fact that big rari's
domain expansion is harmless he can be
as aggressive as he wants and his
activation is extremely Quirk probably
one of the quickest in the entire
universe like it states here that the
dude's activation is faster than that of
Mojito's John oh yeah as the roles of
the idle death game are sent to hejima's
mind he knows that since he's aware the
game is a probability loot type it means
he's likely to keep hitting the jackpot
as he activates increased probability
standing there akari asks him how he is
but Jimmy points out that during this
period he's not actually unkillable and
akari simply responds that the life of
gambling has always come with great
risks flashing in the two monstrous
Sorcerers traded flurry of brutal
punches before Kenji spins away and
activates his continuation effect
absolutely confusing her Gmail with
what's going on Asin explained that
currently Hikari is redoing one
consecutive effect sequence the normal
percentage chance of hitting the jackpot
is over 20 or one in five on its first
activation and because of that there is
usually a high risk of drawing a dud so
typically he only uses this activation
when he has increased probability
igniting the fight once more Hikari
throws another punch but Hajime blocks
it and completely bet as the bulked up
high schooler punching him in the side
of the head and kneeing him in his
stomach jumping back though Curry flexes
while screaming renewal leading the
potty emergency reichy scenario to occur
during this Raichu scenario if the dingy
wannabe who stuck on a hypothetical
train headed to yoyogi doesn't have a
bathroom or more specifically as it
implies here doesn't have any accident
at all will result in a jackpot reichy
scenario for Hikari as the train flies
forward it's shown that this fake
chainsaw man named hero just barely made
it to a stop of our accident causing
akari to once again hit his jackpot
standing there with his eyes closed and
just looking like the absolute King he
is hakari suddenly reopens his eyes and
screams for his music to begin once more
sometimes you know like I I rarely just
personally wish I could make sound
effects like with my mouth and
everything just like boom as a curry
finishes speaking his body once again
erupts with a flood of curse energy
restarting his invincibility and the
brutal Showdown time to like to really
kick things up a notch here boys so
subscribe to please save my throat from
the throat code and push this video to
like 5 or 10K likes just so I know that
you want a full like four hour jjk video
Drop because you know I'll compile all
these parts together and re-edit the
Gojo past Arc and you know I'll do that
or I'll do that or I'll tell you I will
don't make me anyway moving forward
standing opposite him hey Jimmy notes
how this is the same form that will last
for 4 minutes and 11 seconds meaning
that he currently has no restrictions on
cursed energy and can automatically
activate a reverse curse technique
however he also notes that this time the
jackpot was not an even number meaning
that if he activates his domain
expansion right after this his increased
probability will have actually ended so
we won't get another jackpot again as
quickly after he states to himself
though that if he can make it through
the next four minutes and 11 seconds he
will win but as his smile grows larger
he recognizes that that line of thinking
is how losers think instead he screams
that it's time to turn up the volume
because this is a funeral for the living
He releases a massive burst of cursed
energy declaring that even though he may
be unkillable for the next 4 minutes and
11 seconds he will still kill him anyway
oh but before we go any further we skip
back in time to a moment 400 years ago
where her Gmail was approached by
kanjaku asking if he had fun with his
battle honestly any thoughts on who's in
the brain swapping fiend's body right
here I like wouldn't be surprised if it
was Naruto she Cameo to be honest but
who knows let me know what you think
down below anyways anyways after
replying that he didn't have fun at all
wanting to fight him instead kinjaku
asks him to spare him and say that he is
not fit for fighting currently but
reveals he heard something in michinoku
about the greatest cursed energy output
ever coughing up blood though Hajime
asks kinjaku who's the strongest source
for a he knows when through later
replying that it's a Kona before Apollo
apologizing that it was from 600 years
ago and saying that it would never
change his mind on that fact realizing
that he will never get to fulfill his
own wishes Hajime responds that if
that's the case he will entertain what
can jaku has to say so that he can fight
sakuna himself
back in the battle they fight between
kashimo and Hikari intensifies as they
both Chase each other at high speeds
around the port sajimay starts to get
away akari launches another Fat punch
that connects with a shipping container
sending it straight towards the ancient
sorcerer seeing it coming In Time Hajime
responds with his own brutal punch
filling in the container straight back
at the approaching student with him both
being on opposite sides of the container
they both exchanged a multitude of blows
on each side of the metal box completely
deforming and destroying it however
essakari breaks through ready to throw a
massive punch kishimo Dodges by jumping
off the ground before he manages to blow
half of a Curry's freaking face off with
his shipping container door exposing his
face muscles and jaw with he fights line
for a moment hajima deduces that cursed
energy comes from the guard but he has
to use his head to direct the flow of
reverse curse technique so no matter how
powerful his reverse curse technique is
it certainly can't be strong enough to
regenerate his head therefore Kashima
plans to use his lightning to Target his
head and complexly split it open
following this GMA sends his lightning
directly at akari connecting with his
head yet I am here to tell you that this
is just not a normal human this is
Hikari kinji and man just simply blows
out all of the energy from the attack
straight out of his damn nose as it
destroys his face literally allowing him
to regenerate as he breaks realizing
that he almost died there Hikari being
as cool as ever just lasted off and with
only eight seconds remaining on his
jackpot shoots in deciding to use even
more brute force in his punches now
after taking up a thorough of punches to
the face chin and body Hajime darts back
realizing that akari is getting even
faster as the Fight Continues getting
straight back to his face though and
with only a few seconds remaining akari
who's completely unkillable decides to
cut loose and totally beat down on his
opponent elbowing him hard in his guards
yet surprisingly this turns out to be
exactly what Kashima would actually
wants heard and as he smiles he
retrieves a massive streak of electrical
feedback using his staff piston to the
ground at some distance the streak of
instantaneous lightning passes through
the left side of the Curry's tour also
on its way to Hajime before completely
and utterly blowing into pieces mortally
wounding the student just then the theme
song ends Mark in the end of akari's
unkillable period with Hajime then
stating that it's finally over however
to the public surprise of the ancient
sorcerer Hikari is not done yet instead
moving his hands into placement and
opening his domain once more sadly it's
showing though that Hikari is just
making a desperate attempt at casting
his domain after activating his domain
Hikari keeps trying to spin faster even
if the probability is only 1 in 239
immediately Hajime catches on though as
the rules are implanted in his brain and
once again Hikari somehow let the dude
is a completely not a demon gains an
unexpected jackpot due to some kind of
increased probability allowing him to
roll an even number therefore he is
again unkillable for the next 4 minutes
and 11 seconds breathing a sigh of
relief Hikari states that his impressed
with kashimo as he's never faced death
this much in one day but now thanks to
some manga otaku he's got a big manga
brain and asks tajime if he also likes
manga with the letter stating that he
doesn't get any battle underway akari
flips things up a notch figuratively and
literally as he changes his domain's
polarities making down up and also
Shifting the coordinates of his barrier
Over the Sea as a Gmail falls back
towards the sea below him he states that
because his cursed energy is like
electricity it won't stop discharging
until it's fully deplete heard here's
one of two options in the coming water
tussle either he can release his cursed
energy until it's all gone or shuttered
off until he's able to return to land
this obviously goes back to like what
Panda said about someone having that
amazing control over their curse energy
at the beginning of this battle but
anyway anyway however to avoid falling
into the water kishimo stands on the
curse spirits that burst out of the
ocean in an attempt to devour him on the
other hand Hikari who's got his manga
brain fully rolling absolutely pummels a
massive curse Spirit as it bursts out of
the ocean before shooting across at high
speeds toward tajime and see in him
flying into the ocean below with a fat
Kirk then floating above him on some
like fat flying fish look and ask her
spirit he watches it's a Gmail slowly
begins to burn away all of his cursed
energy and the water however Kashima is
actually smarter than this he recalls
that there are two ways to any reverse
cursed energy user one by simply blowing
up their brains or two by using toxins
therefore he uses his electricity on the
sea water to produce a chlorine gas that
completely takes akari by surprise as he
floats above sadly Hikari loses his grip
on the curse monster and ends up falling
into the sea due to the Toxic effect of
chlorine gas as explained that unlike
simple body regeneration addressing a
toxin and one's blood requires insane
skill as well as a higher level of
reverse curse techniques sinking down
through the ocean Jimmy notes that
Hikari doesn't seem to be able to
detoxify fast enough causing the round
to end and allowing hikari's immortality
Shield to fade sngma States this has
been fun preparing to finish him off
akari just like before dispels the
excess cursed energy right out of his
freaking nose and throws a vicious punch
straight into the face of a Gmail taking
him completely by surprise with the two
floating back from each other after the
attack it turns out that the legend of
Jujutsu Tech targeted the toxins in his
body and removed him unconsciously by
his automatic reverse curse energy with
only five seconds left in his jackpot
Hikari realizes casting his domain again
after this one ends will be dangerous
due to the effects of electricity
coursing through the water and the
steadily increasing temperature of the
ocean he Ponders going up to the surface
but it's like nah stuff that dude I
might instead just beat the absolute
hell out of the stood here and proceeds
to throw fairly talk to his opponent's
face kishime though battered and bruised
but still excited to continue drives
forth and grabs a hold of akari's arm
before releasing a massive blast of
electrified cursed energy in an attempt
to destroy hikari's entire arm and
prevent him from being able to cast his
domain again back above the ocean's
surface as all the water rains down we
find a cute baby panda who's changed his
form wandering around as he then comes
cross a car receiving hand as a
previously Lively battle now comes to a
seemingly abrupt end we'll see kashimo
pop out of this sea completely out of
curse energy however right as he is
about to consider himself the winner
Hikari emerges from the sea himself with
one arm and punches him back to reality
it's explained that during the previous
attack a Gmail released before the
electricity could travel all the way
through the water it resulted in a
massive thermal explosion of hot steam
laying down on the ground completely
exhausted Hajime asks how he isn't
ripped apart from this explosion but
akari explains that he knew what his
opponent was up to and purposely
sacrificed his left arm through a
binding vowel so that the curse energy
that usually protected her protected the
wrist of his body hearing this kishimo
finally tells his enemy to end his life
however akari offers him a deal instead
as he personally doesn't see this as a
win akari also brings up how kashimo
technically didn't use his technique to
which the Ancient One actually explains
that he is saving his cursed technique
to use on sakona as it is a single-use
one and okushima wants as a fight for
sakona therefore the ancient sorcerer
agrees to side with akari in exchange
for a future duel with the king of
curses rolling onto the scene and seeing
the two hanging out panda is quite
shocked after hearing that Hajime is now
on the side because he wants to have a
future belt with sakuna Hikari discards
Panda's concerns by casually asserting
that a kohai has to obey his senpai's
wish before randomly leaving the small
panda with the ancient sorcerer to go in
search of someone else this is also
where the announcement of a new rule
being added to the game is made the rule
is that players can also give as many
points as they want to another player
allowing Hajime to send his points over
when like needed obviously it's actually
crazy when you think about it how like
all of these battles are happening
simultaneously like I love how Giga
hasn't given us a timeline per se to go
off but it's more or less just this one
kind of rule that we can refer back to
knowing that all of the fights have been
like in relation with her but anyway
anyway continuing shooting back over to
the Furious wheel we find that Charles
has been chilling out after his defeat
after seeing Hikari rolling up he
confusingly asks what happened to his
his arm with the students stating that
he'll fix it later the two mates think
Becca about their fight hilariously like
akari is actually abusing the dude an
attempt to get the name of his monk out
of him because he'll Buy and read it
what she you know is very nice of him
big plot Twisted I'm gonna Chuck in here
myself that man uh no operator were
talking about for a sick what if Giga is
actually um French himself and this is
like a self-insert of him in the actual
story it'd be kind of funny to like go
back to after the story if Kiki ever
reveals himself and find out that this
was just like himself inserting you know
I'd love to know what you guys think on
that down in the comment section below
but anyway anyway continuing on big Momo
then cruises on and interrupting their
banter and asking if he managed to get
all their points necessary with akari
confirming that he indeed did so uh
quickly before the uh video ends I guess
I better go over their plan so their
plan is obviously to implement four new
rules the first was to make points
transferable to new players which was
done the second is to allow the use of a
hundred points to create a substitute
player so individuals can actually leave
the game third is to remove
communication blocks on these zones and
then finally the fourth is to allow
people in and out of all of the barriers
without consequence ashimaya states that
she wants to forget rule three for now
in place of going to get four first the
reason they like are doing this
obviously is because Marquee can
actually pass through barriers leaving a
carry shocked at this news that you can
thrill you into them he asks how it's
possible with Momo stating that it's
because she has turned into a complete
monster
we found the monster herself Marky and
the sakurajima colony well after
dispatching the tougher's curse spurts
and players she runs into Naruto shikemo
who's undergone like a clean ass looking
transformation man literally had to
switch up his entire look after
realizing he's named after the worst
sorcerer in their family's history but
anyways anyways they both acknowledge
the change in each other's lock with
narutoshi confessing that he's lost his
possession as they came a family's ear
and is fallen from Grace while Marky has
become formidable Naruto he asks Maki to
meet with you you once he leaves the
colony as you know like remember because
of her race and transformation he can
freely travel between colonies but
suddenly their planes are interrupted by
the sudden appearance of a formidable
cursed Spirit as it enters shooting him
through the barrier it disregards
kogane's request to become a new player
telling her to shut up anyway skipping
away from like the action as per usual
and going into a moment it had been a
few days prior we find a hurry Naruto
shikamo running through the house
searching for people until he comes face
to face with a Sino Shino by the way
like has anyone noticed the dramatic
change in gene akatami's art style from
like the beginning of the series till
now I feel like the culling game
especially has changed into this like
darker Arc where his art especially is a
lot more scratchy and like has this more
of a horror style feel to it but anyways
anyways continuing on they say no old
dog asks how kamo got in claiming that
ever since the guard was taken over it's
been completely useless narutoshi tells
the old fart though that it doesn't have
any time for jokes but Shino eerily asks
him and he's forgotten who's actually
the next head of the family as you then
continue spouting more bizarre nonsense
a worried narutoshi presses on and
enters the house inside he is greeted by
the body swapping creep himself kinjaku
who's literally just chilling out and
relaxing as he was waiting for narutoshi
to arrive kinjaku greets narutoshi with
a smile and offers to filament on his
plans he explains how he used Jujutsu
terrorism the ceiling of Saturday Gojo
and the killing game to eliminate all
the uncorrupted members of the Jiu Jutsu
Society he knew that because ganji is
considered trustworthy and had influence
whether he said higher up narutoshi
would have wanted to play with him in an
attempt to track those notices from the
headquarters you know like talking about
the notices that was handed out earlier
like the ceiling of Saturday Gojo and
the killing of Yuji isidori anyway
anyway so he took care of everyone who
wasn't on his side like Gojo gaguganji
masamichi and others like that we
probably never even met to start with by
the way the actual text that goes over
this is like much more confusing where
they explain pretty much how kinjaku
managed to take over like the
conservative faction of the Jitsu World
anyways sitting there konjaku's lived
impressed as Naruto she's only a mere
student they can already see the bigger
picture and acts how he needs two I
silly let down himself narutoshi asks
kinjaku if he's already removed the
people responsible for initiating
sukurukito's execution to which is
confirmed along with a person who named
Yuta as yuji's executioner chuckling and
narutoshi's efforts to approach
kakuganji and fix everything kinshaku
confidently exclaims that the kaimo clan
was the conservative seat but now it's
all utterly belongs to him along with
the title of the 25th kamo family head
feeling challenged narutoshi Sparks up
in in preparation to battle but kinjaku
quickly waves to dismiss him like man
literally laughs at him as like nah bro
just just chill out for one sec confused
narutoshi asks what the hell he's on but
kanjaku just tells him that it's fine
because even if he is alive nothing is
going to change plus he doesn't want to
mess up the new house he tells him
instead to get lost allowing narutoshi
to eventually make his way to where we
find him at the very beginning of this
Arc beckinsucker regime narutoshi and
Maki are left on high alert as they both
spot a supposed curse Spirit chilling
above him in the sky looking at it Marky
just has this weird and uncanny feeling
instantly approaching him at lightning
speed the curse Spirit Rampages towards
Maki tearing up in utterly obliterating
everything in its path it connects with
a blocking Markie to the new crashing
back and allowing the disgusting
amalgamation of a curseberg to Pinner
against a cliff not having seen this
happen narutoshi watches as Maki
struggles to break free she attempts to
hit it but the cursor at speed is too
much food to handle as it Dodges out of
the way of the attack and sends his
shooting into a nearby Cliff face
completely deforming nerds despite being
in a disadvantage Mikey refuses to give
up since he's something weird about this
cursed spirit with determination in her
eyes she quickly Dodges out of the way
of the monsters thundering right Hawk
however the curse manages to flick its
snakey behind around destroying a few
trees in its wake and trapping the
sorcerer up against the cliff emerging
from the head of the curse Spirit no one
other than the misogynistic goon himself
Nao yazinen now reincarnated as a
terrifyingly strong cursed Spirit
reveals himself pinned up against the
wall and unable to move Marky has just
left stunned asking if it's actually him
or the older cousin replying that he's
finally arrived at the other side of
course like if any of you are confused
on how this man managed to like actually
come back Maki thought she took her
brother out with her fists yet it's like
we all know and she isn't privy to Noah
was actually murked by marky's mother
wheeled in a plain steak Knife so he
also wasn't killed by jiu Jutsu with her
and it resulted in him coming back as a
special great curse Spirit but like I
don't even know why I write these
scripts without reading the next chapter
sometimes like literally right as we
jump out of the battle and so we flash
back that takes place this time between
Naruto and where they talk about
itadori's recent death sitting there
gakuganji asks what to keep in mind
while killing a sorcerer to which kaimo
like I just mentioned responds they must
be eliminated using Jujutsu the story
then shoots back over to sakurajima when
Alia still his Maki penned up against
the wall his face continuing to push
even further out of the cursor's shell
quickly Maki comes to the realization
that because she doesn't have curse
energy she failed to finish naoya off in
their previous fight however now you
denies it telling Mahi that she simply
doesn't understand and instead claims
that it was her mother who finished him
off while Marquis left shocked with this
news nayoya takes full advantage of this
situation and declares that he's
returned to completely end her luckily
for our Queen though ignorotoshi blasts
of a shot from his curse tool allowing
Maki to escape the grass with the cursed
spirit that in a way she thanks him but
also asks if he only used intuition to
aim as obviously you know he can't sense
her nearby in the woods narutoshi who's
getting ready for another shot is easily
able to deduce nao's location through
the cursive prisons however he notices
to do see marky's location as a bit more
difficult which is obviously because the
only energy actually coming off her is
that Jiu Jitsu emanating from the sword
that she wields and I'm like pretty sure
that that doesn't actually happen in the
first place that's just hit Canada mine
right there anyway anyway continuing
finally shooting offers three arrows
technique narutoshi is able to expertly
navigate all his arrows around the trees
and other obstacles on their way towards
the curse now yeah spotting the arrows
bursting through the trees behind him
because Spirit Moxy arrows and their
pathetic Spade taking him once up by
surprise though Maki grabs a hold of him
then using the momentum from his massive
size since I'm flying directly into the
path of the arrows which penetrate
deeply into his body as nayo screams in
pain Maki immediately pulls up and
slices him in half with a cursed hole
from a distance narutoshi watches as
Maki Falls onto the buildings below her
while wandering to himself as she
actually managed to exercise naoya to
this shock though our high school of Duo
are left helpless only able to watch is
nowhere's Curse Spirit explodes before
collapsing in on itself like some kind
of curse in dark hole seeing this in the
sky above her Maki immediately begins to
recognize what's actually happening as
it fully begins to form into a ball of
energy she screams out to narutoshi
telling him to shoot at it as she knows
it's a cursed swim that's currently
evolving to prevent disaster and just
looking like hella clean by the way as
well like I'm loving the new drop on
narutoshi he immediately throws up and
destroys a blood bag then uses his curse
technique piercing blood to stop nailya
from completing his transformation The
Beam of blood pierces directly through
Neo's cursed womb causing a massive
flood of blood to begin pouring out the
other side thinking that he could have
possibly exercised the cursed worm
Naruto should watches as the burning
ball begins falling to the ground below
yet as he begins to ponder how insanely
fast it could have been if it survived
it's revealed that area did indeed Dodge
the attack and has evolved into a much
more terrifying form Maki screams from
to dodge but before neoria even his time
to react he's hurt with a devastating
blow that's in some rocketing back
through the forest around them turning
around and calling narutoshi out of
trash we see the grotesque in harrowing
sight of neoya's full train to
information into a foul repulsive curse
Spirit noticing that he managed to
defend himself from the attack nayoyo
state that narutoshi is indeed a clan
head after all as kamo sits there
recovering from the blow as explained
that if he hadn't used his blood to
block the previous blow he would have
died getting back to his feet and with a
revived look of determination on his
face he activates his flowing red scale
ability to attack the quickly
approaching curse seeing the curse
hitting narutoshi's way Maki rushes over
and manages to jump in front before
diving straight towards the curse and
cutting him open with a blade watching
this happen in front of him the Juiced
up narutoshi activates his Crimson
binding technique restraining the curse
spirit and allowing Maki to strike at
him once more yet just as a swing is
about to land naoya spun at a high
velocity to deflect his strike
completely catching monkey by surprise
the combined efforts proved to be
utterly ineffective against nayoya who
still retains his ego from his previous
life getting ready to re-engage Maki
states that Nagoya can still use his
curse technique which explains why he's
being so monstrously fast in retaliation
prolific projection sorcery sending out
a bunch of frames and Mark his Direction
which frees anything that he touches
watch also in this regard is literally
the ear between the two as he instantly
touches the set of frames it creates a
devastating explosion that Marcia and
narutoshi barely Dodge undeterred by
this nayoya takes off at a speed faster
than sound confusing narutoshi who
wonders of his flame but Maki corrects
him stating that he's actually just
speeding up as the curses in and as off
boasting around the jewel discuss what
they're going to do now touch Mahi says
that if he's going to approach them at
the speed of sound then they can lie and
wait and deliver a killing blow since in
the cursor's Direction Changed towards
him Maki bravely steps forward to face
nail you head on to a new companion to
stay back as narutoshi also activates
his technique around her in an attempt
to add some protection with the curse
Spirit destroying every shot of glass in
the building as it builds up its speed
it's explained to us that this
misogynistic demon of a curse brings ear
and threw the inlets on its back and
compresses it along with the curse
energy to then inject it out its back
for even more speed with its max speed
of freaking Mark III achieved now your
strikes were such a devastating force
that it leaves Marky almost completely
unconscious and badly injured standing
above her now now you're mocks Marky
disgusted with himself to ever think
that he could have possibly lost to her
now your state there are things that
children can never do that adults easily
overcome after you grow up you don't
even remember the times where you
constantly failed laughing at the
stupidity of this though Marky mockingly
asks him when he was ever actually an
adult to which naioya easily tells her
that maybe she should ask who did sister
fuming with anger over how his sister
was disrespected Maggie swiftly stands
back up and in perfect coordination with
her narutoshi unleashes two more arrows
into the malevolent entity that's in him
behind narutoshi then employs his own
blood-bending technique slicing into the
curse and learning a devastating blow
leaving Nao you're stunned with the
amount of blood being expended by the
sorcerer coming to though he makes a
connection that narutoshi could possibly
be circulating the blood outside of his
body and then bringing it back in and
continuously that way he won't die of
blood loss knowing that only Mark he can
defeat him though narutoji tells His
companion that he'll hold off naoya
while she makes a run for it but Mikey
refuses just asking for five minutes
narutoshi argues though that she's
probably suffered internal damage and
just a brief break won't be enough yet
still Maggie denies it and tells him
that she isn't bluffing and really does
just need five minutes to fully heal her
injuries I don't know how she's like
actually healing herself I'm assuming
that she's probably running over to one
of the healers from Jiu-Jitsu high and
getting healed there but that's just a
thought of mine either way hearing this
he tells her that he won't make any
promises as honestly it doesn't really
matter whether he lives or dies
reigniting the battle Neo your blasts
towards the duo but Naruto she uses
another technique to form a blood fins
before diving out of the way as naioya
effortlessly bursts throw it noticing it
Mark is vanish and because of the fact
that she's like toji he can't seem to
nail you asked where she's gone
narutoshi in this moment analyzes the
situation and realizes that although
nairu's curse body is incredibly fast
it's not durable he also observes that
naoya has a binding valve that requires
him to curl up at high speeds to avoid
tearing thus increasing his toughness
but due to that binding vow itself we're
not moving at high speeds he's extremely
vulnerable all of a sudden striking
faster than the speed of sound narutoshi
is completely taken off guard and blown
back through a bunch of defenseless
trees by neighbors blow immediately
following up the misogynistic demon
speeds up and Rams straight into the
vulnerable sorcerer causing him to start
spewing up blood with narutoshi Falling
Towards the ground below nayoyo gives
Chase and jokes that blowing blood into
his Inlet was a dirty move however
narutoshi refuses to give up and claps
his hands together before delivering a
powerful blood beam straight to naoya's
head despite his efforts though nayoya
remains completely unfazed and declares
that the Battle Is Over causing
narutoshi to fall into a childhood
flashback so you know big man himself is
having you know his life flesh before
his eyes right now he believes that
honestly he's failed he was never able
to create a safe place for him and his
broken family then coming back to
reality he now sees him a malevolent
figure there is naoya leaning over him
again narutoshi is hit by the shell of
naio's curse sitting him shooting back a
few feet but this time the sorcerer
quickly regains his footing thinking to
himself and knowing that no one in his
personal life needs him anymore
narutoshi attempts to retaliate with a
straight punch while proudly stating
that now it's time to completely burn
away his life then one day in the future
his comrades can do the same upon his
Fallen ashes and I'll say Giga man you
got to chill out you turned into a bit
of a bit of a poll at some of these
lines right here just then as naelia is
about to slip forth and in narutoshi's
life two brand new random ass players
screaming Sumo and Katana arrived to
join the fight so that Reign a man
screaming for a katana is actually an
old schooler who goes by the name of
dido Hagane like the Sumo dude he was
summoned into the current time period
but right in the middle of the kagoshima
sakurajima colony he switched far and
wide night and day looking for a beloved
Katana until one day while searching
through in an abandoned child's room he
finds a commitsuno yaiba first form
water surface sword heading Away In A
Box on the other hand and also on like
the 2nd of November the other random
Cullen game player Mio who was just
summoned walked around and challenged
everyone that he came across for Sumo he
challenged every man and woman and even
a tamed dog but no one accepted his
challenges in the end as he walked
around brokenhearted he heard the phrase
nakota and immediately smashed a
Granny's door down to see a game of sumo
taking place on her television finally
happy with finding that good stuff he
asks for the location and was told that
the fight is happening in ryogoku Tokyo
I actually love how smooth brain looking
this dude is p GE meme character right
here but anyway anyway man's like hmm
ryogoku Tokyo the capital of the East
but you know man is the biggest smooth
brain dude about and went to the wrong
direction he actually went right and
eventually strolled into the sakurajima
colony becoming a culling game player
with narutoshi initially taken off guard
by new people showing up now it takes
advantage of his situation by sending
some tentacles his way hidal girl
quickly shows back up and cuts off the
attacking arm seeing the weapon that
Marky wield Dido screams for her Katana
and runs in a direction beginning to
scream and cry for her sword knowing
that the battle is in a bit of a
stalemate right now Mucky throws her
Katana in the direction of The Old Man
and the hope that an external Pace to
this fight would alter its outcome
instantly as the old geez's fingers
touched the held of Marquis Katana and
grab a hold all four players feel an
overwhelming presence of power emanate
from him it was not cursed energy but an
overwhelming presence of sheer lethality
like a brutal master of death standing
before them it said that this Dido is
The Reincarnation of a nameless
unmatched swordsman who fights only with
a swordsmanship and not with cursed
energy so like he probably does have
curse energy but doesn't know what it is
or doesn't use it for that purpose
anyway anyway slicing at the curse
naioya is just barely able to dodge out
of the way of Dido's attack randomly
though the ancient Samurai gets annoyed
and the katana not actually listening to
him and begins yelling at it asking if
it was trying to shame him like Maki
Dido also has no curse energy and cannot
see the curses so because of that he
asks if there's some kind of ayokashi in
front of him confused is maki assumed
that he could see it she asks if he
can't he explains that if you can see
everything else besides the cursed
Spirit then it isn't technically the
same as saying it once finishing his
sentence he brings the blade down
connecting directly with naoya and
slicing him in half taking him
completely by surprise Blown Away with
what she just witnessed Mikey tries to
understand how she couldn't land any
lethal attacks on aoya but Dido easily
could under the same conditions she
Ponders what it is that she isn't saying
and what if there's still some kind of
difference between her and toji in the
end Maki sends us a simple domain appear
behind her turning around she sees Mio
and is challenged with a Sumo belt Maki
decides to enter his simple domain and
notes it only functions when he wants to
do Sumo it's an extremely simple barrier
focused on only one thing so you know
how he was rolling around previous to
this asking people for sue her matches
well it's actually because during his
pre-sumo belt both the Challenger and
opponent must agree to a match to
complete his domain due to this may asks
Marky for a belt or if she's like
everyone else and is going to refuse to
do Sumo to narutoshi's annoyance though
Marky nonchalantly ends up agreeing to
take part in the belt the massive open
grin appearing on his face Mio finally
achieves Bliss and his domain begins
surrounding him both confuses to why
maki's entering narutoshi asks what she
was thinking but Maki actually responds
that she was in fact overthinking and
just needed to blow us some steam with
the domain fully covering the duo now
Maki enters the ring and as she gets
into her pose begins to wonder what the
hell it is she isn't seeing thinking
more she starts to ponder the true
question that everyone has been thinking
since the introduction of toji what is
she since in the approaching attack Mio
easily manages to Dart behind Mahi
before she can grab him and as she turns
to counter instantly Ducks under her
left grab then quickly spring him back
up he manages to lock his arm perfectly
around hers then uses marky's previous
momentum to throw her over to the edge
of the Ring winning the first bout
standing above her Victorious Mio asks
Marky if she's going another round and
her as the moment that he laid eyes on
her he knew that she was much more
powerful doing like the ballsiest Crouch
ever in front of our Queen he asks
what's up and to tell him what's wrong
why why can't she focus it's explained
that Maki never relied on anyone to
become stronger despite having teachers
that jiu Jutsu High she always believed
in doing everything on her own and being
self-reliant that's why she just doesn't
know what to say to him here our smooth
brain Mio though seems that she was
still thinking about what Dido had said
earlier given her silence all this time
cutting it off her Chain of Thought he
asks her to stand up and have another
Sumo match as that's the only way he
knows how to explain things as they
continue a number of countless matches
me up against explaining to her that she
has become entangled in it all and
because of that she's limited her own
progression too much she needs to
instead let herself loose and experience
what it's like to finally be free while
fighting her opponents then everything
before her eyes like the idea of Victory
and the possibility of defeat will
become meaningless or in other words
exactly what the samurai was talking
about Freedom thanks to the wise words
of the ancient Sumo goat Mio and a
multitude of sumo matches Marky finally
knows what to do next and all she has to
do is experience it for herself where
the two begin in another bed of sumo it
skips fourth and soon comes to an end as
she finishes her match with Mio stepping
out now Maki leaves all of the others
shocked as we see our Queen smiling for
the first time and over a decade finally
ready to be free having exited the
domain it's explained that the exchanges
Mark ahead with Mio hadn't even taken
one minute kind of like in a Dragon Ball
Z with a hyperbolic Time Chamber time
moves slower in Mio's domain and the
time it takes for a thousand Sumo belts
is less than one minute feed up with all
of it though Neo your boosts off into
the sky like last time and begins
raising his speed looking over to the
randoms narutoshi notices them
cooperating and asks who they are but to
his surprise they explain that it
doesn't matter who they are others can
think what they want all they care about
is the new to hold a katana and cut what
needs to be cut or they want to get back
in the ring to wrestle with Marky some
more back in the battle as nario boosts
around Australia city he becomes annoyed
at the fact that he should be
overwhelming her with speed yet for some
reason he can't even touch her sprinting
across a roof now Marquis seasoneria
shoots up and boasts off in front of her
completely shattering all of the glass
from all of the nearby buildings as he
reaches near top speed somehow like I
don't know how she's got this much gas
now all of a sudden making it over and
in front of Naomi's trajectory Marky
drops down and begins to feel everything
around her and they passed she couldn't
see without glasses but once she gained
this body thanks to Mai she became
content as she was finally like everyone
else but toji he wouldn't just reach
that height he would have pushed
forwards without hesitation and even
being able to deflect naoya's top speed
attacks with ease seeing what no one
else sees for the first time Marquis
states that it's not enough to be like
everyone else there are things that only
the chosen ones like toji and herself
conceived
instantly it's now you're going to tears
through the building directly in front
of Maki trying to hit her with his top
speed once more Marky quickly pulls
herself into a ball and manages to dodge
Neo's top speed attack in mid-year
without anything to actually move off
it's just freaking insane a lot of the
fights in the series play off like how
you can catch a person off guard in the
sky as they are unable to completely
Dodge because there's nothing to move
off the skies like untangible so this
just goes to show how much of a beast
Marquee is is right now she's literally
smoking on that and how you're packed
through but anyway anyway moving on
Mucky knows that the air around them may
seem empty but they remind you
differences in the temperature and air
density all Marky needs to do is use
them to her Advantage as naoya then
attempts to boost it her once again Maki
easily Dodges and punches the curse down
towards the ground below monkey's like
also got that Mega Juiced up brain as
somehow she just knew that Mia was
directly below her allowing him to land
a direct headbutt to the side of the
cursor's exoskeleton not done Dido also
reveals himself and slices at the curse
almost completely cutting through the
entirety of naoya and kellingham coming
in his well though and seemingly landed
in the finishing blow Mucky kicks the
back of NATO's curse but I sent in his
top half tumbling across the street in
front of her screaming in denial over
his possible defeat now you're tears his
hands through the shell of his cursewom
fully revealing his human shell while
saying that the only one who deserves to
stand with him is himself before
activating his domain expansion with his
domain expansion time cell Moon Palace
active we see a massive malevolent eye
at this Center staring directly at
everyone within its height instantly
naio activates his ability on both Mio
and Dido causing frames to erupt from
their bodies taking the ancient ones by
surprise however even more to their
surprise it disappears allowing them to
begin their attack again though as soon
as they move both of them drop to the
ground absolutely overpowered banayoya's
sure hit technique for anyone as
confused as these old boys are it's
actually because of the fact that anyone
naio touches has to move like him or
they freeze for one second what makes it
all the more brutal is how his domain
amplifies his innate technique making it
even more precise not only this he can
even manipulate every cell inside of his
opponent's body and when his opponent
moves every cell will become out of
alignment which explains exactly why Mio
and Dido were severely injured by just
taking one step with Mio collapsing to
the ground he states that it's indeed a
good domain however nayoya only made
this domain expansion for Marquee but as
he tries to sense where she died he
can't find her slightly confused because
this is like his space obviously now you
knows that she lacks curse energy like
tochi but thought his domain would be
able to locate her suddenly Dido
purposefully moves his right arm in an
attempt to slice nayoya only to
instantly have it decapitated by the
annoyed cursed Spirit you see though in
typical bottom G Behavior now you're
thought it was pointless however Dido
was constructed of the same material as
our girl and was able to sense her
location checking the katana and Mark
his direction from within his own
Shadows Maki suddenly appears and grabs
her blade before plunging it straight
through a traitorous cousin's back as as
we all knew but like obviously this man
right here just he just couldn't accept
the fact Markie and toji have no cursed
energy so they can easily enter and exit
barriers unless the barrier uses a
physical object as its shell or unless
there is a specific condition placed and
because naioya didn't do that within his
domain he cannot trap her inside of it
going into the twins Dream World for a
moment the sisters are able to reconcile
together as they both recognize that
Maki finally broke free from her curse
correspondingly it's explained that the
sword might Left Behind as the replica
of the curse tool Soul Liberation blade
that's its sword and now Mark is
obviously ignores the hardness of
everything and cuts this sold directly
but to use the full potential requires
having a pair of eyes that can see the
soul of anonymous objects Marky has
achieved this and in the end as NAIA
screams at her telling her that she is
lost because she can no longer move
inside of his domain it's explained to
us that this domain's guaranteed hit
can't recognize Marquee due to her lack
of curse energy as I've been going over
so much already and because of that an
oblivious scenario is completely sliced
in two subsequently causing his domain
to explode well the battle seemingly
coming to an end and both Dido and Mio
shocked to somehow still be alive it
said that 12 years after the death of
toji zenen a demonic fighter of equal
strength was finally born honestly you
know it's just so nice to see Mark even
a smile on her face in each panel such a
lovely change from the angry monkey even
though she looked gangster and was just
ready to mess up anyone's day it's nice
to see her with a smile on your face for
the first time as like her Mission
technically has completely come to an
end now she's just here to be like a
goated warrior in the in the coming
battles pretty much anyway anyway gotta
move forward otherwise all the bottom
G's out there can't take it and they
hate it when I build up amazing female
characters which is really cringe to
them for some reason but anyway so with
the aftermath of Maki and Aria's fight
it's shown that she was fully successful
in exercising her as kamo confirmed the
one Maki claims that the win was thanks
to the randoms that had shown up and
hearing this narutoshi asks about their
condition
just like kaimo Dido and Mio's
conditions are also severe but what Mark
is most concerned about is how narutoshi
just nonchalantly decided to throw his
life away Naruto she tells you though
that he should know his situation
because he's from one of the big
families like her he feels worthless as
he's failed to become the head this also
how he was named by his mother after the
most evil sorcerer in history he asks if
Mahi asked hers to what she says that
she did but then she murked her but now
after hearing what the cursing area told
her she doesn't know if it was the right
decision and honestly just worst then
talked more skipping away for a moment
we've witness a glimpse of camo's past
we remembered his family and how his
name actually originated more or less
the reason as to why she named him
narutoshi was that it was the first
thing that came to her mind and she was
paved at the time she didn't know
exactly what was good for him but just
wished that he would abandon the kamo
family and safely return home to her
this little dude who like I initially
thought was kamo is actually kamo's half
brother I I just had no idea and I
thought this was a flashback with camera
to start with my brain my brain but
anyway he asks if Naruto she's a nice
guy twitch's Mumsy says that of course
he is after all he's my son
kicking things back off we shoot over to
Tokyo Colony number one where Hannah
could assume mysteriously greets and
Awakening Mega me as my fated one still
Dosey Mickey asks how long he was out
for with Yuji who's looking like the
maddest King ever dropped out on a robe
sipping on some wine remarked that he'd
been unconscious for two entire days and
now it's almost the 15th of November
having collected some food himself
takaba enters the room and as Hannah
settles on the couch with a tub of ice
cream the group began discussing how
it's quite odd that the power is still
on in Tokyo Megami presumes that kinjaku
may have colluded with the higher ups to
keep the power on so it wouldn't
interfere with the cullingham herself
and then goes off to take a dump and
because he was out of the action for the
last two days asked to be filled in on
what happened while he was out it's
explained that Yuji bumped into zacaba
and chose to join forces in an attempt
to locate Mega me eventually takaba was
able to locate Hannah carrying Mega me
through the sky and that's how they
ended up all here together bringing him
fully up to date Yuji shows Megami how
many points both Hikari and Yuta have
telling him that including his own
anticaba's Point they've meet the quota
now all that's left is to figure out how
many points are needed to actually leave
the goddamn culling game curiously Mega
me turns and asks Hannah if she's the
player named angel that they were
looking for and asks also why she saved
him in the first place as Hannah
confirms who she is a mouth suddenly
appears on the side of her face telling
them to cut ask any check so many
questions leaving everyone stunned By
Yuji who exclaims that there is someone
else just like him answering migami's
question Angel then goes to tell him why
he was saved but Hannah randomly cuts
the mouth off obviously hiding something
continuing Angel witches like the
incarnated sorcerer inside of her if
anyone's confused on why I keep
referring to like her as Angel and
Hannah while she explains to us how
exactly her technique Works simply it
negates curse techniques seals and
barriers because of this it allows her
freely to travel between colonies hence
how she was like originally in Tokyo
Colony 2 as they thought the reason that
she even left this colony in the first
place was because her main goal is to
purge all incarnated players and Tokyo 2
was saturated and cursed Spirits as we
like obviously saw in the Last Arc her
reasoning for this is because the
vessels of incarnated players are
usually suppressed and destroyed upon
Incarnation which goes against the laws
of God therefore Angel chose to coexist
with Hannah sitting there making me asks
if she could use a curse technique to
free Gojo to what she affirms it's
possible but first wants something in
return the disgraced or the Fallen one
she promises to the boys that if they
manage to take him down she won't
hesitate to help well let me all tell
you things certainly take an interesting
turn as Yuji is summoned into his or
sukunas in a world right here stepping
forth both loathe each other's side yet
there isn't any missing around this time
as no sukuna the king of curse reveals
himself to be the disgraced one which
like absolutely flips the series on its
head and let me tell you right now you
ain't ready for what's about to happen
and I I still can't literally fathom
what's just gone down in 213. anyways
anyways Murphy Ford noticing that
something's up with his boy making me
calls out his name asking if he's okay
looking like he freaking died on the
inside Yuji says that he just ain't
really feeling that well and asks Hannah
to switch places with him so that he can
lie down man's actually suffering after
realizing he's been hunted by yet
another ancient sorcerer having moved
out of Hannah's point of view Yuji then
becomes trying to gesture that the
disgraced one is sukuna man I actually
love Megan he's confused ass face right
here eventually though and after sitting
down with Hannah he realizes what Yuji
is trying to say making me Ponders on
how they need her help to save Gojo but
now they're completely back at square
one as her Target is technically Yuji
similarly Yuki Muses about why sukuna
told him to keep quiet and concludes
that angel must have some sort of
ability that can completely obliterate
zakuna without any chance of return Yuji
obviously being Yuji thinks that this is
a cheap price to pay to end the cursed
spirit and decides that as soon as the
others implement the roles required to
save sakumi he will die for the two
comparatively overthinking everything
angel speaks again breaking their
thoughts and remarking that it's odd how
a large number of people are current
currently entering the colony quickly
the group command equal game to show the
current culling game player base while
they're revealing 807 active players
with more joining every minute so right
now in this story with Yuji and stuff
we're in November of 2018 well taking
things back quite a few months until
February refunded kinjaku and tsukuna's
Chef arume are explaining to the US
officials the existence of curse energy
and cursed Spirits so apparently Chris
is a usually only observable by the
Japanese population or some exceptions
this includes the fact that they are
mostly invisible to like the naked eye
obviously coosa's and curse energy
themselves live within like specific
wavelengths of visible light that the
normal human brain can't pick up on and
man-made cameras don't actually capture
the correct light to view what's really
happening through their lens watch by
the way if you've watched jellemoth's
Dope video going over Jujutsu kaizen's
Iceberg well it goes into the theory
that due to kaizen's Cursed realm is the
same place as in gigo agotami's first
story called number nine and which the
main character who I think like looks
exactly like a mix of Kona Gojo and
Megami uses weapons and shikigami-like
creatures that he summons from nine
different boxes that interact with a
shadowy realm plus remember that one
time Sakura told the black box to open
just before he used a flame Arrow to
send jogo to the cursed realm honestly I
just didn't move on right now otherwise
I might just start dropping series
changing theories that have head Canon
right on the spot so anyway after having
handed out the cursed glasses UDA may
let everyone know that they function as
a screen and will allow them to see
curses along with the Menifee stations
made by Chris energy and certainly after
placing on the glasses the US president
along with his secretary's react in
shock horror asking what kind of
disgusting trick this is Cyrus one of
the US president's officials speaks up
telling them that they all need to calm
down as they'd already been able to
confirm that this is all reality and if
they don't cease this opportunity
they'll fall behind as a global power
the two Sorcerers then exercise the
cursed Spirit assuring the officials
that they mean no harm elaborating some
more on how curses don't appear on
man-made cameras urumi state that they
have video footage recorded using Jiu
Jitsu technology that will works by
capturing a puppet's vision specifically
they show footage to the officials that
was taken through kokichi's puppet's
vision giving them a taste of sukuna
Gojo nanami and Toto's abilities the
president like who's just watched all of
us makes a joke about it not being IMAX
quality however secretary stylists are
oh my God a stylist secretary Cyrus
declares that they just don't eat it
kusinergy has the potential to become
the cleanest energy source in history
replacing every other form of known
energy on the entire planet Cyrus
stresses that even the blonde dude they
just watched through hands possesses
enough curse energy to power an entire
country sitting before them the body
swapping goon then informs them that in
November Tokyo will become a domain of
pure viciousness where all Jiu Jitsu
users will be forced to congregate for a
ritual hearing this and becoming enraged
the president of the good old USA
demands to know if he's being told to
kidnap Japanese citizens and use them as
research subjects standing there himself
Cyrus insists on the importance of
tapping intercourse in energy is an
alternative energy source he emphasizes
that sorcerer's defied modern science in
technology because their brains were
wired differently however the whole idea
of abducting people for human
experimentation truly horrifies the
president in an attempt to fully
convince the big pay Cyrus goes on a mad
ride citing various Nations like China
Russia Saudi Arabia and the Middle East
who would surpass them as a world power
if they did not do anything beginning to
twist facts it declares that their
operation would be to form a protection
for the Japanese people against other
countries that could Target them
indiscriminately sorcerer or not his
advisor also suspected that because this
negotiation was being kept Under Wraps
the failure to comply would force
kinjaku to negotiate with other
countries having overheard them kinshaku
added that because Sorcerers were a
minority even among Japanese citizens
the November Gathering would be an
excellent opportunity to collect
specimens knowing that there are
Japanese descendants in the US the
president orders them to be heavily
guarded in order to protect them from
attacks by foreign countries quickly
following is up hitting turns and asks
for Gary K this Special Operations
Commander how many soldiers they should
deploy to Japan Gary who calls himself
like a military man mate bro we
obviously all figure that one out ask
for more confirmation about the average
strength of sorcerers after learning
that the main threat in Gojo would be
locked away in November Gary becomes
confident that one battalion of 60
soldiers would suffice given that all
these Sorcerers were amateurs he
declared that even with his supernatural
abilities they couldn't compete with his
skill weapons and experience of trained
U.S soldiers kinjaku casually agrees but
States he'd still recommend a full
Battalion of at least 800 soldiers to
deal with these Sorcerers effectively
hearing this Gary dismisses the idea
mocking the Japanese people and pretty
much calling them weak empathy Turk
speaking up odomay proposes a test and
moments later kinjaku Snidely guessed
that the 15 men guarding the amazing
room definitely wasn't everyone here so
I always lose it here but the meeting
actually ends and the special ops
manager goes in depth to the president
about how in addition to the 15 Secret
Service agents guarding their room men
from Sac the caa's paramilitary division
were patrolling the White House along
with them is another 45 elite soldiers
ready to bring down sugodu gitto having
moved from the East to the west side of
the building now they believe that
ghetto would never be able to defeat all
of them a new West office and wanting to
wrap this up keto gets ready to unleash
his technique in a show of dominance
opposite them on the East Side pet crazy
ass man Gary states that these silly old
Japanese people should stick to anime
and cars right now the US objective
isn't to win but to instead present such
an overwhelming show of force that is
America instead though man's instantly
shocked when all of his soldiers began
falling from the sky oblivious to how it
even happened though after chucking on
his sunnies Gary finally realized the
true horrifying power that is conspirate
manipulation back inside kinjaku throws
down all 45 name tags in front of the
president asking if they Now understand
so skipping away from our February like
we were just done and time traveling all
the way up to November and first of all
mind if I like just blow your minds for
a moment here but remember Rico she
wasn't actually the only one that was a
star plasma vessel like I actually
thought there there was only one star
plus my vessel hence why tingham was
like nah I guess I can't anyway she
wasn't Yuki was actually also compatible
with tinken but the reason tenkin chose
Rico was because no one existed with her
potential making her the ideal vessel
which just keeps me wondering like is
Yuji someone who's compatible with
sukuna because he also fits the same
potential as a vessel I don't know it's
just an idea that I've had while
scripting obviously let me know your
thoughts on that down below when Yuki
demanded to know why tingen hadn't rest
not merging with another vessel The
Immortal sorcerer stated that they had
simply accepted reality Tinker knew that
it would eventually happen and he might
become a threat to humanity upon
evolving but reason that they could
retain their sanity using barrier
techniques which does make sense as
tingen is the most proficient barrier
user currently known in the series was
sukuna being the greatest RTC user of
all time as well and since by the
explanation Nation Yuki asks a really
good temp question was it reasonable to
burden all of the children with his own
responsibilities like it's honestly just
said that this thumb of a man doesn't
see these star plasma vessel as humans
but more it's just Expendable paces and
that's why Yuki was so paved with how he
casually disregarded them think he'd
only passed now Yuki grumbles that she
could have helped the start organization
if the aim was to Simply prevent the
merging instead of killing the vessels
as he revealed that Yuki is able to hear
the voices of past star players and
vessels unlike tinken itself tingin
asked Yuki to tell them what their
voices were saying but Yuki refused
stating that the immortal sorcerer would
only use those words to justify their
decision to evolve sign over not really
getting anywhere Tegan states that they
would have liked to chat some more yet
they're unable to as it's shown that the
megalomaniac body swapping Fame kinjaku
was able to break through and enter the
area above the Tomb of the star Corridor
as you all remember from way back at the
beginning of the preparation Arc well
chozo had teamed up with Yuki to protect
tinken from this exact issue due to this
choso our brother is the first to
intercept kinjaku or standing opposite
his disgusting father he States his
intent to finally end him kinjaku though
simply dismisses him as a dispensable
porn declaring for the preparations for
the merger between tengen and the
Japanese civilian population had been
completed with a culling game having now
served its true purpose he then also
states that once he gets his hands on
tingen it's all over Japan and the world
are done for suddenly we then move into
a theater as kinjaku shows his son one
version of what could possibly happen
later on if everyone remembers during
Shibuya and how Yuki mentioned that
optimizing cursed energy through tenken
will cause non-sorcerers to assimilate
well kinjaku adds onto this theory of
who's here revealing that he believed
that to be the step which preceded the
merger and unlike Yuki he didn't want to
create a world without cursed Spirits
kinchaku wanted to cause kuspirus to
evolve to the next stage to create a new
form of cursed energy so in order to
achieve this it began citing his earlier
experimentations including the creation
of the death painting wombs but deemed
him all to be utter failures we all know
from stuff that we've learned so far
that an evolved tengan is more curspeed
than human so emerging or non-sorcerers
with him would cause the Consciousness
to technically cause tingen's
Consciousness to become one with
everyone in Japan this means in
kinjaku's eyes that a hundred million or
so people merging together would be able
to create a god-level monolith with
infinite power with kinjaku's film
coming to a close and the realm changing
back to normal choso just asks why why
is he even doing this touch the craziest
sorcerer alive stated that it just
sounded like fun with kinjaku trying to
drop a joke an infuro edachoso claps his
hands together before beginning an
attack with piercing blood although you
know typical gear fashion we don't
actually get to see that piercing blood
attack straight away and said we go back
to before the fight kicked off but now
with big bro choso in the room as well
there he tells yukin tingen that he'd
like to face kinjaku alone Yuki though
stated that he'll die if he did so to
watch choso like the absolute G he is
counted by asking if she would prefer to
fight kinjaku alongside him he admitted
that in such a situation he would only
be a hinderance so their best bet was
for him to engage kinjaku in combat and
force him to reveal more about his
cursed techniques giving Yuki and tenkin
an advantage Yuki states that he'll
still die but chosu stated that it
didn't matter if it allowed them to end
his and his brother's manipulative
father flashing back as chosu's passing
blood shoots off hinjaku watching the
approaching Tech manages to easily Dodge
out of the way of the attack while
releasing a centipede-like curse to
attack his opponent having destroyed the
curse along with a large section of the
Tome chosu watches kinjaku shoot out in
front of him and fling a large piece of
rubble and his Direction seeing it chosu
screams that he's been underestimated
but instantly he's proven wrong as
several curse Spirits burst out from
behind the throne piece of concrete
throwing a condensed orb of blood
forward himself choto uses Supernova to
eviscerate the cursors however the cloud
provided kinjaku with quick opening to
engage the death painting and
hand-to-hand combats after being pushed
back and realizing that he was at a
disadvantage so as we tried to buy some
time by asking how kinjaku intended to
use Yuji since he was undeniably
different from the death paintings so
obviously it's explained here by kinjaku
that he doesn't really have a plan for
Yuji other than being sakuna's vessel
Yuji and sakuna are catalysts as long as
they told live the chain of curses will
never end choso asly enraged by his
opponent's conviction that Yuji was the
reason for all of this Bloodshed
declares that it was kinjaku whose
existence fueled the chain of curses not
his brothers being taken off guard
Joshua looked down to see some small
curses tugging at him when all of a
sudden kingjaku takes the opportunity
and pummels his face sending him
spinning backwards and suddenly
following up he Stomps our poor boy's
face and condescendently declares that
he's only been using low-level curses on
him but maybe that was unnecessary since
choso was so pathetically weak just
straight up and rage now chosen foot
again but he gets nowhere as he's
quickly slammed back against the floor
kinjaku asks the defending cursed wound
if he even knows what the rank of
special crate stands for which also
unable to block any longer because
overrides and completely decimates him
all the while this body swapping fake
remarks there is the ability to
single-handedly destroy Nations those
like Saturday and suguru with special
grades because of their obvious
abilities to completely obliterate
Nations or create an army of
unparalleled monsters kinjaku added that
by strengthening pathetically weak
curses with curse energy he can easily
deal with a failure like choso laying
there a boy berates himself for failing
to be a good older brother to Yuji and
his other siblings he needed to protect
them and be there to be dependent on as
that's what big brothers do but now he
couldn't even Land one hit against his
creep of a father man will never go down
and still like the king he is chozo
stands back up refusing to evil and his
brother's names be disrespected
screaming he demands all his brothers
lend him their strength as he prepares
to deliver a raging attack from behind
him choso all of a sudden begins to feel
the support of his younger brothers
pushing him forward ESO kachizu and Yuji
assure him that he's got this
subsequently an emotionally overwhelmed
choso begins attacking hinjaku using all
his power and cursed technique standing
there the letter observes that the
pissing blood's initial velocity is its
top speed dodging the attack he
continues explaining that the ability
loses its lethality once the opponent
gets used to its speed and changing the
trajectory will only slow it down
watching hinjaku effortlessly Dodges
attacks Tricia decides to further use an
approximation of one king the most
powerful version of Esau's rot technique
which if you've forgotten what this
technique does well when the lines of
blood connect with its Target they are
instantly burned by the corrosive
effects of the death penis blood as
chosu dots and throwing a fat right Hawk
hinjaku calls his version of eso's
technique just a cheap substitute
however tosu releases the technique
sending four beams of blood shooting
towards the body swapping game having
summoned a curse hinjaku backflips out
of the way using the curse as a shield
before sending a bunch of low-level
curses towards chosen as well having
been hit directly back in jaku's
previous attack the letter explains that
Isla's ability was not as fast as
piercing blood and wouldn't even affect
him as he's his father chilling over on
a tree branch now he asks the cursed
womb if there was even a point to
everything that he's doing now beaten
and bruised chosen declares that he must
fight with the grace of eso the freedom
of kachizu and the domineering strength
of Eugene suddenly kinjaku was taken off
guard when chosu's arm fully detaches
and begins blasting towards his enemy
using the connecting blood as a robe
using his arm is a freaking grappling
hook try to latches on and pulls the
megalomaniac sorcerer towards him
destroying the ground in the process
before reconnecting his hand to his body
and utterly pummeling his fat right Hawk
into the face of kinjaku still like my
man's way too quick somehow big brain
kinjaku managed to use a curse shield to
protect himself and lie on their
unharmed he asks if his son is done
chosen we've just had the fattest grin
on his face like like man's entire
purpose has been for this moment right
here asks the dumbass what he thinks
releasing another burst of asa's ability
he does his best to attack the fleeing
Sorcerer And if you just didn't catch on
to what he's doing right now oh bro big
freaking choso it's actually Omega third
eye level of pre-planning and uses his
brother's technique to create a funnel
to purposely trap kinjaku within giving
him utterly nowhere to run as he
releases a few supernovas on either side
of the malevolent entity instantly as
Supernova activates something destroys
the entire floor all around kijaku only
leaving a precise place where kinjaku
was standing intact kind of confused
chozo Ponders if he Merced but just
knows that he didn't he activated
simultaneous attacks all around him so
how could it be due to this he quickly
deduces that he was finally able to get
him to use something other than cursed
Spirit manipulation finally revealing
herself as well this special grade
sorcerer Yuki sumoku states that she may
have been an only child but thanks chosu
either way as your older brother for all
of his efforts having heard what Yugi
has to say trust me faints as relief
hits him and falls through a gap that
appears in the barrier looking at her
opponent Yuki states that she likes it
wrath but will have to beat him into
shape so as I said just before Yuki is a
special grade sorcerer yet even kinjaku
reveals that because of the security
around her technique he was unable to
acquire any information on her unwilling
to face a close range attack from an
unknown technique kinshaku decides to
maintain a safe distance and summons the
cursed spirit that he had used at the
White House the school spirit here like
I think everyone presumed isn't even
originally from Japan still it's
actually a special Great Divine Bane
which uses a technique that removes
obstacles by using Concepts or logic
against cursed technique targets more or
less it's freaking broken Yuki who's
like obviously interested to see how
strong this Bane is begins darting
forward while raping up his shikagami
called gruda into a ball dropping a
shikagami down towards your feet you hit
him boots it with all of her mind
sending it blasting towards wine curse
From Below kinjaku completely blown away
can only watch as his special grade is
utterly annihilated with a single blow
quickly following up Yuki taunts him for
being cautious against an unknown
technique before revealing her ability
revolves around the idea of mass which
like we all learned in school Mass is
the true weight of something and to
figure out something's mess all we gotta
do is divide mass by gravity so 30 kgs
times 9.8 meters a second squared equals
294 Newtons but I don't even know if
that actually matters to the story here
I just thought I'd Chuck it in because
why not ferociously she punches kinjaku
in the face synonym shoots him back
across the Rome in fact the blow is so
damn strong and not only rips off both
of his arms but also seems on flying
across the empty space within tengen's
barrier utterly pulverizing any
generated structure in his path it's
actually shown that King Jacob was hit
so far that he completely exited the
confines of the barrier itself sitting
there kinjaku realizes that Yuki uses a
specific concept to Target acoustic nag
creating mass overwhelming enough to
obliterate anything and it's path Yuki
standing there and just looking like a
babe explained that she can give herself
any amount of virtual or imaginary mass
and that she calls that technique star
rage having heard this information
kingjaku also deduces that virtual mass
and boob by star rage doesn't actually
affect Yuki as your speed hasn't
decreased at all something super
different about Yuki is the fact that
she also defies Concepts meaning that
kinjaku is completely unable to use a
high grade curse Spirit like he had in
Shibuya looking at her the body swapping
douche wonders if you really can take
down this Beast of a sorcerer
recognizing that kinjaku's previous
ability involved gravity and leaves you
he convinced that kinjaku has at least
three other techniques beside ghetto's
curse manipulation and body hopping
technique he doubts that he has many
more as well as without an external Aid
like Yuda arakatsu's reiker the user's
brain would explode under such stress
she guessed that in the worst case
scenario kinjaku has yet another full
technique upper sleeve thinking as well
kinjaku deduces that yohi's special
grade rank suggests that she probably
has High curse energy output extension
technique what you'll use as your trump
card Yuki's plan here though is that
she's actually going to force kinjaku to
use his domain expansion which as we've
learned so far throughout the series
will make it more difficult for him to
use multiple curse techniques afterwards
in the end she decides to systematically
weaken kingjaku's domain before striking
the final blow but that isn't actually
what's going to happen if you think
alki's plans ever worked out and should
use a Kaizen you are smoking on the
wrong pack this is kinjaku's world man
has the plan planned out alright like
you guys need to get that in your mind
nothing goes anyone's way in the series
he knows that they find each other
tricky but unlike Yuki he doesn't like
the confidence to unleash pure dominance
having moved his hands together hinjaku
releases his domain expansion the
barrierless womb profusion instantly
Yuki streams out to Tinker wondering if
there's still enough time so good older
good old yeah again taking things back a
moment tingen explained that during the
battle they would confront kenjaku in a
labyrinth thing Barrier located directly
below the cursed warehouse and just
above the too many Star Corridor each
romance out of the celebrant themed
barrier is empty this allows a skilled
sorcerer for say like this example King
jaku to be able to alter its structure
or at least that's what they would want
them to think as if that's the case then
he'll most likely feel comfortable and
lower his guard the reason they need him
to feel comfortable is so that he'll
nonchalantly use the domain expansion
within tengen's empty barrier and if
this is the case tinken who's extremely
proficient at barrier control but
obviously from what we've seen but under
the condition that you can hold off
conjunction for 10 seconds be able to
manipulate and dispel the fiend's domain
so obviously Yuki could have also used
the domain expansion here but using her
during that time would also cause her
domain to be dispelled as that's
literally their plan here with tingen
instead to protect herself from Team
then she had planned to use a simple
domain yuhi pondered a fusing her domain
would be a more efficient way of forcing
their opponent to open his domain
however tingen reason that her domain
would be dispelled first as it's
technically the outer layer and might
also give kinjaku the opportunity to
counter with a simple domain or Hollow
wicker basket lastly he warned her that
kinjaku is one of the very few people
who can equal him and barrier usage so
don't assume that his domain is like
everyone else's which was the biggest
foreshadowing to what we've just
freaking sane yet kinjaku's true
potential was even higher than tingen
ever suspected as just like the goat
during Shibuya these body swapping
genius cast a burialis domain leaving no
outer boundary for tinken to remove at
all instantly in retaliation to The
Domain you could cast to a new Shadow
style simple domain however almost
immediately and Judy Kim jaku not having
a barrier on his domain tingen's
technique actually began stripping away
a Yuki shell with no other option she
Sprints forth in an attempt to take
kinjaku down slowly tenkin also begins
stripping away the body swapper's
structuralist barrier however kinshaku
remained unfazed and screamed that
unlike tingen he has lived for over a
thousand years and a cursed world of
Rife with conflicts and alliances
then out of freaking nowhere Yuki who's
left with no defeaters is utterly rocked
by the pure force that is gravity
pounding down on her sending her
shooting through the floor of Tegan's
empty labyrinthine barrier now in the
Tomb of the star Corridor itself and
with Yuki completely and utterly crushed
kinshaku staked they had this special
great sorcerer used her domain instead
of relying on an old fool she may have
feared better man this old dude must
have no friends cause holy he just loves
talking to himself he even further barks
on that tenkaku had hidden a vital piece
of information regarding the culling bro
can't even finish his sentence as he
notices Yuki shikagami still hasn't
disappeared and certainly shooting at
him Garuda destroys the area around
kinjaku forcing her back kinjaku guess
that this sorcerer was trying to buy
herself enough time to heal using RTC
however man is just completely wrong and
Yuki looking like he just got out of a
washing machine after 24 hours still
somehow continues to relentlessly attack
disregarding her injuries and giving the
villain no chance to recover kinjaku
just blown away asked why she is
inhaling but Yuki just utterly doesn't
care continuing like the pure demon she
is Yuki lashes out and kicks the ancient
sorcerer until it seemed as if she may
have finally reached her limit dropping
to the floor saying this kinjaku asked
her if that was it leading Yuki to ask
the villain if he had forgotten her
declaration she likes it wrath they're
right on freaking Q the big man himself
chosu returns to the fight entering the
empty barrier from behind kinjaku with
its technique fully activated doing the
Giga as per usual though would skip back
just before the battle broke out the
death penal reason that domains
neutralize curse techniques so he
wouldn't open his domain if he expected
choso to join the fight later meaning
that he should as he mention before
fight first he suggested that he face
off against the madman first following
him into believing that his only
opponent for the rest of the fight was
Yuki then finally reappear back in the
battle now and completely stunned
kinjaku is immediately restrained by
Garuda laying him down firmly landed on
the ground chosu slaps his hands
together and tells his brother others to
watch as their big bro is about to
commit petrified incidentally our boy
uses pissing blood on his dad at a
point-blank range yet bro have your
brain even managed to dodge there Yuki
and choso are also just like blown away
as they get a glimpse of kinjaku's True
Form you he observed that the villain
had spun his hair deliberately to
deflect the attack which is just
actually insane when you think about it
man's got like a his skull is literally
just a cap at this moment like he's
wearing it around like Chuck like it's
crazy let me interchange caps change
hairstyles and stuff is what I'm
wondering right up anyway I need to
continue on she concluded that conjuga
was desperate enough to do such a move
because he was also becoming troubled
knowing this the duo keep up the hated
bait down attacking in tandem laying fat
kicks punches and elbows on the sorcerer
Yuzu RTC Yuki easily manages to fix her
mangled arm and other injuries but the
momentary distraction weakened star rage
just enough to allow King jacket to
escape welding Garuda like a whip now
Yuki swings at kinjaku only just missing
but the energy released from the attack
as early demolishes the floor and walls
of the star corridor around him with
everyone falling down onto some water
below shotsu takes the opportunity to
attack through this smoke screen while
simultaneously yukilix loves another
attack using a star rage and viewed
cursed Hall korov God themselves though
ochoso and Garuda dropped to the floor
under the weight of kinjaku's
overwhelming gravity and replenished
technique yuhi shikigami lashes out
trying to move but it's unable under the
gravity and while Yuki runs into collect
it she deduces how kinjaku's technique
Works she concludes that the ancient
sorcerer's attacks have a radius of two
or three meters and remained active for
at least six seconds swinging hookah
root at him she knows that once he's
caught something within his gravity trap
Ninjago will then finish it off with a
cursed Spirit but doubt that that will
even work against her and she's not
gonna stop until she baits him down and
wins though she should have honestly
just won and not internalized her as
ginjaku was able to Parry off a vicious
hit punch before grabbing Yuki's arm and
directing a miniature Uzumaki at her
face with Yuki completely fried from the
point-blank blast she begins to Dart
backwards when all all of a sudden
kinjaku follows up and forms another
miniature Uzumaki while remarking that
her density may have increased due to
Star rage but her tensile strength
didn't releasing the ability kinjaku
leads choto screaming in horror as he
attacked his straight through Yuki's
abdomen really damn abruptly rear game
fly into a flashback where our team is
sitting at a bar there Yuki asked choso
if he didn't want to be there for Yuji
since it seemed like he was throwing his
life away now not answering the question
though chosu asked if he's even human he
remembers thinking back to the time when
his brothers took form and realized that
they would never be accepted by humans
because of their deformed locks so from
this chose to decided to live as a curse
with his brothers hence why he killed so
many people in Shibuya and why now he
burdens themselves with their deaths
said him with his choices big bro choto
states that if he had chosen to live as
a human he wouldn't have lost them
weeping he wonders why chose the easy
path was it because he didn't want to
see his brother suffering as humans
however a human thinks showed up who
just happened to be suffering himself
those four were meant to be brothers and
fight together as one but instead he
took the easy Road and left Yuji all
alone returning to the battle choso
gearing up to unleash a spinning wheel
of blood at the enemy states that the
only way to make it up to all of his
brothers is to use up all of his life
here but before he could even do that
the G himself like this is the only time
I'm calling Tegan a g because I don't
know his ulterior motives right here the
G removes him forcibly from the barrier
Yuki looking like Gojo for real tells
him that this battlefield was where the
death paintings Life as a curse ended
and his time as a human begun so because
of that he must live above the falling
choso Yuki's body also falls to the
ground but in two pieces for this
seemingly defeated by kinjaku's previous
blow behind the two tingen then reveals
themselves causing kinjaku to actually
start laughing at his thumb's appearance
even comparing him to sukuna's original
form which actually has to have some
kind of freaking mirror in the story
right there tingin is like dude check
your kills all I had to do was distract
you for literally two damn seconds
allowing Yuki's top half the glue I
don't understand this as well path she
just reaches out and grabs his leg to
literally reach out and grab your cankle
bro not taking him seriously though
kinjaku just tells you to die before all
of a sudden and out of freaking nowhere
a massive Force begins ripping the
sorcerer down towards Yuki as I
mentioned at some point earlier on
Yuki's techniques alteration and mass
doesn't actually affect her up to a
certain density that is and you're
moving kinjaku asked choso what makes a
special grade well nothing you've seen
so far from Yuki would actually give our
girl the ranking of special grade but
yeah she's insane her strength alone is
mental but this next technique is what
makes her the threat to every freaking
life form on this planet when Yuki goes
beyond her Max density control point the
sorcerer can add an infinite amount of
mass with her curse technique and if you
somehow haven't caught on yet yes she
can create a goddamn Black Hole by just
continuously just pushing more and more
density into it the end result of what
she had just formed was the creation of
a black hole which not only consumed
Yuki's entire body but trapped all all
matter and even Light Within it right
before disappearing you hear the clear
tikinjaku but he should have seen this
coming as gravity mass and time or need
to be wielded with Extreme Caution with
the black hole fully formed it began
sucking away literally everything from
the surrounding area inside of the Tomb
of the star Corridor as the energy from
the black hole then finally begins to
subside it's revealed that even the
ceiling of the Tomb again crumbling away
with natural light breaking through and
lighting up the underground Chambers by
the way you know I'm just going to say
this right here recent peace you here
I'm pretty sure she died from that so
rest in peace what an insane attack but
despite the immense gravitational force
exerted by the black hole kinjaku
somehow manages to survive climbing out
from underneath the collapsed deer
Breeze stunned by this himself Tegan
asked if he had used the reverse curse
technique in combination with his
gravity technique but kinjaku actually
makes a shocking Revelation declaring
that the true nature of the technique
had not been gravity at all he admitted
that his third curse technique
originally belonged to Eugene his mother
kaori itadori with its true form being
the anti-gravitational system kinjaku
added that he had taken a risky Gamble
and used laps to reverse the effects of
the technique stabilizing the output and
activation by using his own body as a
domain like I said this is like
obviously kinjaku's freaking world man
has pre-planned absolutely everything
for a millennia so I don't know how our
boys are going to actually end up
wanting here like the famous jjk scholar
broken Ronin also once said every word
in the series has Merit so think on this
kinjaku as he watches tingen's operation
disappearing states that this was just a
warm-up then finding the letters body
encased within the trunk of a tree in
the star Corridor kinjaku says goodbye
to his friend
and I'm just sitting here like hmm
thinking on those
so remember how we leave things with
Yuji and his group at the end of like
the last period well as the influx of
American soldiers entered the culling
game a multitude of code games appeared
and began registering the soldiers as
new players elsewhere kinjaku and arume
are seen at these Xenon Clans Warehouse
which surprisingly it's explained that
there is a secret way to transfer
between colonies simply someone could
not leave a colony unless they've
answered the cogain's call unimpressed
by this but amazing suggested that this
space would be more suitable as the bath
for sukuna's Revival flying back over to
the American troops as they invade
Remy's room which is just like the
biggest L for her not gonna lie in
military fashion they throw flashbang
before rushing in and trying to
immobilize her with a taser allowing
them to then easily inject her with a
sedative outside a group of soldiers are
seen remarking that these Sorcerers were
nothing special and simply wondered why
their Lieutenant was so worried in the
first place rolling up we see another
group of soldiers who were taken out
their target instead of capturing it as
ordered the soldier in charge rebuked
her but they let her flipped said that
it didn't matter since the brain was
unharmed she further complained there
was really nothing worked against the
Sorcerer And even a 50 cal bullet didn't
Pierce through the target's skin so
remember the helicopter dude usually
absolutely pummeled well that's actually
the person her Squad took out here
having heard that the dude had a
helicopter type here the soldier was
hesitant to believe her until he saw
just how damaged the female's comrades
were in the end she concluded that there
must be Sorcerers of various power
levels and she just got stuck with one
of the tougher ones what you know like
to us readers is absolutely hilarious
thinking that Harbor for some reason as
op is too good I can't actually wait
until they find a proper a grade or
above sorcerer and have to fight them in
like some kind of way funnily enough we
pop over and see the Ruffian himself
hazanoki exploding some poor
unsuspecting soldiers Vehicles as they
rolled nearby noticing that the enemy
was a foreigner the sorcerer remembered
Richie's words from earlier and wondered
if this was the bomb he suggested
kinjaku would drop now back with the
megalomaniac himself and ultimate the
latter guessed that the curse and energy
of every Colony would be increased by
petting sorceress against non-sorceries
in any custom before the emerge of a
tinken kinjaku though admitted that what
uduma had guessed is only about 60 of
his plan elaborating that the curse
energy levels in every Colony except
Tokyo and Sendai was still an official
end also kinjaku did only say that Tokyo
was the Battleground to the U.S so I'm
assuming that they like aren't anywhere
else in the country other than Tokyo
Colony number one or two but we're going
to find out about that later on What's
even funnier up at the military is that
kinjaku had only seen in the foreign
military as insurance and was already
aware that the fighting would not be
very intense having manifested a curse
to clean up the mess that was okizen
kinjaku claimed that unlike reincarnated
players those who had only recently
awaken their cursing Knicks would be
reluctant to fight and the US may even
Retreat if they get too many casualties
it'll make question of the military had
been sent in at night to give them an
advantage and also wonders since
non-japanese individuals would not
release curse energy so how is it
actually going to help him yet it's
actually revealed any moment of passing
there is an exception as the stress of
seeing curses pushes them to a new level
it's also considered natural law that
non-sorcerers can't win against Jujutsu
sorcery elsewhere as one poor poor
American Soldier notices a terrifying
curse Spirit it further goes in depth
that kinjagu had released multiple curse
Spirits in every Colony that are
specifically active only at night to
force out that higher level of cursed
energy from these new soldiers back over
with the main crew now Angel quickly
deduced that kinjaku had sent to
non-sorcerers to be killed by curse
Spirits as a Fail-Safe to produce more
curse energy having left the room now
and made their way down some stairs the
group ran into an empty cafeteria right
as a stunning grenade lands in front of
them obviously thrown by the military
boys noticing it Yuji quickly kicks the
flesh being away before it could explode
in front of them seeing the squad pull
up migami initially assumed that these
soldiers were trying to protect people
but instantly discarded the possibility
as these Soldiers with a second thought
began shooting at the sorcerers abruptly
within seem to skip away and see what
seems to be the power memory for make
her spirit feeding three young children
inside of an abandoned building then
back with a group all of a sudden we see
good old Mega me interrogating a
Japanese soldier who was actually acting
as a guide for the foreign military
forces when henna asks why Japan had not
taken the opportunity to become energy
self-sufficient sooner the soldier
responds that jesusu headquarters
controlling the country is too proud and
everyone here is obsessed with
self-responsibility so it never would
caught on like it would have in other
countries it can be also realized that
kinjaku had only lured the military to
the colonies under the false proteins
that curse energy was up for grabs as
another energy source from thus Mickey
with introduces that this soldier's
death would increase the cursed energy
and their colonies and complete the
ritual preceding tinga's merger with the
wider Japanese population making me you
know like obviously it's so damn big
brain that the dude even suspects that
King Jacob has likely orchestrated the
culling game as a distraction for his
true plan stepping in Yuji asks if they
should help them prompting to Kaaba to
ask why they should even help people who
wanted to abduct them for experiment
making me reasons that if they allow
kinjaku to fulfill the ritual everyone
would be caught up in the merger with
tingen yet Angel Cuts in telling them
that it's no use since Tokyo Kalani 1
has already reached their required level
of curse energy Yuji challenges Angel's
decision though stating that it did not
invalidate their saving of other
people's lives the letter tries
explaining to Yuji though that it has a
symbiotic relationship with its vessel
so putting henna at unnecessary risk is
akin to put any curse living within her
body at risk itself shooting over within
City true Terror that some soldiers are
being put through after having fun with
its first Soldier the predatory curse
then picked up its next prey which just
happened to be the same Japanese soldier
the group was interrogating before
laying there and suspecting the worst
his Soldier thinks back on the times he
had believed that he was ready to pass
on but feels that now this is different
and seeing what awaits him truly
shatters his resolve nearby Eugene
migami just happened to be running
through an Alleyway Megami insists to
his boy that he doesn't need to be so
hostile and asks a Fuji's comment about
out not trusting henna was a reference
to bands like sakuna and Angel skipping
away for a moment and referring back to
the random like flashback that we had
just before well it was actually Hannah
as a child sadly she had been forced to
live with that cursed spirit for almost
a year eventually though she managed to
escape after following a white dog with
a fluffy tail of course it was no one
other than megami's white Divine dog who
had little to safety before returning to
him and Gojo as henna watches the three
reunite and begin to leave and flashes
back to the prison as she remembers the
kind nurse because of their moment
during her childhood she decided to try
and help people herself as she's always
believed that someday they would meet
again and she would proudly stand by his
side all Mega me wanted was for Yuji to
be a bit more considerate twitch like
after hearing all of this a boy
confesses that ever since they regrouped
he was just scared that Hannah would
take no virus place what you know oh my
Lord Giga we actually got some nobara
crumbs for the first time in like how
long it's we're damn fiends out here
absolutely wanting anything to do with
her or Gojo man just come on come on
please anyway as in becoming scold shuji
and asks him to apologize to Hannah the
queen herself appears before the boys
bringing the crew fully back together
let the ripening begin if you guys know
what I mean then you know what I mean
it's huge beings of light suddenly
emerged from every Colony throughout
Japan that can detract in the attention
of everyone throughout the entire
country not understanding what's
happening many people just know that
something doesn't feel right like the
ear had become a naturally dry returning
to our crew Maki gives everyone a full
rundown of everything that's happened up
till this point she explained that chose
who had managed to protect the back of
the prison realm but relay the news of
Yuki's defeat in tingen's capture in
another location our boy choso clutchini
bet gay or literally hope itself in this
case here I guess weeps as Carrara asked
him about Yuki's whereabouts pretty much
to me at least confirming her demise
Maki further told the first two years
that the ritual precedingly merger had
already ended calmly Maki concluded that
taking down the villain would be a
challenge leading Yuji to wonder how
they merge ahead and actually started
yet Angel points out to the group that
the Sorceress inside of the colonies
could probably reject the merger with
tinken because of their cursed energy so
because of that nothing is going on
around them being able to travel inside
and out of the barriers herself though
Mucky disagrees and informs them that
apart from a few affected people most of
Japan's population is unaffected as of
now making me suspect that dekhinchaku
either couldn't start the Muji yet or
didn't want to however since there was
no way to find out right now they
decided to focus on friends to make me
first intervening in the conversation
himself Juju decides to list off the
four rules that they decided to
implement mikami again clarifies that
rule 1 does indeed subject a player to
curse technique removal or subsequently
death through something missing with
their brain the purpose of this first
rule was just the star fights with
people but now they can obviously
circumvent theirs Mucky though remarked
that it was actually rules two and three
which were the tricky ones as they
involved somehow creating a form of
movement and communication across
colonies Stephen forth herself henna
declares that she could move across the
colonies by virtue of Angel's curse
technique Maki asked if it's possible
that she could use a curse technique on
someone else to help them leave but the
voice of Angel replied that they could
only extinguish a barrier technique by
destroying the root of the barrier
itself if they can't locate these
so-called Road they're only able to pass
through the colonies without actually
destroying them with the group realizing
that adding new rules might not actually
allow them to move across colonies that
decide to add the fourth Rule and focus
on allowing players to withdraw from the
game entirely so earlier on an Ulta was
back well like mikami was recovering
user had transferred all the accumulated
points over to Mega me bringing its
total number of points up to 359. by the
way there is actually like a tiny mess
up by gear right here notice that it
already says one rule while Giga had
messed up and spoiled everyone in some
kind of way letting them know that
Megami did indeed Implement at least one
rule speaking of himself making me
attempts to add a rule allowing players
to withdraw from the game but cocaine
rejects it Stacy and that it clashed
against rule seven Megami tried a game
ask him if the game master would allow
players to withdraw if they invited a
substitute into the colony to take their
place but still kogane refused however
out of nowhere it actually states that
the culling game has a suggestion it
says that it would indeed let players
leave the game on the condition that
they provided one substitute and spent
100 points unable to negotiate any
further and utterly pay for the result
Megami agreed despite knowing that Ed in
the new rule would require them to take
out at least another 20 Sorcerers to
just leave with all of the negotiations
complete Megami created a new rule rule
11 a player can leave the game by
expending 100 points to invite a new
player into the colony as a substitute
looking over to the clan killer herself
which they don't actually realize there
are monkeys even taken out of Clan yet
mikimi asks if it's okay for her to
transport sakumi to Tokyo Colony number
one Yuki asked though if it would be
safer to transfer the points to her
remotely since she was already outside
the colonies however Megami pointed out
that since the rules illicitly stated
that a player must declare their
participation in a colony within 19 days
trying to circumvence it might lead to a
sister being subject to curse technique
removal when she tries to leave the game
flashing forth now to the fateful day of
November the 16th we see that after
reconnecting with samiki Mahi led her
and the assistant manager ajichi to the
outskirts of Tokyo Colony number one so
when it actually comes to who's going to
be the substitute for uh submaki here
achichi had previously agreed to take
the role due to Marcus lack of curse
energy as it prevents the barrier from
even recognizing her or allowing her to
become a substitute so he is visibly
conflicted by the idea but it gives you
reason that they didn't have enough time
to find someone else as it had literally
been 16 days since everything began
literally only given you three days
before like her brain goes poof standing
there ajichi reminisces on past memories
and how they always wanted to be a
source where they helped people yet goju
demanded that he get his license and
become a manager instead back then
ajichi had thought the sorcerer to be
harsh but now he realized that he would
have been dead by now if he continued
down that path he had previously chosen
so he thanks Gojo for putting him on the
right track so remember like the spawn
glitch Yuji and mega me previously went
through back a little bit well somehow I
don't even know how she managed to do
this but to me he hacked the game and
got insanely lucky appearing directly
before Megami and Yuji upon entering the
barrier completely stunning the both of
them with no time to lose let me not
even speaking to her transferred a
hundred points to a sister asking her to
declare her withdrawal from the game
however to the complete and utter shock
to me he used the points to instead add
a new rule to the game she immediately
makes the 12th rule granting players and
restricted entry and exit across Colony
borders more to fight and literally just
standing there unable to Fathom what
just happened Mega me asks his green
sister Who and the Royal she really was
I wonder so have you ever felt pain and
those few moments before what we now
know his pain crawled its way out of the
dark abyss itself Yuji had just assumed
everything was sweet now samiki was safe
migami would be all right and you would
follow up after and then kill sakona
along with Yuji and release Gojo who
would in turn take care of kinjaku the
plan literally had no folds apart from
the fact that they don't own the playing
field that they're standing on I'm
honestly at the point right now that I
think they just lose here the story ends
on a sad note and will be the first
Shonen to do so with all of the bad guys
winning unless like somehow Gojo gets
out and goes utterly god mode that
that's the only way they win right now
in my eyes it's totally crazy however
samiki was then revealed to be an
imposter watching this thing in front of
him cackle Megami asks the Imposter who
they are Twitchy hysterically gloats
that she's definitely his big sister
stricken and at a loss for words Megami
remembers that the incarnated players
are given access to the memories of
their host thus because of their it's
entirely possible for them to
impersonate their hosts feeling like a
complete idiot now Mega meeperates
himself forever thinking that his sister
had automatically awakened like egoroma
and takaba so this person inside of Mega
me is actually called igorozu a sorcerer
from at least 1 000 years ago just like
a few of the other people here mikimi
who obviously just wants to know why is
told as she pretended to be his big
sister to use the three points for her
own game she hasn't had a good fight in
at least a thousand years and wants to
choose her battle along with this
location claiming that she wants to take
on sakuna first moth like wings began
forming on her back before she jumps off
the building and begins boosting away
Yuji and Hannah like instantly go to
give Chase not wanting her to escape
however like everyone plays just
remember back episode 7 right here and
right now already in a moment of Despair
sukuna uses that opportunity to appear
on the side of yuji's face and utterly
words in chain as per the bunny Val
showing in chapter 11 or episode 7 who
he is intently forced to hand over his
body to sukuna without any hesitation
sakuna immediately appears on the back
of henna taking her out for the complete
ease looking over at me and me whose
brain must be going through it right now
secunda explains that he once made a
vowel with Yuji having explained that he
can't harm anyone to Mega me he knows
they're from here on out everything that
he does is just a complete gamble
sending some form of like channeling
curse energy to yuji's finger sukuna
then proceeds to freak and tear his
entire finger off screaming at this
moment and like pure joy he explained
that it was a gamble because he wasn't
even sure if Yuji included himself in
the veil when stipulating the condition
that zakona must not hurt anyone
typical man like instantly pulls out the
arm movements to do maharaga but I
honestly can't blame him he doesn't
really have any other choice at the
moment so as he tries to summon maharaga
zakuna Datsun graving his face and
restricting the summoning seal before
shoving his finger down her boy's
unsuspecting throat with the cursed
energy pulse 18 through Mega me an
unconscious Yoji comes to not even
realizing what just happened as as per
the vowel stipulations however standing
opposite his boy he hears sakuna say
that indeed he's something interesting
in the future didn't they raising his
head we say that no one other than the
king of curses himself has supposedly
fully reincarnated inside of Megami for
shiguru's body well they're just Heaven
boys and at this moment we very possibly
could have lost yet another of the
original Trio yet in my eyes we can't
lose them we can't lose them all unless
the bad guys actually win in the series
so if down the line it's confirmed and
the bath is completed and everything has
just turned to utter trash remind me
that hope itself was utterly sucked out
of the series at this exact moment
please just come back and let me know
down below anyway going back probably
for a last time I would say into the
inner world of sukonas we see him
monologue about the intricacies of his
plan for Mega me back during the day
when he confronted Mega me as Yuji for
the first time he sensed unmatched
Potential from him his acoustic mix and
his abilities he knew that he could have
forced Mega me to eat his finger then
and there that day but it purposefully
waited until build up enough strength
instead of Yuji to initiate the vowel
actually they have a great Theory here
and like how we all know that hinjaku
had made Yuji specifically forskona well
what if kinchaka also made it a binding
Veil that yuchi would not be able to use
his curse technique while sakuna was
caged inside of him versacuna finally
leaving our boy's body now we may see
for the first time that Yuji actually
like has his mother's technique or
possibly something that even relates to
a literal thing that'll bring up right
at the very end of this video anyway I
top the building meguna which is like
sukuna Mega me mix up I'm just gonna
call him that sometimes the absolute
Beast himself stands there leaving Yuji
stunned asking for his friend to just
talk to him yet as we all probably
expected was just about to happen the
demon Megami asukuna comes in will they
charge and punches Yuji like and this
wasn't any ordinary level of punch as
well meant to separated the fabric
around the area that he hit on Yuji like
it made Yuji freaking throw up while
sending him hurling through a multitude
of different skyscrapers eventually
though Yuji ends up finishing his
destructive path on a rooftop of another
building completely unconscious and
covered in rubble noticing some people
approaching the area sukuna states that
in every damn age and sex always come
crawling out of the woodwork placing his
hands together it informs the sign of
megami's tin Shadows technique more
specifically the hand signs for no way
instantly a monolithic sized Norway is
summoned out of a nearby Skyscraper with
everyone reacting in pure shock and or
at the size of no way it releases it's
usually pretty ineffective attack that
simply stuns people yet this time it
rains deadly lightning down on everyone
from the sky above having recovered from
a previous beating henna quickly makes
your appearance by shooting over showing
up behind the revived demon saying her
sakuna realizes that Hannah and the
angel co-exist and thus she can recover
very fast to say like in comparison to
him and Yuji in the past given that
Hannah is extremely in love with me give
me I would say probably from what I've
read so far she screams and hesitation
not wanting to hurt Mega me however
Angel insists that there is no other
choice he is is the disgraced one and
must be eliminated right away thus as
Hannah cries to get migami back Angel
becomes reciting the Incarnation to
dispel evil itself speaking to God now
she tells him to purify all remove his
anguish transgressions and guilt to
guide him on the correct path instantly
Jacobs later initiates filling the sky
with some form of holy symbol before a
mess of pure light energy strikes down
upon the disgraced one himself in
another note boys just quickly cutting
in here and after browsing the interwebs
myself I'll discover that Jacob's letter
is actually referring to a line from
Genesis 28 10-19 I don't know if that's
actually I think that's how you say uh
Bible lines I shouldn't know I used to I
was raised in the church this part of
like the Bible narrates the story of
Jacob dreaming of the Angels descending
from the heavens and the letter
appearing to take these Souls from Earth
to heaven so in other words the attack
simply dispelled evil while sending the
person's soul on the correct path or at
least that's however interpreted her
attack as with the mass of light bearing
down on that begins tearing at zakuna's
soul in an attempt to bring migami back
as Hannah is crying screaming that Mega
me belongs to her it appears as if the
technique has actually managed to work
dispelling sakuna's Spirit from migami's
body but remember like honestly hit just
how I said before the incarnated
sorcerers and people like sukuna can
mimic how their body used to behave
while Angel realizes that sukuna is
still in control and manipulating henna
with migami's voice not paying attention
though henna falls into migumi's arms
saying that she's always sadly though
she's unable to continue her sentence
has sakona fully reveals himself before
going to strike on an unsuspecting henna
calling her a fuller Schuman shakuna
like an absolutely rabid dog bites in
tears at Hannah before throwing her
across the entirety of the building
causing her to smash into the side of
the protective railing Yuji down below
watching this in shock and not even able
to comprehend what just happened
Witnesses Hannah thud onto the ground
below with no indication that she'll
ever return looking down from the top of
the building himself zakuna is
astonished to see you Fuji somehow alive
after the previous blow with rage
beginning to fill up inside of him and
after realizing that he's lost the one
thing keeping him together and giving
him meaning in life Yuji breaks and a
complete flash usually jumps across the
building breaking the ground below him
and causing the entire skyscraper to
collapse he Graves to Cone his neck and
screams his name before landing a
ferocious punch on the king of cursor's
face forcing him to dub back across the
street for gaining his footing sakuna
wonders just just how many world uses so
strong all of a sudden then in that
freaking moment Yuji takes him off guard
throwing a massive section of the
previously collapsing building into the
Demon's face seeing him shooting back
once again sprinting towards them
himself yuhi grabs a piece of rebar to
beat down onto Kona worth with him
darting him behind the king of curses
Schooner remarks that he should have
seen us coming after all Yuji is from
back then and what do you mean by that
sakuna right there eh anyway having
blocked yuji's strike with the bar
sakuna counters by disarming and kicking
him in the face while noting that King
sure is Twisted I'll expand like more on
what this means in a moment but honestly
in my opinion this all relates back to
Yuji and him having his curse techniques
suppressed or I like it being suppressed
while he was being used as a cage for
his Kona so don't be surprised if our
guy manages to manifest and in the
Heritage technique in the near like very
near future but yeah asuji continues to
approach to Kona trying to attack him he
screams asking him why why is it that he
just can't live normally like everyone
else why can't he live a life without
causing everyone to suffer Yuji
continues approaching when all of a
sudden takuna uses his acoustic name
slash to cut Yuji across the chest
replying to his previous statement
sukuna rebuttals him asking him why so
weak continuously trying to cling to
life he continues by saying that this
suffering is only natural and they are
meant to live life with this misery for
a moment there Yuki forgot that there is
no reasoning with him as they are and
always will be curses do he dares to
Kona to chew on his misery and suffering
instead while beginning to March towards
the damn Lord himself passing him off is
just absolutely pathetic zakuna uses his
curse technique to continuously cut Yuji
over and over and over and over again
yet our boy is just built different and
with a rage-filled heart he puts the
pain aside and stuns sukuna by not
slowing his Approach at all standing
there and actually confused now unlike
like what is going on shakuna wonders
how in the world is so tough then out of
freaking nowhere and just like during
Shibuya once again proving that the body
and soul are won making me hold sukuna's
movement allowing his boy to follow up
and Pummel his face with a fat right
Hawk elsewhere and literally just
boasting it over on a blowfish Express
ultimate enkenjaku are seen traveling
towards what I assume to be the current
bait down back in the battle and having
smack sakuna in the face maguna remarks
that fushiguro is indeed stopping his
curse energy output which is allowing
him to only use 10 of his maximum output
hence how Yuji has managed to survive
they blows so far sakuna notes that well
it's probably expected when the jobs
only half done but still considers it
enough to easily take out ug interesting
so I wonder what the other half of this
ritual to fully take over megami's body
will be probably something to do with
the bath and that'll happen at these in
his household which is their fitting
scene at Megami is actually like from
the Xena's bloodline and all standing
there maguna is completely taken by
surprise as he couldn't see to Maki
actually slowly moving towards the
epicenter of the fight wants you to know
what in the world corsicona's body to
switch into Mega Maze Maki asks to be
brought up to date with Yuji just
completely bedded and bruised telling
her to just kill him as he's not going
to die either way Boosie then Marky
attempts to land a fat head kick in
collaboration with Yuji however mikimi's
body is functioning extremely well
obviously you know from what we've seen
so far and he's comfortably able to
counter his opponent still Mahi with her
immense speed is able to break through
his defenses and send him flying
smashing into some railing nearby taking
the opportunity juji think grabs the
other side of the railing beats in it
around sakuna before Mikey follows up in
combination and kicks him into a
building nearby sending the unharmed
Damon walks out though Maggie wonders if
it's impossible to actually inflict
damage with his sole Liberation sword
because sakuna will use his reverse
curse techniques to heal himself knowing
that no matter what happens here they'll
have to kill sakuna Maki charges insane
he'll have to keep up with his speed
probably running its pitch faster than
sound right now sukuna is surprisingly
able to keep up with the attacks of Maki
and hugee but knows that whenever he
tries to attack them with curse energy
they pull from Mega me inside him is
stronger and thus to get around megame
sakuna like the absolute big brain man
he is uses his curse technique cleave
spider threads on the ground below to
utterly destroy the ground and
disbelance Yuji and Marquee with the
ground around them now falling to butt
zakuna is able to easily Dart in and
Leslie fat right Hawk yet Maki simply
spits out a tooth or two leaving him
completely impressed with how she's
hardly even worried with taking damage
asakuna falls back a little a mysterious
fold and randomly appears from the side
and uses a maximum output technique
called Dead Calm the resulting aftermath
from Tech not only freezes the entirety
of the area but also Marky and Eugene so
their mysterious person happened to be
no one other than the coldest woman out
sakuna's right-hand woman uramae who
apologizes for a grand entrance while
saying that she's still awakened the ice
around Yuji just in case they need him
sukuna though literally doesn't care for
him anymore and instead just compliment
to her stay tuned they're focusing her
energy on Maki was a good idea believing
that everything here is sweet now sukuna
then summons no way saying that this
body is still not complete so they need
to prepare for the bath immediately in
that moment though our goat though
looking more beta than Bros than ever
after this Escalade burst his way out of
the ice noticing this or maybe proposes
taking him out but shakuna says that
they should just look at him and have a
good laugh flying away for what seems
like good in yuji's eyes sukuna having
taken the body of yuji's best friend and
uramae laugh at his face noticing that
he looks just like the person from The
harima Province which is exactly what I
was referring to and goes back to
kinjaku using a binding vowel on Yuji at
Birth or even beforehand The Vow would
not allow him to use this technique in
return for Yuji being used as a vessel
for zakuna to help restore his strength
obviously we know that kinjaku would
like purposely found a bloodline that
has some form of durability as was seen
in Yuji possibly to just keep sukuna
safe during his time in Yuji announced
confirmed that Yuji actually has true
Heritage that originates from a family
in the harima province and this harima
province was established in the 600s A.D
and ran up to the late 1800s so
definitely before like the current time
period so you all thought the arc ended
here well no no no sakuna is Megami
actually speed ran this damn bath and
after having arrived at the xenon's
household we see him falling deeper and
deeper into evil itself outside the bath
urume dressed up in ritual robes asks
hinjaku whether or not he plans to end
the Cullen game twitch kinjaku explains
that his assimilation of The Wider
population can't actually Heaven until
the game ends the recently culling game
was even able to be constructed in the
first place was because kingjaku had
shouldered the burden of an equally
unreasonable binding vowel yet instead
of getting on with Indina currently he's
more interested in sakona's bath and how
it works kinjaku himself knew that the
bath was originally a ritual to
transform vessels that had been
treasured as family heirlooms into
cursed holes to do this the clay must
make a solution of curse energy which
was created by straining organisms
chosen in a kodoku ritual once it has
prepared the vessels are soaked for 10
months in 10 days and the solution so
what's actually really cool about this
ritual is it's actually something from
real Japanese folklore it's a derivative
of the Chinese go magic and it's a type
of poisonous ability and how real life
to create kodoku Sorcerers would mix
civil insects in HR and let them kill
one another until only one survived the
fluids of the insect that survived will
be used to poison an individual with a
curse that would control them causing
Misfortune or kill them the remaining n6
would also be used as a sort of luck
charm granting the one who performed the
ritual great wealth this ritual could
also be used as a death curse by giving
the riches to an ignorant individual
perhaps like kinjaku if the uh if he's
ignorant enough in this example here but
I don't actually think he is the term
kodoku can also be applied to the spirit
which is the Incarnation of this
particular magic funnily enough this
technique was even used in the Nara
period in like real life which we now
know as the era just before the Golden
Age of sorcery introduced to Kaizen so
kinjaku was actually surprised that they
specifically chose to use curses in this
ritual especially for the fact that they
become dust upon their deaths urume
though like the cold queen that she is
actually figured out a way to get around
verse simply if she carefully pins down
the spirits before freezing the cause
they don't turn into dust and it allows
them to strain away the toxins they need
confused with the purpose of it all
kinjaku asks why and urma just tells him
as to get closer to evil the entire
purpose of this ritual is to suppress
migami fushiguru's Soul deeper into the
deeps as they further down and he thinks
the easier it is for sakonas to control
the cage he's currently controlling
having completed the bath the Demon Lord
himself rises from the depths of evil
symbolizing that migami fujiguro has
lost his small hold he head over sakona
hinjaku questions why didn't change his
appearance but sakuna just reasons that
if he's gonna be battling Sorcerers then
it's better to maintain migami's
appearance honestly this is just
probably for the fact that whenever he
runs into a group of people from like
Jujutsu High it'll just completely and
utterly shatter their resolve as he
never actually expected something like
this would ever happen so remember
samiki which is now you got to do well
it was actually a dude that reincarnated
inside of her and after leaving Yuji
they'll travel back to their Hometown
before later heading to the Sendai
colony which was the closest uh I guess
barrier to it having got the rundown on
this from kinjaku sukuna says that he
doesn't give a damn about Yoda Zoo but
instead wants to destroy samiki for
shigaro to completely sink migami Soul
inside of him as they're being leave on
the Blowfish Express kinjaku tells him
that he'll give him a ride to the Colony
but once he points an exchange so I
truly wonder what on the world he's
about to do with the 200 or so points
that he's just received from sukuna here
let me know your thoughts on that down
below do you reckon he's going to like
actually pay for himself to to leave the
game entirely and just let everyone else
do their thing while he causes Havoc
outside of like the colonies and stuff
but anyway I'd love to know your
thoughts down below shooting back to the
Sendai Colony for the first time in a
while both uro and Ryu notice a mass of
bloodlust appear from afar uro utterly
breaks down muttering that here he comes
the king of curses instantly sukuna
arrives in front of Ryu and as he slowly
begins walking up to him he asks if he's
gonna run or not but before Ryu could
even act sukuna activates a slash
technique and slashes Rio across the
chest blown away though because he like
obviously thought he was going to get
cut into a multitude of Paces so Cooney
just laughs and apologizes saying that
he underestimated Ryu but won't hold
back again filling the bloodlust Rising
Ryu jumps back and tries to use Granite
blast but before he could even finish
his attack sequence sukuna slices Ryu
across the face utterly destroying one
of my favorite characters in typical
Giga fashion having left the area that
he was just at and now arriving at a
football field in Sendai zakuna finally
encounters Yoda Zoo
standing there and after realizing this
akona's stolen someone else's body and
switched so Kona just remarks that this
dude's face looked much better and damn
like so that brings us to the very end
of what is the Jujutsu Kaizen story so
far if you guys have enjoyed the video
then make sure you do leave a like down
below and let me know you know what
other series you want me to go over in
the future and all that kind of jazz I
am working on two massive videos right
now I've got a four hour long one punch
Man story going over the entirety of the
monster Association Arc to be coming out
hopefully in the uh the near future
along with a massive also four hour or
five hour I haven't exactly recorded it
yet I'm right at the very end of
scripting house Paradise video to be
coming out probably before the anime is
hopefully that's what I want to happen
but if not then it'll be a few weeks
into the Airing of the anime obviously
thank you to everyone who has you know
stuck around to the very end of the
video as this is like by far the biggest
video I've ever made or like compiled
together obviously this is the comp like
obviously this is the compilation of my
entire Jersey Kaizen Story So Far of me
going over every Arc that has been
released up until I've caught up to the
series you know because this was me
going through and reading the series as
it was releasing and whatnot it's
actually a mental at the moment when you
think about what's going on with mega me
and how sakuna's kind of pushing down
his soul and it makes you think about
like the other stuff that happens in the
series how many times has takuna swap
bodies did kinjaku perhaps try and
distance ghetto from all of his friends
like I said earlier in the video so that
his soul was further inside of his own
body so it was easier for win like he'd
passed away for him to take over his
body type thing as we'd seen his soul
did try to fight back so did kinjaku
have any like form of the bath like
sakuna had or is there anything like
that that he's had to go through I guess
hopefully we can find it in the future
we might never see from Guido again but
it'll be nice to actually see from him
but keep bringing him up so much because
season two releasing in like July or
whatever it is yeah when it comes to
everything that has happened inside and
throughout of jujitsu kaisen like it's
fairly evident that I think I like the
series quite a lot and I rate it pretty
much as highly as say something like
Naruto or bleach or Dragon Ball Z from
my childhood you know I never watched
one piece of my childhood but I watched
the other ones as I was growing up and
everything and it resonates with me on a
kind of level there all of these early
Series in my childhood did so I I just
enjoy it so much and I can't wait to see
how Giga actually ends his story what's
going to be the major
huge plot twist that's going to happen
in the up and coming like arcs and
chapters in this last year of Jiu Jitsu
kaising that it is going to support Giga
because he's absolutely amazing but
obviously you know support me as well
and if you want to support me a little
bit further as well then feel free to go
and check out my patreon which I will
leave down in the description below
where you can get earlier access to all
of these videos Before I Do release them
over on my YouTube sometimes it could
only be a few hours before I actually do
release it on patreon before it comes
out on YouTube because I'm usually
uploading them both at the same time in
preparation for that weekend so I try
and upload them like every weekend or I
try and keep like a a weekly upload
schedule as bad as it is right now it's
an absolutely terrible schedule and I
try to keep up if my videos just take so
much time to do sometimes but that's all
right it's all right either way I hope
you all like I've already said enjoyed
the video and I can't wait to like put
out more great content just like this in
the future on my channel because I
freaking love doing this kind of stuff
and obviously if you love this as well
then make sure you do hit the Subscribe
button and leave a like on the video to
let me know that you guys really do
enjoy this kind of content and want to
see more of it but anyway for now it's
been your professional degenerate dear
follow and I need a haircut and I'll see
you in a bit bye
foreign